erfüllen dann Ausgaben tätigt die ein
pandemiebezug haben das ist ja genau das
gibt ja ein Urteil vom Hessischen
Staatsgerichtshof aus dem Herbst diesen
Jahres der genau das
kritisiert hat dass in Hessen das nicht
passiert ist und ich bin mir sehr sicher
dass das Bundesfinanzministerium diese
Rechtssätze sehr genau bei der
Einbringung berücksichtigen auf die
Kontrolle dieses Fonds und vielleicht
auch andere noch mal kommen aber ich
muss Ihnen trotzdem noch mal fragen
letztes Jahr wenn sie sagen ja
corona-hilfen und jetzt für Klimaschutz
im letzten Jahr es war Corona es war der
zweite Nachtragshaushalt der
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz ihr
jetziger Fraktionsvorsitzender Christian
dürr hat damals beim zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt hier im Bundestag zu
Olaf Scholz gesagt der auch Geld in den
Energie- und klimaforgeschoben hatte das
sind haushaltstricks jetzt machen sie
genau das gleiche wie gesagt erstmal
reden wir über Kredit Ermächtigung die
jetzt da sind wir in das neue Jahr durch
die Rücklage geben damals ging es um
neue Schulden dass das erste zweitens
diese Rücklage einfach so gebildet ohne
weitere Konkretisierung dass die
Investitionsmaßnahmen die daraus
abgerufen werden zur pandemiebekämpfung
da sind drittens muss man sagen was im
Jahr 2020 alles zur
corona-bekämpfung zu pandemiebekämpfung
denken Sie an die
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung denken sie an
Elektro
mobilitätsprämie also das war ein ganzes
Sammelsurium mein Maßnahmen was die
Koalition damals
angeschoben hat und da haben wir in der
Tat gesagt dass das vielleicht nicht
unbedingt alles mit pandemiebezug zu tun
hat und das machen wir anders wir werden
darauf achten dass das im nächsten Jahr
wenn der Fond ausgeschüttet wird
ausgegeben wird das Geld entsprechend
der pandemiebezug hergestellt ist es
sind eindeutig haushaltstricks das ist
genau das was die FDP immer gegeilt hat
und wir brauchen vor allen Dingen das
Geld für soziale Zwecke wir haben das ja
hier auch im Bundestag gestern
diskutiert was alles fehlt das ist an
Pflegekräften das die Schuldenbremse ist
ein Irrweg das wissen sie auch ein
ökonomischer und finanzpolitischer
Irrweg aber Schuldenbremse nicht zu
wollen heißt ja nicht haushaltstrickts
anzuwenden was wollen ist jetzt ein Fond
der nicht kontrollierbar ist oder
hinterher kontrolliert wird vom
Parlament wenn das Geld schon ausgegeben
wird und 60 Milliarden das ist nicht
wenig das ist mehr als der
Verteidigungshaushalt sie sind in der
Opposition wie werden sie diesen Fonds
der jetzt von Energie und klimafreund
die gibt es schon länger der wird jetzt
als Klima und transformationsfonds dann
firmieren wie werden sie als Parlament
als Opposition des kontrollieren wir
werden alles versuchen dass wir wirklich
Details erfahren aber unsere größte
unser größtes Anliegen ist dass in ein
regulären Haushalt zu bringen und diese
ganzen extra Fonds die sind häufig mit
Taschenspieler Tricks verbunden das
können wir nicht akzeptieren und wir
werden in jeder Sitzung nachfragen und
uns genau alles vorlegen lassen herr
Meyer es gibt eine relativ aktuelle
Studie noch vom Oktober
2021 da sind man diese ganzen Schatten
und nebenhaushalte die sich so über die
Jahre angehäuft haben zusammengezählt
worden und da ist gesagt worden vom
Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft dessen
ungefähr im Moment 100 Milliarden Euro
im als Angehörigen
gibt den Vorschlag auch von
finanzwirtschaftswissenschaftler dass
man das alles zusammenpackt in einen
Fonds in einen deutschlandfond
beispielsweise der dann transparent wäre
für jeden für das Parlament für die
Bürger besser zu kontrollieren und
daraus Investitionen zu tätigen warum
könnte man das nicht machen das wäre
auch ein Vorschlag wir gehen jetzt
zunächst erstmal diesen Weg wir sind
jetzt seit einer Woche hier mit der
neuen Bundesregierung im Amt das heißt
wir gucken uns jetzt an was da ist auch
ein Sondervermögen und dann werden wir
das Bewerten am Ende des Tages muss
natürlich darum gehen Sondervermögen die
keine Rechtfertigung haben abzuschmelzen
am besten um in der Tat aus dem Haushalt
die Ausgaben zu finanzieren
das ist aber ein Punkt den wir bewerten
müssen denke ich ab den nächsten Jahr
das Gute was wir in diesen
Koalitionsvertrag als FDP reinverhandelt
haben ist ja dass wir auch eine
Ausgabenkontrolle durchführen wollen das
ist aber etwas was wir nicht im
Nachtragshaushalt 2021 machen können
sondern was vermutlich erst im Haushalt
2022/22 passieren kann deswegen können
Sie uns noch ein bisschen Zeiten dann
werden Sie sehen dass wir zu sehr
solider Finanz- und Haushaltspolitik
zurückkehren werden das was die große
Koalition letzten Jahr nicht geschafft
hat wir kommen noch mal zu den
nicht für die Vorhaben der
Ampelkoalition im nächsten Jahr gilt die
Schuldenbremse noch nicht die Koalition
hat sich darauf verständigt dass er erst
ab 2023 das wieder gilt also könnte man
im nächsten Jahr noch mal Rücklagen
bilden in verschiedenen Fonds es steht
im Koalitionsvertrag auf so schon drin
dass man sich das anschauen will Frau
lutsch was erwarten sie denn jetzt im
nächsten Jahr wird es so weitergehen
also die FDP hat ja jetzt schon ihre
eigenen Prinzipien umgestoßen ist der
erste Punkt was ich erwarte und was ich
fordere dass die Grünen und die SPD der
fdp-finanzpolitik nicht hinterherlaufen
SPD und Grüne haben im Wahlkampf gesagt
Sie wollen von den Vermögenden Steuern
erheben das müssen sie endlich machen
und dürfen sich nicht von der FDP auf
der Nase rumtanzen lassen herr Meier die
Union hat schon angekündigt dass sie
sich vorstellen kann Forst
Bundesverfassungsgericht zu gehen und
dagegen zu klagen dass sie halten das
für verfassungswidrig dieses Vorgehen
diese 60 Milliarden zu verschieben was
machen Sie denn wenn das
Verfassungsgericht sagt ja so geht es
nicht müssen sie dann doch die Steuern
er er muss das Geld ja kommen gilt der
Koalitionsvertrag dass wir keine Steuern
erhöhen wollen und werden deswegen
warten wir jetzt erstmal ab ob die Union
wirklich anders als in den letzten
Jahren was ihre Positionierung angeht
gegen diesen Nachtragshaushalt klagt und
dann warten wir ab was Karlsruhe sagt
wir sind da sehr gut aufgestanden
unseren Argumenten und deswegen gehen
wir momentan nicht davon aus dass wir
irgendeine Abweichung von diesem Plan im
nächsten Monaten machen müssen Frau
lösch gehen sie von Steuererhöhungen
nächsten Jahr aus oder in den nächsten
Jahren wir brauchen Steuererhöhungen und
wir brauchen Steuererhöhungen von den
Reichen und wir schlagen vor eine
Vermögensabgabe für das reichste 0,7%
der Bevölkerung ich wiederhole 0,7%. das
ist in dieser Koalition ja schon durch
sozusagen diskutiert das wird es nicht
gehen wir werden natürlich beobachten
woher das Geld kommen soll für die
wichtigen Vorhaben der neuen
Ampelkoalition ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich dass sie heute morgen bei uns
waren Christoph Meyer von der FDP und
Gesine lötz von der Linken und wir
schauen in den Plenarsaal wo nämlich
gleich die Sitzung eröffnet werden wird
und ich habe auf der Regierungsbank
unter anderem schon gesehen die neue
Außenminister Annalena baerbock und wir
werden dann hören es wird heute morgen
übrigens dann erst noch eine Abstimmung
geben über die Mitglieder des
Vermittlungsausschusses der besteht ja
aus Mitgliedern von Bundestag und
Bundesrat 16 Mitglieder des Bundestages
müssen in diesen Vermittlungsausschuss
entsendet werden und das werden wir
zuerst haben diese Abstimmung und wir
schauen mal in den Saal
wo die Regierungsbank sich schon gefüllt
hat
und sehen
unter anderem
den Justizminister
Marco Buschmann den Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner und jetzt wird diese
Sitzung eröffnet
von der Bundestagspräsidentin
von Bärbel Bass
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ein wunderschönen guten
Morgen die Sitzung ist eröffnet
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung haben
wir eine Wahl durchzuführen auf
Vorschlag der cdu/csu
Fraktion soll die Kolleginnen Daniela
Ludwig als Nachfolgerin für den Kollegen
Michael Frieser zum ordentlichen
Mitglied des
wahlprüfungsausschusses gewählt werden
stimmen Sie dem zu
das ist offensichtlich der Fall damit
ist die Kollegin Ludwig zum ordentlichen
Mitglied des
wahlprüfungsausschusses gewählt
wir kommen herzlichen Glückwunsch
wir kommen zur Tagesordnung mir liegt
ein fristgerecht eingereichter Antrag
der Fraktion von SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP nach § 20 Absatz 2 Satz 3
unserer Geschäftsordnung vor danach soll
ein Antrag mit dem Titel Sitzordnung im
Plenarsaal des Bundestages auf
Drucksache
20268 heute aufgesetzt und abgestimmt
werden
die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat der
Erweiterung der Tagesordnung
widersprochen ich lasse daher abstimmen
wer stimmt für die aufsetzung des
Antrages auf Drucksache 20268
das ist die SPD-Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und die FDP-Fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das ist die Fraktion der CDU CSU und die
afd-fraktion wer enthält sich die
Fraktion DIE LINKE
damit ist die aufsetzung des Antrags auf
Drucksache
20268 als Zusatzpunkt 2 beschlossen
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
dass im Falle der aufsetzung des
Antrages auf Drucksache 20-268 dieser
mit einer debattenzeit von 31 Minuten
nach
Tagesordnungspunkt 10 beraten wird
hier sehe ich auch keinen Widerspruch
dann ist das so beschlossen
außerdem hat die Fraktion der AFD eine
Aktuelle Stunde mit dem Titel
Umsatzeinbußen durch 2g-regelungen in
Gastronomie und Einzelhandel verlangt
die nach Zusatzpunkt 2 aufgerufen wird
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 2
Wahl der vom Deutschen Bundestag zu
entsendenden Mitglieder des Ausschusses
nach Artikel 77 Absatz 2 des
Grundgesetzes das ist der
Vermittlungsausschuss hierzu liegen
Wahlvorschläge aller Fraktionen auf
Drucksache 272 vor wer stimmt für diese
Wahlvorschläge
das sind alle Fraktionen wenn ich das
erkenne Gegenstimmen Enthaltungen
[Musik]
nicht der Fall damit sind die
Wahlvorschläge angenommen
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 3
erste Beratung des von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs über die Feststellung
eines zweiten Nachtrags zum
bundeshaushaltsplan für das
Haushaltsjahr
2021 für die Aussprache ist eine Dauer
von 67 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat als erster für die Bundesregierung
der Bundesminister für Finanzen
Christian Lindner
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung bekennt sich zur
Schuldenbremse unserer Verfassung
so steht es im Koalitionsvertrag wir
werden ab
2023 also schon mit dem Bundeshaushalt
den wir im kommenden Sommer hier im Haus
verhandeln die Vorgaben der
Schuldenbremse einhalten
eine andere Prognose war im Januar in
einem Gastbeitrag im Handelsblatt zu
lesen die Schuldenbremse schrieb der
damalige Kanzleramtsminister sei in den
kommenden Jahren in den kommenden Jahren
auch bei ansonsten strenger
Ausgabendisziplin nicht einzuhalten
deshalb müsse das Grundgesetz geändert
werden um längere Zeit höhere Schulden
machen zu können nun ist Helge braun
auch vorsitzt auf Vorschlag der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion zum
Vorsitzenden des Haushaltsausschusses
gewählt worden ich freue mich lieber
Herr Braun auf die Zusammenarbeit mit
Ihnen im Ausschuss und wir wollen prüfen
ob ein anderer Weg als der den sie
prognostiziert haben möglich wird
meine Damen und Herren der
Koalitionsvertrag umfasst zugleich auch
eine Antwort auf die Pandemie sie setzen
wir mit diesem Nachtragshaushalt als das
Verhandlungsergebnis dreierparteien um
ich danke meinem Vorgänger der dies
konzeptionell vorbereitet hat wir haben
uns ambitionierte Ziele gesetzt die
corona-pandemie zu bewältigen und
gestärkt aus der Krise herauszukommen
für unsere Aufgabe die Transformation
einer der größten Industrienationen hin
zur Klimaneutralität wir stellen uns
diese Aufgabe in einer herausfordernden
Zeit ein großer Teil der öffentlichen
Mittel wird für die Bewältigung der
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Folgen der
Pandemie verwendet und das führt zu
diesem Nachtragsetat zugleich sind durch
die Unsicherheiten und Einschränkungen
der corona-krise viele Investitionen in
die Modernisierung der Wirtschaft
ausgefallen die pandemiebedingten
Restriktion haben auch unsere
Lieferketten gestört zudem
verteuern gestiegene Energiepreise
wirtschaftliche Aktivität die
Herbstprojekt und der Bundesregierung
geht nachher davon aus dass die
Investitionstätigkeit der
Volkswirtschaft in den Jahren 2020 und
21 deutlich unterhalb des in der
Herbstprojektion des Jahres 2019 für
diesen Zeitraum geschätzten Volumens
geblieben ist von grundlegender
Bedeutung jetzt eine nachholprozess zu
organisieren wir dürfen durch die
Pandemie nicht auch noch Zeit bei der
Transformation von Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft verlieren
also meine Damen und Herren wir brauchen
den Mut zum Aufbruch nicht nur die
Menschen benötigen einen Booster auch
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung gerade
jetzt sind öffentliche Investitionen und
die Förderung privater die die
Transformation befördern entscheidend
dabei bedingen sich die Bekämpfung der
Pandemie und die Transformation der
Wirtschaft geradezu die zahlreichen
Hilfen für Unternehmen selbstständige
und beschäftige überbrücken die schwere
Zeit aber langfristig wirken sie nur
wenn wir damit zugleich eine
wirtschaftliche Dynamik entfachen und
mehr Fortschritt wagen es geht um den
Weg aus der Krise und wirtschaftlichen
Erfolg und um viel mehr es geht um die
Verantwortung für die zukünftigen
Generationen
das hat auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht unterstrichen
der Maßstab für den Klimaschutz heute
sind die freiheitschancen künftiger
Generationen die Bundesregierung
orientiert sich an dieser Entscheidung
und zugleich
und zugleich müssen wir die
Schuldenbremse des Grundgesetzes
einhalten beides ist für die
Bundesregierung verbindlich wir handeln
schnell und entschlossen mit diesem
Nachtragshaushalt schaffen wir eine
Basis wir schaffen Planungssicherheit
und setzen Wachstumsimpulse wir bauen
gewissermaßen eine Brücke aus der
Pandemie in eine klimafreundliche
Zukunft eine zentrale Rolle spielt der
energie-prozess geeignete Instrument ich
habe die Kritik der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion wahrgenommen
wir nehmen die Kritik der cdu-bundestags
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion auch ernst
sie entscheidet sich wohltuend von
früheren Äußerungen aus ihren Reihen
bei uns ist der Unterschied
bei uns ist der Unterschied weniger groß
ich will Ihnen deshalb eine klare Zusage
geben
bei der Nutzung der Mittel werden wir
zukünftig darauf achten dass der Bezug
zu den Folgeschäden der Pandemie also
etwa nicht erfolgter Investitionen oder
Preisentwicklung jederzeit bestehen
bleibt mitnichten geht es darum
allgemeine Projekte der Ampelkoalition
oder etwa Staatskonsum zu finanzieren
die Mittel des Fonds werden
zielgerichtet eingesetzt für
transformative Investition
wie
[Musik]
im wie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
nutzen wir Mittel aus den bereits
veranschlagten aber nicht benötigten
Kredit Ermächtigungen wir schlagen vor
die bereits im letzten Jahr von der
Vorgängerregierung erfolgte Zuweisung um
weitere 60 Milliarden Euro zu ergänzen
mehr wäre möglich mehr ist aber nicht
nötig es werden im Vergleich zum
früheren Vorgehen keine zusätzlichen
Kredit Ermächtigungen geschaffen im
Gegenteil sollten sich weitere
Entlastungen im Haushaltsvollzug 2021
ergeben dann werden wir vorschlagen
diese zur Reduzierung der tatsächlichen
Nettokreditaufnahme einzusetzen
nachhaltig zu wirtschaften ist uns
wichtig
denn Deutschland hat auch eine Rolle in
Europa die Rückkehr zu klaren
Fiskalregeln ist entscheidend und
deshalb schließen wir für uns Wege aus
die Änderung der Verfassung umfassen das
erfordert Mut zur Prioritätensetzung
aber darüber verfügen wir
Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister hier seine erste
Lesung zu dem Gesetzentwurf zum
Nachtragshaushalt
Abgeordnete Christian Haase und wir
hören jetzt
Christian Haase für die cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine Münze hinter dem Ohr hervorzaubern
einen Blumenstrauß aus dem Ärmel ziehen
oder einen kleinen Ball in der Hand
verschwinden lassen sowas nennt man
Taschenspielertricks im Mittelalter
standen die Menschen mit großen Augen
vor Jahrmärkten vor gaukland und
schauten sich solche Kunststücke an
heute stehen wir staunen vor dem
Begründungen zum zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt 2021 in einer
wundersamen Wandlung werden
corona-kredite zu klimakrediten
mindestens genauso Staunen müsste der
Kollege dürr ich darf Ihnen übrigens an
dieser Stelle noch einmal zur Wahl als
Fraktionsvorsitzender gratulieren Berta
Kollege bei einem rechtlich deutlich
weniger zweifelhaften zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt 2020 hatten sie im
Juli letzten Jahres scharfe Töne
angeschlagen lassen sie mich aus ihrer
Rede zitieren
Zitat anfangt der zweite
Nachtragshaushalt beeinträchtigt
wesentliche Verfassungsgrundsätze wie
Jährlichkeit Fälligkeit Wahrheit und
Klarheit Zitat Ende und mit Blick auf
die ehemaligen Finanzminister Scholz und
Walter bojans fragte sich der Kollege
dürr damals warum man in der SPD nur
Karriere machen könne wenn man
verfassungswidrige Haushalte vorlege
sind das die Fußstapfen in die sie
treten wollen Herr Lindner sie sind mit
der klaren Aussage angetreten die
Schuldenbremse zu verteidigen und auch
in die Sondierungsgespräche sind sie mit
der klaren roten Linie gegangen kein
Aufweichen der Schuldenbremse hierbei
Finanzminister wollen Sie wirklich
dieses Versprechen mit ihrem ersten
Gesetzentwurf brechen
denn das ist auch offensichtlich dass
sie die Schuldenbremse mit diesem
waghalsigen Manöver ausfüllen zu den
corona-krediten die sie im
energie-regel für Sondervermögen mit dem
einzigen Ziel den verschuldungsspielraum
in den nächsten Jahren vollkommen
unabhängig von Corona zu erhöhen und ich
sage Ihnen ganz deutlich ich halte
diesen Nachtragshaushalt für
verfassungswidrig ich halte diesen
Nachtragshaushalt für dem Anfang vom
Ende der Schuldenbremse und das wird mit
ihrem Namen verbunden sein
und in meinen Bedenken stehe ich nicht
allein da namhafte Staatsrechtler der
Bundesrechnungshof oder der
wissenschaftliche Beirat des
stabilitätsrats haben bereits deutliche
Kritik geäußert die ausschweifende
Begründung im Gesetzentwurf zeigt
anschaulich was für geistige
Verrenkungen nötig sind um diesen
Nachtragshaushalt zu rechtfertigen da
ist die Rede davon dass sie zur
pandemiebewältigung die Zuweisung an den
EKF im Jahre 2020 bewährt habe nein
meine Damen und Herren wenn man einmal
bei Gelb über die Ampel gefahren ist
heißt das nicht dass man beim nächsten
Mal bei Rot fahren darf
die bisherigen kreditermächtigung haben
eine feste corona-konditionierung sie
jetzt nachträglich für die Bekämpfung
des Klimawandels auszuweiten ist nicht
nur verfassungswidrig sondern hat ein
offensichtlichen Logikfehler bereits
seit langem ist doch klar dass der
Klimawandel auch eine finanzielle
Herausforderung ist das hat nichts aber
auch gar nichts mit der Bewältigung der
corona-krise zu tun die Pandemie ist
eine außergewöhnliche Notsituation im
Sinne des Artikels 115 Grundgesetz der
Klimawandel ist dies nicht der
Klimawandel ist eine dauerhafte
Herausforderung der wir uns im Rahmen
der regulären Haushaltsführung stellen
muss und das können wir ohne
Verfassungsbruch
meine Damen und Herren die FDP-Fraktion
hat sich in der vergangenen Wahlperiode
ja immer gerne als service-opposition
bezeichnet darum will ich Ihnen auch
helfen etwas zu tun was nicht
verfassungswidrig ist erstens eine
konsequente Aufgabenkritik wir sind uns
alle einig dass der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel eine der drängsten Aufgaben
ist das muss ich dann durch
Prioritätensetzung im Bundeshaushalt
widerspiegeln bevor man Ausgaben erhöht
sollte man nach Einsparpotenzial schauen
und ich bin erstaunt dass ich ihnen das
erklären muss Herr Lindner bisher war
das auch ihre Linie
zweitens
aktivieren Sie private Investitionen zum
Klimaschutz statt den nächsten
Generationen riesige Schuldenberge zu
hinterlassen die finanziellen
Herausforderungen sind durch die
Demografie bereits groß genug schränken
Sie die Zukunftsmöglichkeiten der
zukünftigen Generation nicht weiter ein
drittens effiziente Förderprogramme sind
einfach besser als immer mehr Geld
befreien Sie sich von der Illusion dass
die Erhöhung öffentlicher Ausgaben
irgendeine kurzfristige Wirkung
entfaltet ein Blick auf den stockenden
Mittelabfluss im EKF sollte für diese
Einsicht genügen stattdessen arbeiten
wir mit Ihnen gerne daran Planverfahren
zu straffen Förderprogramme zu
entschlacken oder noch besser stärken
sie kommunale Investitionen durch eine
erhöhte und Umsatzsteueranteil
eigentlich müsste ich mit diesen
Vorschlägen einem liberalen
Finanzminister aus der Seele sprechen
überzeugen Sie also Ihre
Koalitionspartner dass dies der deutlich
bessere Weg ist als immer zusätzliche
neue Schulden ganz zu schweigen dass sie
ihre Amtszeit mit einem Verfassungsbruch
beginnen ziehen sie deshalb diesen
Nachtragshaushalt zurück
sagt Christian Haase für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
er ist der haushaltspolitische Sprecher
der Unionsfraktion die auch ihre
fachpolitischen Sprecher jetzt bereits
neu besetzt hat und er bekommt viele
Applaus aus den Reihen der Union es gab
ja auch im Vorfeld große große Kritik
bis zur Ankündigung zu klagen vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht und Christian
Haase hat die Kritik noch mal
ausführlich gegründet
nächster Redner ist rote für die SPD
geschätzte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vorweg wir sind
mitten in der Pandemie und auch für die
Haushaltspolitik gilt weiterhin wir
werden nicht beim Gesundheitsschutz der
Bevölkerung sparen der Schutz von Leib
und Leben wird auch für die neue
Koalition allerhöchste Priorität haben
neben dem Gesundheitsschutz haben wir
uns aber in den letzten anderen
Halbjahren auch sehr intensiv mit den
wirtschaftlichen Folgen dieser Pandemie
beschäftigen müssen dafür haben wir
vielfältig Brücken gebaut wir haben
Brücken gebaut für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer insbesondere durch das
Kurzarbeitergeld damit die die vor der
Krise einen Job hatten ihn auch
nachdeckt die sagen wir haben Brücken
gebaut für Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer die vor der Krise
erfolgreich waren damit sie durch
Soforthilfe durch brückenhilfe durch den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch
nach der Krise erfolgreich sein können
wir haben Brücken über diese Krise
gebaut aber jetzt jetzt geht es um die
Frage wohin führen eigentlich diese
Brücken denn die Welt um uns herum ist
ja nicht stehengeblieben es ist ja nicht
nur das Thema Corona was Politik zu
beschäftigen hat und wir erleben dass
wir
dass wir uns mit der Frage
auseinandersetzen müssen landen die
Brücken in der Welt so wie sie vorher
aussah oder schlagen wir diese Brücken
jetzt in die Zukunft wir erleben
weltweit dass die Geschwindigkeit der
wirtschaftlichen Transformation
zugenommen hat viele anderen Länder
setzen darauf CO2-neutral zu werden ihre
Produktion weg von CO2 zu führen und uns
muss klar sein wenn dieser Aufschwung
den wir gerade gestalten wenn diese
Brücken in die Zukunft führen sollen
dann geht das nur wenn wir möglichst
schnell in diesem Land die
Voraussetzungen schaffen auch hier
CO2-neutral zu produzieren und auch an
dieser Stelle wettbewerbsfähig zu
bleiben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und natürlich das kostet eine Menge Geld
und auch die Brücken der letzten
anderthalb Jahre haben eine Menge Geld
gekostet aber hätten wir weggesehen
hätten wir geben sich selbst überlassen
hätten wir nicht gehandelt dann wäre das
alles viel teurer geworden und der
Schaden für unser Land wäre immens viel
größer geworden deshalb ist es richtig
zu handeln liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wie dringend mit Blick auf die
Zukunft kluges Handeln ist sehen wir ja
schon wenn große deutsche Unternehmen
jetzt Entscheidungen treffen dass die
Stahl zukünftig bei fremdländischen
Unternehmen einkaufen weil der
CO2-neutral ist und wir das Angebot noch
nicht zu vorhalten können und gerade
deswegen ist es zwingende Voraussetzung
für die nachhaltige Sicherung der
Arbeitsplätze und des wirtschaftlichen
Wohlstandes dieses Landes das die
Brücken in der Zukunft ankommt dass sie
in der CO2-Neutralität ankommt das ist
unsere Aufgabe im Hier und Jetzt und
genau das
genau das ist der Grund
weswegen wir den
energie-neutralität jetzt zügig in
Angriff zu nehmen und wir kommen damit
unserer Verpflichtung der Verpflichtung
des Staates nach Leben und Gesundheit
vor den Gefahren des Klimawandels zu
schützen wir haben keine Zeit zu
verlieren und wenn das negiert wer das
bestreitet der möge sich doch auch noch
mal die Bilder aus dem Ahrtal angucken
ja wir brauchen die Wirtschaft die
wirtschaftliche Transformation schnell
und den Wohlstand unseres Landes zu
sichern aber wir brauchen eben auch zum
Erhalt des natürlichen Lebensraums auf
dieser Welt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und darum
und darum sage ich in aller Deutlichkeit
in Richtung Union wer davon spricht wir
wollten mit diesem
transformationsfonds irgendwelche
ampelprojekte finanzieren der ist noch
immer noch nicht im Hier und Jetzt und
jetzt noch immer nicht in der Realität
dieses Landes angekommen und
und wer dann sagt er will gegen diese
Rücklage zu dieser unbedingten
notwendigen wirtschaftlichen
Transformationen dieses Landes dann auch
nach Karlsruhe gegen er will dagegen
klagen der macht sich aus Opportunismus
zum Kämpfer gegen den Wohlstand in
diesem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
aber gehen Sie sie werden scheitern zum
einen weil wir der festen Überzeugung
sind man muss eine Krise auch nachhaltig
verlassen und das machen wir mit diesem
Klima und transformationsfonds und weil
wir uns auch sehr intensiv mit dem
Urteil in Hessen des Staatsgerichtshofs
auseinandergesetzt haben und uns auch
angeguckt haben welche Leitplanken
werden da eigentlich gezeichnet und
schnell feststellen konnten zum einen
sind die verfassungsrechtlichen
Grundlagen sehr unterschiedlich und der
Hauptkritikpunkt des hessischen
Staatsgerichtshof war die fehlende
parlamentarische Beteiligung und die
Verletzung des budgetrechts des
Landtages und ich sage Ihnen das würde
bei uns ins leer gelaufen wir der
Deutsche Bundestag wir sind
verantwortlich für die konkrete
Verwendung der Mittel der Sondervermögen
wir beraten jedes Jahr den
Wirtschaftsplan des Energie- und
Klimafonds der Haushaltsausschuss setzt
sich regelmäßig in vielen Sitzungen mit
konkreten Fragen des
energie-vermögen in dem eine
regierungsfrei hantieren kann wir
beschließen kein Sondervermögen der
Bundesregierung wir beschließen ein
Sondervermögen über dessen konkreten
Einsatz zur nachhaltigen Bekämpfung der
Pandemie wir als Deutscher Bundestag
entscheiden werden
wir reden also nicht von einem besonders
Vermögen der exekutiven sondern von
einem der Legislative und das ist der
Unterschied zu Hessen und vielleicht das
auch noch mal ein paar wenige Zahlen
gepackt das hessische Sondervermögen
findet sich auf einer halben Seite
zusammengefasst zwei einnahmepunkte
sieben ausgabepunkte für 12 Milliarden
Euro der Energie-
und
ein Sondervermögen für dringend
notwendige Transformationsprozesse im
Deutschen Bundestag zu nutzen ist nichts
Neues genau dasselbe haben wir in der
letzten Koalition auch gemacht wir haben
mit dem zweiten Nachtragshaushalt 2020
28 Milliarden Euro ebenfalls für
transformationsaufgaben in den Energie-
und klimafond überführt und wir haben
das nicht nur mit den Stimmen der Union
gemacht sondern auch noch voll des Lobes
aus der Union so hat der damalige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Andreas Jung in der Debatte am 2 juli
von diesem Rednerpult von einer
Vitaminspritze für die Zukunft unseres
Landes gesprochen der Kollege
der Kollege Brandl sprach in derselben
Debatte von diesem Rednerpult davon dass
es der Anspruch sein müsste nicht nur
nach der Krise in einem Deutschland
anzukommen wieder vor sondern Zitat
unser Anspruch ist Deutschland damit
besser zu machen sie erkennen also die
Notwendigkeit zu handeln sie haben die
Instrumente die wir selbst die wir
nutzen selbst mit erdacht sie sprachen
von vitaminenspritzen davon Deutschland
besser zu machen und heute verleumten
sie ihre eigene Politik ich frage wer
soll ihnen das eigentlich abnehmen
und der Kollege der Bundesminister
Lindner hat es angesprochen Helge Braun
hat ja selbst einen Vorschlag zur Reform
der Schuldenbremse auf dem Weg gebracht
und die Begründung dafür die Herleitung
ist genauso interessant ich zitiere
Helge braun Handelsblatt 21 Januar 2021
sollte eine strategische Entscheidung
zur wirtschaftlichen Erholung und
getroffen werden ist das mit erheblichen
Belastung für den Bundeshaushalt
verbunden konkret die Schuldenbremse ist
in den kommenden Jahren auch bei
ansonsten strenger Ausgaben
disziplinarse die sie gerade gefordert
haben nicht einzuhalten herrke braun
sagt also ebenfalls dass es einer
strategischen Entscheidung zur
wirtschaftlichen Erholung Bedarf und
dass diese enorme Kosten mit sich bringt
trotzdem wurde sein Vorschlag
insbesondere von ihrer fraktions- und
Parteiführung vehement zurückgewiesen
ihr Credo war keine neuen Schulden keine
zusätzlichen Einnahmen kein Geld für
informationsaufgaben kommt heute noch
dazu und was machen sie machen Helge
braun der alles das erkannt hat zu ihrem
Gesicht für die Haushaltspolitik im
Deutschen Bundestag zum Vorsitzenden des
Haushaltsausschusses des Deutschen
Bundestages was gilt jetzt eigentlich
bei Ihnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und nochmal abschließend was ist der
Preis des Nichtstuns die Brücken nicht
in die Zukunft zu schlagen würde den
wirtschaftlichen ausschwung unseres
Landes massiv gefährden und als stärkste
Volkswirtschaft in Europa würde es die
ökonomische Erholung des gesamten
Kontinents gefährden heute nicht zu
handeln würde den Preis in der Zukunft
um ein Vielfaches erhöhen weil unsere
Wirtschaft abgehängt ist und weil
Katastrophen wie DMA Teil Milliarden an
Schäden mit sich bringt diese Krise ist
nicht beendet sie stellt uns für neue
Herausforderungen wir sind bereit diese
Herausforderung anzugehen der
Nachtragshaushalt ist der erste richtige
Schritt um die richtige Richtung vielen
Dank
Dennis Rohde für die SPD-Fraktion sitzt
der im Haushaltsausschuss ja und diese
Energie und klimafond in denen die 60
Milliarden verschoben werden sollen ist
ein Sondervermögen des Bundes wurde 2011
bereits eingerichtet und über den
Bundeshaushalt hinaus Investitionen
Klimaschutz und so weiter zu ermöglichen
der soll jetzt in Zukunft Klima und
transformations-
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir waren ja schon unter
der groko einiges an Zumutungen gewöhnt
aber es ist schon eine bemerkenswerte
Leistung eines
fdp-finanzministers in seiner
allerersten amtswoche gleich zwei
zentrale FDP Wahlkampfversprechen zu
brechen zunächst mit dem Impfzwang für
Pfleger den Erhalt eines elementaren
Grund- und freiheitsrechts der Menschen
und heute das Versprechen einer seriösen
Haushaltspolitik diesen Ausverkauf des
liberalen Tafelsilbers sollten Sie
dringend ihren betrogenen Wählern
erklären Herr Lindner
der Nachtragshaushalt 2021 über 60
Milliarden Euro soll rückwirkend im
Januar des Folgejahres beschlossen
werden war es schlicht absurd ist man
nimmt kein Geld für ein Jahr auf in dem
der Bund ohnehin bereits 180 Milliarden
Euro Schulden gemacht hat nur weil die
alte groko sich noch weitere 60
Milliarden hat genehmigen lassen und
2021 einfach nicht mehr ausgeben konnte
so wie es die Ampel nun eben auch nicht
mehr tun kann
das sind doch unseriöse Tricks die einer
Bundesregierung unwürdig sind und wenn
ich eben höre Kollege Fricke dass das
Geld nicht mehr ausgegeben wird dann ist
es erst recht ein Argument ist heute
nicht aufzunehmen wenn sie es 2021 an
kameralistischen Haushalt nicht mehr
ausgeben können dann dürfen sie es nicht
ausgeben das sind buchungstricks ich
komme dazu und ja man weiß es ja
offensichtlich bereits wie viel Geld man
in diesen vier Jahren auf Pumpe
benötigen wird und dann fängt man lieber
gleich in den ersten Tagen an richtig
aufzuschulden zudem stellen sich
komplexe rechtliche Fragen zur für Union
und auch FDP offenbar zu komplexe das
zeigt sich am eratischen Verhalten
dieser Fraktion seit 2020 wir haben das
ja eben schon zu Recht gehört die FDP
hatte noch in der Opposition ihr
jetziges Vorgehen in der Regierung als
verfassungsfeindlich und
verfassungswidrig bezeichnet nämlich die
Bildung von über Neuverschuldung
finanzierten Rücklagen das ist nicht
falsches waren ihre Worte sowie die
Zweckentfremdung von Corona Mitteln für
andere Zecke gleich zu ihnen noch Herr
dürr Herr dürrw sie werden gleich noch
mal zitiert alles gut und auch die Union
ist heute überzeugt davon dass ihr
eigenes völlig analoges Vorgehen als
Regierungspartei 2020 nun plötzlich
rechtswidrige finanzakrobatik sei Zitat
eines csu-kollegen sie will nun offenbar
im Zustand des Gedächtnisverlustes ihr
eigenes Tun von damals das heute dass
der Ampel ist nachträglich per Klage in
Karlsruhe prüfen lassen das könnte man
sich nicht ausdenken
die AFD sieht natürlich ebenfalls und
immer noch dieses Vorgehen als
rechtswidrig an immer noch deshalb weil
wir und nur wir bereits 2021 hier im
Haus entsprechend enormen kontrollklagen
Anträge eingebracht hatten zum Nachlesen
für Sie auch Kollegen Brinkhaus Herr
Dobrindt Herr Haase und gerne auch für
die Medien Drucksache
1922926 von September 2020 und 19 26549
von Februar 21 kein einziger
unionsabgeordneter wollte damals diese
Verfassungsklagen unterstützen und nun
erklären sie Kollege Haase gegenüber der
Schatz das Wort Verfassungsbruch liegt
förmlich in der Luft oder eben hier
jetzt gerade verfassungswidrig sie haben
sie ausgesprochen oder was haben sie
noch gesagt nun werden corona-kredite zu
klimakrediten ja in der Tat das war bei
ihnen das gleiche sie haben genau das
gleiche gemacht nur mit etwas kleineren
Summen das ist doch reine realtatiere
hier
die Bildung von schuldenfinanzierten
Rücklagen ist natürlich generell
rechtswidrig das sagen nicht nur der
gesunde ökonomische rechtsverstanden und
der hausarterische Verstand und die AFD
sondern auch der ehemalige Präsident des
Verfassungsgerichts Kirchhoff und der
Bundesrechnungshof der Haushalt herische
Verfassungsgrundsätze die Jährlichkeit
und Klarheit verletzt zieht genau das
was irgendwie immer die FDP früher auch
so gesehen hat Prof schwarz von der Uni
Würzburg erklärt ebenfalls das
Offensichtliche Zitat verfassungswidrig
eine unzulässige Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse und sogar der sehr
liberale staatsrechter gröpel schrieb
dazu im Handelsblatt Verfassungsbruch
par excellence nachlesen und dann wollen
wir in der Tat den ja eben schon sehr
aktiven fdp-kollegen dürr nicht ganz
vergessen sie sagten ihr Herr Dörr an
dieser Stelle am 2 juli 2020 als
Finanzminister Scholz genau denselben
rücklagentrick einwenden wollte Zitat
das Protokoll ist eindeutig dieser
Haushalt verstößt gegen das Grundgesetz
ich verstehe nicht warum man in der SPD
Karriere machen kann und der
spd-fallbeuerns warvergleichbar wenn man
verfassungswidrige Haushalte vorlegt und
weiter warum wird die cdu/csu-fraktion
hier zum Helfershelfer eines möglichen
verfassungsbrechers Zitat Ende heute
will der FDP Minister Lindner davon
nichts mehr hören welchen Unterschied
schon acht Tage an der Macht machen
können das ist wirklich erstaunlich
und nochmals zur Union noch bis Herbst
21 hat die Union genau dieses
verfassungswidrige Vorgehen als
Regierungspartei mitgetragen und nun
reden sie
demonstrativstabilitätspolitisch vom
Verfassungsbruch welchen Unterschied
schon acht Tage in der Opposition
ausmachen auch das ist erstaunlich
wer wie Herr Dobrindt ernsthaft am
vorigen Dienstag der Presse diktiert wer
Finanzpolitik durch finanzakrobatik
ersetzt der bewegt sich schnell
außerhalb des Rechtsrahmens der sollte
ganz dringend in den Rückspiegeln seine
eigenen zwei vergangenen Haushaltsjahre
schauen und verschämt Schweigen diese
gelebte Doppelmoral ist wirklich kaum
noch zu ertragen
nein liebe unionskollegen so leicht
kommen sie nicht aus dem
verfassungsbrechenden Erbe der mörke
ihrer heraus sie kritisieren hier etwas
was sie seit 2020 in mehreren Haushalten
selbst getan haben aber die gute
Nachricht ist wir sind gerne bereit in
unsere Normen kontrollklagen Anträge zur
Verfügung zu stellen für Karlsruhe
die 240 Milliarden Euro Neuverschuldung
für 2021 dürfen nur wegen der
angeblichen pandemischen Notlage
aufgenommen werden und selbstreden auch
nur für diese Notlage genutzt werden das
ist das Konnexitätsprinzip rechtlich
etabliert schon die groko hat es
missachtet aber die Ampel macht nun gar
kein E-Mail mehr daraus angebliche
Corona Notkredite werden ganz offen als
Rücklagen in den neuen Klima- und
transformations vorgesteckt ein
Veranlassungszusammenhang wird nicht
einmal mehr gehorchelt und der hessische
Staatsgerichtshof eben schon zitiert hat
eben ein sehr ähnliches Vorgang der
hessischen Landesregierung für
rechtswidrig erklärt herode sie haben
sehr selektiv zitiert der das Urteil des
hessischen Gerichtshofes ist viel
umfassender als das was sie eben gemacht
haben
der Finanzminister sieht seine Aufgabe
heute ernsthaft als Zitat
ermöglichungsminister Herr Lindner ihre
Aufgabe wäre es alles Mögliche zu tun
und den Steuerzahler vor weiteren
supertollen Zugriffen der rot-grünen
Planwirtschaft und Ideologie Politik zu
schützen nicht etwa diese möglich zu
machen mein letzter Satz die FDP hat
beim Impfzwang und bei der
finanzseriosität vor der Wahl in
zentralen Punkten gelogen das neue Motto
der fdp-schein zu sein lieber
verfassungswidrig und wortbrüchig
regieren als nicht regieren vielen Dank
Peter Böhringer war das für die
afd-fraktion erst der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Sven Christian Kindler
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
bis auf ein paar rechtsradikale
verschwörungsideologen hier im Parlament
kann ja niemand bestreiten dass wir
mitten weit in einer schweren
pandemischen Notlage sind leider leider
ist diese Pandemie noch lange nicht
vorbei wir müssen alles tun um die
Menschen in Deutschland zu schützen
als erstes natürlich durch impfen impfen
impfen das sind besonders bedauerlich
dass anscheinend der bisherige besonders
Gesundheitsminister der alten Regierung
nicht für genug Impfstoff im neuen Jahr
gesorgt hat aber wir wissen auch
mittelfristig ist das der Weg aus der
Krise mit der Fresse ist dass ihr Weg zu
Überwindung der Pandemie alle die
Menschen Deutschland zu impfen aber
kurzfristig reißen wir auf wir brauchen
kontaktbeschränkungen wir brauchen
Untersagung Einschränkungen und regional
lockdowns und wir wissen auch dass
erheblich wirtschaftliche Folgen das
schwächt die Wirtschaft Leistung es ist
eine Belastung für Beschäftigung die
internationalen lieferkettenlauf hat der
Bundesfinanzminister hingewiesen sind
gestört durch die weltweite
corona-pandemie und auch wir haben zu
wenig volkswirtschaftliche Investitionen
in den letzten Jahren in Deutschland
getätigt durch die Pandemie und ihre
Folgen und deswegen hat der Deutsche
Bundestag 2020 und 2021 sammelt der
Bundesregierung erheblich große Summen
an Krediten zu bewältigen dieser
Pandemie bereitgestellt und hat die
außergewöhnliche not nach Artikel 115
hier festgestellt und ich will den mit
einem Missverständnis aufräumen
natürlich waren diese Gelder für die
Stabilisierung des Gesundheitssystems
für Krankenhäuser für Pflegekräfte für
Impfstoffe für Gesundheitsämter sie
waren dafür aber natürlich nicht nur
dafür sie waren natürlich auch für die
Abbildungen der wirtschaftlichen Folgen
der Pandemie für Wirtschaftshilfen für
das Kurzarbeitergeld
sie waren exquisit auf für öffentliche
Investitionen zu Unterstützung der
Wirtschaft zu Stabilisierung der
Volkswirtschaft das war immer die Linie
der Bundesregierung den letzten Jahren
das war die Linie der breiten Mehrheit
des Bundestages in diesem Haus und ich
finde diesen Breiten konnte sollten wir
jetzt nicht aufkündigen diesen Breiten
Konsum jetzt die Union in der Opposition
nicht aufkündigen
denn klar ist doch auch diese großen
ökonomischen Einschnitte die werden
nicht einfach sofort aufhören wenn diese
Pandemie überwunden ist die werden
länger andauern und jeder vernünftige
Ökonomen jede vernünftige Ökonomie wird
ihn bestätigen dass öffentliche
Inquisition denn nachhaltig sind beste
Weg aus dieser Krise ist und deswegen
brauchen wir es eine grundlegende eine
große
investitionsoffensive und die werden wir
in dieser Koalition auf den Weg bringen
deswegen hat die Regierung jetzt einen
zweiten Nachtragshaushalt zum Haus des
Gesetz 2021 auf dem Weg gebracht es
wurde gesagt 60 Milliarden Euro werden
im Energie- und klimafond zugeführt
gleichzeitig wird die Höhe der Kredit
Ermächtigung nicht erhöht die ja noch
die große Koalition und die Union
beschlossen hat und für uns ist klar wir
wollen damit die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
der Pandemie abwehrdern und wir sagen
wenn wir schon investieren da müssen wir
natürlich auch in das neue investieren
in die Zukunft investieren auf den 1,5
Grad Fahrt kommen wir können nicht dann
wieder das alte in das fossile
investieren wir sind eine Koalition die
sehr Zukunft verschrieben hat und
deswegen sagen wir würden sie eine
Politik die auch nach von den Generation
ihr Blick nimmt dass es
generationengerechte Haushaltspolitik
was wir machen das eine smarte
Haushaltspolitik
denn dazu verpflichtet uns auch das
völkerrechtlich verbindliche Pariser
Klimaschutzabkommen und dazu verpflichte
uns auch dass historische und
wegweisende Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
Klimaschutz das nämlich gesagt dass der
Staat eine Schutzpflicht hat für
nachfolgenden Generation der Staat hat
ein verfassungsrechtlich Schutz
Schutzpflicht für unsere Kinder für
unsere Enkel um ihre Freiheitsrechte
auch in der Zukunft zu sichern deswegen
dürfen wir mit konkreten Klimaschutz
Maßnahmen jetzt nicht warten sondern ein
bisschen konkret angehen das ist die
Vorgabe die wir aus Karlsruhe erfüllen
haben und wir legen dafür eine erste
Grundlage mit diesem Nachtragshaushalt
und deswegen ist es jetzt sinnvoll auch
finanzpolitisch zu handeln und nicht
viel später wir haben noch alle gesehen
dass den letzten Jahren die
Naturkatastrophen und klimabedingt
Katastrophen massiv zugenommen haben
weltweit in Deutschland in Europa in
Deutschland haben wir von 2018 bis 2020
drei dürresommer in Folge erlebt mit
erheblichen Schäden für die
Landwirtschaft und unsere Wälder Kollege
Rohde hat auf die schrecklich Tragödien
NRW hingewiesen in den Rheinland-Pfalz
und das hat auch erhebliche Belastung
für die staatlichen Haushalte Bund und
Länder rechnen mit 30 Milliarden Euro
die diese Katastrophe alleine den Staat
kosten wird und das zeigt doch wenn man
Klimaschutz macht dann sagen wir auch
klar das gibt es nicht zum Nulltarif
aber man keinen Klimaschutz macht dann
wird es am Ende richtig richtig teuer
das ist die Lehre die wir hier aufziehen
müssen
und ich bin ehrlich gesagt etwas
verwundert über die Kritik und Empörung
aus der Unionsfraktion
Kollege Rohde hat auf die Debatten zum
zweiten Nachtragshaushalt 2020 im
letzten Jahr schon hingewiesen und der
hochgeschätzte Kollege ehemalige Kollege
Eckhard Rehberg damals Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion für Haushaltspolitik sehr
guter Mann wie Andreas manfell sagt
genau hat damals in der Debatte gesagt
zum Abschluss ist er des zweiten
Nachtragshaushalts 2020 das hat ein
super Ergebnis und er hat in der ersten
Lesung auch hier im Bundestag ausgeführt
dass wir dem nachtragshaus der extrem
viel investiert werden würde er sprach
ich zitiere von Elektromobilität sechs
Milliarden wasserstoffstrategie 9
Milliarden Euro energetische
Gebäudesanierung zwei Milliarden Euro
und er sagte das sind Investitionen in
die Zukunft um aus der Krise
herauszukommen und um Deutschland
zukunftsfähig zu gestalten ich finde der
Kollege Rehberg hatte damals vollständig
recht
er hatte Recht und er bezog sich dabei
auf die Investitionen aus dem Energie-
und klimafond dem berechtigter Weise und
ein Anspruchnahme der corona-bedingten
notfallkredite im zweiten Nachtrag 2020
28 Milliarden Euro zugeführt wurden in
einen Rücklage und das war auch richtig
so wir haben es damals aus der
Opposition als grüne als
verantwortungsvoll Opposition haben wir
es damals begrüßt weil das richtig so
war
und jetzt
und deswegen verstehe ich die Kritik der
Union nicht denn inhaltlich ist dass wir
jetzt machen dass wir damals die große
Koalition 2020 gemacht haben sehr
ähnlich nur es jetzt die Union in der
Opposition und damals war sie in der
Koalition in der Regierung und im klar
zu sagen ich finde das dass sie
einerseits so sagen andererseits so
sagen ich finde das nicht ehrlich das
ist keine redliche Haushaltspolitik das
ist Heuchelei und Doppelmoral
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
halten diesen nachtragsort davon erst
zentralen finanzpolitischen Schritt
dieser neuen Koalition wir zeigen dass
ihr entschlossen handeln dass wir diese
corona-pandemie überwinden wollen und
dass ihr besser aus der Krise
herauskommen dass wir die großen
Aufgaben bei der Transformation und beim
Klimaschutz mit großen Investitionen
angehen ich freue mich auf die Beratung
dazu im weiteren Verlauf im Bundestag
vielen Dank
Sven Christian Kindler war das der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher von Bündnis
90 die Grünen ja es ist die erste Lesung
zu diesem Nachtragsetat der die übrig
gebliebenen 60 Milliarden Kredit
Ermächtigung von der Rekordverschuldung
die eigentlich in diesem Jahr schon
genehmigt war verschieben wollen in den
Energie- und klimafond
speziell genannt haben aber Teile einer
Fraktion und ich bitte darum
an einer angemessene Wortwahl zu denken
und das gilt für alle ich will das noch
mal sagen weil ich das am Anfang meiner
Antrittsrede gesagt habe dass wir hier
alle respektvoll miteinander umgehen
wollen und deshalb will ich das will ich
das noch mal einmal
für alle hier
sagen
und dann fahren wir weiter fort und das
ging damit nicht nur an Sven Christian
Kindler den letzten Rednern sondern an
alle Abgeordneten hier nächste Rednerin
von der Linken Gesine Lötzsch die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
meine Damen und Herren es geht um 60
Milliarden Euro das ist mehr als der
gesamte Verteidigungsetat damit wir
einmal wissen um welche Größenordnung es
geht und diese 60 Milliarden will
Finanzminister Linder der Kontrolle des
Bundestages weitgehend entziehen das ist
ein Angriff auf das Parlament und auf
das Grundgesetz ein denkbar schlechter
Einstieg Herr lindern
in der Opposition hat die FDP ein
solches Vorgehen als verfassungswidrig
gebrandmarkt und auf einmal soll das
alles verfassungskonform sein wir sagen
Ihnen ganz klar nein das ist es nicht
meine Damen und Herren die alte
Bundesregierung war der Auffassung dass
man die Pandemie mit Verordnungen
bekämpfen könne der Bundestag wurde als
Störfaktor ausgeschaltet und wir haben
gesehen wohin das führte mastendealer
schossen die Pilze aus dem Boden und in
der Unionsfraktion konnten wir Anzeichen
von klaren Kriminalität erkennen ich
erinnere nur an den CSU-Abgeordneten
Nüsslein er hat seinen mandatmissbraucht
um dubiose Geschäfte zu machen das ist
nicht vergessen Korruption darf nicht
länger straffrei sein meine Damen und
Herren
Grundrechte einzuschränken und den
Parlament die Kontrollrechte zu
entziehen das ist einer Demokratie
unwürdig wenn Sie mehr Fortschritt wagen
wollen dann geht das nur in Anlehnung an
Willy Brandt mit mehr Demokratie ohne
Demokratie gibt es kein Fortschritt
meine Damen und Herren
240 Milliarden Euro hat der Bundestag
für die Bekämpfung der Pandemie als
kreditermächtigung bewilligt 60
Milliarden wurden nicht ausgegeben warum
nicht fragen wir haben wir etwa genügend
Luftfilter in den Schulen nein haben wir
etwa ausreichend Pflegekräfte nein und
jetzt kommt der Höhepunkt haben wir
ausreichend Impfstoffe auch das nicht
das ist doch nicht zu fassen meine Damen
und Herren in der vergangenen Woche hat
der Bundestag eine einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht beschlossen über eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht wird diskutiert
und Ex-Minister Jens Spahn erklärte
immer wieder es ist ausreichend für alle
da und dann kommt der neue Minister Karl
Lauterbach macht eigenhändig wie wir uns
gestern im Haushaltsausschuss erklärt
hat die Inventur und sagt wir haben zu
wenig es ist doch unglaublich wir sind
voll in der vierten corona-welle und
haben zu wenig Impfstoff das ist eine
große Enttäuschung für uns und für die
Menschen im Land meine Damen und Herren
sie haben viel Geld für die Rettung von
Dax-Konzernen ausgegeben aber sie haben
kein Geld ausgegeben für die Menschen
die sich mit 450 Euro Jobs über Wasser
halten mussten und ohne Kurzarbeitergeld
vor dem nicht stehen und sie haben
nichts unternommen um ausgebildete
Pflegekräfte wieder in den Beruf
zurückzuholen ja das kostet Geld aber
das Geld war auch da die alte Regierung
war unfähig und unwillig dieses Geld
sinnvoll auszugeben und darum wurde sie
auch zu Recht abgewählt aber das
Täuschungsmanöver von Herrn Linden hat
doch nur einen einzigen Grund sie
brauchen dringend und sie wollen nicht
die Steuer für die Vermögenden erhöhen
sie verhalten sich nicht wie ein
Bundesfinanzminister sie verhalten sich
wie ein Vermögensverwalter der
Superreichen und da kann ich nur sagen
die Aufgabe verfehlt meine Damen und
Herren und ich fordere
ich fordere SPD und Grüne ganz deutlich
auf machen Sie dieses Spiel nicht mit
sie hatten in ihren Wahlprogrammen
erklärt sie wollen die Vermögenden
heranziehen zur Finanzierung dieses
Landes und davon dürfen sie sich nicht
verabschieden das ist unser Appell an
Sie meine Damen und Herren
ziehen Sie diesen nach
trags- und über
nehmen Sie Vorschlag wir wollen eine
Vermögensabgabe für das reichste 0,7
Prozent ich wiederhole 0,7 Prozent der
Bevölkerung in diesem Land da hätten wir
hohe Einnahmen das wäre der richtige Weg
das wäre sozial gerecht und nachhaltig
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Otto Fricke Otto Fricke ist der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der
Liberalen
den Kollegen in zwei Minuten habe ich
mir überlegt wie erklärst Du es
eigentlich als Mitglied einer Mitte
gelbkoalition der Opposition rechts
links und naja da müssen wir noch mal
drüber reden
also ich will es einfach machen weil ich
mich mehr an die CDU Wende weil ich da
noch hoffe dass der Verstand noch
zurückkehrt nachdem man eigentlich ja
hier nichts anderes macht als dass man
inneren Stress den man hat versucht
durch einen äußeren Feind zu ersetzen
das wird Ihnen auf Dauer nicht gelingen
versuchen wir es so es gibt kovi das
bekämpfe ich das mache ich mit aktuellen
Mitteln und es gibt longkurve da muss
ich mit mich auch mit beschäftigen und
in der Wirtschaft Liebe CDU nur wie sie
es jetzt wieder getan haben auf
Jährlichkeit zu gucken zu gucken was
mache ich heute und jetzt ist genauso
dumm wie ihr der Ansatz zu sagen ich bin
für null Neuverschuldung das ist wie
wenn Sie übrigens einem Häuslebauer
sagen warte mal bis zu 62 bis un genug
Geld gespart hast und dann fängst du
anzubauen wir schauen auf die nächsten
Jahre mit dem was wir hier mit diesen
Nachtragshaushalt vorlegen und das
bedeutet ganz einfach und verkürzt wir
haben bei dem Thema Investitionen ein
Defizit dieses werden wir in den
nächsten Jahren nachholen dafür nehmen
wir einen Fonds der vom Parlament
begleitet wird wir werden den
Haushaltsberatungen 2022 diesen vor
intensiv beraten und Frau Kollegin muss
eben dann auch als Parlamentarier
intensiv beraten und wie ist der Fondant
zu gestalten so wie das
Verfassungsgericht ist beim Thema
Nachhaltigkeit gesagt hat wir sorgen an
der Stelle dafür dass das was für die
Wirtschaft langfristig notwendig ist und
nicht nur das was kurzfristig nötig ist
erfolgen kann zeigen dass wir diese
Planung machen und geben damit die
Sicherheit die sie in den letzten vier
Jahren als cdu/csu nicht gegeben haben
und zum Schluss noch eine kleine
Anmerkung
weil hier von allen Seiten immer wieder
behauptet wird ja da machen sie neuen
Schulen erstens keine neuen Schulden das
ist der essentielle Unterschied zu dem
was sie als CDU gemacht haben in der
letzten Legislatur zusätzliche Schulden
aufzunehmen zweitens wir werden in der
übernächsten Debatte 350 Milliarden an
Garantien und Krediten streichen das
heißt diese Koalition geht nicht nur hin
sagt das was wir haben nutzen wir wo wir
es brauchen sondern sagt auch da wo es
nicht brauchen streichen wir Kredit
Ermächtigung das ist moderne Politik aus
der Mitte herzlichen Dank
sagt Otto Fricke für die FDP-Fraktion
dass er das naturgemäß anders sieht als
die Union
da gibt es ja die härtesten Angriffe und
die Drohung damit auch nach Karlsruhe zu
gehen und jetzt hören wir aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion noch mal den nächsten
Redner Carsten Körber wird das sein es
Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren am
Sonntag feiern wir den vierten Advent
nächste Woche ist Heiligabend und die
Weihnachtszeit am Jahresende ist doch
für uns alle eine ganz besondere Zeit
Zeit der Ruhe und Zeit der Besinnung und
sie ist auch die Zeit der frohen
Botschaft in der Bibel verkündet ja
Erzengel Gabriel Maria die Geburt Jesu
und da dachte sich jetzt offenbar die
Links gelbe Ampelkoalition wir haben
doch jetzt auch eine frohe Botschaft und
diese Botschaft lautet geld spielt keine
Rolle und der Zweck heiligt die Mittel
sehr geehrter Herr Finanzminister lieber
Herr Lindner ich muss mich doch schon
sehr wundern denn ich wie auch viele
meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
haben noch sehr gut im Ohr wie sie und
ihre Kollegen von der FDP in denen
vergangenen Jahren die Haushaltspolitik
der großen Koalition gegeilt haben als
es darum ging diesem Land und seinen
Menschen durch die corona-pandemie zu
helfen und die corona-pandemie hat uns
seit anfang vergangenen Jahres fest im
Griff und vor ungeahnte
Herausforderungen gestellt und diese
Herausforderungen waren genauso wie die
Maßnahmen sie zu bekämpfen wahrhaft
historisch aber ausschließlich die
corona-pandemie war die Ursache für die
nachtragshaushalte in den vergangenen
beiden Jahren und dieses und nichts
anderes war für uns als Union die
Begründung von der schwarzen Null
abzuweichen
und die vergangene große Koalition hat
gehandelt wie sie damals handeln musste
und wir haben für 2021 eine
Nettokreditaufnahme von bis zu 240
Milliarden Euro beschlossen aber das
sehr geehrter Herr Finanzminister das
was sie jetzt Vorhaben das ist ein
haushaltspolitischer Sündenfall und das
direkt in Woche 2 ihrer Regierungszeit
was haben sie vor
sie wollen 60 Milliarden Euro in den
Energie-
im vergangenen Jahr 2020 lag der Rahmen
der corona-bedingten Nettokreditaufnahme
bei bis zu 217 Milliarden Euro
130 Milliarden wurden im vergangenen
Jahr zur Bekämpfung der corona-pandemie
tatsächlich ein Anspruch genommen
immerhin 87 milliarden wurden nicht in
Anspruch genommen in diesem Jahr haben
wir eine Nettokreditaufnahme von bis zu
240 Milliarden Euro natürlich eine
Nettokreditaufnahme von historischem
Ausmaß bisher wurden in diesem Jahr
allerdings davon 180 Milliarden in
Anspruch genommen und die wurden
zielgerichtet in diesem Jahr zu
pandemiebekämpfung eingesetzt ganz so
wie es Artikel 115 Grundgesetz mit der
Ausnahme von der Schuldenregel
vorschreibt aber da bleiben doch noch 60
Milliarden offen diese werden aktuell
nicht für Corona benötigt eine seriöse
Regierung würde jetzt diese 60
Milliarden nicht in Anspruch nehmen 60
Milliarden die von unseren Kindern und
Enkel in der Zukunft nicht zurückgezahlt
werden müssen das aber sehr geehrter
Herr Finanzminister ficht sie offenbar
nicht an sie wollen diese 60 Milliarden
Schulden trotzdem aufnehmen schlimmer
noch sie wollen diese zweckgebundenen
Mittel Umwelt nennen Klimaschutz ist
ihre Begründung klingt ja total gut aber
am Ende des Tages heiligt der Zweck eben
doch nicht die Mittel sie wollen
sie wollen
letztlich Geld für die Zukunft Bunkern
sie wollen dafür eine
haushaltsrücklage über Kredite
finanzieren und verletzen damit erstens
das haushaltsgebot der Jährlichkeit weil
sie erst frühestens ab 2023 an diese
Mittel dran wollen und mit der Umwidmung
zum Klimaschutz verletzen sie zweitens
zu dem Artikel 115 Grundgesetz da die
Ausnahme von der Schuldenregel
ausschließlich mit der Pandemie
begründet wurde und
und diese Begründung
diese Begründung lassen sie jetzt fallen
und versuchen den Klimawandel generell
als außergewöhnliche Notsituation zu
definieren damit versetzen Sie sehr
geehrter Herr Finanzminister der sie
doch immer eigentlich Fan der
Schuldenbremse waren der Schuldenbremse
den Todesstoß und drittens sie verletzen
mit ihrem Tun auch das
Wirtschaftlichkeitsgebot für Geld das
nicht gebraucht wird dürfen keine
Kredite in Anspruch genommen werden
gegen all diese Regeln verstoßen sie in
dann fragt man sich warum tun sie das
ganz einfach sie haben zu vielen zu
vieles versprochen und das fällt Ihnen
jetzt auf die Füße deshalb kommen sie
jetzt mit einem rechtlich höchst
zweifelhaften Konstrukt eines kann ich
Ihnen sagen die Union wird Ihnen diesen
Nachtragshaushalt so nicht durchgehen
lassen wir werden uns in Karlsruhe
Wiedersehen sehr geehrter Herr Lindner
das das was sie hier abliefern das ist
kein Signal ihrer Handlungsfähigkeit und
auch kein Ausdruck von gestaltungswellen
das ist ein haushaltspolitisches
Armutszeugnis ein Armutszeugnis dass man
von einem aufrechten Liberalen so nicht
erwartet hätte vielen Dank
Carsten Körber für die CDU CSU-Fraktion
der sich ebenfalls am
Bundesfinanzminister abgearbeitet hat
vor allem von den Liberalen hätte man
das so nicht erwartet der
Bundesfinanzminister hat übrigens ja zum
Auftakt dieser Debatte aber auch gerade
in Richtung der cdu/cs Fraktion gesagt
das ist die Zusage gibt dass die Mittel
des Fonds zielgerichtet eingesetzt
werden also nicht für irgendwas was die
Ampel plant sondern eben für
Investitionen in Klimaschutz
und liebe Kollegen
ich habe hier schon ein bisschen ein
Dejavue wenn ich so an die Debatten der
letzten Jahre denke und denke mir so als
Sozialdemokratin wir sind wahrscheinlich
diejenigen die noch am ehesten nicht mit
ihren Zitaten aus der Debatte das
Nachtragshaushalt des 2020 konfrontiert
werden können denn wir fanden es damals
richtig was wir gemeinsam in der großen
Koalition auf Vorschlag von unserem
Finanzminister Olaf Scholz gemacht haben
indem wir nämlich 28 Milliarden Euro mit
dem zweiten Nachtragshaushalt für
Zukunftsinvestitionen in den EKF
verbracht haben übrigens mit der
Zustimmung und dem Beifall der
cdu/csu-fraktion und den Protest der FDP
ja das ist richtig aber heute ist das
Instrument und zwar eigentlich exakt das
gleiche instrument was wir damals
angewandt haben natürlich immer noch
richtig und es ist auch
verfassungskonferenz
und
darum möchte ich kurz zitieren ich würde
gerne mehr zitieren das lässt meine
Redezeit nicht zu aber es lohnt sich für
Sie alle das nachzulesen der
Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages
hat sich nämlich damals mit diesem
Haushalt ausführlich beschäftigt und ich
möchte nur aus der Zusammenfassung der
vielen Seiten folgendes vorlesen mit der
letzten Zielsetzung
längerfristig verbundene nachhaltige
wirtschaftseffekte tragen dazu bei zu im
Interesse zukünftiger Generation
aktiv zu werden und vor diesem
Hintergrund und in Anbetracht der
Unsicherheiten hinsichtlich der
krisendauer erscheinen die Maßnahmen
geeignet und darum erforderlich
lesen Sie das bitte gerne alles noch mal
ausführlich nach weil dazu werden wir
noch Gelegenheit haben und darum möchte
ich sagen es ist hier schon gesprochen
worden von den Brücken die in die
Zukunft führen sollen das ist darum
wichtig ist auch die Zielsetzungen von
Maßnahmen nach zu justieren und nach zu
schärfen und nichts anderes tun wir und
wir tun vor allen Dingen das dass wir
nämlich die Milliarden die wir für
Investitionen zu über der Windel zu
Überwindung der Krise bereitgestellt
haben auch wirklich für die Zukunft
weiter einsetzbar halten und das liebe
Kolleginnen und liebe Kollegen von der
Union ist doch etwas was uns auch in der
Vergangenheit gemeinsam getragen hat und
es sei mir der Hinweis gestattet wir
haben es nicht nur hier im Deutschen
Bundestag getan mit dem zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt 2020 wir haben es auch
auf europäischer Ebene getan und wir
haben es übrigens auch schon in der
großen Koalition in der Finanz- und
Wirtschaftskrise getan das probate
Mittel und unser gemeinsamer Geist war
immer davon getragen dass man in die
Krise nicht hinein sparen darf sondern
dass man sie überwinden muss im Sinne
der Menschen im Sinne der Menschen die
beschäftigt sind die bleiben müssen
im Sinne der Unternehmen die die
Prosperität in unserem Land erzeugen im
Sinne auch unsere europäischen Nachbarn
da steht von Europa habe ich schon
genannt weil nur wenn es unseren
europäischen Nachbarn gut geht können
Sie bei uns einkaufen und wir sind eine
Exportnation und wir leben davon dass es
uns allen in Europa gut geht und darum
haben wir in der letzten großen
Koalition gemeinsam mit Angela Merkel
gemeinsam mit Ursula von der Leyen 750
Milliarden Euro verfügbar gemacht in
Europa ein eigenmittelbeschluss hier im
Deutschen Bundestag herbeigeführt warum
denn um die Krise in ganz Europa zu
bekämpfen und dazu gehört eben nicht nur
dass man die Krankenhäuser stabilisiert
dass man Impfstoffe einkauft Masken und
so weiter mehr dazu gehört auch dass man
die Menschen in Beschäftigung hält dass
man Massenarbeitslosigkeit vermeidet
dass man dafür sorgt dass es den
Familien das ist den Kindern gut geht
das in die Schulen in die Kitas
investiert werden kann und all das
ermöglichen wir in Deutschland und in
Europa und liebe Kollegen von der
cdu/csu das war letztes Jahr richtig und
es bleibt auch in diesem Jahr richtig
und weil das so ist
und weil ich
weil ich ganz viele von ihnen aus der
Zusammenarbeit gut kenne und sehr
schätze würde ich mir wünschen dass sie
ihre neue Oppositionsrolle wirklich an
der Stelle einsetzen wo es möglich
erforderlich ist wir leben hier vom
Streit im Deutschen Bundestag aber das
was sie hier machen es ist im höchsten
Maße inkonsequent und damit
unglaubwürdig und es schadet unseren
Ansehen als Politik insgesamt und darum
bitte ich Sie überdenken Sie das doch
noch mal der Breite Konsens den wir hier
in diesem Haus entwickelt haben zur
Überwindung der Krise im Deutschen
Bundestag und in Europa insgesamt der
ist richtig der bleibt richtig und dass
die Grundlage dafür dass die Menschen
uns vertrauen und dass sie der
Demokratie Vertrauen das gemeinsam zu
stärken darum geht es auch und weil das
so ist bedanke ich mich für den guten
Entwurf empfehle Ihnen zur Zustimmung im
Januar so lange können wir debattieren
wir machen noch eine Anhörung hat der
Haushaltsausschuss gestern beschlossen
wir nehmen Ihre Bedenken ernst aber
bitte erinnern Sie sich an das was sie
noch im letzten Jahr für richtig
gehalten haben es war richtig vielen
Dank
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat der Abgeordnete Helge braun das Wort
zu einer Kurzintervention hegebrauen ist
der neue Vorsitzende des Finanz des
Haushaltsausschusses natürlich Frau
Kollegin Hagedorn sie haben gesagt wir
werden inkonsequent und unglaubwürdig in
unserer Position aber deshalb möchte ich
Sie fragen ob sie nicht folgendes auch
einmal überdenken wollen wenn das was
hier geschieht 60 Milliarden Euro werden
in die Zukunft verschoben an Schulden
und werden für wie sie gesagt haben
Brücken in die Zukunft verwendet und
damit wenn wir das in Zukunft zum
Standard unserer Haushaltspolitik machen
haben wir der Höhe nach keine Begrenzung
der Ausgaben finanzierten Schulden in
den nächsten Jahren und das ist das
exakte Gegenteil von dem was die
Schuldenbremse vorsieht und deshalb will
ich auch bei der Bundesfinanzminister so
auf die freundschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
im Haushaltsausschuss hingewiesen hat
auf die freue ich mich auch aber ich
bitte auch um eins mich nicht dafür was
sie hier machen in die Mithaftung zu
nehmen weil erstens das was ich im
Januar gefordert habe war das was die
FDP massiv bekämpft hat also dass sie
eine 180 Grad Wände machen das ist schon
mal sehr sehr eindeutig das zweite das
was ich damals gesagt habe war sehr klar
wir brauchen wir waren damals in einer
finanziell schwierigen Lage in Corona
und wenn wir dauerhaft die
Schuldenbremse nicht einhalten müssen
brauchen wir dafür eine gesetzliche
Grundlage im Juni hat der Stabilitätsrat
aber sehr deutlich gesagt wir können im
Jahr 2023 die Schuldenbremse wieder
einhalten damit ist das obsolet und
deshalb will ich hier nur noch mal sagen
anders als Sie sich das wünschen liebe
Frau Hagedorn wir werden und auch ich
persönlich werde dem Vorgehen was sicher
haben nicht die Hand reichen das ist die
Axt an der Schuldenbremse
[Musik]
Frau Hagedorn möchten Sie antworten
bitte
lieber Kollege braun dieser
Nachtragshaushalt ist nicht die Axt an
der Schuldenbremse und ich habe im
Übrigen in meinem Redebeitrag auch gar
nicht auf sie abgezielt und ihre
Äußerung das waren andere Kollegen hier
in der Debatte aber fakt ist doch dass
sie im letzten Jahr mit ihren
Bemerkungen nicht etwa von uns oder
anderen sondern von der eigenen Partei
in der eigenen Fraktion gestoppt worden
sind die ein lautes Nachdenken über die
Schuldenbremse nicht haben wollte
in unseren Koalitionsvertrag haben wir
uns alle gemeinsam darauf verpflichtet
die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten und das
ist auch gut so weil wir doch gerade
erleben dass die Schuldenbremse so wie
sie im Grundgesetz steht eben auch in
einer Krise die finanziellen Spielräume
ermöglicht die erforderlich sind um
diese Krise zu bekämpfen wer mit der
Zustimmung des Deutschen Bundestages
haben wir doch diese Krise von
nationaler Tragweite ausgerufen und
damit Spielräume im Haushalt die
sinnvoll sind und darum muss die darum
muss die Schuldenbremse auch nicht im
Grundgesetz verändert werden wir wollen
sie einhalten weil wir davon ausgehen
dass wir die Konsequenzen aus der
Pandemie ab 2023 so weit im Griff haben
dass man das bewältigen kann ohne in die
Krise rein zu sparen das glauben wir und
dafür ist das was wir jetzt machen ein
probates Mittel dass wir in der großen
Koalition auch auch schon erprobt haben
indem wir 28 Milliarden Euro in den EKF
geschickt haben und das ist richtig ich
habe auf den Wissenschaftlichen Dienst
verwiesen weil es zulässig ist nicht nur
medizinische Maßnahmen zu ergreifen mit
diesen Mitteln sondern sehr wohl auch in
die Stabilität der Gesellschaft und vor
allen Dingen der Wirtschaft zu
investieren und das war damals wichtig
und das bleibt richtig
und darum und darum und nur das habe ich
gemeint ich habe die Zusammenarbeit mit
Ihnen immer geschätzt mit ihnen allen
und darum würde ich auch gerne weiter
auf diese Art und Weise mit Ihnen
zusammenarbeiten auch die Grünen und wir
Sozialdemokraten haben damals in der
Griechenland Krise ich möchte daran
erinnern als Opposition sind wir nicht
der Versuchung erlegen einfach dagegen
zu sein sondern wir haben sie
unterstützt obwohl wir viele Maßnahmen
im beteilig richtig fanden damals und
daran appelliere ich nur daran weil das
was damals richtig war dem mich vor
einem Jahr das bleibt jetzt auch richtig
und es ist die Grundlage für diesen
Nachtragshaushalt vielen Dank ja ob
diese Appelle von Bettina Hagedorn hier
bei der Union ankommen das wird man dann
im nächsten Jahr sehen abgestimmt wird
heute über diesen Nachtragshaushalt noch
nicht der ja keine neuen Schulden
aufnimmt sondern alte verschiebt
sozusagen sondern erst im Januar aber
wichtig war in diesem Jahr noch die
Zuleitung zu machen deswegen hat die
Ampel hier diesen Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt Sebastian Schäfer alles für
die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren als Bund nehmen
wir in diesem Jahr Kredite in Höhne von
bis zu 240 Milliarden Euro auf
das ist ungefähr die Hälfte der
Wirtschaftsleistung von
Baden-Württemberg das ist eine gewaltige
Summe
der geltende Bundeshaushalt wurde noch
von der großen Koalition beschlossen und
nicht von unserer fortschrittskoalition
und dennoch kann ich sagen der Beschluss
dieser Rekordverschuldung ist auch in
der großen Koalition nicht leichtfertig
erfolgt
Frau Bundeskanzlerin Dr Merkel hat im
Zusammenhang mit der corona-pandemie von
der größten Krise in unserem Land seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gesprochen und
leider müssen wir in diesen Tagen
feststellen dass die Krise nicht nur
nach wie vor anhält sondern sich noch
einmal verschärft hat mit extremen
Belastungen unsere Pfleger und Ärztinnen
in den Kliniken und einer furchtbar
hohen Zahl von Menschen die jeden Tag an
und mit Corona versterben
auch unsere Wirtschaft ist weiterhin
schwer von der Krise betroffen
wir alle hier
außer die die Krise lieben hätten uns
seine V-förmige Erholung der Wirtschaft
gewünscht aber das tritt leider nicht so
ein gerade haben das Münchner
Ifo-Institut und das Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung in Halle ihre
Wachstumsprognosen für 2022 teils
deutlich nach unten korrigiert es
besteht also weiterhin die Notwendigkeit
die wirtschaftliche Erholung mit
staatlichen Investitionen zu
stabilisieren
wenn unser Land ökonomisch stabil ist
Frau Hagedorn hat gesagt profitieren
davon auch unsere europäischen Nachbarn
mit denen wir wirtschaftlich so eng
verflochten sind wir tragen auch dafür
Verantwortung und jenseits aller
notwendigen Solidarität wir haben auch
was davon
mit dem Klima und transformationsfonds
und mit diesem Nachtragshaushalt geben
wir die richtige Antwort auf die
wirtschaftliche Herausforderung der
Pandemie damit können die Investitionen
umgesetzt werden und private
Investitionen weiter angereizt werden
die ausgeblieben sind in der Pandemie
wir müssen dem Geld eine neue Richtung
geben die Transformation unsere gesamten
Wirtschaft zur Klimaneutralität die
dekarbonisierung insbesondere der
Industrie das ist eine gigantische
Herausforderung
ich vertrete den Wahlkreis Esslingen im
Deutschen Bundestag wir haben einen
hohen Anteil an industrieller
Wertschöpfung mit vielen gut bezahlten
Arbeitsplätzen das ist bei vielen von
ihnen hier ähnlich nicht nur in
Baden-Württemberg und wir brauchen diese
gut bezahlten Arbeitsplätze diese
industrielle Wertschöpfung die wir in
Deutschland haben auch in Zukunft dafür
nehmen wir jetzt Geld in die Hand um die
corona-pandemie wirtschaftlich schnell
zu überwinden und diese notwendige
Transformation zu einem Erfolg zu machen
für unser Land
wir gehen aber nicht nur den
investitionsrückstand in der
Ampelkoalition an wir schaffen mit einem
modernen Einwanderungsgesetz auch die
Grundlage mit der zunehmenden
schwierigeren demografischen
Entwicklungen in unserem Land umzugehen
mit dem Spurwechsel nutzen wir die
Potenziale die jetzt schon in unserem
Land vorhanden sind statt diese
weiterbrach liegen zu lassen
wir haben viel nachzuholen viel zu viel
ist liegengeblieben in diesen letzten
Jahren trotz guter Steuereinnahmen und
immer niedrigere Zinsbelastungen für die
öffentlichen Haushalte dafür schaffen
wir jetzt die Grundlage mit dem
vorliegenden Nachtragshaushalt und dann
im neuen Jahr mit dem regulären
Bundeshaushalt 2022 wir gehen sorgsam
mit den öffentlichen Mitteln um in
dieser Koalition auch das verbindet uns
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank das war übrigens zeitlich
eine Punktlandung herzlichen Glückwunsch
dazu
und das bei der ersten Rede da gibt es
doch nochmal ein besonderes Lob von der
Präsidentin Florian Rosner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der neue
fdp-finanzminister heute
erstaunlich zurückhaltend in seiner Rede
zum Nachtragshaushalt offensichtlich
sind sie selbst nicht derart überzeugt
für im ersten Meisterstück ist offenbar
ein großer faner des Schriftstellers
marketway nach dem Motto von jetzt an
werde ich nur so viel ausgeben wie ich
einnehme selbst wenn ich mir dafür
geldborge anders kann ich mir nämlich
nicht erklären wie das Versprechen der
soliden Finanzen des Ministers keine
Woche nach Amtsantritt gehalten hat
nochmals 60 Milliarden Euro für die
Finanzierung nebulöser Projekte
abzuzweigen ist einfach inakzeptabel und
verfassungsrechtlich mehr als bedenklich
in diesem in diesem Jahr wurde wegen der
Pandemie eine gigantische 240 Milliarden
Euro Kreditlinie aufgenommen eine
unvorstellbare Summe hiervon wurden Gott
sei Dank Gott sei Dank rund 60
Milliarden Euro nicht benötigt was
grundsätzlich positiv ist also statt 240
Milliarden Euro zusatzschulden nur in
Anführungszeichen
180 Milliarden Euro zusätzliche
Belastungen für die deutsche Bevölkerung
so würde man als Normalsterblicher
denken aber nein nicht so in der
finanzierungslogik der Ampelkoalition
die neue Bundesregierung als SPD Grüne
und FDP plant nun stattdessen diese
Mittel dem sogenannten Energie- und
klimafond gut zu schreiben man kann sich
durchaus fragen was der frisch gewählte
Finanzminister dazu noch vor ein paar
Wochen gesagt hätte wäre jetzt nicht
selbst an der Regierung beteiligt auch
ganz nach dem neuen
fDP-Fraktionschef dürr Karriere kann man
nur machen wenn man Verfassungs ihr
Haushalte vorliegt damals galt es noch
für die SPD jetzt gilt es für die FDP
ist das was sie hier machen der Lindner
in der Tat ihr Verständnis vom richtig
regierende FDP für uns als cdu/cs zu
Fraktion hat dies jedenfalls nichts mit
seriösen Wirtschaften zu tun
auch die Begründung der links gelben
Koalition für diesen zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt ist mehr als
fragwürdig denn wenn die Mittel nun für
klimainvestitionen in den kommenden
Jahren genutzt werden fehlt der Bezug
zur Pandemie Notlage mit der Aussetzung
der Schuldenbremse gemäß Artikel 115 ja
ursprünglich begründet war im Falle von
Naturkatastrophen steht da und
außergewöhnlichen Notsituationen die
sich der Kontrolle des Staates entziehen
und die staatliche Finanzlage erheblich
beeinträchtigen können diese
kreditobergrenzen aufgrund des
Beschlusses der Mehrheit der Mitglieder
des Bundestages überschritten werden
klarer Fall nun waren aber die Mittel
ausreichend für dieses Jahr ist besteht
überhaupt kein Grund nun zusätzliche
Geldmittel in einem Fonds zu parken es
sei denn man möchte diese Gelder
überhaupt nicht für
katastrophenbedingte Ausgaben verwenden
und da bin ich schon froh dass auch
mittlerweile der Bundesminister Habig
für den ja dieses große Geschenk
mittlerweile da ist die erste halbe
Stunde hat er die Debatte bei gewohnt
ich denke Liebe Ampel diese
buchungstricks können und dürfen wir
Ihnen als cdu/cs
würde man nun der Argumentation der
Ampelkoalition Folgen hätten wir
aufgrund des Klimawandels und der
notwendigen Transformation der
Wirtschaft eine permanent
außergewöhnliche Notsituation die eine
über die 0,35 Prozent Regeln
hinausgehende Neuverschuldung im
Bundeshaushalt der möglichen würde dies
hätte eine dauerhafte Aussetzung der
Schuldenbremse zur Folge ja sogar die
komplette Auflösung dieser
Schuldengrenze ein Schelm wer böses
dabei denkt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
in der Klimapolitik dringt Rot-Grün Geld
darauf auf völlig zu Recht die Belange
der nächsten Generation zu
berücksichtigen in der Haushaltspolitik
scheint der neuen Bundesregierung die
Generationengerechtigkeit jedoch absolut
egal zu sein wie passt das zusammen die
FAZ kommentierte aus meiner Sicht sehr
zutreffend den Nachtragshaushalt am
letzten Freitag wie folgt in normalen
Jahren erlaubt die Schuldenregel eine
Neuverschuldung von etwa 12 Milliarden
Euro das zeigt es geht hier jetzt nicht
nur um einen Schluck aus der Pulle
sondern um das leer saufen gleich
mehrerer Kanister Zitat Ende
es ist und bleibt falsch weshalb wir als
Union diesen völlig unnötigen
Nachtragshaushalt ablehnen und auch eine
gerichtliche Überprüfung durchführen
alles andere wäre auch völlig
unverantwortlich
der der hessische Staatsgerichtshof
heute schon mehrfach zitiert hat in
einem ähnlichen Fall ja dazu bereits
entschieden dass kreditfinanzierte
Maßnahmen zur Krisenbewältigung nicht
nur geeignet erforderlich und angemessen
sondern auch final auf die Beseitigung
der Notsituation gerichtet sein müssen
für Herren des aus meiner Sicht auch die
Signalwirkung an unsere europäische
Familie wie sollen wir unsere
Europartner von einer soliden
Haushaltsführung überzeugen um den Euro
stabil zu halten falls wir selbst die
größten Sünder sind als stärkste
Volkswirtschaft Europas haben wir nicht
nur das meiste Risiko zu tragen sondern
auch unmissverständliche Vorbildfunktion
zu erfüllen meine lieben Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
das alles ihres nicht gegeben und weit
entfernt von dem was man als nachhaltige
Haushaltspolitik bezeichnen kann zumal
ab dem Jahr 2026 die pandemieschulden
getilgt werden und ein deutlich
geringerer Handlungsspielraum für
zukünftige Investitionen besteht deshalb
abschließend auf Schuldenbergen kann man
keine Zukunft bauen diese bilden eben
kein dauerhaft festes Fundament
herzlichst Vergelts Gott fürs zuhören
florian ausner war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion jetzt hören wir noch
einen Redner in dieser Debatte zum
zweiten Nachtragshaushalt der kommt von
den Sozialdemokraten Andreas Schwarz
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren an den
Fernsehbildschirm Max Frisch hat mal
gesagt chris ist ein produktiver Zustand
man muss ihm nur den ballgeschmack der
Katastrophe nehmen ja wir sind in einem
starken Land mit einem starken Staat wir
haben kreative Unternehmen und wir haben
fleißige Menschen die hier arbeiten ja
und dieses Land war wahrlich gefordert
in den letzten zwei Jahren und wir waren
noch produktiv und ich werde Ihnen auch
sagen warum fangen wir bei den Menschen
an die mussten ihr Leben ändern und sie
haben das angenommen von maskenpflicht
abstandspflichten und und und und wir
haben in einer Rekordzeit einen
Impfstoff entwickelt das zeigt die
klugen Köpfe in unserem Land wir haben
fest und Impfzentren im Betrieb genommen
unser Krankensystem wurde hochgefahren
um mit den Problemen fertig zu werden es
wurden finanzielle Hilfen schnell
organisiert um Arbeitsmarkt und
Wirtschaft zu stabilisieren ja und
zwischendurch war noch nur ein paar
kleine und große Wahlen in dem Land das
heißt es musste sich eine neue Regierung
finden und bilden dass es auch schnell
passiert sie kam auch zügig in den
Arbeitsmodus und liegt auch hier ganz
schnell Gesetze vor wir haben einen
gestaltungs-fortschrittswellen wir haben
am Ende auch sehr viel Verantwortung zu
tragen meine Damen und Herren trotz der
Pandemie die uns sicherlich viel
abverlangt hat wird mit Sicherheit auch
feststehen die wird auch noch ein
bisschen dauern und wir müssen
Gesundheit Gesellschaft Wirtschaft
weiter stabilisieren während Karl
Lauterbach gerade ausreichend Impfstoff
für die Menschen im Land organisiert
kümmert sich unser Finanzminister um die
notwendige finanzielle boosterimpfung
für unsere Wirtschaft Liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen gerade weil die Situation
so ist wie sie ist müssen wir die
wirtschaftlichen Auswirkungen weiterhin
genau im Auge behalten und alles dafür
tun die deutsche Volkswirtschaft wieder
auf einen langfristigen nachhaltigen
Wachstumspfad zu führen das schafft
Generationengerechtigkeit weil wir in
die Zukunft investieren und die Zukunft
im Blick haben dafür benötigen wir hier
mit dem vorgelegten zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt diese 60 Milliarden
Euro die wir in den Energie-
gerade nicht ausgeben konnten und Liebe
ehemaligen Koalitionspartner der Union
das haben wir im letzten Jahr ja auch
schon erfolgreich mit 26 Milliarden Euro
getan und ich bin mir sicher dass das
auch mit unserer Verfassung konform geht
warum diesen Optimismus liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
ziel ist es wir wollen nachhaltig aus
der Krise kommen um Fortschritt für
dieses Land zu organisieren man spart
nicht in die Krise weil das kostet uns
und unseren nachfolgenden Generationen
Zukunft es geht um Digitalisierung
Transformation und Klimaschutz und über
das entscheiden wir hier in diesem
Parlament ja gemeinsam wie Geld wann wo
ausgegeben wird also keine Angst und
gerade Klimaschutzmaßnahmen sind von
besonderer Bedeutung ich erinnere hier
an die Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dass uns
einiges an Hausaufgaben ja
aufgegeben hat um unser Land
zukunftsfähig zu machen Arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und die Menschen in diese neue
Zeit zu begleiten sie merken liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es geht um
Investitionen die über das normale Maß
eines Bundeshaushalts hinausgehen neben
der Pandemie geht es um Transformation
und Wachstum in diesem Land und ist
gleichzeitig und erschwerten
konjunkturellen Bedingungen wir werden
die öffentlichen Investitionen
Investitionen verstärken und durch eine
weitere Steigerung auch private
Investitionen nachhaltig anstoßen das
schafft Anreize und es schafft vorne
auch Planungssicherheit für die Menschen
in diesem Land aber für die Unternehmen
in diesem Land dies ist eines wichtige
Signalwirkung und setzt klare Impulse
die notwendig sind für unsere Wirtschaft
letztendlich ist es nicht nur eine
deutliche Weiterführung unserer
Hilfsmaßnahmen zu Überwindung der
Pandemie sondern es ist auch ein
sichtbarer Einstieg zur nachhaltigen
Finanzierung zu Überwindung der
Klimakrise das sichert nicht nur
vorhandene Arbeitsplätze sondern soll
auch für weitere
Beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten und vor
allen Dingen für starke Impulse für
unsere Wirtschaft ich nenne das
Krisenbewältigung erster Klasse die wir
hier bei vornehmen meine Damen und
Herren sie sehen wir leisten uns mit
unserer Finanzpolitik weiterhin einen
starken und einen Beitrag damit er
soziale und der wirtschaftliche Frieden
in diesem Land und auch der Erfolg in
diesem Land gesichert wird zum Abschluss
meine Damen und Herren mit diesen
nachtrag zum Bundeshaushalt setzen wir
klare Impulse für das Land wir bleibt
insofern nur kurz zum Beginn meiner Rede
zurückzukommen und meine tiefste
Überzeugung kund zu tun Krise ist
durchaus ein produktiver Zustand und ich
ergänze mit den Worten Helmut Schmitz in
der Krise bewahrt sich der wahre
Charakter und dieses Land hat Charakter
in diesem Sinne danke und ich freue mich
auf die weiteren Beratungen
sagt Andreas Schwarz und diese weiteren
Beratungen zum Gesetzentwurf zum zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt wird es geben unter
anderem im Haushaltsausschuss denn der
Gesetzentwurf wird an diesem letzten
Sitzungstag des Bundestages in dieser in
diesem Jahr
dann dort fortgesetzt werden die
Beratung und dann im nächsten Jahr wird
das Ganze abgestimmt die Zuführung noch
in diesem Jahr zu machen diese 60
Milliarden sozusagen schon auf den Weg
zu bringen damit diese
kreditermächtigung nicht verfallen das
gelte war schon mal genehmigt vom
Bundestag nämlich dem vorherigen
Finanzminister diese 60 Milliarden
Kredit Ermächtigungen sind übrig
geblieben und ja was man jetzt damit
macht das ist hier auf sehr
unterschiedliche Resonanz gestoßen das
hatte sich im Vorfeld ja auch schon
angedeutet also die
ampelkoalitionäre und die Opposition
kommen in diesem Punkt nicht zusammen
ein Booster für die Volkswirtschaft sagt
beispielsweise der Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner dazu das Geld in den
Energie und klimafond zu überführen und
dann für Investitionen zweckgebunden zu
nutzen und die
Opposition die Unionsfraktion ganz
vorneweg zweifelt an dass das
verfassungsgemäß ist und wirft hier
haushaltstricks dem Bundesfinanzminister
und der Ampelkoalition vor und da werden
wir mal sehen wie das nächstes Jahr
weitergeht ob die Union dann wie
angekündigt wirklich nach Karlsruhe geht
und vom Bundesverfassungsgericht dagegen
klagen wird es kommen wir zum nächsten
Thema ein ganz anderes Thema was ist
aufgerufen wird es geht um
Menschenrechte und um Religionsfreiheit
der erste Redner Michael Brandt von der
cdu/csu-fraktion und Kollegen wir sind
froh dass wir heute gleich zu Beginn der
neuen Wahlperiode über ein Thema
sprechen das eine weitreichende
Bedeutung für das Verhältnis dieses
Hohen Hauses und auch der neuen
Koalition zum Thema Grundrechte und
Menschenrechte hat wir sind deshalb froh
weil wir hier alle sicher übereinstimmen
dass die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
gerade auch vor dem Hintergrund unserer
Geschichte
Menschenrechte aus gutem Grund zu einem
Teil unserer Staats-
wenn wir heute über die Fortführung
einer jungen aber sehr wirkungsvollen
Institution sprechen nämlich das
Regierungsbeauftragten für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit dann reden wir über
einen wichtigen deutschen Beitrag zum
globalen Monitoring zum aktiven tun und
über einen globalen Beitrag für
Gewissensfreiheit und Glaubensfreiheit
als einem ganz wichtigen Indikator für
die Freiheit und Toleranz von
Gesellschaften 80 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung rechnen sich einer
Religion zu bittere Realität ist dort wo
Religionsfreiheit aus welchen Gründen
auch immer eingeschränkt wird dort
werden in den allermeisten Fällen
regelmäßig auch wesentliche
grundfreiheits- und Menschenrechte
eingeschränkt und deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist es gerade
für ein Land wie Deutschland mit seiner
international anerkannten Position ein
Beitrag zur Religionsfreiheit und zur
weltanschaulichen Freiheit insgesamt so
wertvoll und deshalb ist es wichtig
diese wichtige Situationen der
Bundesregierung inklusive der Berichte
an den Deutschen Bundestag weiter
vorzusetzen und auch auf Dauer
beizubehalten
und wir haben nicht nur als große
Koalition dieses Amt mit guten Gründen
eingerichtet wir haben dafür auch eine
Person gefunden die dieses Amt nach
allgemeiner Einschätzung mit großer
Gewissenhaftigkeit mit großem Einsatz
und auch mit notwendigem Feingefühl
ausgefüllt hat ich glaube ich darf hier
im Namen des gesamten Hauses sprechen
wenn ich unserem Kollegen Markus grübel
hier einmal ganz herzlich dafür danke
mit wie viel Engagement und auch
Empathie er diese Verantwortung
übernommen und auch ausgefüllt hat
vielen Dank lieber Markus
an die neue Koalition und an ihre
stärkste Fraktion die SPD möchte ich
ausdrücklich den Appell und die
Forderungen richten die von uns
gemeinsam 2018 erfolgte Einrichtung
eines religionsbeauftragten nach diesen
Fortschritten und Erfolgen zu wahren ihm
die dauerhafte Verankerung zu geben die
dieses Amt mit all seinem Potenzial für
die Menschenrechte verdient die neue
Bundesregierung wird unter Beweis
stellen müssen wie wichtig ihr
Menschenrechte tatsächlich sind das
zentrale Menschenrecht auf
Religionsfreiheit findet sich im neuen
Koalitionsvertrag nicht ein einziges Mal
im Gegensatz zur Vereinbarung von vor
vier Jahren kein Wort zu dieser
wichtigen Aufgabe in der EU und in
Deutschland ich höre es gibt Bewegung
bei dieser Frage und wenn wir mit
unserer Debatte und mit unserem Beitrag
einen Beitrag dazu leisten die neue
Koalition auf den richtigen Weg zu
bringen dann tun wir das gerne
Menschenrechte sind immer konkret
handeln sie auch konkret vielen dank
Michael Brandt für die CDU CSU-Fraktion
die hier einen Antrag vorlegt nämlich
dieses Amt was in der ersten der letzten
Legislatur eingeführt wurde nämlich das
Beauftragten für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit auch wieder
vorzuführen in dieser Legislatur und die
Ampelkoalition in Person von
bundesentwicklungsministerin Svenja
Schulz hat angekündigt dass sie in Kürze
ein Vorschlag für die Besetzung dieses
Amtes machen wird das ist nämlich in
ihrem Ministerium angesiedelt Frank
Schwabe jetzt für die SPD
frau Präsidentin
für ältere Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verehrte Damen und Herren menschenrechte
sind unteilbar
universell und unveräußerlich man kann
sie nicht mal abgeben wenn man das
selbst möchte sie gelten in Deutschland
und sie gelten eben aber auch in anderen
Teilen der Welt und wir wollen alles
dafür tun und alles dazu beitragen dem
auch Geltung zu verschaffen wir wollen
das Menschen in Freiheit leben und
Freiheit meint eben auch Freiheit zu
glauben was man möchte eine Religion
auszuüben einer Religion nachzugehen
oder eben auch nicht und ich will daran
erinnern dass das natürlich auch eine
Verpflichtung im Inland ist wenn wir das
im Ausland anmahnen und wir müssen immer
daran denken wenn wir über Moschee
Bauten Minarette im hohe zehn Rufe und
anderes reden dass das für uns
entsprechend auch gilt der Kollege
Michael Brandt hat ja den Antrag gerade
vorgestellt der Union und im Antrag
steht ja auch noch mal ausdrücklich drin
wie das Amt geschaffen wurde und ich
will das auch unterstreichen das ist
alles so richtig wir haben das gemeinsam
auch auf eure Initiative so vereinbart
und wir haben einen
Beauftragten für das Thema der
Religionsfreiheit aber eben auch der
Glaubensfreiheit und das war Markus
grübel der erste der das Amt ausgeübt
hat der das Amt wirklich geprägt hat
auch mit seiner Persönlichkeit der
ausgewogenen agiert hat und ich denke
allseits geschätzt wurde deswegen will
ich im Namen meiner Fraktion aber
wahrscheinlich auch von vielen anderen
mehr auch von uns herzlichen Dank sagen
und das Amt wird bleiben das hat gestern
Bundesministerin Svenja Schulze schon
deutlich gemacht es gibt viele Menschen
auf der Welt aber auch in Deutschland
die Hoffnung haben in dieses Amt die
eben unterdrückt werden und gerne hätten
dass ihnen geholfen wird dass ihnen
zugehört wird und deswegen soll das Amt
bleiben wir fangen also nicht bei Null
an nicht in Deutschland aber auch nicht
international wir haben den
eu-beauftragten für religions- und
weltanschauungsfreiheit auch wenn die
Stelle gerade nicht besetzt ist wir
haben ein UN-Sonderberichterstatter für
religions- und Glaubensfreiheit Ahmed
Sahid das war vorher mal Heiner
Bielefeld so das Amt glaube ich dort
sehr geprägt hat ich glaube man muss
klar machen bei der religions- und
weltanschauungsfreiheit geht es um das
religi Recht von Religionsausübung es
geht aber nicht so sehr um das Recht von
Obrigkeiten darüber zu entscheiden wie
Religion ausgeübt wird das Recht eine
Religion zu haben ist ein Freiheitsrecht
so muss es auch verstanden werden es ist
ein individuelles Recht auf Ausübung von
Religion und eben kein kollektivrecht
und deswegen will ich gerne Heiner
Bielefeld der wirklich eine führende
Rolle international spielt da auch noch
mal zitieren ich starte mit dem Zitat
die Religionsfreiheit schützt nicht
religiöse Dogmen oder religiöse Werte
als solche sondern die Freiheit von
Menschen
sich in Fragen von Religion frei zu
orientieren ohne Angst und ohne
Diskriminierung in Freiheit Zitat Ende
will es also nochmal deutlich machen es
geht nicht darum irgendwie Obrigkeiten
zu unterstützen die definieren wollen
was Religion ist wie Religion ausgeübt
werden soll sondern immer darum Menschen
die Freiheit zu geben ihren Glauben ihre
Religion entsprechend auszuüben und das
können viele Menschen auf der Welt eben
leider nicht das ist das Problem nach
den Zahlen des puresearch Centers von
2019 ist es so dass in 92 52 Ländern auf
der Welt die
Religionsfreiheit und die Freiheit von
Religionsgemeinschaften hohen oder sehr
hohen Restriktionen ausgesetzt ist das
in 70 Ländern es Blasphemie oder
antikonversationsgesetze gibt viele sind
davon betroffen weltweit Juden Christen
Muslime vor allem auch aber auch
kleinere religiöse Gruppen oder
Religionsgemeinschaften wie ach die
ahmadia in Pakistan die Bahai im Iran
oder die Kopten in Ägypten das ist nicht
ausführlich da könnte man viele andere
Gruppen hinzufügen all die verdienen
unsere Aufmerksamkeit und unsere
Unterstützung und in diesem Sinne würde
ich nochmal betonen religions- und
weltanschauungsfreiheit ist ein
wichtiges Menschenrecht es darf aber
nicht in künstlichen Gegensatz gesetzt
werden zu anderen Menschenrechten zum
Beispiel zu Menschenrecht auf
Meinungsfreiheit deswegen ist es
manchmal nicht ganz einfache Diskurs den
wir zu führen haben aber es ist ein
wichtiger ein wichtiger Diskurs ein
spannender Diskurs und wir werden ihn
auch in den nächsten vier Jahren hier
gemeinsam führen vielen Dank
sagt Frank Schwabe für die SPD-Fraktion
und die bundesentwicklungsministerin
Svenja Schulze haben sie
zwischenzeitlich auch hier eingefangen
von unserer Regie gesehen auf der
Regierungsbank die ja nach wie vor etwas
auseinander gezogen ist was die
Sitzordnung anbelangt
aufgrund der corona-abstände hier sehen
Sie das noch mal die Minister die sich
jetzt auf drei Reihen verteilen und in
der dritten Reihe ist wenn er Schulze
die jetzt dem nächsten Redebeitrag
zuhören wird Jürgen braun für die AFD
wird das sein
frau Präsidentin liebe Kollegen
unmittelbar vor Weihnachten sendet die
Grünen linke Ampel ein verheerendes
Signal in die Welt mehr als 300
Millionen verfolgten Christen wird
gesagt eure Probleme sind kein Thema für
die Bundesregierung
ich habe dem Beauftragten für
Religionsfreiheit Markus grübel hier vor
einem halben Jahr meinen Respekt
ausgesprochen Dank für die geleistete
Arbeit aber ich sagte schon damals dass
die Regierung Religionsfreiheit in der
deutschen Politik keine Lobby hat außer
der AFD und jetzt kann es jeder sehen
jetzt kann es jeder sehen die AFD hat
wieder einmal Recht behalten
die CDU kann nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass die 16 Jahre lang
Christenverfolgung klein geredet hat sie
hat den Begriff Christenverfolgung in
den letzten Jahren sogar vermieden nur
wir von der AFD prangern die
Christenverfolgung offen an
diese neue links-grüne Regierung mit
leichtem Gelbstich oder mit blass
vergilter Tönung interessiert sich gar
nicht mehr für Christenverfolgung Anfang
November hat die Ampel überhaupt nicht
reagiert als die Veranstalter der
Konferenz Christenverfolgung heute
inständig baten das Amt des
religionsfreiheitsbeauftragten
weiterzuführen und der Koalitionsvertrag
erwähnt das Amt auch mit keinem Wort sie
wollten es stillschweigend abschaffen
die verfolgten Christen können von einer
Außenministerin baerbock nichts erwarten
aber die Anhänger der selbst ernannten
völkerrechtlerin jubeln die Zukunft der
Außenpolitik ist feministisch tja wir
als AFD wissen genau was sie damit
meinen grüne feministische Außenpolitik
bedeutet hifis mit islamistischen
Massenmördern bedeutet europäische
PolitikerInnen auf Delegationsreise in
Kopftüchern bedeutet Unterwerfung der
Frau unter den politischen Islam
die Religionsfreiheit wird nicht durch
alte weiße Männer eingeschränkt die
Religionsfreiheit wird heute vor allem
durch Kommunisten und Islamisten
eingeschränkt
die sogenannte gleichstellungskommission
der EU hat eine Empfehlung vorgelegt auf
der das Wort auf das Wort Weihnachten zu
verzichten weil es diskriminierend sei
so viel zu ihrer Christlichkeit und der
ihrer eu-kumpane aus Brüssel
Christen werden verfolgt werden
abgeschlachtet weltweit gerade an ihren
heiligsten festen gerade auch an
Weihnachten und vor Weihnachten die neue
Ampelkoalition wird für 300 Millionen
verfolgte Christen zur todesampel
unmittelbar vor Weihnachten
[Applaus]
-Fraktion auch
einfach mal bitten auf die Wortwahl zu
achten das habe ich vorhin gesagt und
das gilt auch für ihre Fraktion wie auch
für alle anderen
ja noch mal der Hinweis von Bärbel Barz
wie die Wortwahl und der Umgang
miteinander ist und jetzt für die Grünen
Maxi Lux mit seiner ersten Rede hier er
ist der Hauptmann im Ausschuss für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe für
die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion
ich bezeichne mich als Christ ich passe
vielleicht als Schwuler Katholik nicht
in das Weltbild von einigen hier aber
eins habe ich durch meine Religion
lernen können nämlich dass die Würde
eines jeden Menschen
unantastbar ist und ich finde es
unerträglich was ich dieses Parlament
hier teilweise bieten lassen muss
meine
meine Damen und Herren in meiner
Generation erlebe ich eine sehr sehr
hohe Sensibilität für
Menschenrechtspolitik das ist glaube ich
auch gut so denn
wenn Menschenrechte müssen immer wieder
aufs Neue erkämpft werden und das
fordert auch der Blick auf die
Religionsfreiheit weltweit ein das
fordert zum Beispiel der Blick auf die
dramatische Lage der Christinnen und
Christen in Afghanistan ein die nicht
erst seit der Machtübernahme der Taliban
in Angst vor Diskriminierung leben
müssen das fordert genauso der Blick auf
die Hasara in Afghanistan zum Beispiel
die seit der Machtübernahme der Taliban
in Angst um ihr Lieben fliehen müssen
ich möchte ihr hier heute aber die
Gelegenheit auch nutzen um ganz
besonders an die jesidinnen und
jesidenten zu denken so an das Leid von
Nadja Murat mit ihr hatten wir bei der
Wahl des Bundeskanzlers vergangene Woche
ein ganz besonderen Gast auf unserer
Tribüne hier am dritten August 2014
wurde sie vom is in ihrem Dorf gefangen
genommen sie wurde festklagt sie wurde
vergewaltigt weil sie
intensitischen minderheitsangehört für
ihre Mütter für ihre Mutter und ihre
Brüder kann jede Rettung zu spät in
Deutschland konnte sie Schutz finden und
ist heute
un-sonderbotschafterin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen das Leid der jesidinnen und
Jesiden ist so erdrückend dass wir alles
dafür unternehmen müssen dass dieser
Genozid juristisch und auch politisch in
seiner Systematik weiter aufgearbeitet
wird
die Vertreibung von jesidenen und
Jesiden aus ihren Dörfern der
systematische Einsatz von Vergewaltigung
als Kriegswaffe gegen die siedenen
Sklaverei und Folter angegriffen wurde
hier auch das Menschenrecht auf
Religionsfreiheit aber nicht nur dieses
Menschenrecht sondern alle
Menschenrechte wurden damit angegriffen
und dies zeigt uns auf eine dramatische
Art und Weise die Unteilbarkeit von
Menschenrechten auf ganz egal ob oder an
was wir glauben wenn die Freiheit zum
Glauben angetastet wird dann wird auch
immer die Würde des Menschen in seinem
Kern angetastet und deshalb müssen wir
doch als Abgeordnete dieses Parlamentes
ganz egal ob christlich atheistisch
jüdisch oder muslimisch mit Nachdruck
für die Religionsfreiheit weltweit
einstehen und auch bei uns im Land dafür
sorgen dass sich Juden endlich mit einer
auf die Straße trauen können und
Musliminnen ohne Angst mit Kopftuch nach
draußen gehen können
Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sein Glauben öffentlich und sichtbar zu
leben ist für die allergietische
Gemeinde bei mir im Wahlkreis in Bochum
keine Selbstverständlichkeit bei meinem
Besuch erzielten mir sie dass sie hier
in Deutschland erstmals frei leben
konnten und in der Lage waren Pogrome
aufzuarbeiten zu erdrückend ist die
Stigmatisierung in der Türkei sie
berichteten mir aber auch darüber wie
sie hier Diskriminierung erleben und wie
wenig Gehör sie dafür von der Politik
geschenkt bekommen doch wir hören diese
Diskriminierung wir nehmen das ernst und
wir werden auch die transnationale
Dimension der Verfolgung von religiösen
Minderheiten in den Blick nehmen denn
wir verstehen dass die Religionsfreiheit
keine Grenzen kennen darf
wir werden in der Ampelkoalition dafür
sorgen dass Menschenrechte auch dann
ziehen wenn es um wirklich etwas geht
der unionsantrag mit seiner Verkürzung
der 30 Menschenrechte auf einen
Menschenrecht und ein einzigen
beauftragten wird der weltweiten Lage
nicht gerecht eine klare Kante über
China wenn es um die Minderheitenrechte
von euguren geht ein Rüstungsexport top
für Saudi-Arabien ein erleichterter
Zugang zu humanitären Visa all das
werden wir mit unserer Außenministerin
Annalena baerbock angehen um die
Menschenrechte und auch um das Recht auf
Religionsfreiheit weltweit zu stärken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dazu zielt eben auch und ganz
explizit das weltweite Engagement für
Religionsfreiheit für positive
Religionsfreiheit wie übrigens auch für
negative Religionsfreiheit die in ihrem
Antrag jetzt nicht ganz
deutlich betont wird zu Menschenrechten
zählt eben auch viel mehr und deshalb
freuen wir uns dass wir dann auch noch
über Ihren Antrag weiter beraten können
im Ausschuss danke für die
Aufmerksamkeit
sagt Max Fuchs für die Grünen in seiner
ersten Rede noch mal zum Ende dieses
Beitrags in Richtung der
cdu/csu-fraktion auf Grundlage deren
Antrag ja hier debattiert wird die
cdu/csu-fraktion setzt sich dafür ein
dass das Amt des Beauftragten für
weltweite Religionsfreiheit fortgeführt
wird und die Ampelkoalition hat ja
signalisiert dass im nächsten Jahr ist
dazu ein Personalvorschlag geben soll
Petra Pau hören wir jetzt in der
Aussprache für die Linke
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
cdu/csu-fraktion beantragt das
internationale Engagement für das
Menschenrecht auf religions- und
weltanschauungsfreiheit fortzusetzen und
das Amt des Beauftragten der
Bundesregierung für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit vorzuführen
dem inhaltlichen Anliegen stimmt die
Fraktion DIE LINKE ausdrücklich zu jede
und jeder hat das Recht einer Religion
zu folgen oder eben auch keiner das
gehört zur Selbstbestimmung und darf
nicht vorgeschrieben werden es geht
nicht nur um Glauben sondern zugleich um
Demokratie
Religionsfreiheit ist in Artikel 4
Grundgesetz verankert ebenso in Artikel
18 der Allgemeinen Erklärung der
Menschenrechte sowie in weiteren
internationalen Dokumenten die Praxis in
der Süd weltweit vielfach anders aus und
das ist nicht hinnehmbar ich danke den
Kollegen Brandt Lux und Schwabe für die
Darstellung der Situation weil das
bekomme ich in zwei Minuten nicht unter
aber ich unterstreiche die Situation ist
nicht hinnehmbar
wir müssen nicht in die weite Welt
gucken um auf Probleme mit der
religions- und weltanschauungsfreiheit
zu stoßen ich erinnere nur an den
grassierenden Antisemitismus hierzulande
nun hat der Kollege Schwabe gesagt das
Amt wird bleiben gut allerdings stellt
die Fraktion DIE LINKE sich schon noch
die Frage kann man nicht aufbauen auf
das was der Kollege grübel in den
vergangenen Jahren gemacht hat noch
einmal Weiterdenken braucht es den
religionsbeauftragten beim BMZ oder wäre
es nicht in der Ausgestaltung des
Menschenrechts beauftragten und seiner
Ausstattung auch gut aufgehoben um
sowohl der internationalen Dimensionen
als auch unsere nationalen Dimensionen
und den Problemen zu entsprechen kurzum
das Anliegen teilen wir über die
Ausgestaltung werden wir ja wohl
weiterreden
sagt Petra Pau und über die
Ausgestaltung dann spätestens im
nächsten Jahr
das scheint sich ja schon anzudeuten in
jedem Fall führen wir bevor dann
übrigens Markus krübel auch noch spricht
der hier gerade angesprochen wurde der
im letzten in der letzten Legislatur
dieses Amt begleitet hat das
Beauftragten für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit also bevor er hier
gleich noch sprechen wird hören wir
jetzt
hier steht sie schon Renata alt für die
FDP-Fraktion sie ist die Vorsitzende des
Ausschusses für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe
sehr geehrte Frau Bundestagspräsidentin
meine Damen und Herren Gedanken
Gewissens Religion und
weltanschauungsfreiheit so heißt
eigentlich das Recht über das wir hier
heute sprechen es umfasst gleichermaßen
die Freiheit zu glauben und die Freiheit
nicht gläubig zu sein niemand darf wegen
seines Glaubens oder seines nicht
Glaubens bestraft oder stigmatisiert
werden
und doch wird dieses Recht weltweit
massiv verletzt derzeit gibt es in
mindestens 70 Staaten
antiblasphemiegesetze in circa 40
Staaten weltweit ist mindestens eine
religiöse Gruppe verboten die
covid-pandemie war zum Teil auch ein
wirksamer Vorwand um die religions- und
wertanschauungsfreiheit zu verletzen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
in ihrem Antrag betonen sie die
religions- und weltanschauungsfreiheit
sei ein wichtiges Menschenrecht da haben
sie recht sie haben heben weiter hervor
dass mir den Verletzungen der
Religionsfreiheit oft andere
Menschenrechtsverletzungen einhergehen
auch das stimmt denn oft genug werde die
Religionsfreiheit
missbraucht zum Beispiel wenn es unter
ihren Deckmantel Presse und
Meinungsfreiheit unterdrückt werden es
gibt nur ein Mittel um da gegenzusteuern
es ist ein verstärkter Einsatz für alle
Menschenrechte ohne Ausnahme
doch mein Eindruck ist dass es ihnen in
ihrem Antrag weniger und die
Religionsfreiheit als solche geht Herr
Dr grübel vielmehr geht es ihnen um den
symbolischen Stellenwert des Amtes des
Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
Religionsfreiheit sie werfen der
Ampelkoalition vor dieses Amt abschaffen
zu wollen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nicht alle Ämter die nicht namentlich im
Koalitionsvertrag erwähnt werden werden
auch abgeschafft Herr Schwabe hatte
schon angedeutet
in ihrem Antrag gehen sie überwiegend
auf die Religionsfreiheit der Christen
ein natürlich steht den Christen die die
größte Glaubensgemeinschaft sind ihr
Recht auf Religionsfreiheit zu und
natürlich müssen wir sie schützen sie
erwähnen die Christenverfolgung in
Myanmar aber zu dem Verfolgung zu der
Verfolgung von rohinger sagen sie gar
nichts die kleineren
Religionsgemeinschaften leiden
überproportional unterverfolgung dazu
habe ich in ihrem Antrag nichts gefunden
eine glaubwürdige Menschenrechtspolitik
fängt aber zu Hause an
Religionsfreiheit betrifft auch
Deutschland auch hier müssen wir das
Recht auf Religionsfreiheit schützen
dazu gehört auch eine effektive
Bekämpfung und Prävention von
muslimfreienfeindlichkeit und
Antisemitismus
im Koalitionsvertrag haben wir uns als
Freie Demokraten gemeinsam mit der SPD
und den Grünen zu einer
wertebasierten Außenpolitik verpflichtet
dieses Versprechen werden wir einhalten
und werden uns für alle Menschenrechte
einsetzen auch für die religions- und
weltanschauungsfreiheit das kann ich
Ihnen versichern vielen Dank
verenater alt war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und ja jetzt hören wir den
scheidenden Beauftragten für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit also der das in der
letzten Legislatur inne hatte dieses Amt
Markus grübel wird das sein der auf
verschiedenen genannt wurde für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Religion hat Bedeutung uns
wurde schon gesagt die Fakten sprechen
für sich über 80 Prozent der Menschen in
der Welt sagen von sich sie seien
religiös und bei meiner ersten Reise in
den Norden Iraks als
religionsfreiheitsbeauftragter war ich
im Flüchtlingslager in Doha und habe ein
Mensch getroffen ein Mann Christ hätte
aber auch jesidien kakai Schabak sein
können alles verloren Haus Hof
Landwirtschaft Tiere Auto und er sagte
mir meine Religion ist das wichtigste
und darum habe ich alles zurückgelassen
und darum sage ich Religion hat
Bedeutung und wer Religion geringschätzt
ist schlichterdings weltfremd
drei drei von vier Menschen in der Welt
leben in Ländern in denen die
Religionsfreiheit eingeschränkt wird
oder völlig in Frage gestellt wird und
die Entwicklung ist leider nicht gut
wer eine wertebasierte Politik macht
setzt sich darum für Religionsfreiheit
ein wer Menschenrechte ernst nimmt setzt
sich für Religionsfreiheit ein betroffen
sind viele Millionen Menschen hunderte
Millionen Menschen und darum ist es gut
dass die Koalition dass sie Frau
Ministerin Schulzen und angekündigt
haben die Stelle des Beauftragten wieder
zu besetzen
Religion hat auch ein großes Potenzial
im sozialen für Frieden Kultur für
Umwelt nachhaltige Welt darum hat es
Entwicklungsministerium ja auch eine
Strategie entwickelt Religion und
Entwicklungen internationales Netzwerk
gegründet Part Religion und nachhaltige
Entwicklung Partnerschaft von Religionen
und nachhaltiger Entwicklung und es gibt
im Auswärtigen Amt und Referat
Religionen Außenpolitik wo es um die
friedensverantwortung der Religionen
geht und ein Netzwerk religions for
peace damit aber religionier Potenziale
entfalten kann ihr großes Potenzial
entfaltenhand braucht es die
Religionsfreiheit die Ansiedlung im BMZ
finde ich gut und richtig ich habe viele
Projekte anschieben entwickeln können
begleiten können wo es darum geht ein
friedliches Miteinander Menschen
unterschiedlicher Religion in der Welt
zu ermöglichen und zuletzt habe ich eine
Handreichung erarbeitet wo es um
Schulbildung geht das in der Schule
keine Feind und zellbilder dargestellt
sterben dass alle Menschen alle Kinder
die gleichen Chancen haben unabhängig
von ihr nie oder Religion
eine wichtige Aufgabe des Beauftragten
ist der Bericht der Bundesregierung
Nachschlagewerk für die Regierung für
uns im Parlament für die
Zivilgesellschaft für die Wirtschaft ein
Dokument ist auch im Ausland gelesen
wird gerade in den betroffenen Ländern
als erstes und nun steht der dritte
Bericht an zusammenfassend möchte ich
sagen um was gehts als Aufgabe für den
religionsfreiheitsbeauftragten wir
müssen hinschauen wo wir das
Menschenrecht auf Religionsfreiheit
verletzt wir müssen laut aufschreien
manchmal ist aber auch besser leise zu
sein wir müssen Verbündete suchen und
schließlich gemeinsam handeln und darum
sage ich herzlichen Dank den vielen
Verbündeten hier im Bundestag den
Verbündeten
menschenrechtspolitikern den außen und
entwicklungspolitikern den Sprecherinnen
und Sprechern für Kirchen und religions
Themen für ihre vielfältige
Unterstützung und jetzt geht es darum
gemeinsam und stark zu machen für das
Menschenrecht auf Religionsfreiheit des
Amt zu stärken und auch in der
Europäischen Union zu schauen dass es
Amt wieder besetzt wird herzlichen
Markus grübel
erteile ich dem Abgeordneten Seitz aus
der afd-fraktion ein Ordnungsruf er hat
ein Foto während der laufenden
Plenarsitzung
auf Facebook gepostet von dem Redner Max
Lux die Worte die er dafür gefunden hat
will ich jetzt nicht wiederholen aber
dafür erteile ich Ihnen ja bereits einen
Ordnungsruf
von den Grünen hat hier seine erste Rede
gehalten und ist anscheinend
fotografiert worden von einem
afd-abgeordneten und entsprechend wurde
das kommentiert
und dafür gibt es von Bärbel Bars von
der Bundestagspräsidentin einen
Ordnungsruf nächster Redner jetzt in der
Aussprache zur
Religionsfreiheit Lars castellucci für
die SPD-Fraktion Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
nachdem man in der gestrigen Debatte zur
Regierungserklärung den Eindruck hatte
dass das Wichtigste um was es jetzt geht
ist wo sie künftig sitzen werden
werteantragsteller sind sie jetzt heute
bei den Sachthemen angekommen das ist
schon mal gut die Antrag ist auch gut
aber er ist nicht nötig und frei nach
Montesquieu wo es nicht nötig ist ein
Antrag zu stellen wäre es eigentlich
nötig keinen Antrag zu stellen die
Ministerin hat schon für Klarheit
gesorgt das Amt des Beauftragten für
weltweite Religionsfreiheit wird
fortgesetzt werden es ist auch eine
richtige Entscheidung der neuen
Bundesregierung wir haben gerne
selbstverständlich können wir nicht
sämtliche beauftragte die es im
Geschäftsbereich der Bundesregierung
gibt in allen Koalitionsvertrag
hineinstellen und es ist nicht nur
unsere Aufgabe
das alles nur fortzusetzen sondern auch
mal eine Sekunde darüber nachzudenken ob
alles was angesammelt worden ist über
die letzten Jahre tatsächlich wert ist
fortgeführt zu werden das hat etwas mit
Demokratie zu tun das sollten Sie hier
auch
wenn man so über die Gänge läuft und
sagt man also wörtlich vielleicht nicht
aber man kriegt manchmal den Eindruck
dass denken Leute da ist jetzt so eine
gottlose Truppe unterwegs und das erste
was die Macht ist dieses Amt des
Beauftragten für Religionsfreiheit
abzuschaffen
so erstens ist es nicht so und zweitens
offenbart man ja mit einem solchen
Gerede dass man gerade den Kern von
Religionsfreiheit überhaupt nicht
verstanden hat Mama kann ja nicht unter
der Fahne der Religionsfreiheit
irgendjemand zum Vorwurf machen dass er
einen bestimmten glauben nicht an
anhängt und das muss an dieser Stelle
auch klar gesagt werden
Religionsfreiheit ist Freiheit zum
Glauben aber auch die Freiheit keinen
Glauben anzuhängen und das wird diese
Bundesregierung auch fördern
lassen Sie mich die Gelegenheit nutzen
mal ein bisschen inhaltlich über dieses
Amt zu sprechen
wir haben zwei Berichte vorgelegt
bekommen
[Musik]
wenn das Amt neu besetzt wird ist es
mein Anliegen dass wir tatsächlich zu
etwas kommen was eine Art Monitoring ist
es ist gestartet dass wir einzelne
Länder rausgegriffen haben in der Welt
und das bedeutet doch immer dass wir aus
deutscher Perspektive auf andere mit dem
Finger zeigen und sagen so und so sieht
es bei euch aus und ich glaube das ist
nicht unsere Aufgabe sondern wir
brauchen eine Berichterstattung die uns
einen guten Überblick über die den
Zustand der Religionsfreiheit
tatsächlich weltweit gibt das heißt es
braucht ein Monitoring aller Länder
der zweite Punkt der wichtige ist und er
ist zu meinem Kollegen von den Grünen ja
angesprochen worden meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
wenn wir in einem Land leben in dem Jan
und beinahe täglich zuletzt war es eine
Moschee in Leipzig
Übergriffe auf Synagogen wo Menschen
sich nicht auf die Straße trauen mit
Kippa oder mit Kopftuch dann ist es doch
eine Notwendigkeit eine bittere
Notwendigkeit dass wir sagen wenn wir
weltweite religionsfrei zum Thema machen
dann ist es unsere Aufgabe auch Vorbild
dabei zu sein und nicht nachzulassen
dabei da sind diesem Land jede und jeder
seinen Glauben frei ausleben muss und da
wird diese Regierung noch mal deutlich
eine Schippe drauflegen müssen ich finde
es immer wieder bedrückend und
beschämend wenn ich sehe dass wie wie
Gottes Häuser in diesem Land beschützt
werden müssen es ist nötig dass sie
beschützt werden aber es ist beschämen
stellen wir uns vor diejenigen die dem
christlichen Glauben anhängen wir würden
an Weihnachten durch Sicherheitsanlagen
in die Gottesdienste gehen was wäre denn
dann in diesem Land los und es zeigt
doch dass da eine riesen Aufgabe vor uns
liegt
und ein letzter Punkt zur Rolle des
auftes des neuen beauftragten oder der
neuen beauftragten wir dürfen nicht
immer nur feststellen dass es schlecht
ist und absehbar schlechter wird wir
müssen auch was dafür tun dass es besser
wird und dazu müssen wir diejenigen
unterstützen die für interreligiösen
Dialog und für diese Religionsfreiheit
auch aktiv eintreten gerade in dieser
Woche war der Hohe Kommissar der
Generalsekretär des hohenkommissariats
für die Brüderlichkeit hier im Deutschen
Bundestag auch zu Gast das sind
Initiativen für Dialog von denen kaum
jemand etwas mitbekommt wir müssen sie
stärken dass unsere Aufgabe dem oder der
neuen beauftragen wünsche ich schon
heute eine glückliche Hand und uns allen
frohe Feiertage oder schöne Weihnachten
wenn Sie daran glauben vielen Dank
sagt die Lars castellucci hier für die
SPD-Fraktion erst Mitglied im Ausschuss
für wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung
zu seiner ersten Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag hat nun der Kollege Dr Jonas
Geißler für die cdu/csu-fraktion
und es gab einen Wechsel im
Bundestagspräsidium Petra Paul leitet
jetzt als Bundestagsvizepräsidentin die
Sitzung und jetzt der nächste Redner
Jonas Geißler
frau Präsidentin Liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich stehe vor
ihnen als neu gewählter Abgeordneter der
sich vermutlich seit dem 26 September
unzählige Male gefragt hat über was er
denn zum ersten Mal vor diesem Hohen
Haus sprechen wird und ich sage Ihnen
ganz ehrlich als Demokrat glaube ich es
gibt kein größeres Thema als die rechte
und die Würde des Menschen
als gläubiger Christ weiß ich dass das
Recht auf freie Religionsausübung eines
der heiligsten dieser Rechte ist
ich habe mir viel überlegt was ich heute
sage und ich möchte einfach jetzt gleich
am Anfang mich dafür bedanken dass das
Amt des weltweiten religionsbeauftragten
erhalten bleibt wir sind davon
ausgegangen dass es abgeschafft wird das
ist gut dass sie das machen und das ist
auch richtig so
weltweite Religionsfreiheit beinhaltet
das Recht den eigenen Glauben zu leben
es beinhaltet das Recht zu konvertieren
wenn man das möchte den Glauben
öffentlich auszuleben und es ist
natürlich das ist überhaupt nicht in
Abrede zu stellen auch das Recht keinem
Glauben nachzukommen das stellt niemand
Abrede und es ist ein zentrales Teil
dieses weltanschaulichen rechts für auch
für uns ich möchte Ihnen auch sagen dass
ich glaube dass wir in Deutschland sehr
wohl wissen dass wir uns unserer eigenen
Verantwortung stellen müssen die aus
unserer Geschichte in diesem Fall
begründet ist
und das tun wir das haben wir mit der
Einführung des Amts gemacht und das tun
wir immer wieder wir wissen dafür bin
ich ihnen sehr dankbar dass sie das
gesagt haben wie sehr Religion in
weltweit herausgefordert sind ich glaube
jeder von uns hat die Bilder der
Ermordeten Jesiden im Kopf der
versklavten jesidenen wir alle haben die
Bilder von 200 Millionen Christen auf
der ganzen Welt im Kopf die ihren
Glauben nicht Freileben können die von
Verfolgung Folter und Tod bedroht sind
wir wissen dass es den Hindus und den
Buddhisten nicht anders geht und
Antisemitismus ist und bleibt die Geißel
der Menschheit es ist unser Anspruch dem
entgegenzutreten immer und überall das
ist der Anspruch der deutschen
Außenpolitik das ist aber auch der
Anspruch von uns als Demokraten es gibt
wohl keine Religion die weltweit gelebt
wird die nicht irgendwo auf diesem
Globus verfolgt wird
wir freuen uns darüber dass sie das Amt
beibehalten dafür sind wir in den
dankbar vielleicht haben wir einen
kleinen Beitrag dazu geleistet dass es
wirklich machen und wir wünschen uns
einfach dass sie dieses Amt was mit so
viel Leben erfüllt worden ist auch in
Zukunft lebendig gestalten vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Jonas Geißler mit seiner ersten Rede für
die cdu/csu-fraktion
zu diesem Thema war ja jetzt auch der
letzte Redner
Kollege Geißler ihnen ist etwas gelungen
was nicht vielen Abgeordneten in ihrer
ersten Rede gelingt nämlich eine
absolute Punktlandung was die Einhaltung
der Redezeit wird
das freut natürlich die Sitzungsleitung
ganz besonders aber er hat hier auch
viel Applaus von seiner eigenen Fraktion
bekommen wie das üblich ist für hier die
ersten Reden im Bundestag die natürlich
an diesen ersten Sitzungstagen besonders
vielfältig sind Freiheit fortsetzen Amt
des Beauftragten der Bundesregierung für
weltweite Religionsfreiheit fortführen
die Fraktion der cdu/csu wünscht
Abstimmung in der Sache die Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
wünschen Überweisung zur federführenden
Beratung an den Ausschuss für
Menschenrechte und zur mitberatung an
den Ausschuss an den Auswärtigen
Ausschuss den Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat den Wirtschaftsausschuss den
Ausschuss für Familie Senioren Frauen
und Jugend den Ausschuss für Gesundheit
den Ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit und Entwicklung und an
den muss für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union wir stimmen auch
ständiger Übung zuerst über den Antrag
auf Ausschluss Überweisung ab ich frage
deshalb wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das sind die
Koalitionsfraktionen und die Fraktion
DIE LINKE wer stimmt dagegen
die Fraktionen der cdu/csu und die
afd-fraktion wer enthält sich
niemand dann ist die Überweisung so
beschlossen damit stimmen wir heute über
den Antrag auf Drucksache 267 nicht in
der Sache ab ja das war ja die Grundlage
der letzten Debatte dieser Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion aber in der Aussprache
ist ja deutlich geworden unter anderem
von Seiten der SPD der Antrag sei gut
das ist ein
beauftragt für weltweite
Religionsfreiheit auch in dieser
Legislatur geben soll aber nicht nötig
denn man werde das Amt weiter besetzen
so nächster Tagesordnungspunkt
an diesem letzten Sitzungstag vor der
Weihnachtspause die ampelfraktion wollen
den corona-hilfsfonds und ein halbes
Jahr verlängern da gibt es einen
Gesetzentwurf der vorliegt und der heute
auch abgestimmt wird
die unternehmenshilfen sollen
fortgesetzt werden bis zum 30 Juni 2022
die ampelfraktion Planen allerdings den
Umfang der möglichen Hilfen für die
Unternehmen zu kürzen bisher konnte
dieser fondsgarantien von insgesamt 400
Milliarden Euro gewähren umklammern
Unternehmen zu helfen
dieser Umfang soll jetzt auf insgesamt
100 Milliarden Euro verringert werden
und den Auftakt der Debatte macht
Reinhard Huben für die FDP-Fraktion der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
von 3,6 auf 3,5 von 5,1 Prozent auf 4,0
Prozent
von 5,1% auf 3,7 Prozent das sind die in
den vergangenen Tagen vorgestellten
Anpassungen der Konjunkturprognosen der
bekannten deutschen
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute für das
BIP des kommenden Jahres wir sind
angesichts dieser Zahlen offensichtlich
in der Situation dass wir noch nicht von
einer vollständigen Stabilisierung
unserer Wirtschaft in Deutschland
sprechen können deswegen verlängern wir
heute den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds wir
schaffen damit Kontinuität in einer
immer noch schwierigen Lage
aber diese Verlängerung erfolgt mit
Augenmaß daher bleiben die 100
Milliarden Euro für die KfW Corona
Sonderprogramme unberührt wir reduzieren
jedoch das Volumen für Garantien des
bundesverabsicherung von Krediten von
400 auf 100 Milliarden Euro und der
Umfang der möglichen
rekapitalisierungen sinkt von 100
Milliarden auf 50 Milliarden Euro
angesichts der bisher abgerufenen Mittel
in Höhe von 8 Milliarden Euro gerade in
dieser dritten Säule des WSF bleiben wir
insgesamt im WSF handlungsfähig aber
überführen ihn in die finanzpolitischen
Realitäten
am wichtigsten ist jedoch mit der
Befristung des Zeitraums machen wir klar
dass diese Hilfen nicht bis zum Sankt
nimmerlandstag laufen wird damit
behalten wir das Ziel des WSF im Blick
die Leistung substanzieller Hilfen nach
eingehender Prüfung in akuten Notlagen
der WSF quasi als ultima ratio sprich
sobald sich ein Unternehmen wieder
konsolidiert hat zahlt es die Kredite
und Einlagen zurück und konkurriert
wieder auf dem freien Markt das ist uns
wichtig wir glauben an den Markt und an
den Wettbewerb wir glauben nicht an
staatswirtschaftlichen die regismus
nach jeder Hilfestellung muss er sich
auch wieder
zeitnah also der WSF aus dem betroffenen
Unternehmen zurückziehen das Ziel
erreichen wir so hatte die Lufthansa in
der größten Krise der Luftfahrt mit der
Bundesregierung und der EU-Kommission im
Sommer 2020 ein neun Milliarden Euro
schweres Rettungspaket ausgehandelt drei
Milliarden kamen von der KfW sechs vom
BSF in diesem Rahmen erwarb der Bund auf
20 Prozent an der Lufthansa damit konnte
die Lufthansa stabilisiert und eine
sechsstellige Anzahl von Arbeitsplätzen
gesichert werden
schon im Februar diesen Jahres begann
die Lufthansa einen Teil der in Anspruch
genommenen Kredite zurückzuzahlen und
Mitte November hatte sie sämtliche
Kredite insgesamt 3,5 Milliarden
zurückgezahlt der Bund hat schon im
August einen Teil seiner
Lufthansa-Aktien abgestoßen und ist noch
mit 14 Prozent an diesem Konzern
beteiligt hier wird der Bund bis Oktober
2023 alle seine verbliebenen Anteile
verkaufen genauso war der WSF gedacht
dass sich Unternehmen die darauf
verzichten können auch wieder die Hilfen
zurückgeben und es liegt auch im
Interesse der Unternehmen
Lufthansa-Chef Carsten Spur sprach
zuletzt bezogen auf die Tilgung der
Kredite von einem mentalen
Befreiungsschlag für sein Unternehmen
dadurch scheidet der Staat letztendlich
als Aktionär auch aus
die vorliegende Verlängerung des WSF
steht dabei in einer Linie mit der
beschlossenen Verlängerung der
Überbrückungshilfen und der
neustarthilfe damit senden wir ein
klares Signal an die vielen von der
Krise betroffenen Unternehmen
selbstständigen und beschäftigten wir
lassen sie in der Krise nicht allein der
Bund ist da wenn Unternehmen in
unverschuldeten Notlage geraten meine
Damen und Herren
erlauben Sie mir aber noch eine
Bemerkung zu der Debatte des
vorgehenden
Tagesordnungspunktes Helge Braun hat
davon gesprochen
die Ampel würde die Axt an die
Schuldenbremse ansetzen
allein allein an dem Handeln jetzt beim
WSF können Sie erkennen wenn öffentliche
Gelder nicht gebraucht werden sind wir
als Ampel auch in der Lage auf Gelder zu
verzichten vielen Dank
der Umfang der möglichen Hilfen wird
etwas gekürzt wird erheblich gekürzt
muss man sagen aber dem Hilfen werden
verlängert der WSF also der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds diese
Abkürzung werden sie in diese Debatte
natürlich noch häufig hören war
eingeführt worden mit der corona-krise
im notlande Unternehmen zu retten die
Lufthansa ist schon genannt worden frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrter
die tüdelt hier rum sehr geehrter Herr
Minister Habeck meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren bevor ich zu
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds möchte
ich Ihnen zur Ernennung zumindest dafür
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz ganz herzlich
gratulieren ich habe gehört sie haben
ein gut bestelltes Haus übernommen oder
übertragen bekommen und wir sich in
einer Demokratie gehört ist glaube ich
der Übergang sehr professionell
vonstatten gegangen das erste Gesetz
dass sie in ihrer neuen Verantwortung
nun einbringen das ist die Fortführung
die Fortführung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
wenn ihr Vorgänger Peter Altmaier
bereits initiiert hat und sie haben ein
paar Anpassungen vorgenommen die
zumindest für mich schlüssig sind und
wollen nun die Maximalbetrag für
Garantien von vormals 400 Milliarden
Euro auf 100 Milliarden Euro festlegen
ich glaube das kann man machen ich
glaube das ist in dieser Phase jetzt
verantwortbar und dass sie dieses
Instrument fortführen das ist eine gute
Nachricht insbesondere eine gute
Nachricht für die Unternehmen aber
infolgedessen natürlich auch für die
Arbeitnehmer die das dürfen wir einfach
mal sagen beide in dieser
pandemie-pandemie vielfach über sich
hinaus gewachsen sind und zwar
seinerzeit bei der Konstruktion des WSF
wichtig dass wir ein Signal senden ein
Signal senden dass man sich auf den
Staat verlassen kann denn den
Unternehmen die durch die
corona-maßnahmen
unverschuldet in Schwierigkeiten geraten
sind die musste geholfen werden alles
andere wäre verantwortungslos gewesen
und deshalb werden wir heute diesem WSF
selbstverständlich zustimmen und sehr
geehrter Minister das sollten wir
vielleicht auch nicht vergessen dass wir
eben diesen finanziellen Kraftakt auch
nur stemmen können weil wir in den
vergangenen Jahren vielleicht nicht
alles aber doch sehr sehr vieles richtig
gemacht haben und sie Herr habert sie
sind nun für mich zumindest der sechste
Wirtschaftsminister den ich als
Haushälter begleite ich freue mich auf
die anstehenden Haushaltsberatung mit
ihnen und ich kann Ihnen versprechen wir
werden viel in den kommenden Wochen
kommenden Monaten miteinander zu tun
haben und aber das darf man vielleicht
auch mal sagen fand ich es toll dass sie
bei ihrer Antrittsrede Ministerium
gesagt haben dass das bessere Argument
gewinnen soll und ich glaube sie haben
dann gesagt nur geschlagen von dem noch
besseren und ich kann Ihnen das
versichern sie werden aus rein der
Unionsfraktion auch von mir ganz
natürlich nur noch bessere Argumente
hören die sie dann hoffentlich aber auch
umsetzen
ein wenig verwundert Herr Minister war
ich allerdings dass ihre dann
anscheinend zweite Amtshandlung erst
einmal die Schaffung von 28 neuen
hochdotierten Personalstellen
hauptsächlich für das Amt des
Vizekanzlers war da haben sie sich fast
ein Ministerium im Ministerium
geschaffen das muss man erst mal bringen
sie befinden sich aber hier das darf man
vielleicht auch mal sagen ganz guter
Tradition mit einem ihrer Amtsvorgänger
mit Sigmar Gabriel der auch sofort nach
dem Amtsantritt die vizekanzlerstelle
auch mit stellen so ausgerufen hat aber
ganz ehrlich der war bescheidener als
sie das muss man sich unter Sigmar
Gabriel erstmal vorstellen aber so ich
möchte es fast mal sagen so opulent hat
der das nicht gemacht und das soll schon
was heißen übrigens wurden das können
wir an dieser Stelle auch mal sagen
diese Stellen nie im Ministerium
zurückgefahren so dass sie eigentlich
nun im Wirtschaftsministerium rein
rechnerisch zwei vizekanzlerabteilung
haben das ist schon großartig wie ich
finde
ich darf das in dieser Stelle deshalb
auch sagen mir macht der stellenaufwuchs
auch schon bei der vorherigen Regierung
große Sorge und weil das immer wieder
gesagt wird Otto ich habe das auch schon
bei der vorherigen Regierung gefordert
dass wir Haushälter vielleicht eine
jährliche einprozentige
stelleneinsparung wieder ausweisen
müssen deshalb seinerzeit lieber
orthograf der großen Applaus bei euch
heute ist das anscheinend anders deshalb
auch Herr Habeck ich würde mich freuen
wenn sie neben dem sicherlich auch in
der Union unumstrittenen notwendigen
Thema Klima nicht vergessen dass die
Industrie dass das Handwerk das der
Handel dass der Tourismus der gesamte
Mittelstand das Brot und buttergeschäft
ihres Hauses ist bitte lassen Sie bei
allen Dingen wo sie auf Klimaschutz
schauen lassen Sie diese wichtigen
Bereiche nicht verkümmern legen Sie den
Unternehmen nicht fesseln an entfesseln
Sie diese mit Ideenreichtum dann wissen
Sie die Union dann wissen sie mich als
ihren Haushältern Hauptbericht erstatte
an ihrer Seite in diesem Sinne
herzlichen Dank
Andreas Mattfeld war das für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion und im Haushaltsausschuss
sind verschiedene Abgeordnete für
verschiedene Wirtschaftspläne zuständig
das wird dann besonders interessant wenn
hier haushaltswoche im Bundestag ist für
den nächsten Haushalt 2022 jetzt eine
erste Rede wieder hier die angekündigt
wird und diesmal ist es eine Abgeordnete
der SPD das ist Verena huppers die
gleich neue stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der SPD geworden
ist
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich war
selbstunternehmerin und ich weiß wie
schwer es ist dran zu bleiben auch in
schwierigen Zeiten wie es auch ist wenn
man meine Nacht nicht schlafen kann oder
mehrere weil man sich überlegt wie man
Gehälter und auch Rechnungen zahlt
natürlich plant man langfristig mit
businessplanungen mit ganz vielen
Excel-Tabellen aber manche Dinge die
kann man eben nicht planen dazu gehört
eine Krise und erst recht eine Pandemie
und dieses Virus das hat erstmal den
stoppknopf für uns alle gedrückt die
Familien die Kinder das Gesundheitswesen
aber natürlich auch die Wirtschaft
natürlich auch unsere Unternehmen
wir sind auf einmal alle zu Hause
geblieben wir wollten solidarisch sein
aber
die Reiseindustrie der Einzelhandel die
Gastronomie die Hotellerie um nur mal
ein ganz paar hier zu nennen die haben
es natürlich mit aller Wucht gespürt und
deswegen war es auch richtig dass wir
als Politik geholfen haben flexibel
pragmatisch und auch solidarisch
das waren die Überbrückungshilfen das
war das Kurzarbeitergeld aber in der
Krise da muss man auch mal neue Wege
gehen und nicht dann morgen denken
sondern direkt an übermorgen denn da
müssen wir auch noch mal rauskommen und
der Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds ist
genauso ein langfristiges Vehikel ein
Instrument mit Mut anstatt mit Gießkanne
wir haben nämlich ein zielgenaues
Hilfskonstrukt geschaffen es gibt ja
auch Unternehmen die können nicht zur
Sparkasse um die Ecke gehen und es ist
geklärt es gibt Unternehmen die haben
nicht von den corona-hilfen den vielen
die haben da nicht reingepasst und der
wirtschaftstabilisierungsfonds das ist
ein Baukasten und da ist jede Menge drin
unter anderem Kredite Bürgschaften aber
auch die stille Beteiligung
und in der Krise da sehen wir als Staat
primär die Chance und nicht nur die
Sanierungsfälle und das ist nämlich
genau richtig
und das Instrument der
stillenbeteiligung will ich hier nochmal
ganz besonders erläutern das ist eine
Eigenkapitalfinanzierung wir als Staat
wir gehen hin und wir übernehmen
Unternehmensanteile das bedeutet wenn es
dann wieder bergauf geht dann
partizipieren wir auch an dem Erfolg und
das war auch eine Lehre wenn man mal den
Blick über den Atlantik wirft die
Obama-Regierung die hat das sehr
erfolgreich auch praktiziert in der ein
oder anderen Krise und einiges dieser
Erkenntnisse sind auch beim Aufsetzen in
dieses Programm mit eingeflossen das ist
doch der Staat wie wir uns vorstellen
als Gemeinwohl orientierter
ankerinvestor unserer sozialen
Marktwirtschaft und das auch in
Krisenzeiten
und das Lufthansa Beispiel was wir eben
auch schon gehört haben zeigt doch dass
es geklappt hat wir haben die Jobs
gerettet wir haben aber auch dafür
gesorgt dass wir aus dieser Pandemie mit
der Pandemie rauskommen können dass wir
an den Gewinnen langfristig
partizipieren und ich nenne das mal so
das eine ist eine wirtschaftliche
Rendite und das andere ist die soziale
Rendite und die ist mir besonders
wichtig als Sozialdemokratin
und deswegen bitte ich Sie dass wir
gleich zustimmen dieses Instrument zu
verlängern bis nächstes Jahr 2022 zum 30
Juni wir wollen und das ist auch möglich
im Rahmen der von der EU-Kommission
gesetzten Rahmenbedingungen wir wollen
das Volumen noch mal anpassen weil wir
wie richtig gesagt nicht den vollen
Umfang benötigen wir gehen runter auf
150 Milliarden
und zum Abschluss möchte ich noch mal
hier ein Appell an alle richten
natürlich sind wir in der Pandemie
natürlich sind wir in der Krise wir
kommen dann nur miteinander raus
deswegen lassen sie sich impfen impfen
impfen werden sie in ihrem Umfeld das
ist der einzige Weg raus und das zweite
man kann auch noch ein persönlichen
Beitrag zu dieser ökonomischen Krise
leisten ich weiß nicht ob sie alles
schon ihre Geschenke haben für den
Weihnachtsbaum oder andere
Feierlichkeiten ich noch nicht und
vielleicht denken wir alle mal an den
lokalen Handel vor Ort und nicht den
online-riesen um die Ecke und besorgen
da vielleicht noch mal noch mal ein
bisschen ein oder andere
herzlichen Dank und gemeinsam kommen wir
da wieder raus
sagt Andrea Huppertz für die
SPD-Fraktion hier in ihrer ersten Rede
[Applaus]
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Dr Michael
espendiller für die afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube und ganz besonders liebe
Genossen von der FDP stellen Sie sich
vor Ihre Familie hat ihn nach 80 oder
100 Jahren Existenz die Verantwortung
für das Familienunternehmen anvertraut
und jetzt müssen sie hilflos zuschauen
wie dieses Unternehmen stirbt es stirbt
weil eine Regierung nach der anderen ihm
die Lebensgrundlage entzieht und das ist
keine Fiktion der deutsche Mittelstand
ist in Auflösung begriffen
traditionsreiche Firmen müssen dicht
machen und sich von verdienten und
langjährigen Mitarbeitern trennen und
die staatlichen corona-maßnahmen wirken
dabei wie ein Booster für diese
zerstörerische Entwicklung leider wird
auch die neue ampelregierung diesen
Prozess eher beschleunigen als Bremse
zwar geht es in diesem hier vorgelegten
Gesetzesentwurf um die Verlängerung von
wirtschaftlichen
Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen die sonst zum
Jahresende ausgelaufen wäre doch diese
Instrumente sind zu bürokratisch und
helfen zuvor das den großen und eben
nicht dem Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft
dem deutschen Mittelstand
[Applaus]
sie vergessen bei der Verteilung ihrer
milden Gaben nämlich all jene kleinen
und mittleren Unternehmen die im letzten
Existenzkampf gar nicht mehr die Kraft
haben sich mit ihrer Bürokratie
herumzuschlagen und genau jetzt zur
selben Zeit trudeln bei den
mittelständern die
rückforderungsbescheide zu corona-hilfen
aus dem ersten Lockdown im März 2020 ein
der Verband der Gründer und
Selbstständigen Deutschland befürchtet
dass das für viele Betriebe der
Todesstoß sein wird und dagegen Werte
Kollegen Unternehmen sie leider nichts
und das ist verantwortungslos
es passt aber leider auch zu einer
Politik die die Lebenswirklichkeit der
Unternehmer nicht mehr kennt und nicht
mehr versteht der Mittelstand ist der
Hauptarbeitgeber in Deutschland ist er
besteht aus 40 Millionen Menschen die
zum selbstständigen und Angestellten
Mittelstand gehören und diese Menschen
dürfen wir nicht vergessen in der
corona-maßnahmenzeit haben wir bereits
mehr als
300.000 selbstständige verloren ihre
Zahl ist damit auf rund 3,9 Millionen
gefallen das ist der tiefste Stand seit
25 Jahren und das ist eine riesiger
struktureller und innovativer Aderlass
der und sie aller alarmieren muss
wir in diesem Hohen Haus haben die
Aufgabe auch an die kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen zu denken
und da diese von dem hier vorgelegten
Gesetzesentwurf leider nur mangelhaft
profitieren können wir uns leider auch
nur enthalten wenngleich wie ihr Bemühen
um die Sicherstellung der Liquidität von
Firmen zum Erhalt größere Strukturen
durchaus anerkennen deshalb lehnen wir
den Gesetzentwurf auch nicht ab denn die
AFD will die deutsche Wirtschaft
unterstützen aber wir wenden uns
ausdrücklich gegen den Umbau unserer
Wirtschafts- und Gesellschaftsordnung
zulasten des Mittelstands und zulasten
unserer bürgerlichen Freiheiten wir
appellieren daher an Sie werte Kollegen
der Ampel haben sie auch endlich mal ein
Herz für die Kleinen Selbstständigen in
Deutschland
[Applaus]
michael espendeler war das für die
afd-fraktion hier zur zweiten dritten
Lesung
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
heißt das ganze technisch betrachtet und
dazu hören wir jetzt noch mal eine erste
Rede hier und zwar diesmal aus dem Rhein
der Grünen und das wird seinen Schäfer
sie ist jetzt Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Damen und Herren wir befinden uns immer
noch mitten in einer Pandemie Kliniken
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger Ärztinnen und
Ärzte sind am Rande ihrer
Belastungsgrenze oder schon weiter
darüber hinaus und wir sind es ihnen
schuldig dass wir konsequent im
Maßnahmen ergreift um diese Pandemie zu
bekämpfen ich bin froh sagen zu können
alle demokratischen Parteien dieses
Hauses sind sich darüber einig und das
ist wichtig denn wir müssen
zusammenstehen gegen die Ideologen von
Rechtsaußen die die Ängste der Menschen
für ihren macht
erhaltinstrumentalisieren das ist an
Schäbigkeit und ein Mensch Menschen nach
Verachtung nicht zu überbieten
angesichts gefährlicher Virusvarianten
und einer viel zu niedrigen Impfquote
und der Lage auf den Intensivstationen
sind wir weiterhin
zu kontaktbeschränkungen verpflichtet
Veranstaltungen müssen abgesagt werden
und wir müssen massiv in den Alltag der
Menschen eingreifen wir wissen dass
diese notwendigen Beschränkungen für
viele Branchen und Betriebe sehr
negative teils sehr tragische
Auswirkungen haben viele Unternehmen
sind unverschuldet und Not geraten und
wichtige Wirtschaftszweige wie zum
Beispiel die Veranstaltungsbranche die
Tourismusbranche oder die
Transportbranche und die Gastronomie
sind ganz besonders hart getroffen viele
Unternehmen können nicht mehr vernünftig
Wirtschaften was heißt das ja das heißt
dass viele Menschen da draußen Angst
haben gerade ihren Job zu verlieren das
heißt dass viele Eltern Angst davor
haben ihre Kinder nicht mehr ordentlich
versorgen zu können das Auszubildende
ihre Stelle verlieren und damit
natürlich auch ihre berufliche Zukunft
das sind die echten menschlichen
Schicksale die hinter so abstrakten
Begriffen wie eine abflauenden
Konjunktur stecken
und für die vielen kleinen Betriebe die
durch die notwendigen
kontaktbeschränkungen Straucheln haben
wir die unternehmenshilfen auf den Weg
gebracht das ist gut so aber wir
brauchen auch Hilfen und Instrumente für
größere Unternehmen denn auch sie
sichern zahllose Arbeitsplätze und
leisten einen großen Beitrag zur
Stabilität der Wirtschaft die gesichert
werden muss
[Applaus]
wir dürfen deshalb nicht zulassen dass
die erfolgreichen stabilisierenden
Maßnahmen mitten in der Pandemie
Auslaufen solange es die gravierenden
Einschränkungen gibt die unsere
Unternehmen aber auch Arbeitsplätze und
einkommengefährden brauchen wir sie und
heute können wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass die Handlungsfähigkeit unseres
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch
nach dem 31 dezember 2021 doch
sichergestellt ist wir müssen dieser
Verantwortung heute gerecht werden und
daher Platinen wir dafür die
Verlängerung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds bis
Mitte des nächsten Jahres zuzustimmen
aber und das möchte ich auch ganz
deutlich sagen es kann nicht sein dass
die Allgemeinheit für wirtschaftliche
Risiken aufkommt und das ohne
Gegenleistung
die Vermögen von und von privaten
Eigentümern gerettet werden es ist nicht
zu viel gesagt und verlangt dass bei den
Unternehmen die sich unter den
Schutzschirm stellen auch die
eigentümerseite zu Rettung beiträgt und
daher dient die Verlängerung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch der
Stabilisierung der Wirtschaft und nicht
der Stabilisierung von Manager Boni
wir werden alles dafür tun dass wir im
Haushaltsausschuss sicherstellen dass
auch keinen Steuergeld für
Dividendenzahlungen an an Aktionäre
gegeben wird das Geld muss da landen wo
möglichst viele Menschen profitieren und
nicht nur einige wenige
ja wir reden gerade über die Stabilität
unserer Arbeitsplätze unsere Einkommen
und unserer Wirtschaft und deshalb ist
es eben nicht egal wofür diese Gelder
ausgegeben werden denn zu Stabilität
unseres Wirtschaftens gehört nicht nur
die Rettung von Unternehmen und Jobs
sondern auch die Rettung unserer
Ökosysteme und darum muss klar sein wer
sich unter unseren Rettungsschirm stellt
der muss sich auch mit uns gemeinsam auf
den Pfad der Klimaneutralität begeben
denn es gibt kein Wohlstand ohne den
Schutz unserer Lebensgrundlagen vielen
Dank
das Wort hat die Kollegin Dr Gesine
Lötzsch für die Fraktion DIE LINKE
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren die neue Koalition
nennt sich nun fortschrittskoalition und
darum prüfen wir jedes Gesetz ob diesen
Anspruch auch gerecht wird und ich sage
was dieses Gesetz betrifft es ist kein
Fortschritt meine Damen und Herren ja
wir haben ja wir haben im März 2020 dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds
zugestimmt was waren unsere Gründe wir
wollten möglichst viele Arbeitsplätze
retten doch dem Gesetz und das habe ich
auch in der Rede damals gesagt vielen
damals schon klare soziale und
ökologische Regelung und die vermissen
wir auch in den neuen Gesetz und das
kann ich gehen meine Damen und Herren
die Lufthansa das ist ja schon erwähnt
worden von der FDP wurde mit
Steuergeldern gerettet aber das
Management hat daraufhin tausende
Beschäftigte entlassen und die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter die
bleiben durften mussten kräftige
geldeinbußen hinnehmen und auf der
anderen Seite war das Management nicht
bereit
die Öffentlichkeit über ihre Aktivitäten
in Steueroasen zu unterrichten das ist
nicht hinzunehmen das passt nicht
zusammen meine Damen und Herren
und wenn hier die KfW erwähnt worden ist
will ich doch mal der Öffentlichkeit
sagen dass in der KfW sehr sehr viele
also der Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau
unsere störtliche Förderbank sehr viel
Geld bewegt wird im Jahr 2020 zum
Beispiel waren es 135 Milliarden
Förderung aber im Verwaltungsrat der KfW
sind nicht alle Parteien vertreten und
das ist demokratisch nicht hinnehmen
meine Damen und Herren
die großen hat uns leicht an diese
Fördergelder zu kommen und ich bin immer
wieder entsetzt mit welchen
bürokratischen Aufwand kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen zugeschüttet werden
und wie bedingungslos Konzerne
Milliarden von Steuergeldern bekommen
das darf so nicht weitergehen meine
Damen und Herren
Fortschritt muss heißen klare soziale
und ökologische Vorgaben doch diesen
Fortschritt kann ich in diesem Gesetz
leider nicht erkennen meine Damen und
Herren es ist Zeit für mehr Solidarität
es ist Zeit dass die Vermögenden ihren
Beitrag leisten es ist Zeit für eine
Vermögensabgabe herzlichen Dank
war das von der Linken und die
Vermögensabgabe hatte sie heute schon
mal in einer Rede angeführt nämlich
heute morgen als es um den zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt gegen
Bundestag was ganz neues werden wir
jetzt hören denn es ist ihre erste Rede
von Katrin Michel für die
Sozialdemokraten
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen chestionier Kenia
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
zugegebenermaßen davon habe ich nicht
geträumt als ich dachte worüber ich
meine erste Rede halten werde im
Bundestag doch der Inhalt des Gesetzes
ist klar und deutlich es geht im Kern
dieser Debatte um nichts weniger als
eine krisenbedingt notwendige
Stabilisierung unser heimischen
Wirtschaft die Stabilisierung von
Unternehmen die von den Auswirkungen der
anhaltenden kovit 19 Pandemie
existenziell betroffen sind und nicht
zuletzt auch um den Schutz von
Arbeitsplätzen derjenigen Menschen die
Tag für Tag ihre Arbeit leisten und
damit unsere Wirtschaftskraft prägen die
zu Recht in der ganzen Welt Anerkennung
findet
Corona stellt uns weiterhin vor immense
Herausforderungen viele medizinische
Fachkräfte kämpfen täglich weit über
ihre Kräfte hinaus um das Leben von
Patientinnen und Patienten die auf
Intensivstationen behandelt werden
müssen dass wir den Gesundheitsbereich
schnellstmöglich und nachhaltig
entlasten und die angemessene Versorgung
von Menschen gewährleisten die schwer
krank oder verletzt sind oder sich einer
notwendigen Operation unterziehen müssen
hat höchste Priorität
zugleich wirkt sich die Pandemie auch
auf weitere Bereiche aus die wir im Zuge
der Krisenbewältigung nicht außer Acht
lassen dürfen
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer erleben
in Anbetracht der europa- und weltweit
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Lage auch
weiterhin eine ökonomische Unsicherheit
die wir als Gesetzgeber und
gesetzgeberinnen etwas entgegensetzen
müssen wir wollen und müssen das
Vertrauen in die reaktions- und
Handlungsfähigkeit des Staates
angesichts der anhaltenden corona-krise
Stärken ja wir haben die Pflicht
Lösungen auch für diese bestehende
ökonomische Unsicherheit zu bieten
aus diesem Grund stellen wir die
Handlungsfähigkeit des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch
über den 31 dezember 2021 hinaus sicher
die in unserem Gesetzentwurf vorgesehene
Verlängerung der befristungsregelung im
stabilisierungsfondsgesetz schafft die
notwendige gesetzliche Grundlage zur
Gewährung der Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
durch den Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds für ein weiteres
halbes Jahr eben bis zum 30.06 2022 wir
führen in diesem Zusammenhang eine
Antragsfrist bis zum 30 April 2022 ein
um eben Unternehmen im Speziellen
Bedarfsfall im besagten Zeitraum die
entsprechenden Hilfen gewähren zu können
mit dem vorgelegten Gesetzesentwurf
gewährleisten wir das Härten der
Pandemie abgemildert werden und
betroffene Unternehmen die Sicherheit
geboten wird die sie auch in den
kommenden Monaten dringend benötigen
werden
im Zentrum steht die Solvenz der
Unternehmen zu erhalten Arbeitsplätze
können gesichert werden und somit
entfaltet das Gesetz auch die nötige
arbeitsmarktpolitische Wirkung der
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds wurde
bereits 2020 eingerichtet und auch ich
habe hier das Beispiel der Deutschen
Lufthansa AG auf dem Zettel die stillen
Rücklagen des Bundes konnten vorzeitig
zurückgezahlt werden und das zeigt eben
sehr deutlich dass das hier diskutierte
Instrument wirkt es bietet die
entscheidende Brücke die entscheidende
Brücke für Unternehmen um aus der
finanziellen Hilfsbedürftigkeit rasch zu
unternehmerischen Selbstständigkeit
zurückzufinden es stabilisiert unsere
Wirtschaft wie auch den Arbeitsmarkt
nachhaltig und zugleich ist die
Belastung der öffentlichen Haushalte bei
Anwendung dieser Maßnahme begrenzt auch
durch die im vorgesehene Möglichkeit
staatliche Beteiligung an Unternehmen zu
erwerben und garantieprämien zu erheben
in diesem Zusammenhang trainiere zitiere
ich abschließend unseren Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz kluge Politik zahlt sich aus
und ja kluge Politik zahlt sich in der
Tat aus sie zahlt sich aus wie die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sie
zahlt sich aus für die Stärkung unserer
Wirtschaftskraft und es zeigt sich
deutlich dass das Gesetz genau den
Rahmen bietet den wir brauchen um
weiterhin gemeinsam die Krise zu
bewältigen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen Sie es uns gemeinsam
angehen denn nur so werden wir Erfolg
haben vielen Dank und Glück auf
verbringe ich denn hier mit ihrer ersten
Rede
sie ist über die Landesliste Sachsen
übrigens in den Bundestag eingezogen und
kommt aus der Lausitz
Sebastian Brehm letzte Redner hier zu
diesem Tagesordnungspunkt für die
Unionsfraktion frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mit dem vorliegenden Gesetz sollen die
corona-hilfen für Unternehmen und die
Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen bis
30.06.2022 verlängert werden das ist
notwendig an Gesichts der weiter
anhaltenden Pandemie
wir werden insbesondere unsere
Mittelständler in Deutschland hier nicht
im Regen stehen lassen
das ist selbstverständlich auch übrigens
in unserer neuen Rolle auch Opposition
deshalb stimmen wir heute diesen Gesetz
auch zu
immerhin
ist es eine Verlängerung eines von der
cdu/csu initiierten und eingeführten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds Corona
bedingte Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen waren
zunächst bis 31.12 21 begrenzt und
werden nun richtigerweise bis
30.06.2022 verlängert soweit alles okay
aber es sind drei Dinge die mir große
Sorgen machen erstens
die Beantragung der Hilfen wird nur bis
zum 30.4 genehmigt keine
Fristverlängerung obwohl das Programm
bis
30.06.2022 läuft das ist unsystematisch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
handwerklich übrigens falsch und zeugt
davon dass sie nicht aus der Praxis
kommen und wissen welche Belastung hier
auf den Mittelstand zukommt insbesondere
weil auch im ersten Quartal 2022 die
Schlussrechnungen für 20 und 21
vorgenommen werden müssen zweitens
das haben sie im Koalitionsvertrag zu
vereinbart sie wollen die
Schuldentilgung von 20 Jahren um weitere
16 Jahre auf 36 Jahre verlängern und sie
sprechen von nachhaltiger
Haushaltspolitik das ist keine
nachhaltige Haushaltspolitik sondern
belastet die nächsten Generationen
maßgeblich und drittens
und drittens und das macht mir die
allergrößten sorgen niemand weiß wie die
Ampelkoalition dieses finanzieren will
es liegt kein finanztablor vor die FDP
hätte übrigens damals in ihrer damaligen
Rolle das nie durchgehen lassen und
sofort kritisiert heute ist der
Finanzminister von der FDP und legt kein
finanztable vor also er macht eine
intransparente Haushaltspolitik und er
habe wurde gefragt im ZDF und hat gesagt
ja es gäbe wohl eine Finanzplanung aber
in der Tat hätte man die vielleicht
offenlegen müssen gleichwohl keine
Offenlegung um kein finanztableau und
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wer keine
Offenlegung und keine transparente
Haushaltspolitik macht der hat was zu
verschweigen oder steht zumindest im
Verdacht was zu verschweigen zu wollen
und deswegen frage ich mich warum
und die Frage ist ganz einfach
sie wollen offiziell und offensichtlich
die mit der Nichtvorlage der
Finanzplanung die Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse machen der Kollege dürrer
hat gesagt in der Diskussion im
Bundestag es gibt keine Neuverschuldung
in der Tat gibt es eine Neuverschuldung
von 60 Milliarden Euro das ist die
Wahrheit und es müssen sie auch in der
Debatte sagen und was noch viel
schlimmer ist was noch viel schlimmer
ist
es gibt sie ändern die Buchungsregeln
für diese Sondervermögen
vereinfacht heißt es für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger das Geld kann von in diesem
Sondervermögen ohne Beteiligung des
Haushaltsausschusses für alles andere
verwendet werden außer für die
corona-maßnahmen sie Bunkern damit Geld
im Haushalt für Wahlgeschenke
2023/2024 wenn Ausgaben gemacht werden
muss der Haushaltsausschuss hier
beteiligt werden das ist eine Umgehung
aus meiner Sicht des Haushaltsrechts des
Deutschen Bundestages und es werden wir
ja auch nicht durchgehen lassen das muss
verfassungsrechtlich geklärt werden
gestatten Sie eine Frage oder Berater
jawohl Otto Fricke fragt für die
FDP-Fraktion als Regierungspolitiker
immer als ein fachlich
ausdifferenzierter Kollege
doch wirklich klar geworden und das fand
ich auch immer sehr sehr gut selbst wenn
man unterschiedlicher Meinung ist
deswegen würde ich sie gerne darauf
hinweisen dass sie erstens von zwei
völlig verschiedenen Dingen reden sie
bewusst durcheinanderbringen erstens
was Sie bei diesem Gesetzentwurf hier
kritisiert haben die Fragen der
auseinandergehung der antragspflicht und
die Frage bis wann der Fond noch
arbeitet darf ich Sie darauf hinweisen
dass wenn die CDU wünscht die
antragspflicht bis Ende Juno weiter
vorzusetzen dann müssten Anträge die im
Ende Juno eingehen noch im Juli
bearbeitet werden und dann werden sie
uns Ende Juno sagen wir müssen aber den
Fond noch weiter verlängern denn sie
müssen bearbeiten drittens
drittens Herr Kollege Bremen könnten Sie
mir sagen welchen Änderungsantrag dieser
Art die CDU gestellt hat im Ausschuss
oder hier im Plenum um dieses angeblich
zu verhindern viertens neue Schulden
werden nicht gemacht die
kreditermächtigung bleibt auf dem Niveau
wo sie ist im Haushalt hier streichen
wir kreditermächtigung von 50 Milliarden
und darüber hätten sie reden können
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank ist sie verlängern damit
ihr auch meine Redezeit um noch mal zu
erläutern also vielen Dank
bisher war das immer so dass die
Antragsfristen auch gleich lautend waren
mit der Frist sozusagen oder mit dem
Lauf des Programms und das genau und das
Kürzen sie jetzt bewusst um die
Unternehmer noch mehr unter Druck zu
setzen und diejenigen die die Anträge
bearbeiten müssen damit nein eben nicht
wenn sie sie haben es doch verkürzt er
ist der erste bis 30.04 ist kürzer als
erste erster bis 30.06 das ergibt sich
doch aus der Mathematik schon alleine
also insofern da haben sie glaube ich
werden sie nachbessern müssen es wird im
Frühjahr dazu kommen mit den
schlussabrechnungen mit dieser großen
Belastung des Mittelstands dass sie die
Fristen verlängern müssen um nicht das
Programm zu verlängern aber die
beantragungsfristen müssen sie
verlängern übrigens je mehr sie oder je
mehr Sie die Antragsfristen verkürzen
desto mehr Schätzungen wird es geben
weil man natürlich das auf den fünften
und sechsten Monat schätzen muss das
heißt mehr Unsicherheit gibt es im
deutschen Mittelstand auch bei der
Schlussabrechnung und Rückzahlung also
sie gehen das bewusst ein wir haben das
diskutiert wir haben das auch
angesprochen in der ersten Lesung aber
sie wollten ja nicht hier eine Änderung
vornehmen als er letztlich macht es auch
gar keinen Sinn jetzt ein anderer zu
stellen wo man weiß das ist eh ablehnen
also wenn wenn müssen sie schon einfach
mit aufnehmen aber sie werden es eben
machen müssen sie werden es eben machen
müssen das wird sich im Verlauf der Zeit
im Frühjahr auch ergeben und zweitens
sie nehmen sehr wohl 60 Milliarden neue
Schulden auf und sie ändern sehr wohl
die buchungsregelung für diese
Sondervermögen also das können sie nicht
bestreiten und es liegt auch kein
finanztablow vor das können sie nicht
bestreiten also haben sie intransparente
hauspolitik Haushaltspolitik sie zeigen
uns nicht auf wie Sie das letztendlich
finanzieren und sie geben es auch nicht
in den Haushaltsausschuss wenn hier
Mittel noch frei bleiben wie die dann
ausgegeben werden das ist doch der
Vorwurf das hätten sie wenn sie in der
damaligen Rolle gewesen wären niemals
durchgelassen die reden vom Kollegen
dürr die Reden von ihnen die reden von
der gesamten FDP von meinem Kollege
Lindner die hätte ich eins zu eins heute
hier halten können sie haben innerhalb
von fünf Tagen eine komplette
Kehrtwendung ihrer finanzpolitischen
haushaltspolitischen Grundsätze gemacht
das ist die Wahrheit und das muss man an
seinen solchen Tag auch mal leider sagen
können
die Verlängerung wird kommen müssen aus
praktischen Gründen man wird aber auch
diese haushaltspraktik und diese
Intransparenz letztlich auch in
Karlsruhe prüfen müssen und dann bin ich
gespannt was dabei rauskommt ich denke
dass sie hier nachbessern werden müssen
so lassen wir Ihnen das nicht durchgehen
herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Brehm war das für die cdu/csu
Fraktion allerdings jetzt zu diesem hier
vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf hatte die
cdu/csu-fraktion wo Zustimmung
signalisiert die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung
des
stabilisierungsfondsgesetzes und des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsbeschleunigungsgesetzes
der Hauptausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 246
den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache 189 anzunehmen ich bitte
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen und
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich das sind die
Fraktionen der AFD und die Linke der
Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen
dritte Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der
SPD-Fraktion der FDP-Fraktion der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und der
cdu/csu-fraktion bei Enthaltung der
Fraktion der AFD und die Linke
angenommen
ich rufe an das hatte sich ja in der
Debatte schon angedeutet dass mit den
Ampel Koalitionären hier die
cdu/csu-fraktion eben zustimmt dass
dieser corona-hilfen um ein halbes Jahr
verlängert werden auch wenn das Volumen
insgesamt
verringert wird
und jetzt kommen wir schon zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt ja es war eine
Einigung im letzten Moment kann man
sagen nämlich kurz vor der
Bundestagswahl kam der Rechtsanspruch
zur Ganztagsbetreuung für
Grundschulkinder noch durchzufuhr hatten
Bund und Länder heftig und lange über
die Finanzierung gestritten aber im
September hat der Vermittlungsausschuss
gerade noch rechtzeitig ein Kompromiss
erzielt das Bundestag und Bundesrat
zustimmen konnten sonst wäre das Ganze
verfallen und hätte es von vorne
diskutiert werden müssen wer bezahlt das
alles der große streitpunkt war das in
der Verhandlung einige Länder fanden
dass der Bund so wenig dazu geben wollte
man einigte sich darauf dass der Bund
zunächst mit 3,5 Milliarden
Investitionskosten sich be sieht es wird
nun in dem hier vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf darum gehen die Laufzeit
des Investitionsprogramm für den
beschleunigten Ausbau der
Ganztagsbetreuung für Grundschulkinder
um ein Jahr zu verlängern
und es gibt übrigens auch noch einen
Gesetzentwurf der cdu/csu-fraktion der
hier mit beraten Wurf der entdeckt sich
in vielen Punkten mit dem der
Ampelkoalition
die Laufzeit des Programmes sagt die
cdu/csu müsste aber nicht nur verlängert
werden
öffne die auch die Fristen für die
entsprechenden Mittel sollen angepasst
werden also das werden wir noch
detailliert in der Aussprache hören und
jetzt eine erste Rede einer neuen
Ministerin nämlich von Anne Spiegel der
neuen Bundesfamilienministerin sie war
ja vorher schon Landesministerin in
Rheinland-Pfalz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Abgeordnete sehr geehrte
zuhörende eines der beliebtesten
Gedichte der deutschen heißt Stufen der
Titel ist nicht so bekannt aber den Satz
jedem Anfang wohnt ein Zauber inne den
kennen sehr viele und er passt zu diesem
Tag in verschiedener Hinsicht politisch
weil die neue erste Ampelkoalition auf
Bundesebene ihre Arbeit aufgenommen hat
und zeigt sie will etwas bewegen und so
hoffe ich sie wird auch viel bewegen
aber auch
aber auch für mich persönlich passt der
Satz denn dies ist meine erste Rede als
Bundesfamilienministerin in diesem Hohen
Hause und das gleich zu einem Thema dass
mir auch wirklich sehr am Herzen liegt
es geht um eine gute
zuverlässige Kinderbetreuung die Kinder
und Familien stärkt dafür hat die letzte
Bundesregierung mit dem Rechtsanspruch
auf Ganztagsbetreuung für
Grundschulkinder die Weichen gestellt
und jetzt ist der Zug aus dem Bahnhof
und es liegt in den kommenden Jahren
noch eine lange Strecke vor uns und
deshalb sorgen wir heute dafür dass
unser ganztagszug richtig ins Rollen
kommt ich möchte mich zunächst mal ganz
herzlich bedanken bei den Fraktionen und
dort insbesondere bei den
berichterstatterinnen und
Berichterstattern dass sie diesen
Gesetzentwurf eingebracht haben er ist
wahrlich ein Entwurf aus der Mitte des
Parlaments
wir verlängern mit diesem Gesetzentwurf
die Fristen für die erste Tranche der
Investitionsmittel für den Ausbau von
Ganztagsschulen die Länder erhalten
damit ein Jahr mehr Zeit um die
insgesamt 750 Millionen Euro abzurufen
die der Bund seit Ende 2020 bereitstellt
das fordern auch der Bundesrat und die
cdu/csu-fraktion in ihren jeweiligen
Gesetzentwürfen aber wir gehen darüber
noch hinaus indem wir die Förderstruktur
vereinfachen wir schlagen die
zusätzlichen bonusmittel in Höhe von
nochmal 750 Millionen Euro den Basis
Mittel im ganztagshilfegesetz zu somit
sind zukünftig
2,75 Milliarden Euro im Topf und damit
setzen wir erstens eine Forderung des
Koalitionsvertrages um zweitens kommen
wir damit den Ländern entgegen sie
benötigen mit Blick auf die besonderen
Herausforderungen der corona-pandemie
des Baustoffs und des Fach heute mangels
einfach mehr Zeit um die
Investitionsmittel abzurufen
und drittens und auch das ist wichtig
wir bauen mit dem Gesetz Bürokratie ab
und wir schaffen mehr Planungssicherheit
für Länder und Kommunen was die
Bundesmittel für den ganztagsausbau
angeht meine Damen und Herren was wir
heute der Abstimmung vorlegen ist der
nächste Schritt auf dem Weg zu einer
verlässlichen guten Ganztagsbetreuung in
unserem Land dass wir nur wenige Tage
nach der Regierungsbildung schon diesen
Schritt gehen das freut mich aber ich
sage auch
ich sage auch dass es heute nur der
Anfang gemeinsam mit meinem Haus und
Ihnen liebe Abgeordnete will ich in den
kommenden Jahren der verarbeiten dass
wir unseren Koalitionsvertrag umsetzen
wir wollen das Gute Kita-Gesetz fort
entwickeln und bis Ende der Legislatur
in ein
qualitätsentwicklungsgesetz überführen
wir wollen die Kinder Grundsicherung auf
den Weg bringen
wir wollen den Ausbau der
Ganztagsangebote für Grundschulkinder im
gemeinsamen mit den Ländern voranbringen
und dabei geht es nicht nur um
zusätzliche Horträume ich weiß Gebäude
sind wichtig es heißt nicht umsonst der
Raum ist der dritte Pädagoge es geht
auch um Qualität es geht um förder- und
Freizeitangebote die Kinder wie
Pädagoginnen wie Eltern überzeugen es
geht um Lern- und Lebensorte an denen
sich unsere Kinder wohlfühlen und die
von den Kindern her gedacht und
konzipiert sind und das
und das geht nicht ohne Personal und
deshalb werden wir eine Gesamtstrategie
auf den Weg bringen um mehr Fachkräfte
zu gewinnen und im Beruf zu halten und
noch einiges mehr
das alles kann der Bund nicht alleine
leisten das ist eine gesamtstaatliche
Aufgabe für die es eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung braucht das Gute ist
wir wissen wofür wir es tun für gute
faire Bildungschancen für alle Kinder
und für eine gute Vereinbarkeit auf die
sich Eltern verlassen können damit sie
ihre Kinder auf ihrem Weg in unsere
Gesellschaft gut begleiten können
Schritt für Schritt und Stufe für Stufe
und lassen Sie mich abschließend
ausdrücklich für diese vielen Schritte
und Stufen denjenigen danken die gerade
in einer corona-pandemie tagtäglich in
den Schulen dafür sorgen und zwar
angefangen bei den Hausmeister über die
Reinigungskräfte über die Lehrkräfte die
Schulsozialarbeit bis zu den
Schulleitungen und der Verwaltung die
dafür sorgen dass unsere Kinder
tagtäglich gut lernen gut aufwachsen
können und sie mit diesem
Bildungsangebot ein Anker der Stabilität
und Geborgenheit in sehr schwierigen
corona-pandemie haben
alle Spiegel die neue
Bundesfamilienministerin kennt das
Ringen und den Ausbau der
Ganztagsbetreuung für Grundschulkinder
aus Länder und aus jetzt Bundes sich
denn sie war bis Mai 2021 Ministerin für
Familie Frauen und jugendintegration in
Rheinland-Pfalz seit der Landtagswahl
dann für Klimaschutz und Umwelt
zuständig und seit letzten Mittwoch hier
die Bundesministerin und in der
Aussprache folgt ihr jetzt Dorothee Bär
für die CDU CSU-Fraktion jedes Mal
möchte ich ganz herzlich den beiden
neuen Ministerinnen die jetzt auch
gleich in der Debatte sprechen werden
gratulieren zum neuen Abend liebe Frau
Spiegel liebe Frau starkwatzinger
herzlichen Glückwunsch alles Gute ich
freue mich auf die Zusammenarbeit mit
Ihnen und es wird sicherlich in der
Sache an der ein oder anderen Stelle
auch hart zugehen in den nächsten Jahren
aber immer angemessen im Ton heute ist
es ein Thema wo wir noch nicht streiten
müssen weil sie dankenswerterweise den
Antrag von uns abgeschrieben haben
wir haben gemeinsam am Ende der letzten
Legislaturperiode ja beschlossen die
Nachmittagsbetreuung für
Grundschulkinder auszubauen und ab 2026
kommt der Rechtsanspruch das ist ein
wirklicher Meilenstein für Familie und
Beruf und auch ein maßgeblicher Beitrag
für mehr Bildungsgerechtigkeit in
unserem Land es ist uns wichtig weil es
auch eine echte Entlastung ist für den
Kern unserer Gesellschaft für die Mütter
und Väter in unserem Land die eben jeden
Tag unser Land am Laufen halten und es
ermöglicht und es ist unserer Fraktion
ganz besonders wichtig eben auch echte
Wahlfreiheit
wir haben zugesagt dass die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen geschaffen werden das
Mittel bereitgestellt werden und mit dem
Gesetzentwurf der Regierungskoalition
jetzt zu Änderung des Ganztags
finanzierungsgesetzes und des Ganztags
finanzhilfegesetzes wird jetzt endlich
ich sag endlich weil es jetzt wirklich
kurz vor Schluss ist am Jahresende die
Frist für die Kommunen zum Abruf der
Mittel aus dem ganztagsausbau vor
verlängert das begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
wir begrüßen es weil wir wirklich etwas
auch schaffen nicht nur für die Familien
auf der einen Seite sondern weil wir
auch als Fraktion für die Kommunen auf
der anderen Seite dafür sorgen dass wir
Planungssicherheit für unsere Kommunen
in diesem Land bekommen
Planungssicherheit dass der Ausbau der
nachmittagsbetreuungsplätze auch
weitergehen kann ein ganz ganz wichtiges
Signal und liebe Frau Ministerin Spiegel
sie haben es gerade selber in ihrer Rede
gesagt gut und zuverlässig das
unterstütze ich ausdrücklich und sag
ihnen aber auch an dieser Stelle das
hätten sie alles schon viel früher haben
können warum haben Sie denn unseren
Antrag abgelehnt am 11 November mit
genau dem gleichen Inhalt warum
abgelehnt obwohl er eins zu eins der
gleiche Inhalt ist warum uns ein
Gesetzentwurf vom 18 November hätten sie
auch schon haben können jetzt haben wir
eine Woche vor Weihnachten und die
Kommunen mein Kollege wird ja gleich
noch dazu sprechen von der
kommunalpolitischen Seite hat natürlich
die ganzen Beschwerden bekommen der
Kommunalpolitiker die sich gefragt haben
zuverlässig ist diese neue Regierung für
die Kommunen es bedauere ich sehr der
Bundesrat hat sie auch überholt ihre
eigen regierten Länder haben nicht an
sie geglaubt und haben deswegen auch
noch mal in der Sitzung am 26 November
beschlossen den eigenen Gesetzentwurf
einzubringen einziger Gegenstand der
Fristverlängerung weil das Vertrauen
eben ihre eigenen Länder in sie auch
nicht gegeben ist es muss ihnen doch zu
denken geben an dieser Stelle
jetzt haben wir eben in dem
Gesetzentwurf neben der unzweifelhaften
notwendigen Fristverlängerung auch die
Zusammenlegung der Basis und Bonus
Mittel das ist eine gute Entscheidung
auch das hätten wir gerne schon von
Anfang an in der vorherigen Regierung
beschlossen nur wer hat es abgelehnt wer
hat es abgelehnt der damalige
Bundesfinanzminister ich glaube
mittlerweile ist der Bundeskanzler also
er hat es auf jeden Fall abgelehnt
hätten auch schon länger haben können
ist ja gut dass jetzt eine erfreuliche
Einsicht da ist aber es ist halt schade
so also mir tut es leid weil viel
Vertrauen in die Kommunen ohne Not
zerstört wurde mir tut es leid dass ohne
Not auch viel Vertrauen bei den Familien
verloren gegangen wurde ich kann Ihnen
nur anbieten dass wir immer die Familien
und die Kinder in den Mittelpunkt
unseres Handels stellen und ich wünsche
mir einfach weil es ja heute schon
mehrfach angesprochen wurde dass die
neue Koalition behauptet dass die Macht
des besseren Argumentes zählt dass sie
auch auf eine so gute
Oppositionspartei wie die CDU und die
CSU auch setzen wir zum Wohle der
Familien zum Wohle der Kinder in unserem
Land herzlichen
Dorothee Bär die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
und wer von wem hier abgeschrieben hat
bei den Gesetzentwürfen ja dazu wird es
vielleicht noch die ein oder andere
Stellungnahme geben der
Gesetzentwurf der Unionsfraktion ist
wohl schon im Ausschuss für erledigt
erklärt worden
man hat sich da abgestimmt zwischen der
Ampelkoalition und dann wird es wohl
nachher Zustimmung geben jetzt hören wir
für die SPD Ulrike Bahr liebe Kollegen
Kolleginnen sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerinnen es ist bemerkenswert dass
wir in diese noch sehr jungen
Wahlperiode bereits zum dritten Mal in
vier Wochen über die Finanzierung des
ganztagsausbaus für Grundschulkinder
sprechen aber als Bildungs- und
familienpolitikerin ist mir das
natürlich mehr als recht besonders wenn
es vorangeht heute machen wir mit dem
breit signalisierten Zustimmungen der
Fraktionen den Weg frei für längere
Fristen und das ist der Unterschied zu
ihrem Antrag Frau Kollegin Bär nämlich
auch weniger Bürokratie beim ab Mittel
für den ganztagsausbau
das ist gut das ist gut und richtig und
setzt gleich zu Beginn dieser
Wahlperiode das Signal dass es uns ernst
ist mit guter Bildung und mit echten
Chancen für alle Kinder die Förderung
von Kindern im Ganztag ist nach dem
digitalpakt für schon ein weiteres
Projekt bei dem sich die neue
Kooperation von Bund und Ländern in
Bildungsbereich bewähren kann denn wo
große nationale Anstrengung erforderlich
sind brauchen wir ein kooperationsgebot
kein Kooperationsverbot
nun gilt es die ganztagsförderung ganz
praktisch mit Leben zu füllen vor Ort
mit kindgerechten Räumen und
Bewegungsmöglichkeiten mit
qualifiziertem und motivierten
Fachpersonal und vor allem mit klugen
Konzepten und Angeboten die schulische
Förderung muss ich sportliche Bildung
aber auch Spielspaß und soziales
Miteinander unter einen Hut bringen wir
als Bund Stellen erst einmal nur nur in
Anführungszeichen das Geld zur Verfügung
ein doch was wichtiger Aspekt denn ohne
verlässliche Finanzierungszusagen können
die Kommunen nicht planen und sich nicht
an die Arbeit machen dennoch die
eigentliche Anstrengung folgt noch und
wird uns auf allen Ebenen Bund Länder
und Kommunen noch weiter beschäftigen
noch dringlicher als die v-vorhaben und
noch wesentlich langsamer zu bewältigen
ist der Fachkräftemangel in der
tierischen berufen und ich bin sehr froh
dass wir uns im Koalitionsvertrag der
Regierungsparteien darauf verständigt
haben mit hoher Priorität mit den
Ländern und allen relevanten Akteuren
eine Gesamtstrategie zu entwickeln um
den Fachkräftebedarf für
erziehungsberufe zu sichern
sie liegt auch am Herzen keine
unerwünschten Konkurrenzen aufzubauen
neben Kita und Grundschule braucht auch
die Erziehungshilfe ganz dringend mehr
qualifiziertes Personal diese Sorge eint
Jugendämter und freie Träger darum ist
es nötig sehr schnell voranzukommen mit
einem bundeseinheitlichen Rahmen für
eine vergütete und attraktive Ausbildung
und auch mehr Studienplätze zu schaffen
für Soziale Arbeit und Pädagogik
Weiterbildungen zweite Ausbildungen und
solide nachqualifizierungen für
Quereinsteiger müssen das Angebot
abrunden
die Investitionen in unsere Kinder
dulden keinen Aufschub dann Bildung und
gutes aufwachsen hat ein enges
Zeitfenster in der Pandemie ist uns das
wieder sehr plastisch klar geworden als
Lehrerin habe ich immer wieder sehr
eindrücklich erlebt wie schwierig es ist
auch größere lärmrückstände im laufenden
Schulbetrieb auch wieder aufzuholen und
ähnliches gilt auch für soziale
Lernerfahrungen darum haben wir heute
zwar Fristen verlängert um auf
baustoffmangel und fehlende
Planungskapazitäten zu reagieren aber
wir dürfen uns trotzdem keine Zeit
lassen auch die qualitative
Ausgestaltung und Weiterentwicklung der
Ganztagsangebote wollen wir in dieser
Wahlperiode begleiten und fördern denn
die Qualität entscheidet darüber ob
Kinder nur verwahrt oder umfassend
gefördert werden
und nur die Förderung bietet wirkliche
Bildungschancen zu Qualität gehört auch
Schulen zu öffnen Erfahrungsräume zu
weiten mit externen Partnern zusammen zu
arbeiten und eine aktive Partnerschaft
von Schule und Jugendhilfe umzusetzen
damit meine ich auch aber keineswegs nur
die Schulsozialarbeit die seit dem
Sommer letztendlich im achten
Sozialgesetzbuch verankert ist und auch
hier gibt es ein Projekt für diese
Wahlperiode die Koalitionsfraktionen
haben beschlossen an Schulen in sozialen
Brennpunkten dauerhaft schulische
Sozialarbeit zu fördern
darüber hinaus wünsche ich mir viele
Kooperationen mit der offenen
Jugendarbeit ein ungewohntes Terrain für
die Schulen aber eine Bereicherung für
die Kinder im Sinne eines ganzheitlichen
bildungsansatzes heute
heute sorgen wir erst einmal dafür dass
die Mittel für den Ganztag bei den
Ländern und Kommunen wirklich abgerufen
werden können und ein kleines Puzzleteil
ist dies auf dem Weg zur besseren
Bildung und familienfreundlichen
Strukturen in Deutschland darum vielen
Dank für Ihre Zustimmung und
Unterstützung danke Ihnen
Ulrike Baba das aus der SPD-Fraktion in
der zweiten und dritten Beratung zur
ganztagsfinanzierungsgesetzes geht
insbesondere darum dass
Finanzierungshilfen des Bundes an die
Länder zum Ausbau von
ganztagsbetreuungsmöglichkeiten
verlängert werden und jetzt spricht in
dieser Debatte Martin Reichert für die
afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren schon die
letzte Debatte hat gezeigt dass die
Fristverlängerung des
ganztagsfinanzierungsgesetzes im Grunde
eine Scheindebatte zwischen alter und
neuer Regierung ist es geht darum wer
was vergessen hat und das hat man sich
auch heute hier wieder vorgeworfen sie
reden über Ganztagsbetreuung während
sich Schüler in ganz Deutschland ihr
Recht auf Bildung mit Tests und Impfung
der kaufen sollen sie reden von
Ganztagsbetreuung und meinen eigentlich
die schnellstmögliche Mobilmachung von
Eltern für den Arbeitsmarkt
wir als AFD wollen selbstbestimmte
Wahlfreiheit der Eltern zwischen
elterlicher und Fremdbetreuung und
können uns von daher in dieser Frage nur
enthalten sie reden meine Damen und
Herren von Ganztagsbetreuung während die
FDP Bildungsministerin sagt Impfung von
Schulkindern sei ein wichtiger Beitrag
um Präsenzunterricht zu sichern die FDP
zusammen mit Ihnen allen hier von den
anderen Fraktionen nehmen sich die
Freiheit heraus Eltern zu drangsalieren
mit Impfung oder Schulschließung mit
Impfung oder Ausschluss von sozialer
Teilhabe jetzt sollen schon die
fünfjährigen die Ärmel hochkrempeln um
sich damit Bildung und letztlich dann
auch die von Ihnen hier versprochene
Teilhabe zu sichern dazu sagen wir
eindeutig nein hände weg von unseren
Kindern
wer ständig schwobelnde Minister
Lauterbach nötigt Kinder und Eltern zu
einer Impfung mit Aussagen die keinem
Faktencheck standhalten liebe Eltern
können Eltern eigentlich eine Minister
Vertrauen der sich in der Vergangenheit
öfter geirrt hat als er seine Socken
wechselt meine Damen und Herren
können Eltern Politikern vertrauen die
mit kalter Berechnung Kindern einreden
dass sie eine Gefahr sind liebe Eltern
vertrauen Sie nicht denen denen das Wohl
unserer Kinder weniger wert ist und um
dass sie sich weniger Scheren als um
ihre Ablehnung der Impfpflicht von
gestern meine Damen und Herren
und in dieser ganzen Frage geht es auch
weiter die STIKO gibt eine Empfehlung
für vorerkrankte Kinder von fünf bis elf
Jahren und deren Impfung also keine
allgemeine Empfehlung für diese
Altersgruppe das Paul-Ehrlich-Institut
weist fünf Kinder aus dem Zusammenhang
mit der Impfung gestorben sind und viele
Ärzte weisen diese als medizinisch nicht
ausreichend zurück trotz all dieser
Bedenken sollen jetzt das hat sehr viel
damit zu tun sollen jetzt Kinder in Zoos
von mobilen impfteams geimpft werden
meine Damen und Herren sie reden von
Ganztagsbetreuung aber sie machen das
eine sie würdigen Kinder seit Monaten
zur Verfügungsmasse ihrer Politik herab
die Familienministerin Spiegel will die
Impfung will mit der Impfung ab fünf
Jahren die Pandemie in die Knie zwingen
meine Damen und Herren allein für diese
unsinnige Aussage müssten sie eigentlich
ihren Stuhl wieder räumen
hören Sie endlich auf die Kinder und die
Eltern zu instrumentalisieren stellen
sie wirkliche Normalität in der
Betreuung von Kindern und in der Bildung
wieder her die roten Linien sind
überschritten das hat ihr Kanzler
bereits gesagt beenden sie endlich die
unsinnigen corona-maßnahmen für Kinder
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
und damit ihr keine Missverständnisse
aufkommen dieser Tagesordnungspunkt der
gerade diskutiert wird in dem geht es um
die Verlängerung des
Investitionsprogramms für die
Ganztagsbetreuung da gibt es ja einen
Gesetz und ab
von ab 2021 wird ein Rechtsanspruch auf
Ganztagsbetreuung für alle Kinder im
Grundschulalter ab dem 1 August 2026
stufenweise eingeführt jetzt die zweite
Ministerin in dieser Debatte Bettina
stark Watzinger aus der FDP
Bundesministerin für Bildung und
Forschung
diese Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Herr Abgeordnete Reichert
ich muss auf ihre unhaltbaren Aussagen
gar nicht eingehen aber klar impfen ist
der Weg aus der Krise das Angebot an die
Kinder ist eine Chance das Bildung in
unserem Land stattfinden kann damit die
Schwächsten in unserer Gesellschaft
überhaupt eine Chance haben wir sprechen
heute vordergründig über eine
Fristverlängerung aber dahinter steht
viel mehr wir wissen doch heute dass die
Grundlage für die Bildungswege in der
frühen Kindheit gelegt werden und wenn
wir heute darüber sprechen dass der
Ganztag kommt zügig kommt das
Versprechen auf den Ganztag dann ist das
auch das Angebot an Chancen an Chancen
im Bildungsweg das geht uns alle an und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir es heute
beschließen
die christverlängerung die
Fristverlängerung ist schlicht sinnvoll
da sind wir uns einig wir heute ein
Handwerker buchen möchte der weiß wie
das ist und deswegen ist es gut dass wir
es machen und liebe Frau Bär ich freue
mich auf die Zusammenarbeit und ich bin
mir sicher die wird gut sein aber es ist
ein kluger hesse hat gesagt denken muss
man selber und das kann ich Ihnen
versprechen können wir als Regierung und
deswegen ist unser Gesetzentwurf besser
als das was sie als Antrag eingebracht
haben so das wird das unkompliziert
machen das ist ein Teil dessen was wir
kooperationsgebot nennen es muss uns um
die Sache gehen ja es waren
Konjunkturpaket Mittel aber die Länder
brauchen mehr Zeit da geht es jetzt
nicht um alte politische Muster wir
ändern zügig das Gesetz ein Jahr länger
Zeit die Länder kommen leichter an die
Mittel die bonusmittel sollen in den
basistopf Fließen Anteil für jedes Land
ergibt sich aus dem Königsteiner
Schlüssel das ist das was wir brauchen
Kooperation Hand in Hand von
Ländern und Kommunen reibungslos
zielorientiert und immer mit dem Blick
was den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern in
unserem Land wirklich nützt davon
brauchen wir mehr wenn wir die Bildung
in unserem Land voranbringen wollen denn
auch darin sind wir uns einig die
Bildung in unserem Land ist nicht auf
dem Niveau dass wir uns für ein
Industrie und eine Kulturnation wie wir
sind uns wünschen jeder fünfte
Jugendliche kann nicht gut lesen schon
in der Grundschule hapertis lernen dort
wirklich die Kinder die Grundkompetenzen
in Lesen und Schreiben nein sagt uns die
Wissenschaft zu viele lernen es nicht
ausreichend da müssen wir ran mit mehr
Engagement Engagement breiterem
Engagement und vor allen Dingen mit viel
mehr Mut meine Damen und Herren
und
das Ziel ist die weltbeste Bildung für
alle
unabhängig von Wohnort von der Herkunft
und davon ob Eltern unterstützen oder
nicht der Bund steht bereit wir wollen
keine zentrale Bildungspolitik im Sinne
von ersetzen der Bund leistet ein on top
Engagement für eine on top Bildung meine
Damen und Herren und dazu gehört dass
wir den Schulen auch mehr Freiraum
lassen Schulen die viel mehr selbst
bestimmen Sie wissen was ihre
Schülerinnen und Schüler brauchen das
ist der Weg zu mehr Qualität der
Rechtsanspruch kommt und da muss auch
das Angebot stimmen da geht es nicht um
Quantität sondern da geht es auch um
Qualität nur so nutzen wir die Chance
das ganztags besseres lesen lernen Mint
Sport und soziales Lernen das ist der
Weg in die Bildungsrepublik
das ist der Weg der neuen Bundesrepublik
der neuen Bundesregierung mehr Qualität
in der Bildung zu sichern ich will dazu
so schnell wie möglich mit den Ländern
ins Gespräch kommen mehr Zeit und Geld
und Bildung investieren das heißt gut
investieren jedes Kind das wir so
mitnehmen ist ein Gewinn meine Damen und
Herren
und deshalb
deshalb ist klar wenn der Bund extra
Geld gibt dann muss auch extra Qualität
ankommen das müssen wir möglich machen
dafür treten wir als Regierung dafür
trete ich als Ministerin an meine Damen
und Herren vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat nun die
Kollegin Nicole Gohlke das Wort
Unicorn Gurke ist eine der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
in der Linksfraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jetzt bringen wir also heute
auf den Weg dass die Mittel für den
beschleunigten Ausbau des Ganztags nicht
nur bis Ende diesen Jahres sondern bis
Ende nächsten Jahres abgerufen werden
können das ist eigentlich eine
Selbstverständlichkeit es schafft
Planungssicherheit für die Länder
Kommunen und Träger und deswegen stimmt
die Linke diesem Gesetzentwurf der Ampel
auch zu aber ich muss schon sagen ich
muss schon sagen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen diese letzten drei Debatten zu
diesem Thema mit heute sind es ja sogar
glaube ich vier haben schon auch so ein
bisschen ein Geschmäckle wie man so
schön sagt die Rednerinnen und Redner
der Ampel feiern sich hierfür diese
Selbstverständlichkeit ab und man kann
wirklich nur hoffen dass die Union
irgendwann mal ihre Phantomschmerzen
überwinden wird nicht mehr zu regieren
das ist auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen
ein Problem jetzt Kolleginnen und
Kollegen jetzt muss es aber darum gehen
den Rechtsanspruch für auf
Ganztagsbetreuung für Grundschulkinder
auch Realität werden zu lassen ihn auch
umzusetzen jetzt muss es um die Fragen
gehen wie der enorme Fachkräftemangel im
Bildungsbereich beseitigt werden kann
denn ohne mehrpädagogisches Personal
ohne mehr pädagogisches Personal und
Fachkräfte ohne mehr
Schulsozialarbeiterinnen und
Schulsozialarbeiter wird ein Ganztag ja
gar nicht möglich sein und es muss jetzt
dringend um Qualitätsstandards gehen
darum wie wir zu einem guten Ganztag
kommen was wir nämlich wollen ist ein
Ganztag wo die Kinder gerne hingehen
weil es mehr ist als die Verlängerung
von Leistungsdruck und Stress in den
Nachmittag rein sondern wo ein
angemessener Betreuungsschlüssel und
kleine Gruppen endlich mit dabei helfen
die soziale Spaltung in diesem Land zu
beenden das sind jetzt die Themen die
anstehen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen sie uns
nicht weiter kostbare Zeit verplempern
machen sie einen Aufschlag zur
Entwicklung verbindlicher
Qualitätsstandards legen Sie eine
zeitplanvorspannung silikultusminister
in den Konferenz die Jugend und
familienministerinnenkonferenz die
Fachverbände mit ein und dann lassen Sie
uns loslegen wir arbeiten gerne daran
mit vielen Dank
sagt Nicole Burke die eine der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden in der
Linksfraktion und ihr wird jetzt folgen
am Rednerpult Maria Lisa Maria pardon
Maja Lisa Verlass aus der SPD-Fraktion
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bildung
Forschung und Technik Folgen Abschätzung
und es geht nach wie vor um den Ausbau
der Ganztagsbetreuung für
Grundschulkinder
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren in meiner Rede vor ein
paar Wochen habe ich übrigens auch wie
viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen der jetzt
neuen Ampelkoalition versprochen dass
wir uns als neuer Regierung zeitnah um
die Fristverlängerung für den Abruf der
beschleunigungsmittel für den
ganztagsausbau kümmern werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wissen Sie was
unsere Botschaft damals an Schulträger
an Familien an unsere kommunale Familie
war deutlich wir lassen euch nicht
allein
und
kauf vier Wochen später liegt bereits
das Gesetz von SPD von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und der FDP vor und heute
befinden wir uns jetzt in der
abschließenden Lesung ein Blick auf die
Überschrift unseres koalitions und damit
ist das Motto der Ampelkoalition
deutlich und klar gesagt getan wir
erkennen die Probleme und kümmern uns
zeitnah um deren Lösung darauf können
sich die Familien die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und unserem Land verlassen
und da ich auch selber
kriminalpolitikerin bin nicht nur unsere
Familien können sich auf uns auf die
Ampel verlassen auch die Bürgermeisterin
und Bürgermeister die
Kommunalpolitikerinnen und
Kommunalpolitiker im Grunde ist zu den
Kriterien der fristenverlängerung zum
Gesetzentwurf schon alles gesagt worden
meine liebe Kollegin Ulrike Bahr und
auch unsere beiden neuen Ministerin
herzlich willkommen hier unserer
Bildungs- und familienpolitikfamilie
haben das schon sehr detailliert
ausgeführt ich möchte daher den Fokus
setzen auf das was wir uns in der
Ampelkoalition im Bereich Ganztag in den
nächsten vier Jahren vorgenommen haben
der Koalitionsvertrag ist überschrieben
mit mehr Fortschritt Wagen und als
Lehrerin die viele Jahre auch selber
unterrichtet hat weiß ich wie wichtig
eine gute Bildung ist echter Fortschritt
klappt nämlich nur mit einer guten
Bildung die Eltern unabhängig ist und
von der Herkunft der Eltern entkoppelt
wird
es ist das große Versprechen der
deutschen Sozialdemokratie daran
arbeiten wir mit unseren Partnern schon
seit vielen vielen Jahrzehnten wir sind
noch nicht am Ziel aber ich glaube wir
werden es erreichen das ist unsere große
Hoffnung für unsere Kinder die unsere
Zukunft sind und am Ende des Tages geht
es nicht nur um den Ganztag in der
Grundschule es geht auch um eine
Bildungschance von der Kita über die
Schule bis hin zum Meister oder zum
Master
und der Ganztag spielt dort eine
Schlüsselrolle Frau stark Watzinger hat
das ja eben auch schon ausgeführt und am
Ende ja müssen wir uns tatsächlich mit
zwei Punkten noch mal verstärkt
beschäftigen das eine ist die Frage der
Qualität wie wir sie definieren wie soll
Qualität im Ganztag eigentlich aussehen
und mit der Frage wie wir den
Fachkräftemangel lösen werden
wissen Sie wenn man als Lehrkraft in
einer Klasse steht und mitbekommt wie
viel Arbeit das ist wie man rödeln muss
20 oder sogar 30 Kinder und Jugendliche
mit unterschiedlicher Ausbildung mit
unterschiedlichem Perspektiven mit einem
unterschiedlichen Rucksack mit dem man
dort ankommt wenn man die mitnehmen will
das ist ganz ganz viel Arbeit und umso
kleiner die Kinder sind umso aufwendiger
ist das Ganze von daher ist das eine
Aufgabe die wir schultern müssen wir der
Bund in Zusammenarbeit mit unseren
Ländern mit unseren Kommunen Ganztag ist
eine Gemeinschaftsaufgabe liebe
Kolleginnen und Kolle
wir dürfen die Lehrkräfte die
pädagogische Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter eben aber auch alle anderen
die in Schule und Kita Arbeiten an
dieser Stelle nicht alleine lassen und
meine Botschaft als
SPD-Bundestagsabgeordnete ist wir die
Ampel lassen Sie und lassen euch an
dieser Stelle nicht allein und heute ist
der erste Beweis dafür dass wir unseren
Worten die wir uns in den
Koalitionsvertrag hineingeschrieben
haben auch Taten folgen lassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
auf die nächsten vier Jahre gemeinsam
mit den Kolleginnen und Kollegen von den
Grünen und der FDP mit unseren glaube
ich sehr tollen Ministerinnen ich freue
mich schon auf die Zusammenarbeit dieses
Thema weiter zu betreuen in diesem Sinne
Ihnen allen ein frohes Weihnachtsfest
Maja Lisa Völler ist am Ende noch mit
einem klein wenig Überschwang in
Richtung der neuen Ampel Koalition sie
war die vorletzte Rednerin in dieser
Beratung letzter Redner wird André
berghegger sein der aus der
Unionsfraktion kommt und
diese Aussprache dann beschließen würden
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
lassen sie mich zum Schluss der Debatte
noch einige Gedanken an sie richten aus
Sicht der Kommunen ich würde mal sagen
konstruktive Opposition zahlt sich aus
das sieht man an diesem Beispiel
deswegen vielen Dank an
vielen Dank an die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus meiner Fraktion die sich
immer wieder um dieses Thema gekümmert
haben aber ehrlicherweise wir stimmen am
Ende zu das hat meine Kollegin Bea am
Anfang gesagt aber etwas Wasser muss ich
in den Weinen doch Gießen sehen Sie es
als Anregung für zukünftige Projekte
worum geht es eigentlich wir haben den
Anspruch auf Ganztagsbetreuung für die
Grundschulkinder und dieser erfordert
natürlich bautechnisch ein riesen
Kraftanstrengung das haben wir gehört
keine Zeit ist zu verlieren denn es
fehlen rund 800.000 zusätzliche Plätze
um diesen Anspruch ab 226 aufsteigend
umzusetzen der Bund unterstützt diese
Baumaßnahmen
holzschnittsartig mit dreieinhalb
Milliarden Euro und ein Teil dieser
Mittel 750 Millionen werden für den
beschleunigten Ausbau vorgesehen der
Begriff gibt es vor die Mittel sollen
schnell umgesetzt werden damit schnell
gebaut werden kann aber die Frist für
den Mittelabruf dieser Mittel durch die
Kommunen die Frist soll schon dieses
Jahr enden und das ist natürlich viel zu
schnell für die Kommunen und bedeutet
große Probleme und darauf reagieren wir
jetzt aber ehrlicherweise die
vorliegenden Gesetzesänderung hätten
viel schneller kommen können und können
kommen müssen wenn sie sind wir reden
nicht von einer Woche denn sie sind
dringend notwendig sie alle wissen die
Kommunen sind nicht originär zuständig
für die Ganztagsbetreuung im
Grundschulalter
der Bund wenn er fördert und das macht
er gerne muss aber praktikable
Regelungen treffen und da gibt es Luft
nach oben für die Zukunft die Kommunen
brauchen Planungssicherheit beim Ausbau
keine Unsicherheit es geht doch wer vor
Ort ist wer den Kontakt zu den Kommunen
hat es geht um große bausummen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Ampel
mit etwas mehr Mut mit etwas mehr
Entscheidungsfreude wäre das Thema schon
längst entschieden und das haben sie
leider versäumt
wir hatten
wir hatten bereits vor Wochen einen
entsprechenden Antrag gestellt den haben
sie geparkt und damit wertvolle Zeit
verstreichen lassen ehrlicherweise bis
zum letzten Sitzungstages bis zum
letzten Sitzungstag dieses Jahres und
das ist recht knapp und diesen
Zeitverlust den können die Kommunen
eigentlich nicht so hinnehmen und das
müssen sie sich vorhalten lassen wenn
wir wenn wir nicht immer wieder Druck
gemacht hätten würden sie würden Sie im
Zweifel wir verlassen uns doch auf die
Gesetzesbeschlüsse und nicht auf
Ankündigung das müssen sie auch immer
berücksichtigen
steht noch mehr drin sie kennen ich
komme noch dazu sie kennen doch die
angespannte Situation im Bausektor bei
den Handwerkern das führt zu
Verzögerungen es wäre wichtig gewesen
den Frist zum Abruf dieser besonderen
Mittel viel schneller um ein Jahr auf
das Ende 2022 zu verlängern die Kommunen
müssen doch die Chance haben diese
Mittel auch abzurufen Frau
Frau stark Watzinger ich höre diese
großen Linien gerne und dafür schätze
ich sie auch das unterstreiche ich auch
das finde ich auch richtig aber wir
müssen noch in Zukunft auf
praxisgerechte Regelungen warten und wir
wissen doch dass mit dem zögern den
ganztagsausbau ehrlicherweise zum Teil
ein Bärendienst erbracht worden ist sie
haben es zu vertreten wenn einzelne
Baumaßnahmen wegen der Unsicherheit
verschoben worden sind und teilweise
sogar weniger Plätze vorhanden sind als
zuvor weil wir wissen doch auch in der
Praxis manchmal werden Baukörper
abgerissen und praxisgerecht um neue
modern um größer zu bauen und wenn eine
Unsicherheit vorherrscht dann stellt man
eben als Bürgermeisterin oder
Bürgermeister eine solche Maßnahme ein
jetzt holen wir das nach es ist aber
eine Anregung für die Zukunft
und ihre und ihre Begründung ihr
Gesetzesentwurf sei ja weitergehender
weil er die technisch komplizierten
bosens und basismittel zusammenführt
ehrlicherweise überzeugt mich das nicht
ganz wir hätten ohne Probleme in unserem
Gesetzesentwurf eine Änderung aufnehmen
können wir hätten schon bereits im
Sommer einen Vorschlag gemacht das wurde
auch schon angesprochen der damalige
Finanzminister hat das nicht akzeptiert
das finde ich schade und fahrlässig und
sie schreiben sich doch auf die fahren
enger mit den Kommunen
zusammenzuarbeiten und deswegen mache
ich mir sorgen für die Zukunft ich würde
mir wünschen Verlässlichkeit gegen den
gegenüber den Kommunen die sieht aus
meiner Sicht anders aus handeln Sie
bitte schneller und pragmatischer lassen
Sie Ihren Worten auch Taten folgen die
Kommunen müssen wir nicht verunsichern
lieber Matthias Seestern pauli sondern
wir sollten ihnen vertrauen und sie
stärken vielen Dank fürs freundliches
zuhören
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von den
Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Änderung des Ganztags
finanzierungsgesetzes und das ganztags
Finanz Hilfe gesetztes der
Hauptausschuss empfiehlt unter Buchstabe
a seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 259 den Gesetzentwurf der
Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP auf Drucksache 190 anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um das
Handzeichen
danke wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält
sich danke der Gesetzentwurf ist mit den
Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen der
Fraktion DIE LINKE der Fraktion der
cdu/csu bei Enthaltung der afd-fraktion
angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
danke wer stimmt dagegen
niemand wer enthält sich
danke der Gesetzentwurf ist bei
Enthaltung der afd-fraktion mit den
Stimmen der übrigen Fraktionen des
Hauses angenommen
unter Buchstabe b seiner
Beschlussempfehlung empfiehlt der
Hauptausschuss den von der Fraktion der
cdu/csu eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Fristverlängerung für den beschleunigten
Infrastrukturausbau in der
Ganztagsbetreuung für Grundschulkinder
auf Drucksache 83 für erledigt zu
erklären wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält
sich die Beschlussempfehlung ist
einstimmig angenommen
Tagesordnungspunkt 6 b wir setzen die
Abstimmung zu der Beschlussempfehlung
des Hauptausschusses auf Drucksache 259
fort der Ausschuss empfiehlt und der
Buchstabe c seiner Beschlussempfehlung
den Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksachen 29 mit dem Titel
Planungssicherheit für Familien und
Kommunen Frist für den beschleunigten
Infrastrukturausbau in der
Ganztagsbetreuung verlängern für
erledigt zu erklären wer stimmt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung danke wer
stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich die
Beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig
angenommen
ich rufe auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 und dieser
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 ist ein Antrag der
afd-fraktion in dem es um den
Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken geht und sogar die
wieder in Betriebnahme von Kraftwerken
die bis mindestens zum Ende des nächsten
Jahrzehnts ermöglicht werden soll der
Hintergrund oder die Begründung der
afd-fraktion zu diesem Antrag ist das
Ziel eine Blackout zu reduzieren eine
Blackout Gefahr zu reduzieren welche
vorrangig auf die wetterbedingt
unsichere Wind und solareinspeisung
zurückzuführen sei so formuliert es
jedenfalls die afd-fraktion deren erster
Redner in dieser Debatte Steffen caudré
sein wird während die Fachpolitiker hier
im Plenum noch mal die Plätze tauschen
also die die sich vorrangig mit dem
Thema Ganztagsbetreuung
familienbildungspolitik und allem was
dazugehört beschäftigt haben verlassen
jetzt den Saal die Umwelt und
Energiepolitik
vor weil dann die natürlich hier mit
ihrer Expertise gefragt sein werden in
den nächsten knapp
30 40 Minuten wie diese Debatte dann
dauern wird über den Antrag wie gesagt
der aus der afd-fraktion kommt
und wenn wir noch ein bisschen Zeit
haben bevor die Werte eröffnet wird
vielleicht eine kleine Information noch
vorab denn tatsächlich so hat die
Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung dieser
geschrieben Zeitung dieser Tage
geschrieben ist das Stromnetz stabiler
als gedacht die Anzahl der Stromausfälle
die unterbrechungsdauer ist sogar
gesunken in den vergangenen Jahren
Details gleich noch dazu jetzt erstmal
Steffen coutry
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren aufgrund der
weltdümmsten Energiepolitik haben wir es
mittlerweile fünf Minuten vor zwölf die
Energieversorger schlagen Alarm E.ON
Chef Birnbaum prognostiziert das Strom
Unterdeckung zu Abschaltung ganzer
Städte führen kann und das mit den hohen
Energiepreisen die Industrie aus unserem
Land gejagt wird und auch der
Übertragungsnetzbetreiber Amprion um nur
den einen zu nennen äußert sich ähnlich
sie alle sprechen von erheblicher Gefahr
für unsere Stromversorgung aufgrund der
jetzigen Situation das Stromnetz ist
schon jetzt an seine Leistungsgrenze
angekommen Reserven gibt es nicht mehr
und beenden Sie meine Damen und Herren
bitte jetzt die Lebenslüge dass wir
mittelfristig ohne Kohle und Kernkraft
auskommen werden würden denn ihre
Antwort auf die Stromlücke Gaskraftwerke
und Stromimporte sind der Vater Morgana
zusätzliche Gaskraftwerke sind nicht in
Sicht niemand wird sie bauen und wo soll
das Gas denn eigentlich auch herkommen
wenn die Bundesregierung nordstream 2
verhindern will wenn unsere naive
Außenministerin mit ihrer
Ungeschicklichkeit und mit ihrem
kindlichen Größen waren gegen Russland
und unsere Gasversorgung schießt und
agiert und damit erinnert sie eher an ja
an Größen vielleicht wie Kaiser Wilhelm
II denn an eine moderne die promaten
meine Damen und Herren deutschland
braucht eine
Energieaußenpolitik und keine
energieverhinderungspolitik meine Damen
und Herren
und zum anderen Punkt Stromimporte wird
es in Spitzenlastzeiten eben nicht geben
können weil genau dann eben auch das
Ausland den Strom selbst braucht und die
Antwort ist deshalb naheliegend
Weiterbetrieb der rentablen
Kernkraftwerke
und immer mehr Stimmen sprechen auch
dafür zum Beispiel der Chef für
Volkswagen oder der Ex-Chef von BASF um
auch hier nur einige zu nennen und die
ganze Welt setzt auf die nahezu CO2
freie Kernenergie die Niederlande haben
gerade ihren Fehler eingesehen und
steigen in die Kernenergie wieder ein
eine Großzahl von Kernkraftwerken sind
weltweit in Planung und im Bau und
selbst der sogenannte Weltklimarat geht
davon aus dass die Klimaziele ohne
Kernenergie gar nicht zu erreichen sind
ja viele Menschen haben Vorbehalte
gegenüber der Kernenergie Angst vor
einem Super-GAU aber diese Angst ist
unbegründet moderne Reaktorkonzepte
schließen solche Katastrophen aus meine
Damen und Herren und teilweise ist eine
selbsterhaltende Kettenreaktion
überhaupt nicht mehr notwendig
Forschungsreaktoren diesbezügliche Art
sind längst schon im Bau im angeblich
technologieorientierten Deutschland
jedoch leider nicht
die Endlagerproblematik wird mit der
Transmutation gelöst Reststoffe werden
wiederverwertet heutige strahlungszeit
von 100.000 Jahren verringert sich
morgen 300 übermorgen vielleicht gar
keine mehr das ist
wissenschaftlicher technologischer
Fortschritt meine Damen und Herren den
sie verhindern wollen
die linksgrünen sie wollen CO2-Ausstoß
verringern wir wollen eine preiswerte
sichere Stromversorgung na dann lassen
Sie uns doch zusammenkommen mit moderner
und nahezu CO2-freier Kernenergie ist
eben beides möglich das wäre eine
intelligente das wäre eine versöhnende
und das wäre eine verantwortungsvolle
Politik meine Damen und Herren
aber sie die sie die Kernenergie
verhindern wollen sozusagen als ewig
Gestrige sie werden die Renaissance der
sicheren Kernenergie nicht verhindern
können was sie sicherlich verhindern
dass es unser Wohlstand da sind sie
Weltmeister ihnen zu vernichten wir
werden also gerne Energie später
technologisch wieder teuer einkaufen
müssen aber seien Sie mir sicher um die
Kernenergie kommen wir nicht drum herum
da können sie sich Kopf stellen sie es
nicht mehr aufzuhalten
[Applaus]
der Bundestag diskutiert über einen
Antrag aus der afd-fraktion zum
Weiterbetrieb von
Atomkraftwerken hintergrund ist ein
befürchteter Blackout wenn
beispielsweise Wind und Solar als
Energiequellen nicht reichen nicht
Rednerin in dieser Debatte ist Sena ab
die aus der SPD-Fraktion und es ist ihre
erste Regel im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen meine Damen
und Herren es ist mir eine große Ehre
hier und heute meine erste Rede halten
zu dürfen und obwohl das erst meine
erste Rede hier ist hatte ich an Dejavue
als ich diesen Antrag las erst im
letzten Monat hatte sich die
afd-fraktion in einer Debatte eine
Renaissance der Atom- und Kohle Energie
herbeigewünscht und auch der heutige
Antrag der afd-fraktion basiert wie
gewohnt auf grundlegenden Falschaussagen
und in die Jahre gekommenen Mythen
Atomkraft sei unerlässlich
umweltfreundlich billig und sicher
lassen Sie mich das richtigstellen
beginnen wir mit dem Antrag behaupteten
Blackout der Stromversorgung bereits
dieser Punkt ist falsch
wissenschaftler:innen des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung haben
erst kürzlich wieder in einer Studie
betont dass auch nach Abschaltung der
letzten Atomkraftwerke die
Stromversorgung in Deutschland gesichert
ist
die Forscher in betonen die Wichtigkeit
des Atomausstiegs und einen schnellen
Umstieg auf erneuerbare Energien das
entspricht auch dem politischen
Zielsetzungen die wir im
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten haben
dort bekennen wir uns klipp und klar zum
Ausbauen zur Nutzung erneuerbarer
Energien
auch wird leider immer noch häufig
behauptet dass die Atomenergie
CO2-neutral und damit umweltfreundlich
sei auch das stimmt nicht zahlreiche
Studien zeigen dass bei solchen
Behauptungen die energieaufwendigen
Faktoren der atomenergien nicht
berücksichtigt werden denn auch beim
Abbau von Uran beim Kraftwerksbau und
bei der langwierigen Endlagerung werden
Treibhausgase ausgestoßen für den Bau
der Atomkraftwerke sind neben Stahl und
Zement zudem auch Edelmetalle notwendig
kurzum die Branche der Kernenergie ist
eines ganz sicher nicht emissionsfrei
daher sollte die Kernenergie auch auf
europäischer Ebene nicht als grüne
Energie eingestuft werden
ein weiterer Punkt der Häufigkeit
dargestellt wird und auf denen meine
Kolleginnen aus der Fraktion schon
mehrfach aufmerksam gemacht haben die
Atomenergie zahlt sich nicht aus
Atomkraftwerke sind und waren auch nach
Vergangenheit volkswirtschaftsschädigend
da die wirklichen Kosten durch massive
politische Subventionen abgefedert
wurden die Kosten für die Stromerzeugung
von Wind und Sonnenenergie liegen seit
Jahren darunter
außerdem bleibt die Kernenergie unsicher
in Kernkraftwerken sind jederzeit
schwerwiegende Unglücke möglich wir alle
haben die katastrophalen Bilder aus
Tschernobyl und Fukushima noch immer
ganz deutlich vor Augen von weiteren
Unfällen in anderen Regionen die weit
weniger mediale Aufmerksamkeit bekommen
haben ganz zu schweigen
eine große Herausforderung stellen die
hochradioaktiven Abfälle da die
Endlagerung radioaktiver Abfälle muss
für sage und schreibe eine Million Jahre
gewährleistet sein die damit verbundenen
Risiken sind einfach nicht vorhersehbar
es ist mir zum einen unerklärlich wie
sich eine solche Aufgabe für kommenden
Generationen rechtfertigen lässt zum
anderen
zum anderen frage ich sie in welchen
ihrer Vorgärten hätten Sie es denn gern
lassen Sie uns
lassen Sie uns lieber zukunftsgerichtet
nach vorne schauen die atomeenergie ist
ein reliktvergangener Zeiten sie ist
unsicher umweltschädlich eine
unvorstellbare Belastung für zukünftige
Generationen und dazu noch teurer als
klimafreundliche Energie
ich begrüße es sehr dass wir
ich begrüße es sehr dass wir dem
endgültigen Atomausstieg in Deutschland
zeitlich näher kommen dass die
afd-produktion
Entschuldigung gesetzlich erledigt das
hat er ihnen Kollege sich zu einer Frage
oder Bemerkung gemeldet er hat aber
zurückgezogen
gegen Deutschland seitlich näher kommen
dass die afd-fraktion alten Zeiten nach
trauert und dabei wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse komplett missachtet sind
wir bereits aus diversen Debatten
gewohnt wir hingegen beschäftigen uns
derweil mit dem Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien und der Zukunft unseres Landes
beschäftigen sie sich weiterhin mit
ihren Blackouts vielen Dank
das aus der SPD-Fraktion mit ihrer
ersten Rede im Deutschen Bundestag und
die ist auf großen Applaus der eigenen
Fraktion gestoßen insbesondere die
Schlussbemerkung in dieser Debatte geht
es weiter mit Jens Köppen aus der
Unionsfraktion
dort hat der Kollege Jens K
öppen für die SU
-Fraktion vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Transformation der Energieerzeugung
zu nachhaltigen umweltfreundlichen zu
bezahlbaren und vor allen Dingen aber
auch zu verfügbaren Energien bleibt eine
oder die größte Herausforderung der 20er
und 30er Jahre
auch vor dem Hintergrund dass die
dass der Energiehunger weltweit ins
Unermessliche steigt und vor einigen
Jahren haben wir noch hier gestanden und
haben über Energieeinsparungen
gesprochen davon ist weltweit überhaupt
gar nicht mehr die Rede und zu dieser
Mammutaufgabe kann ich uns nur Erfolg
wünschen uns allen aber das funktioniert
natürlich nur wenn es einigermaßen
Ideologie frei zugeht
es geht nur wenn es auch wenn sie da
stöhnen wenn es auf faktenbasis
stattfindet auf die Naturgesetzen und
nicht auf der Basis von Tagträumereien
und sonst werden wir scheitern denn in
nicht einmal drei Wochen
werden wir die vorletzten drei
Kernkraftwerke abschalten die übrigens
zu den weltweit besten und sichersten
gehören
es handelt sich immerhin um 4,5 Gigawatt
dazu kommen noch die ersten
Kohlekraftwerke sodass ab dem ersten
Januar nahezu 9 Gigawatt fehlen werden
und es gibt bisher keine politische
Antwort keine von niemanden auf die
Frage wie die fehlende Leistung ersetzt
werden kann die gibt es schlecht finde
ich nur die Hoffnung auf die Nachbarn
ist einfach irgendwie zu wenig denn die
Frage ist werden Sie helfen können und
die Frage können Sie am Ende helfen zwar
stellt der Präsident der
Bundesnetzagentur Jochen Humann im
August des Jahres fest dass die
Zuverlässigkeit der Stromversorgung im
Jahre 2020 erneut sehr gut sei
er stellt außerdem fest dass die bisher
niedrigste
Ausfallzeit des Jahres 2019 im Jahr 2020
noch mal
Unterboden werden konnte und das
allgemein ist keine negativen
Auswirkungen auf die
Versorgungssicherheit gibt in der Tat
ist diese Presseveröffentlichung erstmal
ermutigend sie ist auch beruhigend ein
gutes Signal aber die Frage ist wie
lange noch wenn wir die Abschaltzeiten
sehen
und die neue Bundesregierung ist in der
Pflicht dieses Niveau der
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland
mindestens
abzusichern und es reicht eben nicht
auch Kollege ab Kollegen Abdi einfach
nur zigtausende Windräder in Deutschland
zusätzlich hinzustellen oder wertvolle
Agrarflächen mit Solaranlagen
zuzustellen denn auch in der neuen
Regierung bleibt es dabei in der neuen
Regierung bleibt es auch dabei dass bei
Dunkelheit und Flaute diese halt keinen
Strom produzieren und speichern
speichern kann man diese großen
Strommengen auch nicht und schon gar
nicht in Gigawatt Scheiben
und auch mit Wasserstoff wird es
schwierig und auch Erdgas haben Sie hier
und da Probleme und stehen auf Kriegsfuß
und in ihren Koalitionsvertrag ist
unmissverständlich festgeschrieben dass
man am Atomausstieg in Deutschland
festhält idealerweise in Kohleausstieg
auf das Jahr 2030 vorziehen will wie sie
aber die Ziele am Ende des Tages
erreichen wollen bleibt durchgehend
offen und noch mal neue Windkraftanlagen
neue Solaranlagen sind kein Garant für
Versorgungssicherheit sie können immer
nur Teil einer Lösung sein nur Teil
einer Lösung egal wie viel die Fläche
zugestellt wird und dann können sie auch
noch so laut schreien da muss schon mehr
kommen die Bürger warten konkrete
Antworten wie die Versorgungssicherheit
mindestens auf dem jetzigen EU
abgesichert werden sollen sonst bleibt
ihr ganzer Koalitionsvertrag in diesem
Kontext lediglich grüne Makulatur
herzlichen Dank
sagt Jens Köppen aus der Unionsfraktion
in einer Debatte die sich mit dem
Weiterbetrieb von Atomkraftwerken
beschäftigt dazu noch die Information
spätestens Ende letzten Jahres soll das
letzte Atomkraftwerk in Deutschland
abgeschaltet sein und dann wird der
Strombedarf was die inländische
Produktion angeht zum einen noch aus den
laufenden Kohlekraftwerken gespeist
werden als auch aus erneuerbaren
Energien und ob das an der einen oder
anderen Stelle reicht das wird hier und
da bezweifelt nächster Redner ist der
neue umweltpolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen Stefan
Wenzel
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren sehr geehrte Abgeordnete vor gut
zehn Jahren hat der ehemalige
Bundesumweltminister Professor Klaus
Töpfer den Bericht der Ethikkommission
an die Bundesregierung übergeben
Frau Ministerin Frau Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel und Herr bundesminister Rösler
haben diesen Bericht damals
entgegengenommen das ist jetzt zehn
Jahre her und dieser Bericht hat das
Ende der tumenergie in Deutschland
besiegelt meine Damen und Herren gestern
Mittag habe ich versucht den Antrag zu
bekommen der Fraktion der AFD der lag
gestern Mittag noch nicht vor offenbar
scheint es da bei ihnen ein bisschen ein
bisschen Probleme zu geben zehn Jahre
wussten sie was kommt und ein Tag vor
dieser Debatte hatten sie ihren Antrag
noch nicht fertig meine Damen und Herren
da spricht für sich vor zehn
Jahren
vor zehn Jahren meine Damen und Herren
da trafmann
überzeugte
Atomphysiker die sichtlich geschockt
waren nachdem sie gesehen haben was in
Fukushima passiert ist und die auch ganz
persönlich dazu sehr eindrucksvoll
berichtet haben dass sie sich sowas
schlicht und einfach nicht haben
vorstellen können zumal in allen Studien
die es damals gab von erasmusstudien bis
zu vielen anderen solche Ereignisse
kategorisch ausgeschlossen wurden die
wurden einfach schlicht und einfach für
nicht möglich gehalten und dann kam der
Bericht der Ethikkommission
wissenschaftsbasiert da waren sehr gute
serenommierte Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler dabei anerkannte
Persönlichkeiten der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland energiepolitiker und die
haben dann einen Bericht vorgelegt meine
Damen und Herren Deutschlands
Energiewende ein Gemeinschaftswerk
für Deutschlands Zukunft und dort hieß
es
zum atomsturm gibt es Alternativen die
allesamt weniger Risiken aufweisen
allesamt weniger Risiken aufweisen und
man hat dann entschieden sieben
Atomkraftwerke sofort abzuschalten nicht
mehr ans Netz zu gehen zu lassen und
Krümel auch nicht meine Damen und Herren
das ist jetzt zehn Jahre her und wichtig
war der Begriff Gemeinschaftswerk das
sage ich auch mit Blick auf Herrn Köppen
weil das ist nämlich ein ganz
entscheidender begriff dass wir das auch
in Zukunft als Gemeinschaftswerk
betreiben um hier
unsere Energieversorgung sicher
umweltfreundlich und klimafreundlich zu
machen und natürlich
natürlich steht die
Versorgungssicherheit dabei in erster
Stelle mittlerweile haben wir fast 50
Prozent erneuerbaren Strom aus einer
heimischen Energiequelle nämlich den
Erneuerbaren meine Damen und Herren
teilweise wir haben Bundesländer die
Decken mittlerweile schon 90 Prozent des
Verbrauchs ab mit der erneuerbaren
Energie jetzt kommen wärmeverkehr und
Industrie dran dafür hat die
Ampelkoalition Pläne vorgelegt die
Netzbetreiber haben in den letzten
Jahren massiv investiert und sie haben
die Versorgungssicherheit ständig
verbessert die Ausfälle im Netz sind
global gesehen die geringsten und jetzt
kommt mit dem Projekt we dispatch 2.0
noch eine Steigerung und da geht es sehr
wohl um Effizienz Herr Köppen da geht es
um Effizienz bei einem Betreiben des
Netzes da geht es aber auch an anderen
Stellen darum beispielsweise wieder eine
Investition in elektromobilität ist auch
eine Investition in Energieeffizienz
meine Damen und Herren
und wenn ich dann den Antrag ihrer
Fraktion hier auf der rechten Seite lese
meine Damen und Herren sie verbreiten
Märchen da wird von einer Art von
atommüllverbrennung gesprochen man will
Atome mit
Halbwertszeiten von über einer Million
Jahren quasi verbrennen da lesen Sie mal
nach die Gutachten der
endlagerkommission zur Transmutation so
das ist damals sehr das ist damals sehr
gründlich untersucht worden und das ist
von allen Seiten in Bausch und Bogen
verworfen worden meine Damen und Herren
das Projekt können sie vergessen sie
verbreiten hier Märchen und versuchen
den Leuten weiß zu machen man könnte
etwas tun was technisch physikalisch
nicht möglich ist ziehen sie ihren
Antrag zurück wir werden ihn ansonsten
ablehnen vielen Dank fürs zuhören
Stefan Wenzel war das neue Bundestag
aber auch der neue umweltpolitische
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und von 2013 bis 2017 war er
Umweltminister in Niedersachsen Pfalz
dem oder der ein oder anderen von Ihnen
das Gesicht bekannt vorgekommen sein
sollte
eine informelle Verabredung zumindest
gibt dass wir die erste Rede
möglichst nicht euer unterbrechen ich
muss trotzdem jetzt fragen Herr
Abgeordneter Hilfe bestehen sie jetzt
auf einer Intervention
gut dann sage ich einfach den
Abgeordneten Wenzel schon er hat die
Möglichkeit in dieser Zeit darüber
nachzudenken ob er dann noch einmal
Redezeit im Sinne einer Erwiderung
beanspruchen möchte der Abgeordnete
Hilfe hat das Wort zu einer kurze
ich versuche
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin dass sie
die kurze Intervention zulassen ich
kenne diese informelle Vereinbarung
allerdings erschiene der Redner so
rhetorisch gut drauf und sicher dass ich
dann mich doch entschlossen hatte diese
Zwischenfrage zu stellen sie haben
vorhin angegeben dass 50 Prozent
sozusagen aus erneuerbaren Energien
kommen ich würde Ihnen empfehlen ab und
zu mal das agora Meter aufzurufen und
dann sage ich Ihnen mal was hier steht
um 11 Uhr gibt es wird immer angezeigt
wie viel Strom wird gerade produziert
aus welchem Energiequellen und der steht
für 11 Uhr insgesamt also Strom aus Wind
und Sonne
ich schätze mal ca kann man nicht genau
erkennen 18 GB und verbraucht wurde zu
diesem Zeitpunkt 73 Gigawatt
18 Gigawatt haben ihre hochgeliebten
regenerativen Energien produziert und
73 haben wir gebraucht wo soll das
herkommen wenn Sie die Kernkraftwerke
abschalten wenn Sie die Kohlekraftwerke
abschalten wenn sie keine Gaskraftwerke
bauen weil sie Nord Stream 2 verhindern
einfach nur mal Fakten ich möchte es
gern von Ihnen wissen aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie diese Antwort nicht
parat haben
Kollege Wenzel sie haben das Wort
wiederum
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich würde da gern kurz zur
Stellung nehmen ich würde ihnen schlicht
und einfach empfehlen beispielsweise war
beim Fraunhofer-Institut sich ein paar
Charts anzugucken sich ein paar Quellen
anzugucken wo mal über die gesamten
Durchschnittswerte eines Jahres hinweg
die unterschiedlichen Analysen beim
Stromverbrauch dargestellt werden und
natürlich sieht man dort dass wir noch
ein ordentlichen Weg vor uns haben aber
es ist ohne Zweifel möglich die
restlichen Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten
und wir werden die durch erneuerbare
Energien ersetzen und wir werden die
Versorgungssicherheit auf extrem hohem
Niveau auch in Zukunft gewährleisten
Stefan Wenzel mit deiner Erwiderung auf
eine kurze Intervention des
afd-abgeordneten Hülse der sich von
einer sondertribüne gemeldet hat die
formal zum Plenarsaal gehört aber da
oben sitzen halt die MDB die über impf-
oder genesenen Status keine Auskunft
geben wollen und hier geht es weiter mit
Ralf lenkert aus der Linksfraktion
umweltpolitischer Sprecher
Lobbyisten behaupten Atomkraft sei
sicher nur alle 10.000 Betriebsjahre
würde ein schwerer Unfall passieren bei
400 Kernreaktoren weltweit passiert also
alle 25 Jahre Statistik ein Super-GAU
stimmt
1979 Harrisburg 1986 Tschernobyl
2011 Fukushima
und nun hat die AFD die echt blöde Idee
Atomkraftwerke die für 40 Jahre geplant
war 50 Jahre und länger laufen lassen zu
wollen
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger für ein
40-jähriges Auto bekommen sie kaum
Ersatzteile die Wartung wird schwieriger
und teuer und die Technik entspricht
nicht mehr dem aktuellen Stand als
Techniker weiß ich bei alten atommeinern
ist das nicht anders mit jedem
Betriebsjahr steigen die Wartungskosten
und das Ausfallrisiko geht nach oben
und die Gefahr dass nach kleinen
Störfällen und einer Notabschaltung ein
Blackout provoziert wird wächst enorm
deshalb jetzt ein paar wirklich gute
ideen für mehr Versorgungssicherheit
DIE LINKE fordert Energiespeicher damit
der Überschussstrom von Wind und Solar
für später aufgehoben werden kann wir
fordern Elektrolyse und Biogasanlagen
die direkt in das vorhandene Gasnetz
einspeisen damit
zukünftige Reservekraftwerke dieses
erneuerbare Gas in Strom und Wärme bei
dunkelflauten umwandeln und die Linke
stärkt die Stadtwerke denn die
koordinieren vor Ort Erzeugung
Verteilung und Speicherung von Energie
das senkt das Risiko von
deutschlandweiten Blackouts und schafft
regionale Wertschöpfung und übrigens
braucht das weniger starkstromtrassen
und erst recht keine Atomkraftwerke
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger ohne
Subventionen würde Atomstrom 20 Cent die
Kilowattstunde Kosten Wind und
Solarstrom kann man für unter 7 Cent
produzieren also Atomkraftwerke und
starkstromkreisen steigern die Gewinne
der Energiekonzerne aber leider auch die
private Rechnung von uns allen und
schützen nicht vor Blackouts deshalb
fordert DIE LINKE ein Nein zu AKWs und
ein Nein zu überbordenden Netzausbau
vielen Dank
Stefan Ralf lenkert aus der
Linksfraktion sie sehen das Präsidium
hat gewechselt für jetzt sitzt viel zu
Präsidentin Aydan ösus dem Bundestag vor
und in dieser in diesem Bundestag sehen
wir jetzt Lukas Köhler aus der
FDP-Fraktion letzte Legislaturperiode
klimapolitischer Sprecher in dieser ist
der zum stellvertretenden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden aufgestiegen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Antrag der vorliegt ist ich finde er ist
also vielerlei Hinsicht dünn aber erst
vor allen Dingen in der Sache falsch sie
gehen von zwei grundprämissen von zwei
Grundideen aus warum wir in Deutschland
die Kernkraft verlängern sollten die
eine ist wir brauchen die Kernkraft vor
zur Versorgungssicherheit die zweite
Kompromisse ist dass Kernkraft für
günstige Stromversorgung so beides ist
defaktor und an den unterschiedlichsten
Stellen widerlegt worden diese nationale
diese Nation diese Fasten
nationalistische Idee hier in
Deutschland jetzt eine Technologie zu
verlängern in der die Leute in der die
Unternehmen schon lange nicht mehr
investieren in denen wir gar nicht mehr
dafür sorgen können dass sie
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können
ist völlig absurd es ist völlig absurd
weil wir schon lange schon lange in
Deutschland sehen dass wir aus der
Atomenergie aussteigen und auch
natürlich die Unternehmen nicht mehr
weiter investiert haben das heißt rein
pragmatisch und es geht bei
Energiepolitik aus meiner Sicht ganz
ganz viel um die Idee des Pragmatismus
rein pragmatisch wird es nicht
funktionieren der zweite Punkt sie Frage
des Preises die Frage des preisesenergie
und wir sehen in den
internationalen Märkten dass immer dann
wenn wir neue Atomkraftwerke wie zum
Beispiel hinklipoint bauen dass diese
Atomkraft extrem teuer wird und
gegenüber gegenüber erneuerbaren
Energien immer abfällt immer sie müssen
hinkleepoint mit 10 Cent die
Kilowattstunde absichern und haben bauen
Solarparks in Portugal für 1 Cent die da
haben sie immer noch immer noch 19 zur
Verfügung um Speicher zu nutzen um
Wasserstoff zu produzieren um ja auch
Gaskraftwerke mit erneuerbarer Energie
zu versorgen weil das ist das Ziel der
Versorgungssicherheit die Idee die
hinter Atomenergie steht ist hat ein
sozialistischen Grundzug denn sie
verlagern die Risiken der
Atomenergie auf die Allgemeinheit sie
können die Risiken der Atomenergie nur
über den Start absichern und das meine
Damen und Herren ist genau der falsche
Weg in der Versorgung mit Energie
diese Kombination aus einem rein
nationalen Interesse und der Verlagerung
der Risiken der Verschiebung der Risiken
auf die Allgemeinheit ist eine Idee die
aus einer vergangenen Zeit statt meine
Damen und ich glaube nicht dass sie uns
gut tut in keinerlei Hinsicht der Punkt
der Versorgungssicherheit wird in
Deutschland über eine hohes Maß an
Flexibilität ablenken wir brauchen dazu
Speicher
Speicher definieren wir Speicher bauen
wir und das Prinzip der Elektrolyse
sollten Sie selbst sie im
Chemieunterricht gelernt haben
wir werden über Wasserstoff in Zukunft
Deutschland versorgungssicher machen und
das Ziel der Versorgungssicherheit ist
gegeben wir werden den Weg über Gas
geben müssen Erdgas wird eine
Übergangstechnologie sein aber dieser
Weg ist vorgezeichnet aber meine Damen
und Herren ich finde es ist eine sehr
rückwärtsgewandte Debatte die Sie uns
hier aufgezwungen haben sie haben eine
rückwärtsgewandte Debatte deswegen auch
gemacht weil sie irgendwie alte
Technologien verlängern wollen die
Zukunft
die Zukunft um die es geht geht in die
Richtung der Frage wie versorgen wir den
globalen Süden mit
Versorgungssicherheit vor allen Dingen
aber wer wird den globalen Süden mit
erneuerbarer günstiger energieversorgt
und das ist die Aufgabe von der diese
Bundesregierung steht wir müssen
beweisen dass wir ein Energiesystem
schaffen das günstige CO2-neutrale
Energie versorgt und der einzige Weg den
das den wir beschreiten können mit
deutscher Technologie in anderen Ländern
dafür zu sorgen dass wir Klimaschutz
gemeinsam als tolle Herausforderung
verstehen und umsetzen ist der Weg über
die Kombination aus erneuerbaren
Energien und Wasserstoff und das können
wir beweisen wenn wir das nicht beweisen
in Zukunft dann werden wir keinen
Klimaschutz machen und deswegen meine
Damen und Herren müssen wir uns dafür
anstrengen dass dieser Weg in Zukunft
gegangen wird und dafür steht neue
Bundesregierung darauf freue ich mich
soweit der neue stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der FDP-Fraktion Lukas
Köhler wie gesagt letzte
Legislaturperiode klimapolitischer
Sprecher und es kommt wiederum jemand
mit einer neuen Funktion nämlich Andreas
Lenz aus der Unionsfraktion nicht neu im
Parlament aber neu als Sprecher für
Klimaschutz und Energie
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir werden
heute an einen Antrag der AFD und der
Antrag ist weder besonders neu noch
besonders originell aber das sind wir ja
gewöhnt es handelt sich um an eine
Ansammlung von
Fehlinformationen von Irrtümern aber
auch von Falschinformationen und und
deshalb werden wir den Antrag
entsprechend ablehnen das Thema
Atomstrom wird unterschiedlich
unterschiedlich gesehen unterschiedlich
diskutiert und auch unterschiedlich
bewertet auch auf europäischer Ebene das
muss man ja schlicht konstatieren aber
zum einen wollen die deutschen
Kraftwerksbetreiber diese
technologiemoment nicht und zum anderen
ist auch klar atomstrom ist eben nicht
die günstigste Form der Energieerzeugung
und übrigens ist es auch so dass kein
Versicherungsunternehmen der Welt
Atomkraftwerke versichert
Marktwirtschaft sieht anders aus liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und daher erübrigt sich für den Moment
die Diskussion aber ich möchte schon
auch sagen dass das Thema Forschung und
Entwicklung auch in diesem Themenbereich
von uns offen gesehen und unterstützt
wird unter der unionsgeführten
Bundesregierung ging der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren massiv voran wir stehen bei
annähern 50% erneuerbare im Strombereich
natürlich immer natürlich immer im
Schnitt und wir haben die
Klimaschutzziele 2020 erreicht 40%
weniger CO2-Ausstoß im Vergleich zu 1990
und wir haben
vom wir haben das Wirtschaftswachstum
von Ressourcenverbrauch entkoppelt und
man muss hier auch mal konstatieren das
waren wir und es war nicht sie liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Union hat eine nationale
wasserstoffstrategie initiiert diese
muss jetzt natürlich weiter gedacht
werden Stichwort Delegierter Rechtsakt
die Energiewende zu Ende gedacht wird
nicht nur in Deutschland stattfinden es
geht internationale Partnerschaften für
die Erzeugung von power to X von
synthetischen Kraftstoffen aber eben
auch von Wasserstoff zu schmieden wir
werden auch zukünftig nicht
energieautark in Deutschland sein können
wir müssen natürlich nationale
Potenziale heben aber wir müssen auch
global denken deutschland hat im
internationalen Vergleich mit die
höchsten Strom- und Energiekosten das
ist langfristig natürlich Gift für den
Produktionsstandort
und es ist natürlich auch eine soziale
Frage und wir wollten schon in der
letzten Legislatur die
ig-umlage abschaffen es ging leider
damals mit dem
Bundesfinanzminister nicht und wir
werden ganz genau schauen
wir werden ganz genau schauen ob und wie
sie die eg-umlage jetzt auch tatsächlich
abschaffen wollen und sie wollen ja
einiges jetzt in der Ampelkoalition wenn
man den
Koalitionsvertrag auch liest aber das
wollen alleine das wird nicht reichen
wir werden auch ganz genau schauen ob
sie und wie sie die Dinge auch erreichen
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir werden sie wir werden Sie an der
Realität messen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
versorgungsversorgungssicherheit ist
wichtig das Thema sollte auch gesetzlich
entsprechend definiert auch
endgesetzlich geregelt werden wenn wir
aus Atomen aus Kohle aussteigen brauchen
wir
Ersatzkapazitäten sie schreiben zwar ein
Koalitionsvertrag dass sie Gaskraftwerke
errichten wollen aber die wachsen
natürlich nicht einfach aus dem Boden
wir brauchen für diese neuen Kraftwerke
Anreize wir brauchen
Investitionssicherheit wir brauchen
letzten Endes auch Planungssicherheit
mit einem kapazitätsmarkt und sie müssen
außerdem in ihrer Koalition ihr
Verhältnis zu Nord Stream 2 immer noch
klären da gibt es völlig
unterschiedliche Wahrnehmungen oder auch
widersprüchliche Aussagen auch daran
werden wir sie messen klar ist für uns
wir brauchen weiterhin Innovationen wir
brauchen Technik wir brauchen Anreize
wir brauchen einen massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien aber eben auch
Versorgungssicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
und dafür stehen wir in dem Sinne
herzlichen Dank
Andreas Lenz aus der Unionsfraktion bei
der vorletzte Redner in der Debatte zu
einem Antrag der afd-fraktion zum
Weiterbetrieb von Atomkraftwerken
letzter Redner wird Jakob Blankenburg
sein er ist aktuell der jüngste
Abgeordnete in der
SPD-Fraktion seine erste Rede und er
kommt übrigens aus dem Landkreis
Lüchow-Dannenberg wo ist sie
bekanntermaßen auch die Gemeinde
Gorleben mit dem Atommüll Zwischenlager
gibt die 2011 ihren letzten Castor
Transport entgegennahmen
Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet und damit
endet auch ein Stück deutscher
Geschichte eine Geschichte die mit dem
Glauben an Technik und Fortschritt
begann und im erbitterten Widerstand von
Teilen der Bevölkerung mündete
eine Geschichte die eigentlich schon
viel früher hätte beendet werden sollen
und dann doch weiter erzählt wurde eine
Geschichte an deren Ende eine Menge hoch
radioaktiver Müll stehen wird man kann
diese Geschichte aus verschiedenen
Perspektiven erzählen aber das Fazit das
ist immer das gleiche es ist gut dass
wir aus der Atomenergie aussteigen und
das haben wir auch im Koalitionsvertrag
bekräftigt
die AFD schlägt nun alle Jahre wieder
vor den Weiterbetrieb der Kernkraftwerke
zu ermöglichen die Geschichte der
deutschen Atomkraft soll nach dem Willen
der AFD nicht enden sie begründet das
mit der angeblichen
Versorgungssicherheit und der
vermeintlichen Umweltfreundlichkeit aber
liebe AFD mit Verlaub das ist Unsinn der
Anteil der Atomkraft am
Primärenergieverbrauch ist gering sie
kann deshalb kein erwähnenswerten
Beitrag zum Erreichen der Klimaziele
leisten eine Abschaltung der AKWs wird
auch nicht zum Blackout führen wie wir
heute auch schon von meinen
Vorrednerinnen gut ausgeführt bekommen
haben
Atomkraft ist unglaublich teuer und vor
allem wenn man die Kosten für zwischen-
und endlagerungen mit rein rechnet und
jeder Cent der in Atomkraft investiert
wird zählt beim Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Wendland mein Wahlkreis ist ganz
besonders eng mit der Geschichte der
Atomenergie verbunden im Gorleben sollte
ein atomares Endlager entstehen sie alle
kennen die Bilder von Polizei
Hundertschaften von Großdemonstrationen
von Menschen die sich an Gleise kennen
im Wendland steht heute noch das
Anti-Atom Kraft x in jedem zweiten
Vorgarten das Misstrauen und das Gefühl
der Ohnmacht haben die Menschen hier
geprägt die Atomkraft und die Frage der
atomaren Endlagerung war lange Zeit ein
zentrales Konfliktfeld im Wendland und
im ganzen Land mit dem Reaktorunglück in
Fukushima hat dieses Haus im
parteiübergreifenden Konsens endgültig
den Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie
beschlossen absolut zu recht
der Beschluss zum Ausstieg aus der
Atomkraft hat Konfliktlinien befriedet
er hat dafür gesorgt dass sich
unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche und
politische Gruppen an einen Tisch setzen
konnten die Endlagersuche erfolgt nun
nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien sie
wird ergebnisoffen durchgeführt und die
Bevölkerung wird in die Suche mit
einbezogen am Ende dieser Suche wird es
einen Standort für radioaktiven Müll in
Deutschland geben bis zu 1.900 Castoren
mit hoch radioaktiven Abfällen werden
dort lagern denn der Müll bleibt auch
dann wenn wir über die zivile Nutzung
der Atomkraft in Deutschland nur noch in
den Geschichtsbüchern lesen können ich
kann nur sagen jeder einzelne Tag den
ein AKW weiterläuft wird mehr Atommüll
produziert jeder Tag den die
Atomkraftwerke in Deutschland nach 2022
weiterlaufen werden ist ein Tag zu viel
und dieser Meinung dieser Meinung sind
im Übrigen nicht nur die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der demokratischen Fraktion und
ich selbst die Betreiber der sechs noch
laufenden Atomkraftwerke stimmen uns zu
ich zitiere kurz vor abschalten in
Deutschland eine Debatte darüber zu
starten ob Kernkraftwerke noch einen
wichtigen Beitrag zum Klimaschutz
leisten ist befremdlich sagte zum
Beispiel am 11 November diesen Jahres
der von Ihnen zitierte er und Chef
Birnbaum dem Handelsblatt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir haben nur wenige Jahrzehnte
Atomkraft genutzt meine Generation und
alle folgenden haben kaum oder gar nicht
davon profitiert mit dem Atome müssen
wir trotzdem leben das können wir nicht
mehr ändern in Sachen Strom wird es in
unserem Land aber eine neue Geschichte
geschrieben die AKWs werden geschlossen
die Entlagerung Endlagerung ist auf dem
Weg erneuerbare Energien werden enorm
ausgebaut das ist das was wir in Sachen
Versorgungssicherheit brauchen deshalb
leben wir den Antrag der AFD ab vielen
Dank
und mit der ersten Rede von Jobst Jakob
Blankenburg endet dieser
Tagesordnungspunkte über den Antrag der
AFD wird direkt abgestimmt
zwei sieben vier mit dem Titel Blackout
verhindern Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke ermöglichen wer stimmt
für diesen Antrag
das ist die afd-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen
das sind alle übrigen Fraktionen wer
enthält sich dann ist der Antrag
abgelehnt
ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 8a
und 8b und auch dazu können wir ganz fix
zwei Sätze sagen es geht um zwei Anträge
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE der erste
trägt den Titel würde und Teilhabe ernst
nehmen sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung
statt Bürgergeld und der zweite trägt
den Titel Existenzminimum sichern
Inflationsausgleich bei Regelsätzen
garantieren hintergrund ist die aktuell
hohe Inflationsrate die wir ja haben auf
der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite dass der Linksfraktion die Reform
von Hartz IV wie es jetzt die
Ampelkoalition angestrebt hat nicht weit
genug geht Details dazu werden wir
Details dazu werden wir im Laufe dieser
Debatte hier hören erste Rednerin wird
sein katja Kipping wie er bekanntermaßen
Sozialsenatorin in Berlin werden könnte
da haben sich bislang noch nicht alle
Parteien zu geäußert zu dem
Koalitionsvertrag der hier verhandelt
worden ist Berlin es läuft der
Mitgliederentscheid noch bis morgen und
dann wissen wir mehr und dann könnte es
sein das katja Kipping den Bundestag
verlässt aber jetzt erstmal die beiden
Anträge zur Sozialpolitik
[Musik]
seit der Erfindung von Hartz IV kämpft
die Linke für die Überwindung von Hartz
IV und dass das guten Grund denn Hartz
IV bedeutet Armut per Gesetz
in all den Jahren war hier im Bundestag
immer ein abwehrmuster zu beobachten die
Anhänger der
hartz-iv-sanktionslogik versuchten die
hart arbeitenden Menschen gegen die
Erwerbslosen auszuspielen als ob die
Verkäuferin auf nur ein Cent mehr in der
Tasche hat wenn es anderen noch
schlechter geht und wir wissen doch das
Gegenteil ist der Fall niedrige
Sozialleistung und das Damoklesschwert
der Sanktion hat das Lohnniveau nach
unten gedrückt wer so möchte dass die
Verkäuferin mehr bekommt muss ich für
höhere Löhne einsetzen aber nicht für
niedrigere Sozialleistung
wir lassen Hartz 4 hinter uns das war
das große Versprechen der SPD als es in
den Umfragen schlecht ging die Grünen
versprachen im Wahlkampf dann immerhin
einer Erhöhung um 50 Euro und zwischen
steht fest die Ampel wird die
Sozialleistung nicht erhöhen Hartz IV
heißt jetzt Bürgergeld aber es ist
weiter Armut per Gesetz und ich sage
neue Begriffe allein füllen kein
Kühlschrank wer Hartz IV wirklich
überwinden will der muss gute Arbeit und
eine sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung in
Höhe von 1200 Euro durchsetzen
und auch die jährliche Anpassung bleibt
weit hinter der Inflation zurück während
die Lebensmittelpreise im November um
4,5 Prozent Geigen sollen die
Sozialleistungen nur um 0,7% steigen
4,5% Anstieg bei den Lebensmittelpreisen
0,7 jährliche Anpassung der
Sozialleistung das heißt bei den Armen
wird weniger Geld zur Verfügung stehen
für Lebensmittel der Kampf gegen Armut
erfordert Empathie für die Betroffenen
ein regen Austausch mit Ihnen aber er
fordert schlichtweg auch Geld und
deshalb braucht es eins so dringend Mumm
um der FDP contra zu geben und höhere
Steuern auf millionenerbschaften
millioneneinkommen und Millionengewinne
durchzusetzen ist ein Jammer dass dieser
Mum aktuell nicht zu finden ist in der
Ampel
und an die Adresse von SPD und Grünen
dass ihr im Moment eures Erfolges just
das Versprechen gegenüber den Ärmsten
sofort vergessen habt das wird an euch
hängen bleiben das wird an euch hängen
bleiben wenn ihr hier nicht nachsteuert
meine Damen und Herren
oft Haaren als ob Armut und Hartz IV nur
die Probleme der anderen sein die
corona-krise hat uns jedoch eins sehr
klar vor Augen geführt es kann sehr
schnell gehen gerade noch läuft das
Geschäft gut und dann ist man auf
Unterstützung angewiesen und deshalb
gilt ein sicheres soziales Netz ja
soziale Garantien sind nicht nur für die
akut darauf angewiesenen wichtig sondern
sie prägen das ganze gesellschaftliche
Klima kurzum von sozialen Garantien
profitieren wir alle und deswegen wird
die Linke nicht locker lassen und weiter
dafür streiten vielen Dank
der Kipping für die n auf unserer Liste
Annika Klose neu im Deutschen Bundestag
war JUSO Landesvorsitzende hier in
Berlin ist also eine von den knapp 50
SPD Abgeordneten unter 35 und auch sie
hält hier heute ihre erste Rede im
Parlament
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Sozialdemokratie wurde mit dem Ziel
gegründet allen Menschen ein Leben frei
von Armut und Ausbeutung zu ermöglichen
dass die Zahl der Menschen in unserem
Land die von Armut bedroht sind derzeit
steigt ist für uns inakzeptabel durch
die corona-pandemie droht sich die
finanzielle Situation von Menschen mit
geringen Einkommen noch weiter zu
verschärfen daher danke ich den Kollegin
von der Fraktion DIE LINKE für ihre
beiden Anträge mit denen Sie diese
wichtigen Themen heute hier auf die
Tagesordnung setzen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich kann Ihnen aber
versichern unsere Koalition wird mit
aller Kraft daran arbeiten für alle
Menschen in diesem Land ein Leben im mit
Respekt und Würde zu ermöglichen in
Zeiten der Pandemie und darüber hinaus
der Koalitionsvertrag der ampelfraktion
bietet dafür die richtigen Bausteine
diese Bundesregierung wird das
Bürgergeld einführen und endlich Hartz 4
überwinden
ich freue mich sehr über diesen längst
überfälligen Paradigmenwechsel
Paradigmenwechsel in unserem
gesellschaftlichen Umgang mit Armut und
Arbeitslosigkeit es ist absolut
notwendig dass jeder Mensch in diesem
Land zu jedem Zeitpunkt und in jeder
Lebenssituation mit Respekt und Würde
bald begegnet wird zu oft haben Menschen
im Hartz IV Bezug den Eindruck gewonnen
dass dies nicht der Fall ist und haben
sich durch staatliche Maßnahmen
schikaniert gefühlt das wollen und das
werden wir ändern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Fraktion DIE LINKE ich finde es schade
dass sie diesen wichtigen
Paradigmenwechsel jetzt klein reden
obwohl auch sie jahrelang für genau
diese Änderung gekämpft haben das
Bürgergeld ist keine Veränderung bloß
auf dem Papier sondern bedeutet eine
ganz konkrete Verbesserung der
Lebenssituation für die betroffenen
Menschen
wir machen Schluss mit der
Misstrauenskultur und werden eine Kultur
auf Augenhöhe einführen und so neues
Vertrauen schaffen denn wir gehen davon
aus dass jeder Mensch grundsätzlich
etwas zu dieser Gesellschaft beitragen
möchte dabei werden wir Sie unterstützen
vertrauen
Vertrauen heißt auch in den ersten
beiden Jahren des Bürgergeldes Bezugs
werden Vermögen nicht angerechnet und
die Größe der Wohnung wird nicht
überprüft der arbeitslos wird muss
keiner Angst haben direkt die
Ersparnisse fürs Alters zu verlieren
oder aus dem gewohnten Umfeld verdrängt
zu werden im Gegenteil das Bürgergeld
bietet neue Chancen und Unterstützung in
einer sicher rasant werden in den
wandelnden Arbeitswelt kann niemand mehr
davon ausgehen ein Leben lang im selben
Beruf zu arbeiten meine Generation schon
gar nicht daher schaffen wir auch den
vermittlungsvorgang ab das heißt dass
man nicht mehr dem nächstbestenfreien
Job annehmen muss sondern das
Weiterqualifizierung und eine neue
Ausbildung gleichwertig unterstützt
werden
und ganz besonders freut es mich dass
wir in dieser Legislatur den Kampf gegen
Kinder und jugendarmut aktiv angehen
werden gerade für Kinder aus Familien
und bisherigen Hartz iv-bezug werden wir
die Lebensbedingungen massiv verbessern
wir werden eine Kindergrundsicherung
einführen und Jugendliche und Kinder vor
Armut schützen ganz unabhängig von der
Einkommenssituation der Eltern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch vom
Thema Sanktionen wurde hier gesprochen
von den Sanktionen Hartz-IV-System sind
vor allem Menschen betroffen die schon
länger in einer Grundsicherung sich
schon länger an einer Grundsicherung
befinden oft liegt da nicht der Unwillen
der Betroffenen mitzuwirken zugrunde
sondern es liegt an vorhandenen sozialen
und psychischen Problemen wir wollen
diese Menschen nicht sanktionieren
sondern wir wollen Ihnen helfen daher
setzen wir vor allem auf aufsuchende
Sozialarbeit und neue Angebote
und im kommenden Jahr werden wir die
Mitwirkungspflichten evaluieren und neue
Regeln denn unser Sozialstaat lebt vom
Solidarsystem das bedeutet das möglichst
alle ihren Beitrag leisten so wie sie es
können und Unterstützung sicher ist wenn
man sie braucht dafür steht das neue
Bürgergeld
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
heutigen Debatte geht es auch um die
Auswirkung der Inflation auf Menschen
mit geringem Einkommen dafür möchte ich
zunächst festhalten dass die aktuelle
hohe Inflationsrate ein temporäres
Phänomen ist wie meine Kollegin schansee
kieselteppe und Martin Rosemann letzte
Woche schon ausführlich dargelegt haben
aber dennoch werden wir natürlich uns
für die Menschen mit geringen Einkommen
Einsätzen und Abhilfe schaffen
insbesondere bei den stark steigenden
Heizkosten für Beziehungen von
Grundsicherungsleistungen werden die
Kosten für Unterkunft übernommen und
damit auch die gestiegenen Heizkosten
und für Menschen mit geringen Einkommen
ohne Grundsicherung haben wir uns als
Koalition darauf verständigt dass die
gestiegenen Heizkosten über eine
klimakomponente im Wohngeld ausgeglichen
werden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie zu
Beginn gesagt niemand soll in diesem
Land in Armut leben mit dem Bürgergeld
der Kindergrundsicherung 12 Euro
Mindestlohn und einer tatkräftigen
Bundesregierung wird dieses Ziel
Realität ich freue mich darauf daran
mitzuarbeiten und auf die künftige
Zusammenarbeit vielen Dank
vielen Dank an die kaktose
als nächster Redner in dieser Debatte
erhält für die cdu/csu-fraktion Kai
Whittaker das sword
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine beiden Vorrednerinnen und
haben sich redlich Mühe gegeben den
anscheinend zu erwecken dass es einen
großen Unterschied zwischen der SPD und
den linken gibt mir scheint aber die
Linke ist über Nacht heimlich der
Ampelkoalition beigetreten denn was man
da in dem Antrag liest findet sie sich
auch im Koalitionsvertrag wieder meine
Damen und Herren die LINKE fordert die
Sanktionen abzuschaffen den
Wohnkostenzuschuss zu erhöhen das
Schonvermögen zu erhöhen all das hat die
Ampel auch vor die Ampel ist also beim
Arbeitslosengeld II einer Meinung mit
den Linken wenn aber es von der Linken
über Rot-Grün bis zur FDP kein
Unterschied mehr gibt in der
Sozialpolitik dann ist ein
christdemokratischer ein christozialer
Gegenentwurf umso wichtiger
gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage der
Abgeordneten Kipping sehr gerne
Herr Kollege wittiger wenn sie ihr den
Eindruck erweckendes das was wir als
LINKE in diesem Punkt vorgelegt haben
die sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung von
1.200 identisch ist mit dem Bürgergeld
der Ampelkoalition dann würde ich gerne
mal ein paar Faktoren Abfragen erste
Frage sozusagen sind Sie der Meinung
dass wir die gleichen Regelungen bei den
Sanktionen haben also können sie mit
Sicherheit sagen dass die Koalition
wirklich eine hundertprozentige
sanktionsfreiheit will und zweite Frage
und das war der zentrale Kern zu dem ich
gesprochen habe ist ihm bewusst dass wir
als Linker eine Mindestsicherung von
1200 Euro wollen und finden dass die
Regelsätze mindestens auf 658 Euro
erhöht werden müssen und wissen sie dass
die Ampel keinerlei Erhöhung vorsieht
liebe Frau Kollegin kippeln wenn Sie
wissen wollen was die Koalition vorhat
dann muss ich Ihnen sagen das kann ich
Ihnen als Mitglied der COC so Fraktion
nicht mehr sagen das haben sie ja
hoffentlich mitbekommen aber ich kann
nur eins sagen was zum Beispiel das
Thema Sanktionen angeht dass sie
Ampelkoalition vorhat bis zur Regelung
eines neuen SGB ii-gesetzes die
Sanktionen auszusetzen und das bedeutet
dass wir dann mit dem nächsten Jahr weil
ich vermute mal es wird ziemlich lange
dauern bis dieser Gesetzentwurf hier
durch das Parlament geht und dann und
dann und na es geht nicht schneller weil
sie werden schon noch die Verwaltung
auch brauchen Herr Kohle damit es auch
funktioniert sie wollen ja die Leute
nicht ins Chaos stürzen dass wir dann
drei Jahre lang schon keine Sanktionen
mehr in diesem Land haben weil seine
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil vor zwei
Jahren die Sanktionen de facto
ausgesetzt sind und da sage ich nur
Nachtigall ich höre jetzt Raps nicht ich
glaube nicht dass die Ampelkoalition den
Mut hat dann die Sanktionen wieder
einzuführen sondern sie wird natürlich
versuchen sie so weit wie möglich
abzuschaffen weil im das Vertrag sich
davon auch überhaupt nichts liest und
deshalb glaube ich nicht dass nachher
die Unterschiede zwischen ihrer Politik
und der Ampel so wahnsinnig groß sind
dessen eher homöopathische Unterschiede
also es ist wichtig für ein Gegenentwurf
und dieser Arbeit die Arbeitsmarkt und
die Sozialpolitik der Union unser
Gegenentwurf der folgt drei einfachen
Prinzipien der christlichen Soziallehre
es geht uns um die Personalität also die
Würde des Menschen steht im Mittelpunkt
zweitens braucht es die Subsidiarität
wonach zunächst jeder das tun soll was
er kann und mit seiner Hände Arbeit den
Lebensunterhalt für sich und designen zu
verdienen denn die Subsidiarität ist die
Voraussetzung für das dritte Prinzip die
Solidarität wonach jeder der auf die
Hilfe der Gemeinschaft angewiesen ist
sie auch erhält wenn ich diese
Prinzipien an die Sozialpolitik der
Linken und der Ampel anlege dann
scheitern sie kläglich ihre
Sozialpolitik erschöpft sich nämlich
darin arbeitslosen Menschen mehr Geld zu
geben es bequemer im System zu machen
aber würde es für uns mehr als nur Geld
würde und Teilhabe bedeutet dass wir
Arbeitslosen wieder eine echte Chance
geben auf den eigenen Beinen im Leben zu
stehen uns geht es nicht darum dass es
im Jobcenter muckeliger zugeht sondern
dass man da nicht mehr hin muss frau
Kipping das ist der Unterschied und
apropos Jobcenter was mich wirklich
ärgert und dann muss ich auch leider
meine Vorrednerinnen mit Haftung nehmen
sie stellen sich gerne hierhin und
danken der den Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern in den Jobcentern für ihre
Arbeit und gleichzeitig bringen sie es
fertig auch wieder heute in ihrem Antrag
von Druck und Repressalien in den
Jobcentern zu berichten damit
verunglimpfen sie die Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter ich sage hören sie auf
damit Frau Kipping wir als Union sind
stolz auf die Sozialverwaltung unseres
Landes
und auch das Prinzip der Solidarität
verkommt bei ihnen zur Einbahnstraße
wenn wir in den letzten Jahren zum
Arbeitslosengeld debattiert haben haben
wir nur noch über Sanktionen gesprochen
dabei betreffen sie bis heute nur einen
Bruchteil der Menschen
aber wer die Hilfe der Gemeinschaft in
Anspruch nimmt hat auch die
Verantwortung schnell aus dieser Hilfe
wieder herauszukommen denn am Ende
müssen diese Leistungen auch durch
Steuern bezahlt werden übrigens und
gerade auch von Menschen die wenig Geld
verdienen Sanktionen treffen die
Sanktionen treffen die die sich dieser
Solidarität verweigern sie bleiben aus
unserer Sicht aber notwendig selbst der
Chef der Bundesagentur für Arbeit Detlef
Scheele Mitglieder SPD sagt dass die
Sanktionen ein Mittel sind und mit
diesen Menschen in Kontakt zu bleiben
hören sie auf ihn liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel meine Damen und
Herren um es klipp und klar zu sagen
eine Politik die nur noch fördert und
nichts mehr fordert Vani unsere Politik
ist es nicht und wird es nicht werden
die Erfolge der letzten 16 Jahre kann
man am Arbeitsmarkt sehen wir haben die
Arbeitslosenquote mehr als halbiert
unser irgendwo steht würde
Eigenverantwortung und Hilfe der
Gemeinschaft gehören für uns untrennbar
zusammen dankeschön
kein Whittaker für die Unionsfraktion in
einer Debatte im Deutschen Bundestag
über zwar zu zwei Anträgen der
Linksfraktion wo es um das Thema
Bürgergeld bzw Mindestsicherung und auch
Inflationsausgleich geht und wir haben
wieder einen neuen den Parlament nämlich
Andreas audritsch einer der wenigen die
die Seite gewechselt haben die eher
ungewohnt ist oder der Wechsel zumindest
nämlich vom Pressesprecher unter anderem
im Bundesfamilienministerium in die
Politik in den Bundestag in die Fraktion
von Bündnis 90 grünen Andreas audritsch
vielleicht direkt zu Anfang man kann
vortrefflich streiten über die
Unterschiede von der FDP über die Grünen
SPD Linkspartei kann man alles tun aber
dass sie die allererste Rede die sie
hier zu diesem Thema halten nur dazu
nutzen Stolz zu berichten dass sie die
aller unsozialsten sind das zeigt nur
eins dass es gut dass sie nicht mehr
Teil dieser Bundesregierung sind
für
Menschen in der Grundsicherung wird auch
dieser Winter wieder ein besonders
harter und das liegt nicht nur an der
Inflation die hier genannt wurde die
corona-krise die trifft die ärmsten
Menschen in diesem Land am aller
härtesten gerade vor einigen Minuten ist
ein Bericht des Paritätischen
veröffentlicht worden der genau das
einmal mehr bestätigt und wenn dann noch
dazu kommt dass die Masken teuer sind
dass jedes Schulessen das Zuhause
eingenommen wird weil in der Schule
wieder Quarantäne angesagt war das geht
alles auf das Geld bei denjenigen die
ohnehin am allerwenigsten haben und
deswegen ist es völlig klar dass wir an
der Stelle Lösungen vorlegen müssen und
ich sage Ihnen eins genau das tun wir
Liebe
katja Kipping vielleicht machen wir es
mal ganz konkret Anja Anja Spiegel
unsere Bundesfamilienministerin die hat
am Tag der Amtseinführung das war eine
der allerersten Handlungen sofort einen
sofortzuschlag für Kinder aus armen
Familien angekündigt 2,7 Millionen junge
Menschen werden genau davon profitieren
das ist was was wir jetzt direkt
umsetzen und zwar mit dem
bundessozialminister und noch eine Sache
die mir noch viel besser gefällt daran
gemeinsam in der gesamten Ampel hier im
Deutschen Bundestag
besonders
besonders akut ist die Lage bei den
steigenden Energiekosten bei den
Heizkosten und auch da müssen wir
reagieren selbstverständlich deswegen
erstens es ist wichtig dass die
Jobcenter die Nachzahlungen
unbürokratisch erstatten und zweitens
wir lassen auch die Menschen die
Wohngeld beziehen nicht aus dem Blick
schauen sie mal auf Seite 91 des
Koalitionsvertrages wir werden
kurzfristig einen einmalig erhöhten
Heizkostenzuschuss zahlen das ist das
was da steht und auch das werden wir
jetzt angehen und jetzt ist Winter
kurzfristig halt selbstverständlich das
muss schnell kommen und das werden wir
jetzt in der Ampelkoalition ebenso
angehen
die akutmaßnahmen die ich genannt habe
sind alles wichtige Schritte aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist doch genauso klar
dass diese ersten Schritte nur ein
erster Punkt sein können um das System
Hartz IV ganz grundsätzlich zu
überwinden die Ampelkoalition plant
nichts Geringeres als die größte
sozialpolitische Reform seit der Agenda
2010 ja wir werden Hartz IV überwinden
das ist das Ziel und ein völlig neues
auch in der Substanz völlig neues
Bürgergeld vorliegen daran arbeiten wir
und nichts weniger ist der Anspruch
dieser Koalition was heißt das konkret
was heißt das konkret wir wollen einen
Sozialstaat auf Augenhöhe Sanktionen
unter das Existenzminimum sind absolut
inakzeptabel und deswegen
und deswegen starten wir genau auf
diesem Weg wir werden ein Moratorium in
Kraft setzen und bis Ende 2022 wird es
ein völlig neues Gesetz ergeben und
glauben Sie mir wir treten in diesem
Prozess der jetzt ansteht dafür ein dass
wir dann auch eine dauerhaft gute Lösung
finden an der Stelle
zweiter Punkt
zweiter Punkt der mir wichtig ist ich
sehe das in meinem Wahlkreis hier in
Berlin-Neukölln immer wieder es gibt so
viele Menschen die gehen erst gar nicht
in die Grundsicherung weil sie Angst
haben sie haben schlicht und ergreifend
Angst ihre Wohnung zu verlieren das ist
das was passiert und auch damit machen
wir jetzt Schluss in Zukunft wird es so
sein dass in den ersten zwei Jahren die
tatsächlichen Kosten der Unterkunft
übernommen werden ohne Wenn und Aber das
ein riesig großer Schritt den kann man
gar nicht hoch genug einstufen gerade
vor dem Hintergrund dass wir damit
verdeckte Armut angeben
und ein weiterer Punkt ist wichtig wie
oft haben wir den Satz gehört arbeit
muss sich lohnen aus den ganz
verschiedenen Ecken jetzt gehen wir das
tatsächlich konkret an wir regeln die
Hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten völlig neu
schüler:innen und Studierende zum
Beispiel in der Grundsicherung sind
sollen künftig das was sie verdienen
auch behalten können auch das ein
riesiger Schritt übrigens ganz besonders
für die jungen Menschen in unserem Land
und zum Schluss komme ich zu einem Punkt
der mir sehr wichtig ist im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dass das
Bürgergeld und ich zitiere
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe ermöglichen
soll und an der Stelle mache ich keinen
Hehl daraus wir Grüne haben sehr genau
berechnet was das bedeutet und wir sind
an der Stelle sehr sehr klar die
Regelsätze sind zu niedrig die
Regelsätze müssen steigen und das werden
wir in der Debatte und in der Reform die
jetzt ansteht auch genauso in den
Mittelpunkt stellen
zum Schluss kommen die Zeit zu Ende ist
ein letzter Satz die Umsetzung des
ganzen die beginnt jetzt wir machen uns
an die Arbeit und das machen wir
zusammen mit den Wohlfahrtsverbänden das
machen wir zusammen mit den
Gewerkschaften kommen Sie bitte zusammen
mit den Initiativen und das wird nicht
leicht aber ich bin mir sicher wir
schaffen einen echten Paradigmenwechsel
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die afd-fraktion erhält jetzt das
Wort auch für ihre erste Rede gerrituy
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren verehrte Bürger
die Fraktion DIE LINKE will Hartz IV
Empfänger angesichts der stark
angestiegenen Inflation mit einer
Aufbesserung ihres Regelbedarfs
unterstützen das finden wir gut
gar nicht gut finden wir allerdings dass
sie wesentliche Teile der Bevölkerung
dabei komplett vergessen hat nämlich
sehr sehr viele Rentner und leider auch
sehr viele Beschäftigte die mit ihrem
Einkommen angesichts der rasant
steigenden Preise nicht mehr über die
Runden kommen denn die Inflation in
Deutschland explodiert im November
betrug die Preissteigerung bereits 5,2
Prozent der höchste Anstieg seit fast 30
Jahren Heizung Strom Kraftstoffe
verteuerten sich sogar um mehr als 20
Prozent von Geldwertstabilität kann da
keine Rede mehr sein und genau diese
Inflation trifft Sozialhilfeempfänger
Geringverdiener und Menschen mit
niedriger Rente am härtesten die
grassierende teurerung frisst zudem ihre
sparrücklagen auf das alles scheint die
ampelregierung nicht zu rühren
unbeirrt von den Sorgen der Bürger
setzte ihren drastischen
verteuerungskurs fort der Grund der
Bürger soll erzogen werden er soll
weniger
heizen weniger Autofahren weniger
Fleisch essen all das wird gezielt
verteuert es verteuht sich aber auch
vieles andere mehr denn Energiekosten
stecken in praktisch allen Produkten und
diese werden ja zusätzlich mit der
co2-steuerbeaufschlagt als wenn nicht
schon genug Steuern in den Energiekosten
steckten mehr als 50% der Stromkosten
und fast 70% der Spritkosten sind
Steuern
und diese Wirtschaft schädigende
CO2-Steuer soll dann ja für ja weiter
erhöht werden wir fördern weg damit das
Klima wird sich dadurch sicherlich nicht
umstimmen lassen
wenn die Ampel dann auch noch nordstream
2 blockiert werden die Gaspreise weiter
eskalieren und Liebe linke eine
sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung für
arbeitsfähige Menschen geht gar nicht
sie nennen die Zahlen selbst 7 Millionen
sozialgeld-empfänger davon gut die
Hälfte erwerbsfähig genau dort werden
übrigens auch viele der Asylsuchenden
die die Ampel ins Land holen will
schon heute beziehen zwei Millionen
Ausländer Hartz IV Leistungen dem
gegenüber stehen gerade einmal 15
Millionen nettosteuerzahler die nicht
nur die hartz-iv-leistung finanzieren
sondern unsere gesamten Staatsausgaben
das ist auf Dauer schlicht nicht
finanzierbar schon jetzt bleibt immer
weniger übrig für die eigenen Bürger das
Armutsrisiko in Deutschland ist mit
nahezu 20 Prozent eines der höchsten in
Westeuropa für den hart arbeitenden
Bürger steht nur noch die AFD ein wir
hören seine Sorgen wir schauen auf seine
Nöte aber auch die Regierung muss
endlich die Augen aufmachen und erkennen
was sie in diesem Land anrichtet
entlasten sie endlich die Bürger in
einem ersten Schritt fordern wir
erhöhen sie den steuerlichen Freibetrag
auf 12.600 Euro das ist der gleiche
Betrag den auch der VdK fordert und
passen sie ihn regelmäßig an die
Inflation an das entlastet auf effektive
Weise Menschen mit niedriger Rente und
Geringverdiener und es bleibt ihnen dann
spürbar mehr Netto vom Brutto danke
schön
[Applaus]
vielen Dank als nächster Redner in
dieser Debatte erhält das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion Pascal Kuba
ist sozialpolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir debattieren
hier zwei Anträge der Linken der eine
beschäftigt sich mit der Frage der
steigenden Kosten durch die Inflation
das ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches
Problem das trifft Menschen im
sozialleistungsbezug betrifft aber auch
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen und
letztlich alle in unserer Gesellschaft
und deshalb muss da ein gesamtes Konzept
durchdacht werden und in Anschlag
gebraucht werden darüber werden wir noch
diskutieren der andere Antrag aber denn
die Linken hier in den Bundestag
eingebracht haben beschäftigt sich auf
dreieinhalb Seiten in 17 Themenkomplexen
vor allen Dingen wird der Frage der
Ausweitung der Sozialleistungen in
unserem Sozialstaat in 16 dieser 17
Abschnitte stellen Sie die Frage wie man
Sozialleistungen ausweiten kann und nur
in einem einzigen dieser 17 Abschnitte
stellen Sie sich die Frage wie Menschen
eigentlich den sozialleistungsbezug
verlassen können nur in die einzigen
dieser 17 Abschnitte stellen sich die
Frage wie Menschen in Arbeit kommen
können und allein die Gewichtung dieser
Themen zeigt den Unterschied zwischen
Ihnen und uns wir haben in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag festgestellt dass wir
die Potenziale der Menschen in den
Mittelpunkt stellen wollen und das ist
der fundamentale Unterschied
aber sie glauben eben nicht an die
Potenziale der Menschen sie glauben
nicht an die Kräfte der Menschen sie
glauben nicht an der an die
Möglichkeiten der Menschen sie glauben
nicht an den selbstbestimmungs- und
selbstbehauptungswählen der Menschen sie
glauben nicht an die Chancen und deshalb
kommen sie ganz natürlicherweise zu der
Gewichtung wie sie sich in ihrem Antrag
zeigt und das ist ein ganz ganz großer
Unterschied zwischen uns und Ihnen denn
wir wollen die Menschen im Bürgergeld
Bezug wenn uns dann das Bürgergeld sein
wird eben nicht aufgeben wir wollen
Ihnen den Einstieg oder den
Wiedereinstieg in den Arbeitsmarkt in
die Selbstbestimmtheit ermöglichen und
diesen Unterschied den möchte ich hier
ganz deutlich herausstellen und betonen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und schaut man dann genauer hin in ihren
Antrag schaut man dann in diesen einen
Abschnitt mit dem sie sich in der Frage
mit dem sie die Frage aufwerfen wie
Menschen in Arbeit kommen können dann
sind ihnen drei Forderungen eingefallen
die eine das ist nämlich die Abschaffung
des vermittlungsvorrang den haben Sie
bei uns abgeschrieben da stehen auch in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag die zweite
nämlich die Einführung eines
weiterbildungsgeldes auch das findet
sich bei uns im Koalitionsvertrag also
schauen wir auf ihre dritte Forderung da
sagen sie dass sie einen Rechtsanspruch
auf vorrangig abschlussbezogene aus- und
Weiterbildung wollen auch wir sagen in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag dass die
berufsqualifizierende Ausbildung stärker
in den Mittelpunkt der Arbeitsförderung
gerichtet ausgerichtet sein muss auch
das sagen wir nur an der Stelle zeigt
sich einmal mehr wie weit sie eigentlich
von der Lebenssituation der Menschen
entfernt sind weil das kann ja nur für
viele der zweite Schritt sein für viele
ist der erste Schritt zunächst einmal
die Grundkompetenzen fördert denn es
macht keinen Sinn in eine
berufsqualifizierende Ausbildung zu
gehen wenn man sie am Ende
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schafft weil
man die Voraussetzungen dafür nicht
mitbringt und diesen realistischen Blick
auf die Menschen in unserem Sozialstaat
den muss man haben sonst geht
Sozialpolitik am Thema vorbei und das
ist leider bei Ihnen der Fall
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Linken es ist eben kein Zufall dass Sie
Ihren Antrag so ausgerichtet haben es
ist kein Zufall dass sie
leistungsausweitungen in den Mittelpunkt
stellen weil für sie die Unabhängigkeit
der Gedanke der Unabhängigkeit vom
Sozialstaat für sie keinen Wert an sich
ist und das unterscheidet sie von uns
und Ihnen und das diesen Unterschied
werden wir auch weiter betonen wir
werden Ihnen zeigen wie man
Sozialpolitik macht damit Menschen in
die Unabhängigkeit des Sozialstaates
kommen das ist nämlich etwas was mit
Respekt zu tun hat und dafür kämpft
diese Ampelkoalition vielen Dank liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Pascal Kober sozialpolitischer Sprecher
der FDP-Fraktion war der drittletzte
Redner in dieser Debatte über zwei
Anträge aus der Linksfraktion zur
Sozialpolitik insbesondere zur
sanktionsfreien Mindestsicherung und zu
einem Inflationsausgleich und dazu
spricht jetzt auch Peter Aumer aus der
Unionsfraktion liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen
ich darf auf den Antrag Existenzminimum
sichern Inflationsausgleich bei
Regelsätzen garantieren eingehen
von Inflation meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren sind
Grundsicherungsempfänger betroffen ja
aber auch Rentnerinnen und Rentner
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer und das
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren ist
ein Problem unseres Landes unserer
Gesellschaft und der Antrag der Linken
zeigt wie eindimensional sie denken
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
wenn man sich die Rednerinnen und Redner
eines Teils der Ampel anschaut dann ist
es genauso und ich glaube das zeigt auch
ihre Haltung das zeigt auch ihre Haltung
sehr geehrte Frau Kipping es zeigt dass
die Verbindung von Wirtschaft und
Sozialpolitik zunehmend in unwuchtgerät
in unserem Land und aus Sicht unserer
Partei meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren muss das zusammengesehen werden
für uns ist das Prinzip der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft sehr geehrter Herr Kobe
sie haben das versucht anzudeuten das
Wesentliche unserer Entscheidungen und
wenn man jede vergleicht mit den Reden
ihrer beiden Koalitionspartner dann ist
es Selbstverständnis nicht von wirklich
erstem Anblick gegeben also ich bin
gespannt wie dann dieses Bürgergeld
tatsächlich ausschaut der Bundeskanzler
der gestern den Rahmen in seiner in
seiner Regierungserklärung gesetzt und
ich bin gespannt Herr coole wie wir dann
darüber streiten und wie man das
liberale Bürgergeld mit den Ansätzen von
Rot und Grün zusammenbringt diese
Auseinandersetzung ist es wert und ich
glaube wir müssen in unserem Land ganz
aktuell schauen dass wir das Thema
Inflation für alle auch im Blick haben
Preisstabilität ist Thema vor allem der
EZB das ist mir auch klar aber auch
politisch Verantwortliche müssen bei
ihren Entscheidungen auch ökonomische
Vernunft walten lassen ich habe gestern
einen Artikel von hans Werner Sinn
gelesen der die Ampelkoalition als
Inflationstreiber beschreibt und sollte
uns allen auch zu denken geben vor allem
auch dem neuen Bundesfinanzminister den
zusätzliche Schulden machen ist auch
nicht unbedingt der richtige Weg um
Inflation einzudämmen und das meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich denke ich
ein ganz wesentlicher Punkt über den wir
uns in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
auch Gedanken machen müssen am Ziel kann
es nicht sein sehr geehrte Frau Kipping
sozialgarantien Verlangen zu verlangen
wie sieht es in ihrer Rede gemacht haben
ich habe mir mal geschaut wie der
Bundesrat entschieden hat als es um die
Erhöhung der Regelsätze geht und ich
habe mir sehr genau angeschaut wie ihr
Ministerpräsident der Linken abgestimmt
hat wie das Bundesland Thüringen
abgestimmt hat ist er zugestimmt bei der
Erhöhung der Regelsätze ja das ist das
ist nicht irgendetwas sondern ich glaube
Politik muss dringend sein und Politik
muss auch ehrlich sein und ich denke das
das ist kein eigenes Argument es ist
Ehrlichkeit ja also das Frau
Fraktionsvorsitzende ist einfach so und
ich glaube wir müssen schauen dass wir
dort ansetzen wo die Probleme sind wir
müssen schauen dass wir die Preistreiber
nach unten bekommen wir müssen die
Energiepreise senken unser Vorschlag
wird sehr schnell gehen EEG-Umlage
EEG-Umlage abschaffen Arbeit muss ich
lohnen das Grundprinzip der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft und ich glaube daran
müssen wir arbeiten da sind die Kollegen
der FDP in der Ampel gefordert und ich
bin gespannt wie wir das so hinbekommen
dass das für unser Land auch gut
funktioniert wir sind verlässlicher
Partner wir haben die Menschen im Blick
wir haben aber unser Land in Gänze im
Blick die Breite die Vielfalt der
Menschen die Unternehmer die
Arbeitnehmer und auch die
Grundsicherungsempfänger und wenn man in
dieser Breite diskutieren dann sind wir
auf dem richtigen Weg herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Auma
als nächstes erhält das Wort auch für
seine erste Rede im Deutschen Bundestag
Tag ist mit Ali
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren an erster
Stelle muss ich mich aber bei der
Fraktion DIE LINKE erst dafür bedanken
für diesen Antrag weil sie geben uns
einfach noch mal die Chance diesen
großartigen Koalitionsvertrag noch mal
vorstellen zu dürfen nämlich unseren
Bürgergeld also vielen vielen Dank
und unmöglicherweise haben sie den auch
gar nicht vorgelesen aber ich komme ja
noch gleich dazu
und meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
das Licht vielleicht auch daran weil sie
eine Sache eine wichtige Sache verkennen
bei unserem Bürgergeld geht es nicht nur
darum dass wir eine sozialrechtliche
Reform voranbringen indem wir da die
Arbeitslosenversicherung verändern
sondern es handelt sich hierbei um ein
neues gesellschaftsstärkendes und
teilhabeorientiertes Konzept meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
was wir was wir aber mit dem Bürgergeld
erreichen wollen entspricht den
Ansprüchen einer modernen
leistungssystematik die jeder und jedem
gerecht werden soll meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren insbesondere von der
Linksfraktion hat ja schon vorhin gesagt
hätten sie sich unser Koalitionsvertrag
ordentlich durchgelesen hätten sie sich
auch ein paar Dinge in ihrem Antrag auch
ersparen können aber ich will Ihnen ja
geschwind mal erzählen worum es geht
erstens in den ersten beiden Jahren der
Leistungsberechtigung wird es keine
Anrechnung des Vermögens geben und wir
werden die Angemessenheit der Wohnung
anerkennen und das was sie im übrigen
auch fordern deshalb weiß ich gar nicht
warum sie den Antrag wieder unverändert
so eingereicht haben
meine Damen und Herren aber warum ist
das denn so wichtig wir werden damit
unserem Wahlversprechen gerecht werden
all jenen respektvoll gegenüberzutreten
die aufgrund der unabwegbarkeiten des
Lebens ihren Arbeitsplatz verloren haben
diese Menschen haben ja teilweise
jahrelang gearbeitet und sollen daher
nicht den Duktus zu spüren bekommen dass
der Staat jetzt bei dieser schwierigen
Lebenslage Ihnen alles wieder wegnehmen
wird und das zeugt an Respekt was wir
gegenüber dem Mitbürger und Mitbürger in
diesem Land auch zeigen möchten
zweitens wir gehen aber auch
grundsätzlich an die Definition der
angemessenheitsgrenzen ran
und Sie werden mir beipflichten dass das
in den letzten Jahren ja sehr sehr
schwierig war dass insbesondere mit der
Union zu machen jetzt beglückwünschen
Sie uns doch dass wir da auch rangehen
wollen und unterstützen Sie uns doch
auch in dieser Sache
aber das Wesentliche aber das
Wesentliche kommt ja noch wenn ich wenn
ich so ihren Antrag lese zur Abschaffung
von Hartz IV habe ich manchmal das
Gefühl schon dass sie von veralteten
sozialstaatsmodellen ausgehen wir legen
aber ein Konzept zur Verfügung dass im
übrigen auch unabhängig der
sozialrechtlichen Bewertung meiner
Meinung auch sozialpädagogisch sehr viel
helfen wird sondern wir stellen eben
Rahmenbedingungen zur Verfügung die
einen größeren Personenkreis
einschließen wird und damit werden wir
auch die Arbeitsmarktpolitik positiv
beeinflussen während ihr Antrag sich
hauptsächlich mit Geldleistungen
beschäftigt werden wir im Gegensatz zu
ihnen die Lebensziele und die Wünsche
der Menschen in den Vordergrund stellen
meine sehr geehrten
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wie
schon bereits erläutert worden ist wir
machen das durch ein Potenzial
orientierten Ansatz wir versprechen
Beratung auf Augenhöhe und werden vor
allen Dingen wieder das Vertrauen in die
Institutionen wiederherstellen was aber
viel wichtiger in diesem Zusammenhang
auch ist ist dass wir ein
Kompetenzfeststellungsverfahren
einführen was nicht nur die Hard Skills
in den Vordergrund bringen wird sondern
auch die Soft Skills weil wir den
Menschen sehen seine Förderung sehen und
danach erst fordern werden
wir werden
wir werden in diesem Zusammenhang auch
die Eingliederungsvereinbarung
abschaffen und durch eine
teilhabevereinbarung ersetzen und ich
möchte Ihnen noch etwas Wichtiges
mitteilen
wir werden ein begleitet begleitendes
Coaching und aufsuchende Hilfen durch
Sozialarbeit zur Verfügung stellen das
ist deshalb so wichtig weil wir jetzt
einen Schritt weiter gehen müssen um die
Lebenswelten der Menschen zu verstehen
und die persönliche Lage der Menschen zu
verstehen und nicht nur vom Schreibtisch
aus die durch Aktenlage bewerten sondern
wir gehen vor Ort und unterstützen die
Menschen da wo sie ihre Hilfen benötigen
das ist der Vorteil und das ist auch das
neue was wir in unserem Bürgergeld auch
beabsichtigen daher zeigt ihr Antrag
dass sie nicht verstanden haben dass es
nicht nur um Geld gehen kann sondern
dass es um die individuellen Bedürfnisse
der Menschen geht und darauf muss man
sich einlassen kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss Herr Kollege kommt sofort zum
Schluss ich möchte nur in diesem
Zusammenhang sagen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir werden zuhören weil
wir an die Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
glauben und weil wir Ihnen vertrauen und
wir werden ein Sozialstaat ein modernen
Sozialstaat zur Verfügung stellen an
denen sich die Menschen messen lassen
können vielen Dank fürs Zuhören alles
Gute und eine schöne Zeit
diese Wünsche haben wir noch relativ
wenig gehört obwohl das ja hier die
mutmaßliche letzte Sitzung des
Bundestages vor der Weihnachts vor den
Weihnachtsferien ist das war tagessen
Mehmet Ali aus der SPD-Fraktion jetzt
wird abgestimmt über die beiden Anträge
der Linksfraktion
auf dass sie die Masken nicht nur über
den Mund sondern auch über die Nase
haben es ist ja auch ein bisschen
anstrengend immer zu jedem einzelnen
hingehen zu müssen ich gucke jetzt mal
so ein bisschen auf die rechte Seite und
hoffe dass sie das da hinter ihnen der
Kollege dass er einfach auch seine Nase
noch mal einbezieht in die Maske
so so ist es richtig wunderbar
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlage auf Drucksache 271 an den
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales
vorgeschlagen gibt es weitere
überweisungsvorschläge das ist nicht der
Fall dann verfahren wir wie
vorgeschlagen wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über den Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke
auf Drucksache 100 mit dem Titel
Existenzminimum sichern inflations-
das ist DIE LINKE wer stimmt dagegen
das sind SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen CDU
CSU und FDP wer enthält sich die AFD
damit ist der Antrag mit großer Mehrheit
abgelehnt so damit haben wir auch
Klarheit in dieser Angelegenheit einen
Antrag abgelehnt der zu sanktionsfreien
Mindestsicherung wird im Ausschuss für
Arbeit und Soziales ein wenig weiter
diskutiert werden damit kommen wir zum
Tagesordnungspunkt 9 in dieser
Sitzungswoche anpassungsverfahren der
Abgeordneten Diäten da hat der Bundestag
vor einigen Jahren ja beschlossen
nachdem es immer und immer wieder
Diskussionen über die Erhöhung der
Abgeordneten Diäten gegeben hat das
ganze ein ein anderes Verfahren zu
koppeln bzw ein anderes Verfahren zu
benennen sondern Grundlage für die
Entwicklung der Abgeordneten Diäten ist
seit der einigen Jahren der sogenannte
nominale lohnindex den das Statistische
Bundesamt ermittelt und das bedeutet je
nachdem wie sich die Löhne normal
entwickeln entsprechend in einem
entsprechenden Wert steigen dann auch
die Diäten der Bundestagsabgeordneten
das führt aber auch dazu wenn der
nominal lohn-index mal sinken sollte so
wie im vergangenen Jahr das auch
wiederum Folgen hat für die Abgeordneten
und so müssen sie ab 1 Juli eine
Reduzierung um 0,7% hinnehmen dieses
Verfahren das muss jetzt auch für die
neue Legislaturperiode wieder abgestimmt
bzw übernommen werden und darum dreht es
sich jetzt in dieser Debatte in der
Johannes Fechner für die SPD-Fraktion
schon zu sprechen begonnen hat klare
nachvollziehbare Regelungen wie wir die
Höhe der Abgeordneten Diäten festsetzen
und genau das schaffen wir mit diesem
Gesetz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es
ist gut dass ich die neue Ampelkoalition
schon im Koalitionsvertrag vorgenommen
hat für mehr Transparenz und mehr Bürger
in unseren Entscheidungen hier im
Parlament zu sorgen das ist ein ganz
wichtiges Vorhaben ein ganz wichtiges
Signal um das Vertrauen der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in unsere Entscheidungen hier
im Bundestag zu sichern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
so werden wir um ein paar Punkte zu
nennen mit einem noch effektiveren
lobberegister sicherstellen dass
Transparenz darüber herrscht welche
Interessenverband Einfluss genommen hat
auf ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren und wir
wollen zudem mit dem sogenannten
exekutiven Fußabdruck Klarheit darüber
schaffen wie und ob Interessenvertreter
bei der Erstellung von Gesetzen in den
Ministerien Einfluss genommen haben
durch Kontakte mit Bundesministerien und
wir wollen den Straftatbestand der
Abgeordnetenbestechung und der
Abgeordneten Bestechlichkeit effektiv
verschärfen denn es muss immer klar sein
und das müssen wir hier auch
strafrechtlich sichern wir Abgeordneten
haben für das Allgemeinwohl zu arbeiten
nicht für den allgemein für den eigenen
Geldbeutel und schon gar nicht für
kriminelle Interessen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und also oft wird
kritisiert dass wir Abgeordneten selbst
über unsere eigene Entlohnung
entscheiden dazu sind wir als
Gesetzgeber befugt und es ist auch
unsere Aufgabe selbst für die Festlegung
unserer Einkommen zu sorgen gerade
deshalb braucht es aber hier maximale
Transparenz und ganz klare Regeln
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir heute
mit diesem Beschluss für diese
Wahlperiode die 20 Wahlperiode festlegen
dass unsere Diäten an das allgemeine
Lohnniveau gekoppelt sind liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine ganz
wichtige Entscheidung für diese
wahlperiode
und es ist fair und gerecht dass unsere
Diäten nur in dem Umfang steigen können
in dem auch die Löhne der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger steigen sinken die nominal
Löhne wie zum Beispiel coronabedingt
2020 dann sinken auch die
abgeordnetengehälter konkret ändern sich
unsere Diäten jährlich zum ersten Juli
in dem Umfang in dem das Statistische
Bundesamt in dessen jeweils im März
erstellten Bericht Änderungen bei der
Entwicklung der nominal Löhne feststellt
das ist fair und transparent und deshalb
ist es gut dass wir gleich zu Beginn
unserer Amtszeit dieser Wahlperiode für
diese Wahlperiode die Höhe der
Abgeordneten Diäten Gandhi
Lohnentwicklung der Bevölkerung binden
das schafft Vertrauen und damit
Glaubwürdigkeit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und bei der Höhe der Diäten der
orientieren wir uns ganz klar weiterhin
an der richterbesoldung die Stufe R6 das
entspricht etwa dem Gehalt wenn sie mir
den Vergleich aus meiner
baden-württembergischen Heimat gestatten
mit einem Oberbürgermeister einer
baden-württembergischen Gemeinde mit
50.000 Einwohnern ohne Frage das ist
viel Geld das ist eine sehr gute
Bezahlung aber wer unseren
abgeordnetenjob ernst nimmt und wirklich
die aller allermeisten machen das ja
auch der hat viele Stunden zu tun der
hat Wochenendtermine der ist unter der
Woche viel unterwegs nicht nur hier in
Berlin sondern auch in den nicht
Sitzungswochen im Wahlkreis viele haben
auch einen betreuungswahlkreis also da
kommen wirklich sehr sehr viel Zeit und
Engagement zusammen und außerdem tragen
wir mit unserem Amt hier wirklich eine
ganz große Verantwortung für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger durch unsere
Entscheidungen und deswegen ist es
gerechtfertigt dass unser Amt als
Bundestagsabgeordneter als
Bundestagsabgeordnete wirklich auch
angemessen bezahlt ist entscheidend ist
aber dass wir dafür transparente und
klare und nachvollziehbare Regelungen
haben liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
genau dafür wollen wir heute mit diesem
Beschluss sorgen klare Regeln klare
Bindung an die allgemeine
Lohnentwicklung klare Orientierung an
der richterbesoldung das ist bürgernare
Transparenz damit wollen wir vertrauen
schaffen ich bitte um Zustimmung vielen
Dank
Johannes Fechner parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion außerdem Justitia
in dieser Fraktion mit seiner Begründung
für die Übernahme des Verfahrens aus den
vergangenen Jahren was die
Abgeordneten
Diäten angeht nächster Redner in dieser
Debatte ist Patrick Schnieder auch erst
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer
seiner Fraktion in diesem Fall der
Unionsfraktion der Kollegin Werte
Kollegen in der Tat wir führen hier eine
wichtige Debatte ist auch wichtig dass
wir diese Debatte öffentlich führen weil
sie zu Transparenz führt wir regeln
nämlich heute die Frage wie es mit
unseren abgeordneten-
und da stimme ich dem Vorredner im
Kollegen Dr Fechner zu das gehört in die
Öffentlichkeit damit müssen wir nicht
hinter dem Berg halten und dann kann man
muss man offen darüber reden die Frage
ist was ist angemessen
gehen die Meinungen sicherlich weit
auseinander wenn man die Menschen danach
fragen würde was angemessen für die
Bezahlung eines Abgeordneten
zunächst ist festzuhalten wir müssen
selbst über diese Frage entscheiden ist
das Bundesverfassungsgericht in seinem
diäten-urteil 1975 so festgestellt wir
sind der Gesetzgeber müssen in diesem
Fall eben auch über unsere eigenen
Rahmenbedingungen hier entscheiden und
wir haben im Jahre 2013 im Deutschen
Bundestag eine Expertenkommission
eingesetzt die hat auch viele
Sachverständigen angehört und dieses zu
zwei Ergebnissen gekommen das erste
Ergebnis in der Höhe der Abgeordneten
Entschädigung der Höhe der Diät ist es
angebracht sich zu orientieren an dem
Gehalt eines Bundesrichters
Besoldungsstufe R6 warum weil ein
Bundesrichter wie Richter insgesamt
unabhängig sind und weil sie eben
Entscheidungen treffen die bundesweit
wirken und das entspricht auch wenn man
das nicht direkt vergleichen kann
natürlich auch dem was wir als
Abgeordnete tun und die zweite
Feststellung dieser Expertenkommission
und als Ergebnis der Anhörung der
Sachverständigen war dass wir die Diäten
am besten koppeln an die Lohnentwicklung
in Deutschland das haben wir getan und
damit das weiter fort gilt das haben wir
2014 getan damit das weiter fort gilt
sind wir eben gehalten innerhalb der
ersten drei Monate zu Beginn einer
Wahlperiode diesen Beschluss neu zu
fassen und damit das Verfahren in Kraft
zu setzen
und ich kann nur sagen es hat sich
bewährt dieses Verfahren weil es
nachvollziehbar ist weil es fair und
gerecht ist und es ist letztlich eben
auch wenn man so will eine Art
Leistungs- oder
erfolgsgerechte Bezahlung wenn es dem
Land gut geht wenn es den Menschen gut
geht dann sieht man an der
Lohnentwicklung dann steigen unsere
Diäten eben im gleichen Umfang und wenn
es zurück geht dann werden unsere Diäten
auch gekürzen das haben wir im letzten
Jahr oder in diesem Jahr eben erlebt mit
-0,7 Prozent und wir können dieses
Verfahren auch jederzeit aussetzen oder
wir können in besonderen Situationen
auch besonders reagieren das haben wir
2020 getan zu Beginn der corona-pandemie
da war die allgemeine Lohnentwicklung
noch plus 2,6 Prozent gleichwohl haben
wir gesagt und zurecht gesagt
wir wollen ein Nullrunde einlegen weil
wir gesehen haben was da auf uns was auf
die Gesellschaft zukommt also alle
Möglichkeiten bleiben beim par bleiben
hier darüber zu entscheiden
nun wird die AFD auf der rechten Seite
auch heute wieder versuchen diese dieses
Parlament die Abgeordneten verächtlich
zu machen vor vier Jahren ist hier schon
ist schon ausgeführt worden das ist eine
automatische Diätenerhöhung die letzten
vier Jahre haben gezeigt dass das wieder
eine Fake News der AFD war ich habe das
gerade geschildert sondern es ist
nachvollziehbar als orientiert sich an
der allgemeinen Lohnentwicklung noch mal
ein transparentes Verfahren ein faires
Verfahren ein gerechtes Verfahren und
deshalb sollten wir es auch hier für die
nächsten vier Jahre wieder in Kraft
setzen
sagt Patrick Schnieder parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer in der Unionsfraktion
und zu demselben Thema jetzt Irene mir
Lecce aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen wo sie vor wenigen Tagen zur
ersten parlamentarischen im
Geschäftsführerin gewählt worden ist
ihrer Fraktion Amtes geht weiter um das
Verfahren zur Anpassung der Abgeordneten
Diäten
Präsidentin Liebe
Kolleg Deutschen Bundestages etwas sehr
kluges entschieden sie haben gesagt das
ist nicht gut dass die Abgeordneten
komplett selbst darüber befinden wie
sich die Diäten entwickeln auch wenn wir
natürlich nach der Rechtsprechung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts dazu
angehalten sind ist es aber dennoch in
der Sache nicht gut und politisch immer
sehr aufladbar im Sinne populistischer
Stimmungsmache wie wir wahrscheinlich
nachher wieder hören werden damals wurde
eine unabhängige Kommission zu Fragen
des
abgeordnetenrechtseingesetzt die im
Ergebnis Empfehlungen zur Abgeordneten
Entschädigung erarbeitet und
ausgesprochen hat und auf Grundlage eben
dieser Empfehlungen gilt seit der 18
Wahlperiode ein Verfahren in dem die
Abgeordneten Entschädigung jährlich zum
ersten Juli entsprechend dem
nominalohnindex angepasst wird und der
angepasste Betrag wird transparent in
einer bundestags-drucksache
veröffentlicht
dieses anpassungsverfahren muss aber
zwingend spätestens jeweils drei Monate
nach der konstituierenden Sitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages wieder beschlossen
werden damit es gültig bleibt das ist
gesetzlich so vorgesehen und deswegen
führen wir heute hier diese Debatte und
das geschieht nicht nur wie oft und
gerne und wahrscheinlich nachher auch
wieder behauptet wird damit die Diäten
steigen können sondern eben auch damit
sie automatisch sinken können so wie es
eben auch im letzten Jahr geschehen ist
und auch darüber hinaus hat sich dieses
Verfahren bewährt bewährt übrigens auch
als es galt davon abzuweichen wie im
Jahr 2020 geschehen als wir angesichts
der corona-pandemie aktiv darauf
verzichtet haben die Diäten zu erhöhen
auch wenn es im Anpassungsmechanismus
eigentlich vorgesehen wäre
und wie eben erwähnt musste das
2021 gar nicht erst geschehen denn die
Entschädigung Sankt ohnehin aufgrund der
negativen Lohnentwicklung in der Krise
und wir werden auch zukünftig und das
ist meiner Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen auch sehr sehr wichtig
äußerst sensibel auf die Umstände achten
wenn es für andere aufgrund von
krisenhaften Entwicklungen große
Einschränkungen gibt muss sich das auch
bei den Abgeordneten widerspiegeln meine
Damen und Herren
aber ich bin aufgrund der Erfahrung von
2020 auch sehr sicher dass wir einen
solchen Schritt wieder in großer
Einmütigkeit gehen würden wenn es denn
erforderlich ist und deshalb kann ich
sagen die Regel also der
Anpassungsmechanismus hat sich gerade da
bewährt wo es auch galt eine Ausnahme zu
machen und deswegen gilt für meine
Fraktion das anpassungsverfahren
gewährleistet eine für die
Öffentlichkeit
nachvollziehbare und zugleich
angemessene die Unabhängigkeit der
Abgeordneten sichern der Entschädigung
gemäß Artikel 48 Absatz 3 des
Grundgesetzes und deshalb soll es auch
in dieser Wahlperiode wieder fortgeführt
werden ganz herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Michalitsch
und als nächster
[Applaus]
erhält für die afd-fraktion das Wort
Stefan Brandner
[Applaus]
ja meine Damen und Präsidentin diese
Debatte ist ja gar keine Debatte denn
Debatte würde er davon leben dass eine
Vielzahl von Meinungen vertreten wird
hier ist wie so oft die gesamte
altparteien-schar einer Meinung bis auf
die Alternative für Deutschland die das
etwas differenzierter sieht alle vier
Jahre gönnen wir uns 31 Minuten um über
die nächsten vier Jahre unserer
diätenentwicklung zu debattieren das ist
alles andere als transparent der Fechner
das ist so ein bisschen verschämt
verbremt Hauptsache kriegt keiner mit
wir müssen es aber trotzdem mal hier
gründlich besprechen wir würden das
gerne jedes Jahr tun sie drücken sich
davor es geht ja nicht nur um die gut
10.000 Euro brutto die wir im Monat
bekommen dazu kommen noch viereinhalb
tausend Euro netto 1000 €
sachkostenpauschale helftiger Zuschuss
zur Krankenversicherung Bahncard 1
Klasse die üblicherweise mit 7000 € im
Jahr etwa zu Buche schlägt frei Flüge
mit der Lufthansa Fahrdienst in Berlin
für manche auch Fahrdienst darüber
hinaus Gesetz Karte der Berliner
Verkehrsbetriebe Übergangsgeld bis zu 18
Monaten das sind ungefähr 180.000 Euro
die eine Rolle spielen eine
üppige Hinterbliebenen Versorgung und
dann natürlich ein Rentenanspruch der
nicht ansatzweise irgendwie zu begründen
ist ein Rentenanspruch pro Jahr den wir
hier er dienen von 250 Euro also ein
Jahr Bundestag gleich 250 Euro etwa
Rentenanspruch vier Jahre Bundestag etwa
1.000 Euro Rentenanspruch vier Jahre
Bundestag heißt also dass der
Rentenanspruch den draußen Leute nach
einem ganzen Arbeitsleben nicht für sich
vereinnahmen können das ist einfach
schlicht und ergreifend ungerecht das
können Sie natürlich reinrufen ja dann
verzichten Sie doch Brandner verzichtet
doch von der afd-fraktion auch darauf
haben sie schon reagiert Paragraph 31
das Abgeordneten Gesetzes verbietet es
darauf zu verzichten also wir könnten
gar nicht sogar wenn wir wollen wir als
rechtsfahrtstaatspartei halten uns daran
sie verbieten dass auch diese üppigen
Bezüge verzichtet werden darf das ist
einfach weltfremd und Bürger fremd
abgehoben wir Freunde liebe Freunde von
den Altparteien Existenz Schausteller
Gastronomen Hoteliers Einzelhändler die
würden gerne Planungssicherheit für die
nächsten zwei oder drei Wochen haben
weil sie sich hier ist was sie sich
heute gönnen wollen ist eine
Planungssicherheit für die nächsten vier
Jahre auch darauf haben die Menschen
draußen kein Verständnis dass wir sagen
vier Jahre interpretiert 30 Minuten
haben für vier Jahre unsere Schäfchen im
Trockenen das geht so nicht das geht an
der Lebenswirklichkeit völlig vorbei was
ich sagen will am Ende diese
Automatismus der hier eingeführt wird
ist ein Anachronismus der sofort
ausgesetzt gehört es war bisher immer so
mit Ausnahme des letzten Jahres das ist
üppige Diätenerhöhung im dreistelligen
Bereich gab bin ich mir die Prognose für
die Rentenentwicklung anschaut vier fünf
Prozent das würde für uns möglicherweise
bedeuten 400 500 Euro mehr in diesem
Jahr das geht in der Lage draußen nicht
deshalb folgen Sie die Alternative für
Deutschland Automatismen
ich muss sofort beenden mehr Transparenz
jedes Jahr zumindest über debattieren
wie die Enden sich entwickeln sollen und
eine grundsätzliche
diätenversorgungs- und Privilegien
Reform das stündet den Bundestag sehr
gut zu Gesicht vielen Dank
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
als nächstes erhält das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion der Kollege Stefan Thome
und auch er ist parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer seiner Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin für ihre
Kolleginnen für die Kollegen wie auch
Bestellung konnte Kollege Brandner der
Versuchung wieder mal nicht widerstehen
wie mit einem Stichwort diese Debatte zu
nutzen um das Parlament und seine Arbeit
verächtlich zu machen und
herabzuwürdigen meine Damen und Herren
zu Beginn einer jeden Wahlperiode
beschließen wir einen transparenten
nachvollziehbaren und plausiblen
Verfahren wie die Diäten der aktuelles
Hauses angepasst werden sollen und das
ist immer der Augenblick in dem Kritiker
des Parlamentarismus die Gelegenheit
Ergreifung der Bundestag vorzuwerfen die
erste Amtshandlung sei nichts anderes
als eine eigenen Vorteile zu sichern
aber die Wahrheit ist doch dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht selbst in dem
schon erwähnt jeden Urteil von das 75
verlangt hat dass sie Abgeordneten hier
in diesem Hause die Entwicklung ihrer
Diäten im Plenum diskutieren und in
einem offenen Verfahren vor den Augen
der Öffentlichkeit beschließen müssen
denn das so das Gericht sei neben dem
Bundespräsidenten und dem Gericht selbst
die einzige wirksame Kontrolle weil der
Bundestag ja hier in eigener Sache
entscheidet und so hat eine
Expertenkommission 2013 empfohlen dass
die ab die Entwicklung der Diäten der
Abgeordneten an die Entwicklung der
Löhne im Land angepasst werden sollen
und über diese anpassungsregelung nur
darüber muss der Bundestag nach dem
Gesetz innerhalb von drei Monaten in der
Wahlperiode abstimmen und genau dieser
Empfehlung der Expertenkommission folgt
auch der 20 Deutsche Bundestag mit dem
heutigen Beschluss meine Damen und
Herren
wir
beschließen also heute keine
Diätenerhöhung sondern wir bestimmen
über das unsere eigenen Bewertung
entzogene Verfahren wie die Diäten sich
in der Wahlperiode entwickeln sollen und
wie könnte man eigentlich besser
widerlegen dass wir unsere Diäten nach
Gutdünken festsetzen als dadurch dass
wir die diätenentwicklung einen
sachliches unserem Zugriff entzogenes
Kriterium koppeln wie die allgemeine
Lohnentwicklung im Land meine Damen und
Herren und deswegen sind Corona bedingt
auch die Diäten in den letzten zwei
Jahren nicht gestiegen sondern sogar
gesunken und nun gibt es natürlich zu
allen Zeiten immer wieder Diskussionen
und Kritik über die Höhe der Diäten und
da orientieren wir uns an den
bruttobezügen der Bundesrichter nach der
Gruppe R6 oder B6 für Bundesbeamte was
ein unter Abteilungsleiter eines
Ministeriums entspricht und diese
blutetierten sind natürlich Steuersatz
zu versteuern und mit der Höhe der
Bezüge stellen wir eine angemessene der
Verantwortung und auch Stellung eines
Abgeordneten angemessenen Entschädigung
sicher denn die Diäten sollten schon so
hoch sein dass ein Bundestagsmandat auch
für jemanden attraktiv ist der sie
selber schon vorher eine eigene
Lebensstellung erworben hat denn Wende
Diäten zu niedrig werden auch das ist
ein wichtiger Gedanke dann wäre ein
Bundestagsmandat ein Privileg für
jemanden der über irgendwelche anderen
regelmäßigen Einkünfte verfügt oder
Vermögen besitzt und das kann auch
niemand wollen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren und aus all diesen Gründen
halten wir das gefundene Verfahren dass
wir heute beschließen wollen für
hinreichend transparent und auch gut
begründbar und werden deshalb diesen
Verfahren auch in dieser Wahlperiode
zustimmen vielen Dank
Stefan Thome der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer beziehungsweise einer
der Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer
der FDP-Fraktion und die nächste
Rednerin in dieser Aussprache ist Nicole
Gohlke die haben wir vor kurzem schon
einmal gesehen und deswegen wissen Sie
möglicherweise auch noch dass sie
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eine
ursprüngliche Idee der Abgeordneten
Entschädigung oder der sogenannten
Diäten war ja auch dass Menschen ohne
eigenes Vermögen in Unabhängigkeit als
Abgeordnete arbeiten können diese Idee
ist gut und sie sah heute
selbstverständlich noch richtig aber
dass die Abgeordneten Entschädigung
heute so hoch ist wie sie ist das obwohl
sie so hoch ist immer noch einige meinen
sich mit teilweise dubiosen
Nebentätigkeiten zusätzlich die Taschen
voll machen zu müssen und dass die Diät
in der Regel auch noch automatisch
ansteigt ohne dass das hier noch einmal
debattiert werden müsste das ist
unverhältnismäßig und das ist auch
ungerecht und das wird nicht mehr
verstanden außerhalb dieses Saales und
das müssen sie zur Kenntnis nehmen
über 10.000 Euro brutto brutto pro Monat
und das in den allermeisten Jahren mit
quasi garantierter Tarifsteigerung
Kolleginnen und Kollegen davon kann der
Großteil der Beschäftigten in diesem
Land wirklich nur träumen und genau
deswegen gehört dieser Mechanismus
dringend überarbeitet mindestens gehört
aber noch einmal ausgesetzt so wie das
der Bundestag letztes Jahr einmalig
beschlossen hatte das war ein richtiges
Signal inmitten dieser Pandemie
und nur mal so zum Vergleich
Pflegefachkräfte die jetzt in dieser
Pandemie Tag und Nacht erkrankte retten
bekommen im Krankenhaus circa 3.500 Euro
brutto in Pflegeheimen 2900 Euro brutto
das Gehalt von Erzieherinnen und
Erziehern liegt bei rund 3000 Euro im
Einzelhandel verdienen die Beschäftigten
im Schnitt 2600 Euro und sie alle sie
alle haben seit Jahren mehr verdient für
ihre wichtige Arbeit und da warten
Menschen jahrelang auf eine Erhöhung des
Hartz-IV-Regelsatzes oder bei
Mindestlohn darauf dass der endlich mal
so hoch ist dass man wenigstens nicht im
Alter in Armut fällt und da gibt es dann
wenn überhaupt nur Anpassungen in so
lächerlich kleinen Schritten das ist
fast nur noch als respektlos empfunden
werden kann und bei den Diäten der
Abgeordneten da soll es dann aber
einfach flutschen das geht doch so nicht
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das geht so
nicht ganz ehrlich
ich finde beim Start einer neuen
Regierung inmitten einer Pandemie die
Millionen Menschen in Existenz Nöte
bringt und bei einem Kanzler mit
SPD-Parteibuch wäre hier wirklich etwas
anderes angezeigt gewesen die LINKE wird
diesem Antrag nicht zustimmen wir lehnen
ab herzlichen Dank
also ein Votum aus den Rhein der AFD
entgegen das bisherige Verfahren und ein
Votum aus ein gegenvotum aus der
Linksfraktion auch vor allem wegen die
Höhe der Abgeordneten Diäten insgesamt
und im Allgemeinen und deswegen wollen
wir noch mal hören was Michael friesa
dazu sagt Mitglied der CSU und
Landesgruppe und Justitia seiner
Fraktion
also wirklich zum erhellen der
derzeitigen Situation und des
Tagesordnungspunkte Frau Kollegin hat
Gohlke hat die Rede nicht ganz
beigetragen denn das Anliegen zu sagen
wir würden jetzt den Mechanismus mittels
eines anderen Antrages aussetzen hieße
auch dass wir eine Verringerung der
Diäten im Augenblick aussetzen würden
dass wir im Augenblick gerade auch der
Verringerung widersprechen würden ich
glaube das ist kontraintuitiv das ist
genau das was sie nicht wollten nein sie
wussten es tun um zu verkaufen um
gesehen wie wird der deutsche
Abgeordnete bezahlt das Bedienen einen
ins Klischees das aus meiner Sichtweise
weder der Arbeit des Parlaments noch
auch dem Status des Abgeordneten
irgendeiner Art und Weise gerecht wird
Herr Kollege Fechner 30 Sekunden ihrer
Rede zum Thema des Tagesordnungspunktes
um dann den Eindruck zu erwecken das was
sie heute als Antrag auf den Weg bringen
sei etwas revolutionär neu ist also
wirklich ich verstehe auch diesen
Gedanken als SPD so zu tun als ob man in
den 20 letzten Jahren kaum etwas mit der
Frage der Regierung und der Mehrheit im
Parlament zu tun gehabt hätte bleibt
aber dabei der Weg den wir eingeschlagen
sind Frau Merlin sie haben es angedeutet
ist tatsächlich der einzige Weg der uns
bleibt um zwei Dinge zu erreichen wen
sollen wir den Fragen auf der Welt als
Abgeordnete was man verdienen kann will
oder muss wenn nicht uns selber es kommt
da oben
der der sonst sagen kann das hat uns das
Verfassungsgericht aufgegeben und dass
wir das Binden an eine Lohnentwicklung
ist doch geradezu der Gedanke daran wie
ist der Kollege Schnieder ausdrückt wenn
es dem Land gut geht dann kann auch der
Abgeordnete übrigens moderat daran
mitverdienen fast ein Prämiensystem und
wenn es aber zurückgeht mit den Löhnen
dann gehen auch unsere Diäten zurück das
ist der Grundgedanke zu dem wir uns
relativ Weise ich sag mal die Mehrheiten
von damals haben es möglich gemacht auch
dazu gefunden haben und es könnte nichts
falscher sein als an dieser Frage immer
wieder aufzuhängen wie rachgierig oder
wie gierig denn tatsächlich der deutsche
Parlamentarismus wäre wir warten
sehnsüchtig auf einen Antrag ein anderes
Verfahren ein Verfahren das eine andere
Angemessenheit zugrunde legt und
übrigens die Tatsache von Verzicht redet
gar bei der AFD sie könnten ihre
Gehälter gerne dem vor der AFD
Geschädigten zur Verfügung stellen hätte
in diesem Land niemand etwas dagegen
glauben Sie mir sich hier hinzustellen
und bar jeder Kenntnis
wo ich immer sagen muss wenn man schon
nicht denken will kann man auch nicht
rechnen natürlich ist es richtig in
einer Phase in der es schwierig wird wo
man noch von der letztjährigen Erhöhung
profitieren würde zu sagen nein macht es
Parlament nicht mit es ist gerade im
Sinne der Regelung das eben eine
Lohnentwicklung insgesamt auch über
längere Zeiträume darüber entscheidet
was der deutsche Bundestag verdienen
kann also Kollegen Sie auf diese Könige
auf Nein vielen herzlichen Dank Frau
aber die Debatte kann ja an anderer
Stelle noch weitergehen hören sie auf an
dieser Stelle einen Eindruck ein
Klischee zu bedienen das am Ende des
Tages nur in der Lage ist letztendlich
die eigene Verantwortung zu dekorieren
aber nicht mehr in der Lage ist deutlich
zu machen dass auch dieses Parlament
eine Grundlage braucht auf die sie sich
auch in Zukunft verlassen können um
Transparenz regelgerecht und in
Übereinstimmung mit den Grundsätzen des
Verfassungsgerichtes zu entscheiden
vielen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Frieser und für
eine
Kurzintervention erhält das Wort der
Abgeordnete Kräuter
vielen Dank frau Präsidentin ich kann es
jetzt nicht lassen doch noch dazu
Stellung zu nehmen nachdem hier in
diesem Hause großes AFD Bashing gemacht
wurde wir hätten dieses Parlament vor
vier Jahren schon verächtlich gemacht
der Kollege Brandner hätte dann noch mal
nachgesetzt dem muss ich ganz klar
widersprechen für die die vor denn der
letzten Legislaturperiode schon diesem
Haus war und zugehört haben ging es uns
vor allen Dingen darum darauf
hinzuweisen dass es nicht geht diesen
Beschluss ohne Debatte durchzubringen
sie wollten es heimlich still und leise
machen ohne Debatte und erst auf Drängen
der AFD haben sie hier überhaupt eine
Debatte zugelassen und Kollege der
gerade vor mir sprach sagen Sie mir doch
mal was im Paragraph 31 das
abgeordnetengesetzes steht ich sage es
Ihnen da steht nämlich ganz klar drin
dass ein Abgeordneter auf diese Diäten
weder teilweise noch komplett verzichten
kann und wenn ich sie jetzt hier gerade
gehört habe dann kriege ich ja fast
Mitleid das hört sich so an als wollten
sie hier diesen Automatismus einführen
um um die Diäten senken zu können das
ist nicht so wir hatten in der Corona
Situation jetzt mal eine
Ausnahmesituation ansonsten haben sie
sich immer einen Schluck aus der Pulle
mehr genehmigt da sagen wir das geht so
nicht die Abgeordneten bekommen genug
verlassen sie ihre Blase haben sie ein
Ohr am Volk was das Volk sagt es kommt
nicht jemand über ihn aber es kommt
jemand unter ihnen jemand der sich
hierhin gewählt hat der sie letztendlich
bezahlt und es wäre schön wenn sie mich
angucken wenn ich gerade mit Ihnen
spreche und mir nicht ihren Rücken
zudrehe und lasse mich abschließend noch
sagen wenn sie mit einem Rentner oder
einem alleinerziehend sprechen welche
Probleme diese hat dann wissen Sie wie
Sie sich hierzu verhalten hätten vielen
Dank
Herr Kollege gucken darf jeder hier noch
wohin er möchte und der Kollege friesa
bekommt jetzt die Möglichkeit zu
Erwiderung
frau Präsidentin aber wenn man sich mal
Namen merken könnte würde ich auch
hingucken aber andere Frage nichts
könnte falscher sein als die Tatsache
dass ich dieses Parlament gerade diesem
Diskussionsprozess entziehen würde was
tun wir denn heute was gibt uns denn das
eigenformulierte Gesetz auf nämlich
selbst regelmäßig darüber zu entscheiden
transparent öffentlich wirksam und auch
nachvollziehbar es ist nichts
gespenstiges daran es passiert nichts
hinter verschlossenen Türen also
insofern ist alles falsch erstens die
Tatsache dass es keine Debatte gibt
zweitens die Tatsache das ist nicht
berechenbar wäre das ist um irgendeinen
Schluck aus einer Pulle ginge im
Gegenteil wenn dieses Parlament des
Gefühl hat das ist zu viel wäre weil es
auf alten Maßstäben passiert dann kehren
wir zurück können auch verzichten auf
eine solche Form von Anpassung wenn sie
nicht in die Zeit passt das ist
parlamentar los das ist Verantwortung
und das vor allem den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern gegenüber
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Frieser wir
kommen zur Abstimmung ich schließe die
Aussprache wir kommen zur Abstimmung
über den Antrag der Fraktionen SPD
cdu/csu Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
auf Drucksache 269 mit dem Titel
anpassungsverfahren gemäß Paragraph 11
Absatz 4 des abgeordnetengesetzes wer
stimmt für diesen Antrag
das sind SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
cdu/csu und FDP wer stimmt dagegen das
ist die AFD und die Linke entsprechend
keine Enthaltung
damit ist der Antrag angenommen ich und
das bedeutet dass das weitere Verfahren
was die Abgeordneten Besoldung angeht
sofortgesetzt wird wie in den
vergangenen zehn Jahren nämlich dass es
an den nominal lohnindex gekoppelt sein
wird in einer bestimmten gehaltszirke
Klasse nämlich orientiert an bestimmten
gerichtergehältern und das kann eben
unter anderem dazu führen dass die
Diäten auch mal weniger werden als im
Jahr zuvor und das wird ab 1.7 des
nächsten Jahres der Fall sein wenn auch
nur minimal aber es wird eben es gibt
keine garantierte Abgeordneten Diäten
Erhöhung wie es hier teilweise
angeklungen ist wir verlassen
vorübergehend den Plenarsaal des
Deutschen Bundestages sind aber so in
acht neun Minuten wieder da weil da wird
sich wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ein
klein wenig hoch hergehen denn es
nämlich um die Sitzordnung hier im
Deutschen Bundestag geht sie haben die
Debatte mit Sicherheit verfolgt aber es
passieren auch anderswo auf der Welt
Dinge unter anderem mit dem neuen
deutschen Kanzler und was das alles ist
und was es dazu zeigen und zu hören gibt
sagt ihnen Florian Bauer in Bonn
diejenigen die
dem gezeichnet
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen cdu/csu und FDP wer stimmt
dagegen das ist die AFD Enthaltung keine
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung mit großer Mehrheit angenommen
Dritter Beratung und Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
das ist wieder die Linke SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen CDU CSU und FDP vielen Dank
wer stimmt dagegen das ist die AFD der
Gesetzentwurf Enthaltung entsprechend
keine damit ist der Gesetzentwurf mit
großer Mehrheit angenommen
tagungsordnungspunkte 10b bis 10J wir
kommen zu den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Petitionsausschusses sammelübersicht
sechs auf Drucksache 237 es handelt sich
um 88 Petitionen wer stimmt dafür
dass es DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen cdu/csu FDP und AFD
Gegenstimmen keine Enthaltung keine
damit ist die sammelübersicht 6
einstimmig angenommen sammelübersicht
sieben auf Drucksache 238 das sind 76
Petitionen wer stimmt dafür
das sind alle Fraktionen im Haus wer
stimmt dagegen
Enthaltungen keine damit ist sie
sammelübersicht sieben einstimmig
angenommen sammelübersicht 8 auf
Drucksache 239 19 Petition wer stimmt
dafür
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
cdu/csu FDP und AFD wer stimmt dagegen
die Linke Enthaltung keine damit ist die
sammelübersicht 8 mit breiter Mehrheit
angenommen sammelübersicht 9 auf
Drucksache 240 7 Petitionen
wer stimmt dafür
das ist DIE LINKE SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen cdu/csu auch ja und die FDP wer
stimmt dagegen die AFD Enthaltung keine
sammelübersicht 9 ist mit großer
Mehrheit angenommen
sammelübersicht 10 auf Drucksache 241 5
Petition wer stimmt dafür
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
cdu/cs und FDP wer stimmt dagegen die
linke und die AFD wer enthält sich keine
Fraktion sammelübersicht 10 ist mit
großer Mehrheit angenommen
sammelübersicht 11 auf Drucksache 242
eine Petition wer stimmt dafür
linke SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen CDU CSU
und FDP und AFD alle Fraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen entsprechend keiner
Enthaltung keiner sammelt Übersicht 11
ist einstimmig angenommen
sammelübersicht 12 auf Drucksache 243
218 Petition wer stimmt dafür
dass die spd-bündnis 90 die Grünen
cdu/csu FDP und AFD wer stimmt dagegen
die Linke Enthaltung keine
sammelübersicht 12 ist mit großer
Mehrheit angenommen sammelübersicht 13
auf Drucksache 244 eine Petition wer
stimmt dafür
hat sich die CDU entschieden okay das
sind also alle Fraktionen außer der
cdu/csu wer stimmt dagegen die
cdu/csu-fraktion Enthaltung keine damit
es sammelübersicht 13 mit großer
Mehrheit angenommen und sammelübersicht
14 auf Drucksache 245 fünf Petitionen
wer stimmt dafür
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und die FDP wer stimmt dagegen
linke cdu/csu und AFD Enthaltung keine
damit es sammelübersicht 14 angenommen
ich rufe auf den Zusatzpunkt 2 Beratung
des Antrags der Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90
die grün- und FDP mit dem Titel
Sitzordnung im Plenarsaal des
Bundestages für die Aussprache ist eine
Dauer von 31 Minuten beschlossen ich
eröffne die Aussprache und jetzt muss
ich
die richtige Reihenfolge nehmen so da
sind wir wieder rechtzeitig zurück denn
hier ist gerade aufgerufen die schon
angekündigte Debatte Zusatzpunkt 2 des
heutigen debattentages Sitzordnung im
Plenarsaal des Bundestages die kennen
das Ansehen der FDP-Fraktion nicht mehr
weiter außen sitzen zu wollen also
direkt neben der AFD sondern in die
Mitte zu rücken und da hat sich die
Koalition insgesamt angeschlossen und
die Begründung dazu jetzt von Irene
mihalic
gesagt ein bisschen unglücklich dass wir
jetzt hier diese Debatte in der Sache
führen müssen weil ich erstens ehrlich
gesagt davon ausgegangen bin dass alle
Argumente zu diesem Punkt bereits
ausgetauscht sind und zweitens versuche
mir vorzustellen wie eine solche Debatte
auf die Menschen in unserem Land wirkt
angesichts der vielen Probleme die wir
zu bewältigen haben ja
wir haben die Debatte nicht angezettelt
meine Damen und Herren
ja wir als Mitglieder des Deutschen
Bundestages müssen uns wirklich multiple
Problemlagen dringend mit Kraft und mit
lösungswillen widmen ob das die
Klimakrise ist ob das die Pandemie ist
oder auch die terroristische Bedrohung
und und führen wir hier eine Debatte zu
Sitzordnung nun denn aber ich will diese
Frage gar nicht trivialisieren ja denn
sie ist in diesem konkreten Fall für
mindestens zwei Fraktionen hier im Haus
von sehr großer Bedeutung aber man
sollte diese Frage auch nicht überhöhen
meine Damen und Herren die Sitzordnung
des Deutschen Bundestages ist nicht in
Stein gemeint und Fraktionen im
politischen Koordinatensystem ganz grob
aber mehr auch nicht und in der Mitte
meine Damen und Herren und in der Mitte
während sich ja dabei fast jede Partei
und wenn wir uns die Sitzordnung in den
Landtagen anschauen dann finden wir da
auch kein einheitliches System vor
sondern so ziemlich jede irgendwie
denkbare Konstellation und ja es stimmt
wir haben die Sitzordnung auf diese
Weise noch nie geändert was aber nicht
bedeutet dass daran nie ein Interesse
gab und da steht jede Legislaturperiode
für sich die FDP wollte schon bei ihrem
Wiedereinzug in den Bundestag 2017 eine
Veränderung der Sitzordnung damals hat
sich die cdu/csu durchgesetzt jetzt zu
sagen das war doch schon immer so ist
natürlich nachvollziehbar aber
inhaltlich auch ein denkbar schwaches
Argument meine Damen und Herren für uns
für uns erscheint der Wunsch der FDP
nach einer Veränderung mindestens
genauso nachvollziehbar wie der Wunsch
der Union alles so zu belassen wie es
jetzt ist da zeigen wir uns in dieser
Frage mit unserem Koalitionspartner
solidarisch und Stimmen für die
Veränderung der Sitzordnung doch und das
lassen Sie mich bitte noch sagen doch
wir appellieren auch an beide Fraktionen
meine Damen und Herren in gegenseitigem
Respekt und in Anerkennung des
Standpunktes des jeweils anderen im
Laufe dieser Wahlperiode ein Dialog über
den Zusammenhang politischer
selbstverordnung und Sitzordnung zu
führen damit wir nicht in vier Jahren
wieder hier stehen und die gleiche
Debatte erneut führen müssen ganz
herzlichen Dank
Irene mihalicianas erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen es geht
um die Sitzordnung hier im Bundestag es
geht um den Wunsch der FDP in die Mitte
zurück Rücken und das würde bedeuten
dass die Unionsfraktion ein bisschen aus
dem Präsidium Sicht nach rechts zurück
rücken muss Torsten frei wird jetzt
seine Sicht der Dinge darlegen er ist
erster Pille im parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der Unionsfraktion und
gegen diese Idee
[Applaus]
RTV Vize frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Frau Dr
michaelitsch Menzi hier von Respekt
sprechen dann will ich Ihnen gleich
sagen dass wir das Verhalten der
Koalitionsfraktionen als Ausdruck von
Respektlosigkeit Empfinden nicht anders
kann man das nennen was sie hier
beantragt haben das meine ich in der
Sache das meine ich aber auch in der
Form sie haben hier einen Antrag
vorgelegt der nicht einen einzigen Satz
der Begründung enthält keinen einzigen
Satz und darüber hinaus
also wir haben Ihnen diese Debatte nicht
aufgedrängt wir haben Ihnen vor allen
Dingen diesen Tagesordnungspunkt nicht
aufgedrängt aber dass sie hingehen und
diesen Punkt vorweihnachten ohne Debatte
still und heimlich durch den Bundestag
zu treiben das ist wirklich der Gipfel
der Respektlosigkeit und das lassen wir
Ihnen so nicht durchgehen da werden die
Menschen nämlich sehen dass das ganz
offensichtlich die Themen sind und die
Probleme die für die
Koalitionsfraktionen aktuell die
beherrschenden und die wichtigen sind
wir sehen das anders aber zu glauben das
über die kalte Küche zu machen das
lassen wir Ihnen nicht durchgehen und
ich will ihnen einfach auch nur sagen
sie haben wirklich nur wenige Tage
gebraucht um den ersten wichtigen Punkt
ihres eigenen Koalitionsvertrages ad
acta zu legen da steht nämlich
geschrieben wir wollen den Deutschen
Bundestag wieder zum zentralen
debattenort in der Politik machen und
das tun sie eben gerade nicht der Punkt
gilt offensichtlich nur dann wenn die
Debatten Ihnen angenehm sind wenn sie
ihnen in ihren Interessen entsprechen
und ansonsten halten sie sich nicht
daran ich will
ich will
an dieser Stelle gerne folgendes sagen
es gibt im Grunde genommen klar
durchsichtige parteipolitische Gründe
warum sie das machen sie möchten uns von
unseren Plätzen an den Rand des Plenums
drücken sie möchten einen monolithischen
regierungsblock in der Mitte statuieren
sie möchten für die Mehrheit die
zentralen Plätze hier im Plenum haben
und das ist nicht in Ordnung und liebe
Frau Dr mihalic
ich muss Ihnen sagen
es ist ja nicht nur so dass seit mehr
als 70 Jahren die Sitzordnung im
Deutschen Bundestag so ist wie sie ist
sondern wenn Sie sich erinnern an das
Jahr 1983 da sind die Grünen in den
Deutschen Bundestag eingezogen und es
war die cdu/csu-fraktion die ihnen einen
zentralen Platz zwischen SPD und Union
zugebilligt hat weil wir erkannt haben
dass es wichtig ist dass auch
Mehrheitsfraktionen der Minderheit einen
zentralen Ort im Parlament belassen das
ist auch eine Frage der Repräsentanz das
ist auch eine Frage des
Erscheinungsbildes des Parlamentes und
deswegen ist es für mich was sie hier
tun ein Zeichen großer Schwäche das muss
ich wirklich sagen es ist ein Zeichen
von Kleinkariertheit weil sie sich nicht
um die wesentlichen Themen kümmern
sondern weil sie sich auf
musikschauplätzen tummeln und ich will
ihnen eines sagen
respizephine bedenken sie das Ende
eigentlich hat doch jeder hier in diesem
rund die Erfahrung dass im
Parlamentarismus in der Demokratie jede
Mehrheit zur Minderheit und jede
Minderheit zur Mehrheit werden kann wenn
sie das zur Disposition stellen wenn Sie
einen solchen comment zu Disposition
stellen dann müssen sie damit leben das
in Zukunft auch sie dorthin platziert
werden wo sie nicht hin möchten was
werden sie denn sagen wenn irgendwann
mal wenn irgendwann mal die AFD zwischen
Grünen und FDP platziert wird dann
möchte ich gerne mal ihre Kommentare
hören ich bin sicher sie werden als
Zauberlehrling enden weil sie die
Geister die sie heute rufen nicht mehr
loswerden erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage des Abgeordneten dran
an sich gerne aber ich glaube das tut
jetzt wirklich nichts zur Sache ich
möchte zu meiner Schlussbemerkung kommen
das was ich eben angesprochen habe
bedenke das Ende das hat eine populäre
Vertreterin dieses Hauses frühzeitig
erkannt deswegen möchte ich gerne mit
Erlaubnis der Frau Präsidentin gerne
zitieren und zwar die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bass die am
23 November in der Berliner Zeitung
folgendes gesagt hat das ist nur wenige
Tage her ich rate den Fraktionen fragen
wie die Sitzordnung einvernehmlich zu
lösen der natürlich birgt das Konflikte
wenn man jetzt nicht einfach mit
Mehrheit bestimmt dass eine Fraktion
gegen ihren Willen umziehen muss am Ende
fangen wir nach jeder Wahl an über die
Sitzordnung zu streiten Zitat Ende
besser kann man es nicht sagen unser
Ratschlag nehmen Sie Ihren Antrag den
sie zurück in den Ältestenrat
ihn zurück lernen sie Respekt
eigentlich ganz unwichtiger Punkt den du
hast ein Freitag macht normalerweise
werden solche Sachen tatsächlich im
Ältestenrat besprochen wir werfen einen
Blick in den Plenarsaal der hat im
Moment die Unionsfraktion am besten
mobilisiert auch die Grünen sind nahezu
komplett in dieser Debatte schauen und
so nach und nach fühlen sich jetzt auch
die Reihen der SPD-Fraktion weil das
wäre ja ein Ding wenn hier am Ende
dieser Debatte die eine Ampelkoalition
möglicherweise nicht so präsent wäre wie
nötig um für diesen Antrag eine Mehrheit
hier zu bekommen also ganz schön viel
los hier im Plenarsaal in diesen Minuten
zu einem Thema das wahrscheinlich nicht
entscheidend sein wird für die Politik
der Ampelkoalition aber die
offensichtlich vielen Abgeordneten sehr
sehr wichtig ist merken sie jetzt gerade
am rhythmischen Applaus für die Rede von
Thorsten frei eigentlich sollte nämlich
jetzt beginnen Johannes Vogel erster im
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer der
FDP-Fraktion der kriegt jetzt auch viel
Applaus aber natürlich auch seinem rein
mal gucken wie das hier weitergeht
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Regierung die gibt es in jedem Staat
aber Parlamente die gibt es nur in
Demokratie und deshalb sind
Organisationsfragen des
Parlamentarismus auch nicht egal liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und es wichtig
dass wir hier im Plenum darüber sprechen
und
dass wir es diese Woche sprechen darüber
sprechen das liegt ja in der Natur der
Sache denn um zu funktionieren muss sich
ein parlament-konstituieren und das tun
wir diese Woche mit der Konstituierung
der Ausschüsse und deshalb ist es auch
klar dass wir wenn wir von der
vorläufigen zur dauerhaften Ordnung
dieses Bundestages für diese Legislatur
übergehen dass wir die Frage der
Sitzordnung ein für alle Mal entscheiden
diese Woche liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union und das ist
richtig
und wir erklären wir klären diese Frage
allein deshalb ausnahmsweise nicht im
Ältestenrat sondern hier im Plenum weil
sie nicht mit sich haben reden lassen
diese Frage kommt doch wahrlich nicht
überraschend wir haben sie aufgebracht
2017 als wir erstmalig in den Bundestag
als erneuerte FDP zurückgekehrt sind sie
wollten nicht mit sich reden lassen sie
war Gegenstand im vorältestenrat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie war
Gegenstand von medialen Debatten sie war
Gegenstand des allerersten Interviews
das Thorsten frei als Kollege erster PGF
und ich gemeinsam hier gegeben haben
jetzt tun sie doch nicht so als würde
hier ein Hauruck-Verfahren erfolgen die
Kollegin Mia leschals gesagt die
Argumente sind ausgetauscht wir müssen
entscheiden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union und das machen
wir heute
worum es geht ist eine ganz einfache
Frage nämlich das links rechtsschema der
Politik das ist wahrlich nicht perfekt
aber das links rechtsschema der Politik
ist ganz offenkundig das nachdem dieser
Deutsche Bundestag bei seinen Fraktionen
mit einer Ausnahme sortiert ist jeder
kann das Sehen jede Besucherin jeder
Besucher der hier den Plenarsaal erklärt
bekommt versteht das und sieht das jede
Schülerin die über den Bundestag in der
Schule lernt versteht das es gibt nur
eine einzige Anomalie nämlich dass die
Freien Demokraten nicht in der Mitte
sitzen denn wir sind eine Kraft der
politischen Mitte und deshalb gehören
wir auch in die Mitte des Plenums liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
so war und ist es in der klaren Mehrheit
der Parlamente weltweit so ist es
übrigens auch in ganz vielen Landtagen
in Schleswig-Holstein in Hamburg in
Niedersachsen in Rheinland-Pfalz im
traditionsreichen Baden-Württemberg so
war es übrigens 2018 bis 2018 auch in
Hessen da saßen die Freien Demokraten
traditionell in der Mitte des Plenums
bis ja bis Volker Bouffier mit seiner
Mehrheit entschieden hat dass die Freien
Demokraten gegen ihren Willen rechts von
der Union gesetzt werden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen so war es
übrigens auch in Bayern da saßen die
Freien Demokraten immer in der Mitte des
Maximilianeums wenn Sie den Parlament
angehört haben bis 2018 wo die CSU mit
ihrer Mehrheit entschieden hat dass die
Freien Demokraten gegen ihren Willen
nach rechts gerückt werden Phasen sie
doch nicht von Arroganz der Macht und
Respektlosigkeit wenn sie das selber in
Hessen und Bayern machen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
von ihnen lassen wir uns dann nicht zu
Arroganz der Macht erzählen wahrlich
nicht
und kommen Sie mir auch nicht bitte mit
das war schon immer so das ist ja das
Argument was angeführt wurde in der
Paulskirche im ersten gewählten
Parlament auf Bundesebene dem rechts
nach politischen Spektrum sortiert und
wo saßen die Liberalen Gruppen in der
Mitte in Weimar da saß die ddp die
Partei von Walter Rathenau nachdem heute
unser Fraktionssaal benannt ist die
Partei von Friedrich Naumann nach dem
unsere parteisiftung benannt ist die
Partei vom ersten Bundespräsidenten
Theodor Heuss saß in der Mitte und
rechts von ihr das Zentrum eindeutig
ihre vorgängerpartei es war nicht immer
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sondern die Freien Demokraten die
Liberalen gehören diesem Land in die
Mitte auch im Plenum liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union
natürlich ist die Mitte vielfältig wer
repräsentieren sie nicht alleine das ist
auch gut so deswegen sind wir als
demokratische Parteien der Mitte
koalitionsfähig aber es kann doch kein
Zweifel bestehen das SPD und Grüne sich
als Mitte Linksparteien begreifen und es
kann doch auch kein Zweifel bestehen
dass sie sich auch als konservativ
begreifen also als Mitte Rechtsparteien
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union Liberalismus das ist die
Verbindung von wirtschaftlicher und
gesellschaftlicher Freiheit ich bin
stolz drauf dass der Präsident von
Gesamtmetall den Koalitionsvertrag den
aktuellen lobt als besser den an dem sie
beteiligt waren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union ich bin stolz
darauf dass wir für Marktwirtschaft
stehen und für gegen Steuererhöhung aber
ich sage Ihnen auch ich bin auch stolz
darauf dass wir für gesellschaftliche
Freiheit stehen diese Koalition die
liberalisiert das
Reproduktionsmedizin die Verband die
Vorratsdatenspeicherung aus dem Gesetz
die modernisiert das Staatsbürger erst
recht die schafft
Verantwortungsgemeinschaften und für all
diese Vorhaben wird diese Koalition von
rechts von ihnen kritisiert das ist doch
auch die Wahrheiten der
traditionsbestand den wir abbilden
müssen in diesem Plenum liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich respektiere das weil diese Breite
des demokratischen Spektrums in der
Meinung Streit hier zu unserer
Demokratie dazu gehört aber das macht
doch deutlich dass das nachvollziehbare
Anliegen das Plenum hier nach dem links
rechtsspektrum nach dem politischen
Spektrum zu sortieren dass sich das
gegen niemanden richtet sie selber
diffamieren diese Koalition ja nicht als
links rechts sondern als links gelb und
die CSU beispielsweise hat gerade ihren
Mitgliedermagazin ein fiktives Interview
mit Franz Josef Strauß abgedruckt auf
vier Seiten hat das mit Interesse
gelesen weil Franz Josef Strauß der hat
mal gesagt rechts von der Union soll es
keine demokratische Partei geben die
unzweifelhaft auf dem Boden der
Verfassung steht Franz Josef Strauß soll
seinen Willen haben liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der dafür sorgen wir hier
im Deutschen Bundestag
es gibt
es gibt kein historisch schlüssiges
Argument gegen die Sitzordnung die wir
heute hier beschließen wollen es gibt
auch keinen sachlich schlüssiges
Argument liebe Kolleginnen und von der
Union es gibt einfach nur dass das
zuletzt so war es gibt einfach nur ein
bisschen Gewohnheit ich verstehe das aus
konservativer Perspektive man etwas
nicht verändert will an dass man gewohnt
ist wir sind ehrlich gesagt andere
Auffassung
wir sind der Auffassung man verändert
etwas wenn es dafür einen vernünftigen
Grund gibt deshalb beschließen wir das
heute und danach streiten wir wieder
über die Sache vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
Johannes Vogel erster parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion hat
unter anderem ein Interview erwähnt dass
er gemeinsam gegeben hat mit Thorsten
Frey in der vergangenen Woche war das
und jetzt raten Sie mal über welchen
kleinen tapferen Sender das
stattgefunden hat der Bundestag
diskutiert weiter über die Sitzordnung
hier im Plenarsaal und da ist auf der
Rednerliste jetzt vorgesehen Stefan
Brandner aus der afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
will ich unwürdiges Schauspiel ich hoffe
wirklich dass viele Millionen Menschen
draußen mal schauen was hier in diesem
Bundestag los ist zu welchem
Kasperletheater Sie diesen Bundestag
haben verkommen lassen heute morgen
sollte über einen 60 Milliarden
Nachtragshaushalt 30 Minuten debattiert
werden wir sind dann Gott sei Dank
eingeschnitten dann wurden 60 Minuten
draußen normalerweise wird über
Auslandseinsätze der Bundeswehr wo es um
Leben und Tod unserer Soldaten geht 30
Minuten debattiert und das machen die
jetzt wie debattiert 30 Minuten lang
weil die weil ihr nicht nebeneinander
sitzen wollt weil der dir Sitzplan
durcheinander geredet ist ja wie krank
ist denn sowas wichtige Debatten gehören
hier ins Haus und nicht so ein
Kasperletheater wäre neben wem sitzt und
ich nehme es vorweg und es sowieso
wurscht wir nehmen und sitzt wir sitzen
sowieso demnächst überall von daher ist
es das ganz egal
aber wenn Ihnen das so wichtig ist und
ich kündige das für die afd-fraktion an
wenn Ihnen das so wichtig ist dann
können wir gerne am Ende der Debatte den
namentliche Abstimmung darüber machen
und mal sehen wer sich namentlich wie
positioniert dich bitte dass ihr den PGF
aufzunehmen meine Damen und Herren
736 Abgeordnete mal eine halbe Stunde
sind ungefähr 380 Mann Stunden die wir
jetzt darauf verschwenden dass die
hellbraune Koalition wenn man Rot und
Grün vermengt und bisschen gelb dazu
mich kommt der hellbraun raus dass die
hellbraune Koalition jetzt wird sich die
Sitzordnung hier ändern möchte sollen
sie tun wir haben nichts dagegen die CDU
kann sich gerne neben uns setzen sie
kann viel lernen wie geht gute
Oppositionsarbeit das ist bei uns zu
lernen wie geht vor allem
korruptionsfreie politische Arbeit das
kann man von uns lernen und so langsam
Liebe CDU ja verbindet uns ja auch dass
es uns glücklich macht das Merkel weg
ist oder das sehe ich Ihnen an also wir
werden glaube ich auch eine gute
Nachbarschaft hierhin arbeiten und sind
im Endeffekt sehr sehr froh darüber
insofern könnte man meinen dass wir als
AFD da richtig geschickt vorgegangen
sind denn wir wollen neben diesen
blasierten Typen von der FDP
Universitäten es ist unerträglich was in
dieser Fraktion in letzter Zeit los ist
je näher die sich so an die Macht
heranrobten desto blasierter wurde diese
macht versessene macht vergessene
grünlingsdevote Posten Grabscher Truppe
von der FDP ekelhaft was aus dieser
Partei geworden ist von uns auf die
linke Seite am besten so weit weg wie
möglich von uns apropos Posten Grabscher
auch was an sexistischen Sprüchen und
anmachen aus der fdp-truppe kommen das
werden sie dann hier von den Grünen
demnächst erleben wir haben
grau melierte Freiheitskämpfer der FDP
die Robben sich schamlos an die
afd-abgeordnete tinnen heran der
Fraktionsvorsitzende berichtet mir von
lüsternden blicken einer
verteidigungspolitischen Sprecherin der
FDP die er fühlt sich sexuell belästigt
es ist eine Katastrophe was da ist sie
hören Sprüche
[Applaus]
sie hören Sprüche sperrt die AFD in
Lager sie hören Sprüche ihr kommt zu
viel aus dem ossi-land das ist eine
verkommene Gurkentruppe geworden wir
wünschen uns wirklich dass diese weit
weg die von uns sitzen wie möglich und
freuen uns auf eine gute Nachbarschaft
zur CDU zur CSU im Sinn einer guten
konstruktiven Oppositionsarbeit vielen
Dank
Stefan Brandner aus der afd-fraktion
was soll man sagen wir geben rüber in
die Bundespressekonferenz nicht weit von
hier denn da gibt es die wöchentliche in
den letzten Monaten und Jahren
jedenfalls zu wöchentlich immer
stattgefunden haben eine Pressekonferenz
des Bundesgesundheitsministers mit dem
Präsidenten des Robert Koch-Instituts
der Bundesgesundheitsminister hat
gewechselt die Pressekonferenz bleibt
ich gebe rüber in die
Bundespressekonferenz
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich kann
verstehen dass wir hier eine Debatte
führen wer sitzt künftig neben der AFD
im Deutschen Bundestag weil das ist das
eigentliche Thema über das wir reden und
ich verstehe jeden hier im Haus der sich
schämt neben ihnen zu sitzen
und weil weil wir so ein paar Argumente
gefallen sind will ich noch mal sagen
worum es geht natürlich hat der Kollege
frei damit recht dass man Dinge
einvernehmlich im Ältestenrat klärt nur
dieses Thema ist nicht einvernehmlich im
Ältestenrat zu klären und deshalb muss
es dorthin wo es geklärt werden kann in
des Parlament im Deutschen Bundestag und
deshalb wird es hier heute entschieden
Herr Kollege frei
und wieso haben wir dieses Thema ohne
Debatte aufgesetzt weil wir finden es
muss entschieden werden aber wir
brauchen auch keine lange Debatte dazu
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger da draußen
die erwarten von uns dass wir über die
Pandemie Bekämpfung sprechen die
erwarten von uns dass wir in Antworten
geben wie wir Arbeitsplätze sichern in
dieser Transformation die erwarten von
uns wie wir die Klimakrise bekämpfen die
Demografie und die Globalisierung
deshalb haben wir das ohne Debatte
aufgesetzt es ist ihr gutes Recht dem
von dem haben sie Gebrauch gemacht
Debatte aufzusetzen der stellen wir uns
auch hier mit an dieser Stelle
und lassen sie mich zum Schluss kommen
sagen wir haben gestern die
Regierungserklärung vom Kanzler der
Ampel gehabt von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz er hat viele Antworten auf die
Fragen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
gegeben und für uns alle ist klar wir
sind eine Koalition der Mitte und
deshalb stimmen wir heute als SPD auf
der Veränderung dieser Sozialordnung zu
[Applaus]
ich grüße Sie herzlich von hier aus und
gebe das Wort dem Kollegen Jan Kotte von
der Fraktion DIE LINKE
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das glaube ich wird bis jetzt die beste
Debatte die wir in dieser
Legislaturperiode hier hatten will ich
mal voraussagen können es fällt doch ein
wenig auf und dann möchte ich was zu
sagen Kollege frei ich finde das schon
relativ bemerkenswert das muss ich ja
mal sagen wie Sie und Ihre Fraktion 30
Jahren mit meiner Partei damals der PDS
und dann der Linksfraktion umgegangen
sind und sich jetzt hier hinstellen weil
es jetzt Ihnen einmal hier an den Kragen
geht diese Weinerlichkeit das ist
wirklich sehr traurig wir sind in einer
Zeit mal sagen ist ja ein Heulsusen tun
besonders gleich ich möchte kurz
begründen warum müssen wir uns heute mit
dieser zunächst auf den ersten Blick
mittelwichtigen Frage überhaupt
beschäftigen zunächst einmal sagt etwas
dieser Antrag aus dass überhaupt
gestellt werden muss über die braune
kaspertruppe dort vorne das ist ja das
eigentliche Sinn das sagt nämlich aus
sie haben ja plakatiert Deutschland aber
normal war glaube ich ihr Slogan und ich
kann hier zumindest mal für die
demokratischen Abgeordneten feststellen
jeder und normale Abgeordnete möchte
nicht neben
die Sachlage mit der wir hier zu tun
haben das gilt für alle anderen
Fraktionen so sieht es hier mal aus
und das auch meine aller Klarheit zu
sagen warum solltet ihr Union und meine
Fraktion Die Linke findet dies Verfahren
vielleicht etwas unglückliches gewählt
wurde aber wir tragen es inhaltlich mit
warum ich möchte es begründen zunächst
einmal gibt es das links rechtsklima
seit der großen französischen Revolution
und deswegen hat das einen bestimmten
Grund und es auch sehr sinnvoll denn
auch wir als LINKE behalten daran fest
dass wir die Politik einordnen und
analysieren müssen anhand des links
rechts Schemas dabei bleiben wir und das
hat auch sehr gute Gründe aus
historischer Verantwortung jetzt will
ich aber auch politisch aktuelle Gründe
dafür führen warum sie dorthin müssen
und sie dorthin müssen das will ich
sagen gestern bei der Rede ihres
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Ralf Brinkhaus es
hört ja nicht auf bei ihnen ja und da
müssen sie gucken Kollege Freise sie
haben ihm gesagt bedenke das Ende also
das ist erstmal etwas das haben sie so
wie sie mit uns immer umgegangen sind
nicht bedacht das sehen Sie dann jetzt
heute das ist aber eine andere Frage ich
will aber noch mal was sagen ich will
das auch tagespolitischer aktuell machen
Ralf Brinkhaus sagte gestern an dieser
Stelle zum wiederholten Male wie sie das
die ganze Zeit tun dass sie weder mit
der AFD noch mit der Link etwas zu tun
haben wollen also diese Gleichsetzung
von links und rechts das ist eine
Tradition von rechtsreaktionärer
Geschichtsschreibung für die
insbesondere Ernst noltest geht und wer
so rumschmeckt darf sich nicht wundern
dass er dann weiter nach rechts gesetzt
wird das ist mal die Sachlage hier ja
ich kann
ja lesen wird unterschätzt so dann will
ich zum zweiten zum zweiten noch einen
inhaltlichen Grund geben sie haben
insbesondere in den letzten Jahren die
AFD erst stark gemacht weil sie die
ganze Zeit insbesondere Kollege Dobrindt
ist er gerade anwesend Söder hat das
dann bis vor zwei Jahren gemacht dann
hat er was ganz anderes gemacht haben
sie das Zeug nachgeplappert insbesondere
zum Bereich der Migration und haben die
Truppe erst mit stark gemacht auch das
ist ein Grund dafür dass sie weiter
rechts sitzen müssen das ist nämlich die
richtige Schlussfolgerung
so und dann will ich noch mal sagen ich
habe meinen Wahlkreis in Sachsen-Anhalt
also ich glaube sie haben in
sachsen-anhalt-führung überhaupt in den
ostdeutschen Landesverbänden der CDU
doch mal ein fettes Problem denn die Tür
zu den Nazis ist bei ihnen dort nicht zu
die Sperrmüll weit offen das müssen wir
erklären vielleicht hilft es dann
erstmal die Lage in der wir sind so und
da bin ich ja jetzt und da Pulli ja und
da Politik natürlich ein politischer
Prozess ich will das schon sagen also
bei der FDP nach der Gründung der
Bundesrepublik wäre das noch wirklich
falsch gewesen wenn sie dort gesessen
hätten da gehörten sie in der Tat an den
rechten Rand das muss man hier Ferne
selber mal sagen es gab eine Zeit nach
der Gründer 1948 da gab es den
Alliierten Hochkommissar mcleute hat man
überlegt ob in NRW Verband der FDP Mal
verhaftet weil er das halbe 30 als
Hauptamt und so rumhängen in ihrer Zeit
aber kann er feststellen dass ich da
sehr viel geändert hat und deswegen
finde ich das eine legitime Forderung
und meine Fraktion wird das heute hier
unterstützen ich kann abschließend sagen
für uns als Fraktion DIE LINKE leider
Gottes etwas kleiner geworden aber ich
kann wir uns feststellen wir sind stolz
und sitzen gerne hier ganz Linksaußen
denn weltweit sitzen dort in den
Parlamenten diejenigen Kräfte die schon
immer für eine Idee der Freiheit und
Gleichheit am konsequentesten gekämpft
haben und deswegen sind wir ganz in
Ordnung mit der Sitzordnung unterstützen
den Antrag vielen Dank
das war für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat der
Kollege Patrick Schnieder
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen
wenn ich mir die Beiträge der
Koalitionsfraktionen hier vor Augen
führe fühle ich mich erinnert an die
Regierungserklärung von gestern die
Tagesschau hat dazu gesagt viel geredet
wenig gesagt
inhaltlich haben sie überhaupt kein
Argument für das Ansinnen geliefert die
Sitzordnung heute zu enden
sie haben in der Sache im Vorfeld dieser
Debatte einen Grund genannt und heute
hat die Linke ihnen sekundiert ihnen von
der FDP sekundiert sie wollen nicht
neben der AFD sitzen das ist ja nun
wirklich ein kindergartenargument aber
im übrigen gilt das für alle Fraktionen
hier es gilt vielleicht nicht für eine
Fraktion das was Herr kortet gerade
gesagt hat würde ihn dazu prädestinieren
den Platz neben der neben den rechten
hier im Parlament einzunehmen
sie haben Ihren Antrag und es geht ja
auf die FDP zurück alleine damit
begründet dass sie über 200 Jahre
parlamentarische Tradition hier
referiert haben und wenn wir dabei
feststellen dass die FDP mal mehr oder
weniger rechts gesessen hat mal mehr
oder weniger in der Mitte gesessen hat
dann sagt das nur eines aus nämlich ihre
politische Beliebigkeit wenn Sie in
diesem Schema rechts links weiter denken
wird
und eines kann ich Ihnen nicht ersparen
und das merkt man ja bei den
Redebeiträgen ihrer Koalitionspartner
das sieht man auch an dem Redezeiten die
verteilt worden den ist das doch
peinlich darüber zu reden und sie müssen
uns noch nicht den Vorwurf machen dass
wir hier eine Debatte führen sie haben
das Thema aufgemacht als gäbe es nichts
Wichtigeres in diesem Lande als die
Sitzordnung im Deutschen Bundestag zu
Ende
und dann ist dieses Verfahren am
Intransparenz ja nicht zu überbieten
auch das müssen sich mal hinter die
Ohren schreiben gestern ist der Antrag
eingegangen dass man als ohne
debattenpunkt heute über diese Frage
redet es ist es ist im Normalfall so das
ist parlamentarische Tradition dass wir
über Fragen die das Parlament als Ganzes
betreffen im Ältestenrat reden aber
nicht im Verborgenen und geheimen und
ohne Aussprache und deshalb haben wir zu
Recht das heute hier als Debatte
aufgesetzt um zu zeigen wie Sie mit
diesem Parlament umgehen und auch das
erinnert mich auch das erinnert mich an
die an die Regierungserklärung von
gestern da hat der Bundeskanzler gefühlt
in jedem zweiten Satz abgewechsel
zwischen den Worten Respekt und neuer
Stil wenn das der neue Stil ist da muss
ich sagen ist ein schlechter Stil den
Sie hier praktizieren
und ich kann nur betonen ist ein
Respektlosigkeit nicht zu überbieten so
mit der Opposition umzugehen denn der
einzige Grund warum sie die Sitzordnung
ändern wollen ist der dass sie sich als
Koalition prominent in die Mitte des
Parlaments sitzen wollen die Opposition
an den Rand drängen wollen das ist
schlechter Stil das ist schlecht
Respektlosigkeit und deshalb lassen wir
Ihnen die Verfahren auch nicht
durchzählen
so
damit
damit schließe ich die Aussprache
geklatscht werden darf natürlich auch
nachdem die Aussprache geschlossen ist
und ich komme zur Abstimmung über den
Antrag der Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen und FDP auf Drucksache 268
mit dem Titel Sitzordnung im Plenarsaal
des Bundestages wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
vielen Dank damit ist dieser Antrag
angenommen bei Zustimmung durch die
Fraktion DIE LINKE der SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen und der FDP dagegen hat
gestimmt die Fraktion der CDU CSU die
Fraktion der AFD hat sich enthalten
ich rufe jetzt auf den Zusatzpunkt
aktuelle Stunde die Fraktion der AFD hat
eine Aktuelle Stunde verlangt zu dem
Thema
Umsatzeinbußen durch zwei g-regelungen
in Gastronomie und Einzelhandel
möglicherweise haben einige Kolleginnen
und Kollegen vor sich jetzt in Richtung
Gastronomie und Einzelhandel zu begeben
oder an die Schreibtische im Büro
deswegen warte ich noch einen Moment bis
wir
zum Beginn der Debatte kommen
ich weiße sie dann vorab schon einmal
darauf finden dass wir am Anfang der
Legislaturperiode sind und mithin auch
in dieser Debatte einige Kolleginnen
haben die in dieser Debatte ihre erste
Rede halten wir haben die gute Tradition
und Ordnung dass es bei der ersten Rede
keine Zwischenfragen gibt weil die hier
ausgewiesen sind sage ich sie an
allerdings haben wir eine Aktuelle
Stunde wo das sowieso nicht vorgesehen
ist und deswegen deswegen auch gleich
das für alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die neu sind die wird es sowieso nicht
geben aber wer seine erste Rede heute
hält wird natürlich einen freundlichen
Gruß der Präsidentin erhalten so jetzt
habe ich hier noch einige
stehgruppen unter anderem genau in der
Mitte des Parlaments in der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen da ist der
Fraktionsvorstand aus bestehend aus der
parlamentarischen Geschäftsführerin der
fraktionsvollsten meine Bitte wäre
Gespräche draußen
[Musik]
drinnen Debatte verfolgen herzlichen
Dank
Herr Brandner sie müssen sich gar nicht
umsetzen sondern ihre Maske aufsetzen
ich rede gerade deswegen tue ich das im
Moment nicht und jetzt bitte ich den
Kollegen Kai-uwe Ziegler von der
afd-fraktion um seinen Redebeitrag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich finde es wahnsinnig bezeichnend dass
sie bei dem kindergartentheater über
ihre Sitzplätze
volle Plätze haben
und die wirtschaftsfreundlichen Parteien
von FDP und CDU wenn dieser Tagesordnung
vorbei ist
fluchtartig den Saal verlassen ich würde
mir wirklich wünschen dass ihre Wähler
aus ihre Wähler das sehen wie wichtig in
ihr Sitzplatz ist und die unwichtig die
Belange des Handels draußen in unserem
Land
[Applaus]
liebe Kollegen ich bin seit 30 Jahren
selbst im Textil Einzelhandel ich weiß
was da draußen gerade abgeht ich weiß
wie sich das anfühlt
wurde zweimal in den Lockdown geschickt
mit zwei Tagen Vorlauf
da ist plötzlich alles was sie bis dahin
geplant haben vorbei sie können mit
ihren Mitarbeitern nicht mehr arbeiten
sie müssen ihnen Kurzarbeit stecken mit
60 Prozent und das ist der Bereich der
mit dem Mindestlohn bezahlt wird wie
sich das anfühlt für jemanden der seine
Leute ordentlich bezahlen möchte kann
ich ihnen überhaupt nicht beschreiben
wenn sie ohne eigenes Verschulden ihre
Geschäfte schließen müssen
dann fühlt sich das extrem hilflos an im
Moment haben wir eine Situation dass
dezember ist und das ist eigentlich der
wichtigste Monat für uns in dieser
Branche
und nein es geht nicht darum
große Gewinne zu machen sondern die
Verluste diesen Jahres irgendwie
ausgleichen zu können Reserven anzulegen
und für das nächste Jahr und das was da
vielleicht noch kommen wird gewappnet zu
sein
das alles können wir gerade vergessen
unsere Mitarbeiter sollen Ausweise
kontrollieren impfzertifikate
und wir wissen nicht mal ob sie dazu
befugt sind ob sie das dürfen und was
passiert wenn sie da einen Fehler machen
wer zahlt die Strafen
unsere Mitarbeiter müssen Kunden diese
seit Jahrzehnten kennen
an der Tür abfangen
und wenn die das dritte g für gesund
nicht erfüllen wieder rausschicken
das ist die Basis dieser Geschäfte das
Fundament und diese Leute müssen wir
wieder zur Tür weisen das ist
unerträglich und es hat mit dem was
draußen die Wirtschaft machen muss
nichts zu tun
die pressetitelt apokalyptische
Situation bei den Händlern
Umsatzverluste bis 80 Prozent
aber
das Geld ist nicht weg das haben nur
andere
die großen Online-Anbieter feiern gerade
ihr zweites Umsatz Weihnachtsfest
die großen
Supermärkte haben gerade ihr Sortiment
umgestellt und alles das was der Kleine
einzeichner nicht mehr verkaufen kann
gibt es dort plötzlich zu kaufen wenn es
überhaupt kein Problem wenn dort 100
Leute an den Sonderangeboten stehen und
bei dem kleinen Händler bei 100
Quadratmetern der eine der das letzte
gehen nicht erfüllt sich nicht aufhalten
darf
sie können
in ein Tabakwarengeschäft gehen ohne die
drei-regelung zu erfüllen sie können
aber nicht Nachbarn ein Spielzeug
Geschenk für ihre Tochter kaufen das ist
nicht möglich und das ist furchtbar
traurig und das aber Realität in unserem
Land
wenn ich das alles Revue passieren lasse
dieser Druck der auf die ungeimpften
gerade ausgeführt wird dann habe ich den
Eindruck es geht gar nicht um Gesundheit
es geht darum die ungeimpften zur
Spritze zu nötigen und das auf dem
Rücken der einsehändler der Gastronomen
und der anderen Dienstleistungsbetriebe
das ist eine Realität die draußen
stattfindet und die wir nicht
akzeptieren können sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler
vor ein paar Tagen konnte ich noch lesen
sie sind auch der Kanzler der
ungeimpften
machen Sie Schluss mit der
Diskriminierung der ungeimpften
machen Sie Schluss auf dem Rücken des
Einzelhandels der Gastronomie diese
Leute auszuschließen denn diese Bereiche
haben sich anderthalb Jahre vorbildlich
solidarisch und vernünftig verhalten
geben Sie bitte meinen Kollegen umgehend
Ihre unternehmerischen Freiheiten zurück
und beenden damit die ihre Zerstörung
einer Säule der deutschen Wirtschaft und
wenn ihr das nicht reichen sollte
und wenn Ihnen das nicht reichen sollte
dann tun Sie es bitte für die Millionen
fleißigen Mitarbeiter die Angst haben
und ihren Job
und ihre Existenz vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das wird für die SPD-Fraktion hat der
Kollege Bernd Westphal
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren in dieser
aktuellen Stunde geht es vor allem darum
wie können wir in der Pandemie unser
Land stabilisieren und bisher hat die
alte und auch die neue Bundesregierung
drei Punkte als Schwerpunkte vor Augen
wie man diese Pandemie bekämpft das
erste war wie können wir unser
Gesundheitssystem stärken da geht es
darum vor allen Dingen den Beschäftigten
den Strukturen wie es angeboten wird in
den Krankenhäusern in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen in den Arztpraxen
alles dafür zu tun dass man die
Rahmenbedingungen stabilisiert gehen
genau das ist das was wir seit zwei
Jahren massiv fordern unser
Gesundheitssystem muss stabilisiert
werden dafür werden wir alle
Finanzmittel und alle Ressourcen zur
Verfügung stellen
der zweite Punkt ist der Zusammenhalt in
der Gesellschaft und hier geht es nicht
darum zu spalten zu auszugrenzen zu
diskriminieren wie mein Vorredner hier
uns glauben schenken wollte sondern es
geht darum den Zusammenhalt in dieser
schwierigen Zeit zu organisieren und
deshalb gibt es Unterstützung gerade
auch für Familien gerade auch für den
Bereich wo Kinder im Bereich von Schulen
in den Bereich von älteren Menschen und
vor allen Dingen haben wir auch was die
Beschäftigten angeht durch
Kurzarbeitergeld beschäftigt und
gesichert das sichert Einkommen für
Familien stabilisiert sozial und bringt
sozialen Zusammenhalt meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
und
und der dritte Punkt das ist die
Stabilisierung unserer Wirtschaft unsere
ökonomische Basis zu sichern haben wir
mit vielen Wirtschaftshilfen mit
Überbrückungshilfen
Überbrückungshilfe 1 bis 3 jetzt sogar
Überbrückungshilfe 4 für das erste
Quartal
2022 auf den Weg gebracht wir haben
heute den Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds und vor allen
Dingen haben wir mit vielen detailhilfen
immer wieder nachgesteuert um der
Wirtschaft wie kleinteilig sie auch ist
vom Mittelstand über Handwerk bis zu
gastronomie-kultureinrichtungen
Veranstaltungsmanagement bis hin zur
Industrie eben diese Hilfe zu
organisieren und das ist gelungen weil
wir einen handlungsfähigen Staat haben
weil wir mit Wirtschaftshilfen genau
diese Stabilisierung von den Betrieben
von den Unternehmen ermöglicht haben
damit überhaupt heute
Einzelhandel stattfinden kann wenn diese
Hilfen nicht gewesen wären würde der
Handel gar nicht mehr existieren heute
und ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
dadurch dass wir diese Maßnahmen auf den
Weg gebracht haben dafür dass wir jetzt
einen Impfstoff haben dafür dass wir mit
impfdämpfer nach vorne kommen das
Hygienekonzepte eingehalten werden gibt
es keinen Lockdown sondern findet
Einzelhandel statt meine Damen und
Herren das ist genau die Lösung die wir
brauchen
was bei der Diskussion ob 2G 2g+ oder
3g-regelung vergessen wird ist dass
diejenigen die in den Bereichen arbeiten
und gerade im Einzelhandel auch ein
Anrecht haben geschützt zu werden und
deshalb ist es richtig mit einer
zwei-regelung auch dafür zu sorgen dass
diejenigen die in die Geschäfte kommen
keine Ansteckungsgefahr ausgeht weil das
Personal geschützt werden muss ich finde
das ist genau der richtige Weg den wir
brauchen
sie haben einen Punkt angesprochen eine
der wenigen der richtig war der handle
hat Herausforderung und zwar ist das der
zunehmende Online-Handel das ist durch
die Pandemie sicherlich noch mal
verstärkt worden aber wir haben das
schon vor der Pandemie gesehen acht bis
zehn Prozent Zunahme Umsätze pro Jahr im
Online-Handel und das ist etwas was
natürlich Städte herausfordert und
deshalb gibt es von der Bundesregierung
auf den Weg gebracht Unterstützung durch
Bundesmittel für die Belebung der
Innenstädte und hier muss man sich genau
angucken wie kann man die
Aufenthaltsqualität in den Innenstädten
verbessern das ist sicherlich das was an
Einzelhandelsgeschäften ist aber auch an
Gastronomie an Kultur an verweilplätzen
vielleicht auch Wohnbereiche attraktiver
gestalten für die Innenstädte das sind
Konzepte die auch dazu beitragen dass
Menschen wieder in die Innenstädte gehen
dass sie dort einkaufen und für Umsatz
sorgen und lassen sie mich zum Schluss
noch mal sagen der Weg aus der Pandemie
ist impfen das hat überhaupt nichts
damit zu tun dass wir einen zwingen oder
irgendwelchen dass wir jemanden
verachten oder diskriminieren sondern es
ist vielen Menschen klar die vielleicht
jetzt noch auch zögern dieses Angebot
wahrzunehmen zu unterstützen
Hilfestellung zu geben zu argumentieren
nehmen Sie das impfangebot an sorgen Sie
dafür dass wir den Weg aus der Pandemie
gemeinsam gestalten und so werden wir
das im gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
auch schaffen und weil das die letzte
Debatte vor Weihnachten ist wünsche ich
Ihnen allen ein frohes Fest herzliches
glück auf
[Applaus]
zu seiner ersten Rede erteile ich das
Wort dem Kollegen Thema in Kuban für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
afd-fraktion ihr Abgeordneter Johannes
Huber hat vor einigen Tagen im
telegram-chat ziemlich genau beschrieben
wie man sich ein genesenen Zertifikat
erschleicht seine Empfehlung man solle
sich die Spucke eines infizierten
einfach vor dem Test in die Nase sprühen
lassen zwei Wochen zu Hause warten und
schon bekäme man ein Zertifikat
und Sie haben ja in den vergangenen
Monaten der Pandemie auch schon öfter
besonders unsinnige Vorschläge gehabt
denn wenn es nach ihnen geht dann wäre
in diesem Land niemand geimpft dann
würde keiner Maske tragen und dann würde
auch niemand getestet werden und wenn
wir Ihren Vorschlägen gefolgt werden
dann hätten wir schon spätestens seit
Oktober wieder voll Lockdown Tausende
von Toten zu beschlagen und das weiß
auch jeder Gastronom in diesem Land
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde
und
sie wollen heute ernsthaft mit uns über
wirtschaftspolitische Folgen der
Pandemie sprechen am Ende haben sie
allerdings nur hohen- und Spott für jede
Wirtin im Schwarzwald für jeden Hotelier
in Görlitz oder die Händler im
Hannoveraner Umland und erst recht für
jeden Intensivpfleger oder jede Ärztin
in diesem Land übrig anders kann man es
nicht verstehen diese Rede die Herr
Ziegler hier vorhin gehalten hat
und sie zeigen mit dieser aktuellen
Stunde und dem Vorgehen ihres
Abgeordneten auch dass es ihnen darum
geht
Fundamentalopposition zu betreiben und
das unterscheidet uns grundsätzlich
voneinander denn wir als Union sehen uns
nicht als Opposition zum Start und
unserem Gemeinwesen wir sehen uns als
Opposition in diesem Parlament wir haben
das Wohl der Menschen im Blick und wir
tragen Verantwortung für dieses Land und
wir wünschen uns dass sie es auch mal
täten und ich sage es Ihnen
ich sage es Ihnen noch einmal in
einfacheren Worten ihre Politik ist wie
wenn man ein Erfolg befahrenen Straße
stehen würde und Kindern zurufft einfach
los es wird schon nichts passieren Tote
und Verletzte mit Ansage
ja viele einzelhändler und Gastronomen
haben erhebliche Umsatzeinbußen und
leiden unter der aktuellen
Verunsicherung auch durch die
2g-regelung
sie sind diejenigen die für
Lebensqualität stehen die unser
Miteinander einen Raum geben und die vor
der Pandemie Jobmotor gewesen sind und
deswegen kann ich die Bundesregierung
nur ermutigen auch an die Arbeit zu
gehen und nicht dem Stile von Karl
Lauterbach zu folgen alles bei den
Vorgängern abzuladen und sich erst
einmal die letzten Monate wegzuducken
sie sind gewählt um Lösungen zu
erarbeiten und ich bitte Sie an die
Arbeit zu gehen
und deshalb
möchte ich auch noch zwei sehr konkrete
Vorschläge für unsere Gastronomen und
unsere Einzelhändler machen die wir
jetzt brauchen ohne die bisherigen
Hilfen hätten von den über 200.000
Gastronomen in diesem Land ist
wahrscheinlich fast 70.000 nicht
überlebt und deswegen ist es gut und
richtig dass wir auch noch mal die
Überbrückungshilfe vier verlängert haben
und auch eben die Abschlagszahlung
wieder möglich gemacht haben aber wenn
Sie jetzt den Betroffenen wirklich
helfen wollen dann sorgen Sie dafür dass
die 30 Milliarden Euro die im Haushalt
noch zur Verfügung stehen auch wirklich
abgerufen werden sorgen Sie dafür dass
der Bundes dass die Bundesregelung
Schadensausgleich auch für die
2g-einschränkungen gilt und auf keinemus
ausgeweitet wird sorgen Sie dafür dass
die personalkostenpauschale in eine
spitzabrechnung umgewandelt wird und
sorgen Sie dafür dass die
Unternehmerlohn Regelung nicht nur in
Sachsen sondern bundesweit eingeführt
wird damit helfen sie den
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmern und
den Unternehmen in schweren Zeiten
und zweitens und zweitens Herr Minister
Habeck ist ja leider nicht da aber Herr
Staatssekretär Krischer kann es ja
vielleicht weitergeben laden Sie bitte
zu einer
wirtschaftsministerkonferenz ein und
sorgen Sie dafür dass die
Bundesregierung mit den Ländern
Ministern ins Gespräch kommt weil es
kann doch nicht sein dass in Düsseldorf
Menschen mit einem impf- und genesenen
Zertifikat dieses einmal vorlegen müssen
anschließend ein Bändchen bekommen und
nicht weiter kontrolliert werden und in
anderen Teilen des Landes ist es anders
es kann doch nicht sein dass in
Baden-Württemberg richtigerweise lange
Zeit nur Stichproben durchgeführt wurden
im Handel und jetzt anders gearbeitet
wird es kann doch nicht sein dass in
einigen Ländern Booster geimpfte überall
reinkommen und den anderen Ländern nicht
gerade mit Blick auf Weihnachten braucht
es klare Regeln eindeutige Haltung und
keinen immer größeren Flickenteppich und
die Unsicherheit der Bevölkerung zu
entgegenzuwirken
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dies sind
keine Weihnachtswünsche auch wenn ich
ihn natürlich auch ein frohes
Weihnachtsfest wünsche wir müssen uns
jetzt entscheiden wollen wir auch in
Zukunft attraktive Innenstädte in denen
man sich austauschen kann in denen man
genießen kann und einkaufen kann wollen
wir auch in Zukunft die Gastronomie als
Wohnzimmer der Gesellschaft erhalten
dann tragen wir alle eine Verantwortung
dafür im übrigen auch sie liebe Kollegen
von der afd-fraktion vielen Dank
[Applaus]
dieter janitschek hat das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Kollege Quan erstmal herzlichen
Glückwunsch zu ersten Rede
aber ich will Ihnen schon sagen wir
haben uns jetzt hier in den letzten
Wochen nicht zurückgehalten sondern auch
als wir noch nicht an der Regierung
waren über das Thema Überbrückungshilfe
vier gesprochen und wir danken auch für
die Zusammenarbeit mit dem damaligen
geschäftsführenden Minister Peter
Altmaier und auch Robert Habeck wird das
jetzt in die Hand nehmen dass wir da
zielgerichte gute Hilfen schaffen für
die Wirtschaft das ist uns ein großes
Anliegen
mir wird es traurig ums Herz muss ich
Ihnen sagen von der AFD wenn ich sie
reden höre
in München wird jetzt am Wochenende in
der Clubszene eine große Aktion beginnen
wo alle Clubs unter dem Motto wenn schon
nicht tanzen dann doch wenigstens impfen
in die Vorlage geben von 10 Uhr bis 22
Uhr mit umfassenden Angebot und dafür
sorgen dass wir endlich in Deutschland
eine höhere Impfquote kriegen
und ich würde Sie bitten dass sie dort
wo sie Verantwortung haben in den
Kreisen in den Kommunen Gott sei Dank
nicht in Landesregierung dass sie dort
endlich anfangen auch die Menschen zu
motivieren impfen zu gehen warum haben
wir in Sachsen einen wochenlangen
Lockdown weil Menschen wie sie den
Menschen vor Ort einreden dass sie sich
nicht impfen lassen sollen sie sind
verantwortlich für die Schließung der
Gastronomie aber was viel schlimmer ist
sie sind mitverantwortlich dafür dass
die Krankenhäuser volllaufen das macht
mich wirklich wütend das muss ich Ihnen
sagen dass sie sich dann hier hinstellen
und versuchen in Empathie für die
Gastroszene zu sprechen das kann doch
nicht wahr sein
wenn wir wie in Kanada in Portugal in
Spanien oder auch in Bremen heute schon
so weit wären hätten wir die Probleme
nicht dann hätten wir eine viel
lebendigere Kulturszene eine viel
lebendige Gastroszene und auch der
Einzelhandel hätte dieses Leid nicht was
er hat und er hat ein Leiden momentan zu
ertragen weil die Menschen verunsichert
sind weil die Zahlen so hoch sind und
das ist wirklich etwas was uns alle sehr
sehr bedrückender helfen auch
Wirtschaftshilfen natürlich auf Dauer
nicht ich verstehe alle die sagen wir
brauchen eine Perspektive
und ich will auch mal kritisch sagen in
den letzten Jahren sind sie jetzt schon
so sind nicht alle Maßnahmen die er
getroffen worden sind sehr plausibel ich
komme aus Bayern
wir haben jetzt ja da merkt man schon
dann eine Reaktion dass das Menschen
versteht
wir haben zum Beispiel jetzt im Bereich
der Gastronomie 2G das sei den
Gastwirten gegönnt und dadurch
funktioniert die Gastronomie soweit sie
funktionieren kann wir haben im Bereich
der Kultur 25 Prozent
Kapazität und 2g+ wenn ich ins Theater
gehen mit Maske und mich teste und 2G
habe dann kann das Theater eigentlich so
auf Dauer nicht funktionieren wenn ich
ins Theater Kneipe gehe gegen einen über
habe ich 100 Prozent Auslastung das
verstehen viele auch im Kulturbereich
nicht und da kann ich wirklich auch
nachvollziehen dass wir da auch noch mal
nachbessern müssen wo Regeln einfach
nicht mehr verständlich sind
ich will aber auch sagen
dass wir
wirklich
jetzt dafür sorgen müssen dass die
Unsicherheiten die bei den Schaustellern
zum Beispiel jetzt über die
Weihnachtsmärkte dass wir da auch noch
mal rangehen und diskutieren da sind
jetzt auch noch mal Maßnahmen getroffen
worden für Schausteller über 50
mitarbeiter:innen das Team dort einfach
die Hilfen auch bekommen und wir werden
wahrscheinlich auch nicht umhin kommen
immer wieder auch zu gucken welche
Betriebe die Veranstaltungsbranche
beispielsweise die Veranstaltungsbranche
hat in diesem Winter erneut kein
relevantes Geschäft das ist eine große
Branche mit hunderttausenden von
MitarbeiterInnen wir können also auf
Dauer nur eines bieten wenn Sie mich das
zu direkt fragen wir müssen endlich es
schaffen wo osterkampagne Impfkampagne
hoch Sicherheit schaffen durch höchsten
Gesundheitsschutz und das ist der Weg
und dann müssen wir jetzt alle kraftvoll
zusammenarbeiten dass wir das auch
wirklich hinkriegen und die Regeln
nachvollziehbar machen
es wird wieder ein harter Winter und wir
müssen auch jede Regel immer auch
hinterfragen und gucken wenn Zahlen nach
unten gehen dann müssen die auch nicht
immer so bleiben das will ich auch in
Zusagen die Länder haben ja auch
Vollmachten trotzdem ist es gut dass wir
eine Einheitlichkeit jetzt geschaffen
haben das war ja oft auch nicht
darstellbar es wurden ja nicht alle
Menschen in einem Bundesland und gehen
nicht über die Landesgrenze dass sie
dann nicht mehr wussten wo sie heute
dran sind wenn sie von Baden-Württemberg
nach Bayern zum Beispiel gehen also da
sind auch einfach Einheitlichkeit ein
gutes Vorbild in dem Bereichen wo es
sinnvoll ist aber vor allem das
abzuschließen wir verstehen das Leid wir
verstehen dass wir einfach auch Wut
unterwegs ist ich kann das verstehen
weil ich auch mit vielen spreche wie sie
hoffentlich auch übrigens auch manchmal
Vorschläge gemacht habt zum Beispiel die
Außenwirtschaft nach dem ersten Lockdown
in München dann die Gastronomie auf die
Straße zu holen wo das möglich war sehr
schnell Kollege Roloff aus München weiß
das auch also lassen Sie uns auch
kreativ sein dass wir gute Lösungen
finden wo es notwendig ist aber lassen
Sie uns jetzt vor allem eine hohe
Impfquote über den Winter besorgen damit
wir diese Situation nicht noch einmal
ertragen müssen danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
Pascal Meise hat das Wort für die
Fraktion DIE LINKE
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren dass ich ausgerechnet
die AFD hier hinstellt und
Krokodilstränen über die Folgen der
Pandemie vergießt dass ich schon preisst
sie von der AFD sind es doch die seit
Monaten nichts anderes tun als selbst
das mildeste Mittel zu Bekämpfung der
Pandemie zu kritisieren und auch zu
topidieren sei es die maskenpflicht sei
es das Testen die man an einigen Nasen
da oben sehen kann sei es dass
freiwillige impfen und dann wundern sie
sich wenn die Pandemie mit aller Macht
jetzt wieder auf unser Land zuschlägt
auch die Gastronomie und den
Einzelhandel trifft das ist doch absurd
meine Damen und Herren
und dass sie von der AFD in ihrer Rede
nicht ein Wort zum Gesundheitsschutz der
Beschäftigten im Einzelhandel und der
Gastronomie verlieren das finde ich
schon bezeichnen das finde ich
bezeichnen und das zeigt nur einmal
wieder sehr deutlich dass sie alles sind
aber nicht die Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der kleinen Leute der
Verkäuferin und der Leute die in der
Gastronomie arbeiten meine Damen und
Herren das war heute wieder sehr
entlarvend
jetzt aber zur Bundesregierung wenn sie
aufgrund der Versäumnisse der
Vorgängerregierung der gerüchteweise
auch der ein oder andere der neuen
Regierung schon angehört haben soll
insbesondere bei der Impfkampagne jetzt
wieder zu strikteren Maßnahmen greifen
müssen dann sind sie selbstverständlich
auch in der Pflicht dort überall wo es
nötig ist die Menschen und die
Unternehmen mit den Folgen der Maßnahmen
nicht alleine zu lassen deswegen
begrüßen wir als Fraktion DIE LINKE auch
ausdrücklich dass die sogenannten
Überbrückungshilfen jetzt zumindest bis
Ende März verlängert werden aber wenn
sie es ernst damit meinen dann dürfen
Sie jetzt auch nicht einfach die Fehler
der alten Regierung fortschreiben bei
der viel zu viele durchs Raster der
Hilfsprogramme gefallen sind und ich
hätte da auch einige Hinweise und helfe
Ihnen gerne auf die Sprünge erstens
warum halten sie weiter krampfhaft daran
fest dass ein Unternehmen ein
Umsatzausfall von mindestens 30 Prozent
haben muss um überhaupt Unterstützung zu
halten wir wissen doch gerade im
Einzelhandel wo der Umsatzeinbußen von
20 bis 25 Prozent haben das und genau
deswegen durchs Raster fallen ich finde
da müssen Sie dringend nacharbeiten
zweitens für Unternehmen die vollständig
schließen müssen reicht eine Erstattung
von 90 Prozent der Fixkosten auf Dauer
nicht aus wer hundert Prozent
Umsatzausfall hat muss er 100% der
Fixkosten erstattet bekommen das haben
es hätten noch die Kolleginnen Kollegen
von den Grünen mit Klatschen können das
haben sie nämlich wortwörtlich in dem
Antrag Anfang des Jahres so geschrieben
und ich glaube es war niemand geringeres
als die geschätzte Kollegen Tröge die
als Fraktionsvorsitzende ist hier auch
vorgetragen hat das war damals richtig
es ist immer noch richtig und ich frage
mich schon warum handeln Sie jetzt mit
der neuen Regierung nicht entsprechend
drittens
sorgen sie endlich dafür dass die
Überbrückungshilfen am Ende auch immer
und zwingend dem Schutz der
Beschäftigten in entsprechenden
Unternehmen zugute kommen koppeln sie
die Hilfen endlich an ein Verbot
betriebsbedingter Kündigung
viertens noch immer haben kleine
Selbstständige die mindestens einen
Mitarbeiter eine Mitarbeiterin haben
nicht die Möglichkeit bei den
Überbrückungshilfen nach Mittel für die
eigene Existenzsicherung zu beantragen
und während stattdessen direkt auf Hartz
IV verwiesen ich finde das auch
weiterhin respektlos
und noch Anfang des Jahres haben wir
auch Sie von der FDP in einem Antrag die
Forderung der Erstattung eines solchen
sogenannten Unternehmer Lohns
unterstützt jetzt hätten sie die Chance
auch entsprechend ihren Worten Taten
folgen zu lassen was passiert nichts das
ist und bleibt beschämen meine Damen und
Herren
und fünftens
sorgen sie endlich für einen Corona
Kurzarbeitergeld von dem auch Menschen
mit einem geringen Einkommen anständig
leben können sich streichen Sie die
Einschränkungen die es gibt dass nur
diejenigen nach drei beziehungsweise
sechs Monaten in den Genuss des
angehobenen Kurzarbeitergeldes kommen
die nicht mehr als 50 Prozent ihrer
Arbeitszeit in Kurzarbeit sind erhöhen
Sie das Kurzarbeitergeld endlich ab dem
ersten Monat auf 90% des normalen nettos
und führen sie ein armutsfestes mindest
Kurzarbeitergeld ein gerade die
Beschäftigten in der Gastronomie gerade
die Beschäftigten im Einzelhandel haben
häufig Niedriglöhne sie sind auf einer
erhöhtes Kurzarbeitergeld dringend
angewiesen meine Damen und Herren
übrigens auch das haben sie von den
Grünen im Antrag noch vor der Wahl so
beantragt warum handeln Sie jetzt nicht
entsprechend
meine Damen und Herren von der
Ampelkoalition ich sage Ihnen wenn Sie
es wirklich ernst meinen mit einem
Neustart dann müssen sie an den
genannten Stellen handeln dann dürfen
Sie in dieser Krise tatsächlich
niemanden mehr im Regen stehen lassen
wie als Fraktion DIE LINKE werden nicht
ruhen und sie auch weiterhin überall wo
es nötig ist daran erinnern dass sie ihr
Handeln müssen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
wie Sie sehen geht auch eher davon aus
der Kollege manfred totenhausen hat das
Wort für die Fraktion der FDP
ja vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen meine Damen
und Herren in den letzten zwei Jahren
gibt es sicher einige Unternehmen die
besonders unter Corona und den deren
Maßnahmen gelitten haben es gab und gibt
nach wie vor Umsatzeinbußen und das ganz
besonders beim Einzelhandel der
Gastronomie und auch bei den
Schaustellern die jetzt gerade die
Weihnachtsmärkte machen denn deren
Hauptgeschäft läuft gerade jetzt in der
Weihnachtszeit in der Adventszeit und
als Koalition wissen wir das und deshalb
machen sich macht sich niemand weder im
Bund noch in den Rändern
das leicht wie jetzt gehandelt wird die
Freien Demokraten begrüßen aber die
neuen
corona-maßnahmen zu einemdämmung der
Infektionen auch wenn dies auf dem
ersten Blick für einige rechtsstrengen
wirkt unser Ziel ist es und war es immer
einen flächendeckenden Lockdown zu
verhindern daran haben wir die ganze
Zeit gearbeitet mit den neuen Regeln die
die Koalition in das
Infektionsschutzgesetz geschrieben hat
ist das nun möglich sie von der AFD
verharmlosen die Lage
und jetzt
wo die Zahlen von problematischen Fällen
in den Kliniken wieder zunehmen um wir
entsprechend vorsorgen wettern sie gar
gegen die 2G Regeln meine Damen und
Herren für uns als Koalition gilt
weiterhin wir sind jetzt im Winter
wieder in einer entscheidenden Phase wo
es gilt die Inzidenzen und die Belegung
von
krankenhausintensivbetten im Auge zu
behalten zu reduzieren und wenn nötig
können die Bundesländer weitere
Maßnahmen ergreifen um das
Infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen dazu
zählen besagte Vorsichtsmaßnahmen die
für Handel und Gastronomie derzeit
gelten und wissen Sie was
die Menschen draußen nehmen die Regel in
der Mehrheit sogar an mit jedenfalls die
mit denen ich gesprochen haben so wie es
auch wie sie sich auch impfen lassen
viele Kundinnen und Gäste in Gastronomie
fühlen sich einfach viel sicherer wenn
diese Regeln sind und gehen auch wie
viel lieber dorthin habe ich gerade
frisch erlebt natürlich gibt es unseits
einen boosten im Vergleich zu 20 19 auch
die letzte Regierung hat aber auch
Verantwortung übernommen und Maßnahmen
durchgeführt und was der Unterschied was
ist der Unterschied zum letzten Jahr
Geschäfte und Gastronomie sind offen das
waren sie letztes Jahr nicht nicht
jedenfalls so wie jetzt und es gibt
keinen Lockdown auch das war gab es
letztes Jahr nicht es finden in vielen
Bundesländern sogar weiterhin
Weihnachtsmärkte statt wir beide meine
Kolleginnen aus Wuppertal wir kennen das
wir gehen auch wahrscheinlich jetzt
wieder dorthin die Bundesregierung hat
mit ihrer
Überbrückungshilfe 3+ sogar dafür
gesorgt dass Händler wie Gastronomen
bereits ab 30 Prozent Umsatzverlust
einen Antrag stellen können und das ist
richtig außerdem wird es die
Sonderregelung zur Abschreibung von
Warenbeständen für Hersteller
Großhändler Einzelhändler professionelle
Verwender
wird wird fortgeführt wir verlängern die
Überbrückungshilfe 3 bis ins nächste
Jahr haben ist gerade schon mehrfach
angesprochen worden so dass sie
Überbrückungshilfe vier nahtlos
anschließen kann übrigens meine Damen
und Herren die Neuinfektionen und die
sieben Tage Inzidenz nehmen Gott sei
Dank schon ab daran sieht man
kontaktreduzierungen wirken und je eher
die Zahlen nach unten gehen desto eher
können wir die Regelungen wieder locken
lockern darauf arbeiten wir alle hin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen machen
wir uns noch nichts vor es gibt doch
noch einen weiteren Grund der zum
Umsatzrückgang führt haben wir heute
morgen alle wer Fernsehen geguckt hat
morgens früh um 6 Uhr der hat es gehört
das sind die Lieferprobleme bei
bestimmten Produktgruppen das führt
natürlich auch zu Umsatzrückgang
außerdem gehen die Bürger doch nicht
wegen der Regeln weniger in den Läden
und in den Restaurants nein sondern sie
gehen sie meiden die Innenstädte weil
sie Sorge vor Ansteckungen haben und
diese sorgen müssen wollen wir ihnen
nehmen und zwar sich impfen impfen
impfen wir haben das schon tausendmal
gehört fast können wir es nicht mehr
hören aber ihren Aufruf zum Impfen habe
ich bis jetzt noch nicht gehört
was hat das werden sie auch nicht das
hat er gerade gesagt schön dass es den
Protokoll steht mit abgestuften Regeln
wie 2G ist alles ist für alle möglichst
die Läden offen zu halten und darauf
kommt es doch an wir müssen offen halten
um den Händlern eine Chance zu geben auf
welchen Weg auch immer für alle bleiben
außerdem Supermärkte Drogerie in andere
Versorger ohne Einschränkungen offen da
kann auch jeder hingehen auch ungeimpfte
auf sie dürfen dahin gleichzeitig können
Restaurants und Geschäfte auch nach
Hause liefern ist ja auch eine
Möglichkeit wie wir die Unternehmen und
auch die regionalen Unternehmen schützen
mehr noch da wo die Bundesländer
kreative lösen zusammen mit dem Handel
finden sind die Kunden sogar weiterhin
viel die
bändchenlösung wir haben heute gott sei
dank noch nicht gehört sonst fast alles
gesagt die neben Hamburg und den FDP
regierten Ländern NRW Rheinland-Pfalz
und Schleswig-Holsteins als erstes
umgesetzt worden ist schon jetzt ein
großer Erfolg andere Bundesländer ziehen
noch diese Woche nach damit man nicht
bei jedem Laden eine neue zeigen muss
hoffen wir auch dass auch Bayern den
Pfad der Einsicht kommt und diese Lösung
annimmt ich würde das jedenfalls
begrüßen wenn das der Fall wäre und
jetzt komme ich zu meinem
muss ich gucken wo ich kürze ihre Kritik
und ihre Vorschläge gehen tatsächlich
auf Kosten der Gesundheit aller und das
macht die Mehrheit in diesem Haus nicht
mit und das ist gut so meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wir schaffen
diese Lösung nur gemeinsam und ich mache
mich jetzt vom will ich gerade meine
Zeit falsch eingesetzt
vielen Dank
so das Pult ist bereitet für die erste
Rede und die Kollegin Lena Werner von
der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich halte euch
heute hier meine erste Rede im Deutschen
Bundestag und passender könnte das Thema
gar nicht sein ich selbst habe jahrelang
in der Gastronomie gearbeitet und ein
Hotelfachausbildung und wissen Sie warum
ich gerne in der Gastronomie gearbeitet
habe wissen Sie warum dort viele
Menschen wirklich gerne arbeiten auch
wenn die Arbeitsbedingungen nicht immer
einfach sind
in der Gastronomie steht der
Servicegedanke im Vordergrund der
Kontakt zu den Menschen der Austausch
mit anderen Menschen und das Gefühl
jemandem anderen etwas Gutes zu tun
und genau darauf mussten wir in den
letzten zwei Jahren viele verzichten die
Gäste aber auch die gastronom:innen und
Hoteliers die Branche lebt vom
zwischenmenschlichen Kontakt und der war
und ist sehr eingeschränkt
die Menschen haben großen Aufwand
betrieben trotz allem ihre Angebote
aufrecht zu erhalten und weiterhin Gäste
empfangen zu können
in den vergangenen Wochen hat die
Ampelkoalition deutlich gemacht dass
diese Bemühungen unterstützt und ein
weiterer Lockdown verhindert werden will
dass die afd-fraktion hier jetzt zu tut
als sei die zwei Regel zwei geh-regel
verantwortlich für geringere Umsätze ist
eine Frechheit in
den vergangenen Wochen habe ich viele
Gespräche geführt mit meinen ehemaligen
Kolleginnen und weiteren Vertreter in
der Gastronomie und des Einzelhandels
und alle sind sich einig sie leiden
nicht an der 2g-regel sie leiden an der
pandemischen Lage sie leiden darunter
dass kein Kontakt mit den Gästen
stattfinden kann und sie wissen die
zweijährige hilft ein Lockdown zu
verhindern
und sie wollen genauso wie wir alle dass
diese Pandemie schnellstmöglich vorbei
ist
damit wir wieder ganz ohne Sorge ins
Restaurant essen gehen können damit wir
wieder feiern gehen können damit wir
wieder in unsere Lieblingsbar gehen
können ohne Angst zu haben uns und
andere zu infizieren
was mir meine ehemaligen Kollegin auch
gesagt haben auch schon vor der
zweijährigen haben fast ausschließlich
geimpfte und genesene Personen die
Restaurants und Bars besucht es gab kaum
jemanden der nur getestet zu Besuch kam
die Pandemie ist verantwortlich für die
Umsatzeinbußen und nicht eine
zweijährigen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Zahlen zeigen eindeutig wir sind mitten
in der nächsten Welle und deshalb
bleiben die Menschen zu Hause sie sind
vorsichtig und wollen sich und andere
schützen und das ist auch richtig so
Veranstaltungen wie Weihnachtsfeiern
werden abgesagt weil die Menschen ihre
Kontakte beschränken wollen dadurch
entstehen die Umsatzeinbußen
es ist uns ein bewusst dass die
Situation weiterhin sehr schwierig ist
Unterstützung ist und bleibt dringend
notwendig die umfangreichen und
unterschiedlichen Programme haben
Unternehmen gastronom:innen und den
Einzelhandel unterstützt und tun das
noch weiterhin fast 60 Milliarden Euro
wurden bis Anfang Dezember ausgezahlt
da müssen wir beides angehen das Ende
der Pandemie und die wirtschaftlichen
Einbußen für letzteres gibt es die
umfangreichen Hilfen für ersteres
brauchen wir Instrumente wie die
zweijährige denn was wäre die
Alternative wir würden früher oder
später wieder in einer neuen
lockdown-littern das wiederum würde zu
größeren Umsatzeinbußen führen
eine Aufhebung der 2g-regel ist also
nicht im Interesse der Branche wenn wir
ernsthaft diese Pandemie besiegen wollen
denn das muss doch weiterhin das oberste
Ziel bleiben das Ende der Pandemie um
das zu schaffen braucht es weiterhin die
Solidarität aller daher meine Bitte an
sie lassen sie sich impfen lassen sie
sich Boostern und lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam diese Pandemie besiegen
und das alles damit wir nächstes Jahr
wieder alle unsere Weihnachtsfeiern
feiern können damit wir wieder ohne
Sorge in unsere Lieblingsbar gehen
können damit wir wieder unbeschwert mit
unseren Freundinnen essen gehen können
und dann steigen auch die Umsätze wieder
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die cdu/csu-fraktion hat der
Kollegen Klaus-peter
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen
Herr Krischer ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass der Minister heute da wäre aber es
gibt sicher wichtige Gründe aber Sie
können ihm das ja ausrichten was ich dem
Haus mitgeben möchte gerade für
ungelernte in sachenwirtschaft wer ist
ganz gut gewesen wenn Sie heute da
gewesen wären aber das trifft auf sie ja
auch zu und insofern ist diese
dieser Hinweis nach wie vor
gerechtfertigt die die
wir konnten jetzt Lesen dieser Tage was
die neue wirtschaftspolitische Agenda
anbelangt da ist man ja auf die dürren
Worte des
Koalitionsvertrages
beschränkt oder eingeschränkt ich habe
da mal noch mal ein bisschen gesucht
konnte es gar nicht glauben Gastronomie
finden sich überhaupt nicht in den 1077
auf den 177 Seiten
es findet sich was zu Tourismus also
Hotellerie gibt es auch nicht zu
Tourismus steht was das der klimaneutral
sein muss und
mehr digital das ist ja auch alles
wichtig und gut damals ja auch schon
drum gekümmert aber ich habe nicht den
Eindruck dass in dieser neuen
ampelregierung dieser große Bereich von
Tourismus von Gastronomie von Hotellerie
überhaupt eine Rolle spielen würde und
ich frag mich er wo die FDP da war bei
den Verhandlungen ist das zu spät der
Stunde gewesen wo er geschlafen hab
sonst habt ihr da immer getan als ob ihr
die einzigen Sachwalter hier wird
die
also ich glaube es ist Zeit wenn sie das
dem Minister bitte Ausrichten von den
Höhen des Veritas des veritonistischen
Olymps und der weltenrettung
herabzusteigen und sich der
Lebenswirklichkeit in Deutschland zu
widmen und die ist eben Pandemie und die
Auswirkung dieser Pandemie auf die
wirtschaftliche Lage in unserem Land und
insofern ich fühle mich nicht weiter mit
diesen abwegigen Herleitungen von Herrn
Ziegler aufhalten aber dass die
Temperatur heute geführt wird finde ich
gut denn es ist genau in diese es ist
genau diese Zeit in der das gerade
stattfindet über was wir jetzt hier
reden die Gastronomen haben jetzt ihre
Ausfälle die fach-einzelhändler haben
jetzt ihrer ihrer Ausfälle und wenn sie
sich Gedanken machen das freut mich ja
dass sie auch weiterhin Innenstadt Kerne
stärken wollen und Struktur Strukturen
für den Handel erhalten aber wenn das
noch ein bisschen so geht dann macht er
überhaupt nichts mehr auf dann sind da
nur noch Nagelstudios und und und
Handyshops und sonst nichts mehr und
wenn wir den Fach Einzelhandel erhalten
wollen ist das auch eine Voraussetzung
dafür dass ihre elektrolasträder
überhaupt nach weil wenn keiner mehr was
auszufahren hat dann wird da auch nicht
mehr ein Fahrrad beantragen bei ihnen
elektrisch ist und dann ist es
interessant für ihn zu wissen dass ab
2023 die e-autoförderung sich ändern
wird also ein bisschen priorisieren und
der Wirklichkeit
die im Lande gerade beobachtbar ist sich
auch zu stellen täte gut und ich will
appellieren an die an die Parlamentarier
ich habe das eben genossen dass der Band
Westphal gesprochen hat wir haben ja
wirklich eine intensive Zusammenarbeit
in dieser Zeit auch als Parlament mit
der Administration gehabt wir hatten
wöchentlich sitzen spätestens
sitzungswöchentlich ein Austausch mit
dem Ministerium auf ministereben oder
staatssekretärsebene wo wir immer wieder
Gelegenheit auch hatten und genommen
haben unsere Berichte aus den
Wahlkreisen hineinzutragen in die
Administration damit nicht an der
Faktenlage vorbei geholfen wird sondern
da geholfen wird wo es Not tut und das
brauchen wir dringend auch in Zukunft
das sind sie dass die Parlamentarier die
Sachwalter gegenüber der Regierung das
weiterhin hier ein offenes Ohr bleibt
und wir hier einen Zugang finden
ich will daran erinnern dass es nicht
immer einfach war das BMF stand oft auf
der Bremse wir wollten sehr viel früher
steuerlich durch großzügige verlustrück
vortragsmöglichkeiten helfen aber da war
der Chef des BMF oder wer auch immer bei
ihm jedenfalls in seiner Verantwortung
Olaf Scholz am Anfang strikte dagegen
deshalb mussten wir komplizierte
komplizierte
sonderfördermöglichkeiten schaffen erst
durch diesen Grund und dass wir das
alles dass das alles dieses Mal besser
geht das wünschen wir uns sehr bisher
ist leider nicht zu sehen ist das Thema
wirklich oben auf der Agenda wäre ich
habe sehr viel mit Gastronomen mit
Hoteliers mit
Facheinzelhändler gesprochen in diesen
letzten Tagen und Wochen und
da gibt es einige Zahlen sind genannt
vor 30 40 Prozent Rückgang ich habe
heute morgen damit mein Schwiegervater
telefoniert die schwiegerleute haben
Gastronomie in der Oberlausitz die haben
zwei Drittel Prozent zwei Drittel
Prozent Umsatz und ich finde um das um
da auch noch mal ein Stück Gemeinsamkeit
zu zeigen eigentlich auch dass zwei g
eine Erleichterung ist für ein
funktionieren zumindest für die die so
verhalten wie ich mir es Wünsche die
sich impfen lassen
aber wir dürfen trotzdem nicht die Augen
davor zu machen wenn wir riskieren dass
in großer Bereich mit vielen
Beschäftigten und viel Lebensqualität
für uns alle Fach Einzelhandel
innerstädtisches Leben und Gastronomie
einfach den Bach runtergehen und deshalb
bleibt das eine wichtige Aufgabe und
nehmen Sie meine frohen Grüße für
Weihnachten das klingt die Präsidentin
aber das darf ich bestimmt noch sagen
bitte noch mit wir haben eine besondere
Zeit für uns bleiben Sie offen für die
frohe Botschaft der Heiligen Nacht und
möge der Heiland unser Land und seine
Menschen schützen
vielen Dank auch dafür
die nächste Rednerin die hier im Hause
ihre erste Rede absolviert ist die
Kollegin Katharina Beck wir Bündnis 90
Sekunden
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im
Bundestag liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und lieber Herr Wilsch ich bin aus
Hamburg dem Tor zur Welt und natürlich
spielt der Tourismus bei uns in dieser
Ampelkoalition eine riesenrolle darauf
können Sie sich verlassen
liebe Kolleginnen von der AFD ich finde
das einfach unredlich was sie tun sie
nutzen die tatsächliche Notlage von
Millionen von Menschen in gastrokultur
Einzelhandel um hier politisches Kapital
zu schlagen um ihren verqueren
totalitätsanspruch individueller
Freiheit voranzutreiben wo ein ich will
aber meine Maske nicht tragen wichtiger
ist als der Schutz Menschenleben anderer
wissen Sie ich wünsche mir ja auch
wieder ein Leben ohne Corona ja gerne
auch eines ohne Maske ein Leben mit
unbeschwertem Restaurantbesuch mit einem
Bummel in der Innenstadt aber wir haben
nun mal Corona und mit omikon ist die
nächste Steigerung schlimmer Weise schon
in Sicht ihr Eintreten für das nicht
impfen und dass ich will aber keine
Maske führt doch erst dazu dass wir in
der vierten und bald in der fünften
Welle stecken und eben zu Maßnahmen
gezwungen sind die und darauf können
sich verlassen hier wirklich niemand
auch nur das kleinste bisschen Lust hat
auch zu haben aber das zugrunde liegende
Problem heißt nichts 2G und die anderen
Schutzmaßnahmen das zugrunde liegende
Problem ist der noch immer viel zu große
Anteil an nicht geimpften und dem Effekt
auf die Belegung der Intensivbetten
und Liebe AFD eine Idee habe ich ihnen
mitgebracht wenn ihnen die Menschen in
der Gastro und dem Einzelhandel wirklich
am Herzen legen schreiben sie doch ihren
Mitgliedern mal eine E-Mail und fordern
sie zum Impfen auf das wäre effektiv
und jetzt möchte ich endlich zu dem
kommen worum es eigentlich gehen sollte
um die Menschen die hinter den Zahlen
stecken hinter den Millionen von kleinen
Unternehmen solo-selbstständigen den
Ladenbesitzer in Joggerin in Gastro
Einzelhandel Kultur viele von ihnen
können einfach nicht mehr das Bild des
neuen Geschäftsklimaindex für
soloselbstständige und kleinen
Unternehmen des ifo-Instituts ist
dramatisch über 25 Prozent stehen vor
dem Aus ihrer Existenz fast doppelt so
viel als die Gesamtwirtschaft und gar
nicht zu sprechen von den psychischen
Belastungen einmal durch die finanzielle
Lage aber eben auch wenn man seine
beruflichen Leidenschaft und das prägt
gerade Kleinunternehmer in und Branchen
wie Gastro und Kultur enorm wenn man der
nicht mehr nachgehen kann
und somit finde ich es exorbitant gut
dass wir schon im Koalitionsvertrag
gemeinsam miteinander vereinbaren
konnten dass wir die rückzahlmodalitäten
der Entschuldigung jetzt ist meine Seite
leider falsch hier ich finde es gleich
exorbitant gut jetzt möchte ich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier erstmal
noch mal das Vertrauen dieser Menschen
in uns in die Politik adressieren ein
ganz akutes Problem sind nämlich die
Rückforderungen der ersten corona-hilfen
vom Frühjahr 2020
diese Soforthilfen als Liquiditätshilfen
waren nicht das richtige Mittel damals
zuständigkeitsgerangel nicht
funktionierende it sich dauernd endende
AGBs kamen hinzu seit ein paar Monaten
flattern Rückzahlungsforderungen dieser
ersten Corona Soforthilfen in die
Briefkästen vieler solo-selbständiger
und KleinunternehmerInnen zur Unzeit
gerade jetzt in der vierten Welle und
für uns hier in diesem Haus ist aber
noch wichtiger da geht es auch um unsere
Kommunikation und Glaubwürdigkeit lieber
Herr Scholz sie haben damals im März
2020 richtigerweise den Menschen Mut
gemacht haben die Bazooka angekündigt
aber es wurde damals eben auch leider
angekündigt von ihnen und Herrn Altmaier
dass es sich um Zuschüsse handeln würde
die nicht zurückgezahlt werden müssen
das steht so wörtlich
Anfang April 2020 hatten knapp 1,8
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland diese
Hilfen beantragt in der detaillierten
Umsetzung wurde es dann aber leider vor
Ort oft anders gehandhabt und diese
Rückforderungen mögen dadurch in vielen
Fällen juristisch korrekt sein
kommunikativ ist das aber schlimm denn
so kann leider Vertrauen kaputt gehen
doch ich finde es exorbitant gut dass
wir schon im Koalitionsvertrag gemeinsam
neue Wege miteinander gehen und sagen
wir werden die rückzahlmodalitäten der
Corona Soforthilfen prüfen das ist genau
die Politik des Lernenden Staates die
ich mir wünsche
viele Betroffene viele Betroffene nehmen
das auch wahr aber wir müssen nun auch
Taten folgen lassen und das dringenst
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
ist der Grund warum ich hier heute
unbedingt sprechen wollte ich möchte sie
alle für zwei konkrete Ideen bezüglich
der
corona-rückzahlungsforderungen gewinnen
lassen Sie uns ein
rückteilungsmoratorium beschließen in
Verbindung mit einer Taskforce die
diesmal ihren Namen auch verdient die
aus juristischer unternehmerischer und
politischer Perspektive die Regelungen
und Zuständigkeiten aufdröselt und
Lösungen erarbeitet und zweitens lassen
Sie uns dabei bitte auch kulanzregeln
bis zu einer gewissen Höhe ernsthaft in
Betracht ziehen Präsidentin ich sehe die
Lampe
wenn wir die Gesamtkosten für die
Rückzahlungsforderungen und Folgekosten
abwägen dann bekommen wir für eine
überschaubaren Betrag in einer Zeit
existenzieller Unsicherheit die Hoffnung
für ein gesellschaftliches wir das auch
die einzelnen stützt ich hoffe ich
konnte sie dafür gewinnen und freue mich
auf die weitere Zusammenarbeit vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank und meine Kulanz erstreckt
sich ausschließlich auf die erste Rede
in diesem Haus und deswegen trifft das
jetzt auch im positiven Sinn die
Kolleginnen Christine Lüdke die gleich
für die FDP-Fraktion ihre erste Regel
hier sprechen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
letztes Jahr um diese Zeit hieß es kein
Sport kein Shopping kein Schulunterricht
alles war komplett dicht heute sind
Schulen Läden Restaurants Sport und
Kultureinrichtungen offen aber eben mit
Einschränkungen wie der Bundeskanzler
Scholz gestern in seiner
Regierungserklärung eindrücklich
geschildert hat niemanden geht es
momentan richtig gut und keiner ist
wirklich in froher Weihnachtsstimmung
und freut sich auf unbeschwerte Tage mit
seinen Lieben
wir durchleben als Gesellschaft den
zweiten dunklen pandem pandemiewinter
mehr als 100.000 Menschen sind bereits
an oder mit Corona verstorben die
Intensivstationen und Krankenhäuser
laufen wieder voll Ärztinnen Pfleger und
Krankenhauspersonal arbeiten seit fast
zwei Jahren am Limit und ganz oft weit
darüber hinaus und wir fragen uns doch
alle wird es jemals wieder so wie früher
sein das wissen wir nicht denn mit dem
sich immer wieder ändernden Virus müssen
auch wir uns auf immer wieder neue
Umstände einstellen aber wir lernen doch
immer besser damit umzugehen
manche Maßnahmen die werden uns noch
eine Weile begleiten auch um die
Pandemie langfristig und endgültig zu
bewältigen und dazu zählen auch die
2g-regeln in den besonders von der
Pandemie betroffenen Regionen das ist
herausfordernd auch wirtschaftlich für
Einzelhandel Gastronomie und Hotellerie
aber sehr geehrte Damen und Herren von
der AFD machen Sie sich bitte ehrlich
diese aktuelle Stunde die dient ihnen
doch nur dazu um ihre schrumpfenden
Anhängerschaft von ungeimpften und
unverbesserlichen Querdenkern nach dem
Mund zu reden
ihr vorgeschobenes Interesse und ihr
vermeintlicher Einsatz für Einzelhandel
Gastronomie und Hotellerie der ist doch
eine Farce ich bin selbstunternehmerin
in der Gesundheitsbranche ich bin also
doppelt betroffen wenn Sie so wollen ich
kenne viele Einzelhändler Gastronomen
und Hoteliers persönlich und ich weiß
diese Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer
die sind verantwortungsbewusst die
wollen explizit ihre Hygienekonzepte
umsetzen und die organisieren auch
selbstständig Impfkampagnen für ihre
Belegschaften und was wollen Sie
aufmachen ohne Regulierungen mit der
Begründung des Branchen zu sehr leiden
würden und was glauben Sie denn wo das
am Ende hinführt wir haben es doch
gesehen wie es in manchen unser
Nachbarländern lief nachdem fast alle
Regeln fallen gelassen wurden nämlich
wie in Österreich direkt zurück in den
nächsten Lockdown
und was hat der Einzelhandel das
Restaurant das Café ums Eck oder das
Hotel dann gewonnen
nichts einfach aufmachen das ist
angesichts von Varianten wie Delta und
Omegon schlichtweg nicht möglich und das
wird nur wieder zurück zu
Ausgangssperren flächendeckenden
lockdowns Schulschließungen verschobenen
Operationen und zu besuchsverboten in
Pflegeheimen und Krankenhäusern gerade
jetzt über Weihnachten und Neujahr und
eins das kann ich Ihnen mit Sicherheit
sagen das ist keine Alternative für
Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
letztes Jahr da haben wir noch
diskutiert wie viele Familienmitglieder
überhaupt beim Weihnachtsessen zusammen
am Tisch sitzen können wir haben darauf
verzichtet Oma und Opa dazu zu holen und
sehnsüchtig darauf gewartet dass der in
Deutschland entwickelte Impfstoff uns
ein kleines Stück Normalität zurückgibt
und das hat er auch aber nur mit einer
hohen Impfquote nur dann können wir uns
echter Normalität wieder nähern bis
dahin müssen wir andere Maßnahmen
einhalten Abstand Masken Tests und auch
impfnachweise die werden uns noch eine
ganze Weile begleiten
und natürlich ist die Kontrolle von
2gnachweisen eine zusätzliche Belastung
natürlich ist sie verbunden mit Aufwand
und mit zusätzlichen Kosten und mit
Umsatzeinbußen das weiß ich als
mittelständische Unternehmerin nur zu
gut
aber wir wollen doch nicht leichtfertig
auf Spiel setzen was wir in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten erreicht haben wir
wollen die Infektionsketten da
unterbrechen wo sie entstehen und das
das schaffen wir mit den neu
beschlossenen Regeln von der neuen
Koalition und wir sehen doch es
funktioniert seit einer Woche sind die
Zahlen rückläufig dass meine Damen und
Herren das ist ein Erfolg dieser
Ampelkoalition
unser Ziel ist offen halten das geht nur
mit Einschränkungen aber damit gehen wir
doch ein ganzes Stück normaler durch
diesen Winter als noch durch den letzten
letztes Jahr um diese Zeit hieß es kein
Sport kein Shopping kein Schulunterricht
dieses Jahr ist all das wenn auch mit
Einschränkungen möglich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das ist
kurz vor Weihnachten dann doch ein ganz
kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank und jetzt hat das Wort der
Kollege Dr Volker Ulrich für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
eine Aktuelle Stunde hat sich mit den
aktuellen Ereignissen zu beschäftigen
und wenn wir über die Fragen der
Impfungen sprechen
ist ein positives Signal das gestern 1,5
Millionen Menschen sich haben impfen
lassen
aber es haben sich erst in Deutschland
stand gestern 70 Prozent der
Bundesbürger insgesamt impfen lassen
eine Zahl die übrigens in Spanien in
Italien bereits im Spätsommer im Herbst
erreicht wurde
der Rückstand
an erstimpfungen und ein zweitimpfungen
ist auch dem Umstand geschuldet dass sie
von der AFD die Debatte vergiften und
die Menschen vorsätzlich gefährden indem
sie die Wirkungen von Impfungen Abrede
stellen
und wenn man über Impfungen spricht dann
brauchen wir jetzt auch eine klare und
gute Kommunikation
und das sage ich ist das was der
Bundesgesundheitsminister getan hat
nicht eine Frage von klarer
Kommunikation man darf bei der Lieferung
von Impfdosen nicht verwirren sondern
muss klar und deutlich kommunizieren
das gleiche Muster findet sich auch bei
der Frage des Infektionsschutzgesetzes
es war unserem Ansinnen geschuldet dass
dieses Gesetz angesichts der Lage
zweimal nachgebessert wurde und wenn wir
über die Lage sprechen hat ist doch ganz
klar das vor dem Hintergrund der
verfassungsrechtlichen
Verhältnismäßigkeit ein Zugang zum
Einzelhandel und zur Gastronomie unter
2g-bedingungen wesentlich besser ist als
wenn es geschlossen wäre gar keine Frage
und auch wenn uns bewusst ist dass
dieser Umstand
Umsatzeinbußen bringt so ist das besser
übrigens auch für das Gemüt und für die
Zusammenhalt eine Gesellschaft wenn
diejenigen die sich geimpft haben auch
den Zugang haben zur Einzelhandel und zu
Gastronomie ich glaube das ist wichtig
in einer Zeit die nach wie vor als
schwer zu kennzeichnen ist
und wichtig ist mir auch bei der
Gelegenheit daran zu erinnern dass
einzelne Gastronomie nicht nur aus
Kunden und Gästen besteht sondern auch
aus dem Mitarbeitern und Mitarbeitern
und auch die haben verdient dass wir uns
um Ihren Gesundheitsschutz kümmern und
an dieser Stelle übrigens auch ein
herzliches Dankeschön für ihren Dienst
in der Pandemie der nicht einfach war
ja wir blicken auch auf die
Schaustellerbranche auf abgesagte
Weihnachtsmärkte
und da muss klar sein dass in einer
Branche deren Jahresumsatz bis zu 50%
aus den Weihnachtsmärkten besteht dass
es hier allein nicht sein kann mit der
Erstattung von anteiligen Fixkosten
sondern hier muss der Staat auch durch
die Zahlung von Unternehmerlohn zur
Seite stehen sowie das Bayern oder
Sachsen macht und klar und deutlich zu
machen dass diese diese Weihnachtsmärkte
ein Kulturgut sind und dass wir die
Strukturen erhalten wollen damit es auch
nächsten Jahr wieder Weihnachtsmärkte
geben kann in unserem Land
mir ist aber noch wichtig
auf drei Sachen hinzuwirken zum einen
wir brauchen in der Tat eine
bundeseinheitliche Regelung in Bezug auf
die Frage ist das Konzept das einmal
Prüfens und dann mit Bändchen ein
taugliches und kann das auch umgesetzt
werden da darf es zwischen
unterschiedlichen Regionen keine
Rechtsunsicherheit geben wir brauchen
zum zweiten auch bei den Hilfen eine
klare und deutliche Handschrift dass
diese 30 Prozent Umsatzrückgang eine
Grenze ist die vielleicht zu starr ist
dann müssen wir die individuellen
Betroffenheiten stärker in den in den
Mittelpunkt unserer Betrachtung rücken
weil wir wollen nämlich klar und
deutlich machen dass durch diese
Pandemie doch Einschränkungen die
notwendig sind die Strukturen nicht
zerstört werden sondern wir wollen diese
Strukturen erhalten auch im Sinne der
Lebendigkeit unserer Ortskerne und der
Stadtzentren und wenn wir über impfen
sprechen
da muss auch deutlich sein dass die
Frage einer möglichen Impfpflicht
hier im Bundestag umfassend debattiert
werden muss gar keine Frage
aber ich finde eine neu gewählte
Bundesregierung darf sich bei diesem
Thema nicht wegdrücken sie muss klar und
deutlich zum Ausdruck bringen wie sie zu
einer möglichen Impfpflicht steht ein
verweisen auf gruppenanträge ist bei
diesem Thema nicht angebracht das ist
nicht ernsthaft genug
deswegen lassen Sie uns mit der
gebotenen Ernsthaftigkeit über diese
Themen sprechen und seien wir froh dass
zumindest über die 2g-regeln in
weihnachtszeiten ein bisschen Licht in
eine etwas schwierige Zeit kommt
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
wir freuen uns natürlich alle auf eine
weitere erste Rede nämlich die des
Kollegen Esra Leon Limbacher für die
SPD-Fraktion
der Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist erinnere
mich ganz gut noch an die
Vorweihnachtszeit im letzten Jahr
Gastronomie und Einzelhandel waren auch
damals massiv unter Druck viele Menschen
haben ihre Besorgung für Weihnachten im
Internet erledigt gleichzeitig sind die
Lager im Einzelhandel vollgelaufen
ich habe damals in Homburg in einer
Stadt in meinem Wahlkreis im Saarland
eine Plakatkampagne gestartet gemeinsam
mit der SPD haben wir dafür geworben
dass sie Weihnachtseinkäufe vor Ort zu
erledigen sind leider kam der Lockdown
und damit ein herber-rückschlag für alle
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt
einen großen Unterschied zum letzten
Jahr heute haben wir den Impfstoff heute
kann sich jeder impfen und Boostern
lassen und je mehr Menschen dieses
Angebot nutzen desto besser kommen wir
durch den Winter diesen Jahr und im
nächsten Jahr
heute stehen wir mitten in der vierten
Welle und dieses Jahr haben wir alles
daran gesetzt dass der Einzelhandel
nicht mehr schließen muss und das
Weihnachtsgeschäft nicht komplett
verloren gehen die Läden sind offen und
wir setzen alles daran dass das auch
genau so bleibt
die Läden sind deshalb offen weil wir
mit passgenauen hygienevorgaben unter
anderem auch zwei g auf die hohe Zahl
der Neuinfektionen reagiert haben zum
Schutze aller und gibt es eine
Alternative klar die gibt's eine
Alternative zu 2G ist 0 g die
Alternative zu passgenauen Lösungen ist
der Lockdown diese Ehrlichkeit gegenüber
den Gewerbetreibenden habe ich bei
manchen Kolleginnen heute vermisst
Umsatzeinbußen in der Gastronomie und im
Einzelhandel die gibt es natürlich und
ja es ist schwieriger geworden für alle
ich höre das ständig im in den
Gesprächen mit Vertreterinnen und
Vertretern aus dem Einzelhandel in
meinen Wahlkreis gerade gestern wieder
da habe ich mit Nico ganz da aus meinem
Wahlkreis gesprochen vom Verein Handel
und Gewerbe in einer Stadt in meinem
Wahlkreis St Ingbert heißt sie er hat
mir berichtet dass sie aktuellen
Vorgaben seiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen
natürlich vor enorme Herausforderungen
stellen trotzdem haben sie diese in der
täglichen Praxis alles in allen sehr gut
umgesetzt es gab keine Verstöße keine
Probleme das alles ist mit mehr Aufwand
mit mehr Zeit und mit mehr Arbeit
verbunden und in vielen Fällen leider
auch mit Mehrkosten und genau aus diesem
Grund möchte ich hier an dieser Stelle
ganz herzlich Danke sagen
danke an den gesamten Einzelhandel der
so schnell reagiert und kurzfristig
diese Regelungen umgesetzt hat vielen
Dank
wir wissen aber auch wissen aber auch
wie hart es für den Einzelhandel ist
deswegen Sorgen wir in der Koalition
dafür dass sie Überbrückungshilfen
weiter fließen wir lassen den
Einzelhandel nicht im Stich und wir
lassen alle anderen Betroffenen nicht im
Stich seit Beginn der Pandemie sind rund
4 Millionen Anträge für die Hilfen
eingegangen über 59 Milliarden Euro
wurden ausgezahlt 59 Milliarden Euro das
ist im übrigen europaweit Spitze und ich
habe gerade von Vertreterinnen und
Vertretern des Einzelhandels und dem
Herrn ganzer den ich gestern mit dem ich
gestern gesprochen habe auch ein Brief
erhalten und würde gerne aus dem Brief
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin zitieren
er schreibt
wir sehen gravierende Veränderungen in
den Fußgängerzonen unserer Städte den
appellkontakte zu vermeiden spüren wir
jeden Tag
weniger Besucher geringere Frequenz die
Fußgängerzone verlieren ihre Bedeutung
als soziale und kommunikatives Zentrum
und ich finde Herr ganzer hat vollkommen
recht nicht Amazon sorgt für lebenswerte
Innenstädte das sind die Cafés der
Buchladen die currywurstbute und die
Restaurants die wir alle kennen die
sorgen dafür und die wollen wir in
Zukunft weiterhin unterstützen
und wir wollen das genau die auch nach
der Pandemie noch tätig sein können
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn alle
Menschen sich impfen lassen würden
bräuchten wir diese Debatte heute nicht
dann hätten wir auch im Einzelhandel
genau diese Probleme nicht mehr die
Krankenhäuser würden entlastet und diese
aktuelle Stunde könnten wir nutzen um
konstruktive Ideen und Vorschläge
auszutauschen statt Teil der politischen
inszenierungsversuche der afd-fraktion
zu sein übrigens
übrigens eine konstruktive Idee jetzt
kurz vor Weihnachten wäre doch kaufen
Sie vor Ort ein
und unterstützen sie den Einzelhandel
genau jetzt wo es besonders notwendig
ist gerade jetzt in der
Vorweihnachtszeit vielen Dank und schöne
Weihnachtsferien
herzlichen dank ihnen ich schließe damit
die Aussprache die Aktuelle Stunde ist
beendet am Ende dieses dieser Debatte
will ich allen gratulieren die ihre
erste Rede gehalten haben auf gute
Zusammenarbeit in diesem Haus ich will
mich gleich wohl auch bedanken bei den
saaldienerinnen und saldinern ihnen
insbesondere eine frohe und gute
Weihnachtszeit wünschen vielen Dank dass
Sie gleich hier noch für uns aufräumen
wie sie das immer tun und dass sie hier
für uns arbeiten in allen
in allen hier wünsche ich eine frohe und
den die damit was anfangen können
gesegnete Weihnachtszeit einen guten
Übergang genießen Sie die Familie die
Wahlverwandtschaft die Freundinnen
natürlich im kleinen Kreis bleiben sie
heiter und hoffnungsvoll denken Sie an
die Nachbarin und Nachbarn wie das viele
in unserem Land ja selbstverständlich
auch tun die womöglich doch allein sind
genießen Sie die Zeit und vielen Dank an
alle Kinder die sehr viel ausgehalten
haben auch in diesem Jahr und insofern
ich schließe die Sitzung und Berufe die
nächste ein in der Woche vom
höchstwahrscheinlich in der Woche vom 10
januar des genaue Datum wird Ihnen noch
zugehen wir haben im Ältestenrat vorhin
darüber noch nicht endgültig beschließen
können also bleiben sie in der Nähe
lassen sie ab und an das Telefon an und
checken Sie Ihre Mails alles Gute und
frohe Zeiten
[Applaus]